hello everyone
welcome to this full course video in
data science with python
in this video tutorial we will cover
everything from basics to advanced that
will help you become a data scientist
our experienced instructors with immense
industry experience will take you
through this video you will first
understand the basics of data science in
5 minutes from an animated video
you will then learn the important
libraries in python such as numpy pandas
and matplotlib
you will get an idea about the various
data science concepts along with
mathematics statistics and linear
algebra
you will look at the essential
algorithms like linear regression
logistic regression decision trees
random forests k-nearest neighbors and
k-means clustering
you will also learn about reinforcement
learning and q-learning techniques
finally you will learn how to become a
data scientist in 2021 so let's begin
are you one of the many who dreams of
becoming a data scientist keep watching
this video if you're passionate about
data science because we will tell you
how does it really work under the hood
emma is a data scientist let's see how a
day in her life goes while she's working
on a data science project well it is
very important to understand the
business problem first in our meeting
with the clients emma asks relevant
questions understands and defines
objectives for the problem that needs to
be tackled she is a curious soul who
asks a lot of eyes one of the many
traits of a good data scientist
now she gears up for data acquisition to
gather and scrape data from multiple
sources like web servers logs databases
apis and online repositories oh it seems
like finding the right data takes both
time and effort after the data is
gathered comes data preparation this
step involves data cleaning and data
transformation data cleaning is the most
time consuming process as it involves
handling many complex scenarios here mr
deals with inconsistent data types
misspelled attributes missing values
duplicate values and what not then in
data transformation she modifies the
data based on defined mapping rules in a
project etl tools like talent and
informatica are used to perform complex
transformations that helps the team to
understand the data structure better
then understanding what you actually can
do with your data is very crucial for
that emr does exploratory data analysis
with the help of eda she defines and
refines the selection of feature
variables that will be used in the model
development but what if emma skips this
step she might end up choosing the wrong
variables which will produce an
inaccurate model thus exploratory data
analysis becomes the most important step
now she proceeds to the core activity of
a data science project which is data
modeling she repetitively applies
diverse machine learning techniques like
knn decision tree knife base to the data
to identify the model that best fits the
business requirement she trains the
models on the training data set and test
them to select the best performing model
emma prefers python for modeling the
data however it can also be done using r
and sas well the trickiest part is not
yet over visualization and communication
emma meets the clients again to
communicate the business findings in a
simple and effective manner to convince
the stakeholders she uses tools like
tableau power bi and qlikview that can
help her in creating powerful reports
and dashboards and then finally she
deploys and maintains the model she
tests the selected model in a
pre-production environment before
deploying it in the production
environment which is the best practice
right after successfully deploying it
she uses reports and dashboards to get
real-time analytics further she also
monitors and maintains the project's
performance well that's how emma
completes the data science project we
have seen the daily routine of a data
scientist is a whole lot of fun has a
lot of interesting aspects and comes
with its own share of challenges now
let's see how data science is changing
the world data science techniques along
with genomic data provides a deeper
understanding of genetic issues and
reaction to particular drugs and
diseases logistic companies like dhl
fedex have discovered the best rules to
ship the best suited time to deliver the
best mode of transport to choose thus
leading to cost efficiency with data
science it is possible to not only
predict employee attrition but to also
understand the key variables that
influence employee turnover also the
airline companies can now easily predict
flight delay and notify the passengers
beforehand to enhance their travel
experience well if you're wondering
there are various roles offered to a
data scientist like data analyst machine
learning engineer deep learning engineer
data engineer and of course data
scientist the median base salaries of a
data scientist can range from 95 000 to
165 000
so that was about the data science are
you ready to be a data scientist if yes
then start today the world of data needs
you python is the most widely used
programming language today when it comes
to solving data science tasks and
challenges python never ceases to
surprise its audience most data
scientists out there are already
leveraging the power of python every day
hi i'm abeksha from simply learn and
well after some thought and a bit more
research i was finally able to narrow
down my choice of top python libraries
for data science what are they let's
find out so let's talk about this
amazing library tensorflow which is also
one of my favorites so tensorflow is a
library for high performance numerical
computations with around 35 000 github
comments and a vibrant community of
around 1500 contributors and it's used
across various scientific domains it's
basically a framework where we can
define and run computations which
involves tensors and tensors we can see
are partially defined computational
objects again where they will eventually
produce a value that was about
tensorflow let's talk about the features
of tensorflow so tensorflow is majorly
used in deep learning models and neural
networks where we have other libraries
like torch and theano also but
tensorflow has hands down better
computational graphical visualizations
when compared to them also tensorflow
reduces the error largely by 50 to 60
percent in neural machine translations
it's highly parallel in a way where it
can train multiple neural networks and
multiple gpus for highly efficient and
scalable models this parallel computing
feature of tensorflow is also called
pipelining also tensorflow has the
advantage of seamless performance as
it's backed by google it has quicker
updates frequent new releases with the
latest of features now let's look at
some applications tensorflow is
extensively used in speech and image
recognition text based applications time
series analysis and forecasting and
various other applications involving
video detection so favorite thing about
tensorflow that it's already popular
among the machine learning community and
most are open to trying it and some of
us are already using it now let's look
at an example of a tensorflow model in
this example we will not dive deep into
the explanation of the model as it is
beyond the scope of this video so here
we are using amnest dataset which
consists of images of handwritten digits
handwritten digits can be easily
recognized by building a simple
tensorflow model let's see how when we
visualize our data using matplotlib
library the inputs will look something
like this then we create our tensorflow
model to create a basic tensorflow model
we need to initialize the variables and
start a session then after training the
model we can validate the data and then
predict the accuracy this model has
predicted 92 accuracy let's see which is
pretty well for this model so that's all
for tensorflow if you need to understand
this tutorial in detail then you can go
ahead and watch our deep learning
tutorial from simply learn as shown in
the right corner interesting right let's
move on to the next library now let's
talk about a common yet a very powerful
python library called numpy numpy is a
fundamental package for numerical
computation in python it stands for
numerical python as the name suggests it
has around 18 000 comments on github
with an active community of 700
contributors it's a general purpose
array processing package in a way that
it provides high performance
multi-dimensional objects called arrays
and tools for working with them also
numpy addresses the slowness problem
partly by providing these
multi-dimensional arrays that we talked
about and then functions and operators
that operate efficiently on these arrays
interesting right now let's talk about
features of number it's very easy to
work with large arrays and mattresses
using numpy numpy fully supports object
oriented approach for example coming
back to nd array once again it's a class
possessing numerous methods and
attributes ndra provides for larger and
repeated computations numpy offers
vectorization it's more faster and
compact than traditional methods i
always wanted to get rid of loops and
vectorization of numpy clearly helps me
with that now let's talk about the
applications of numpy numpy along with
pandas is extensively used in data
analysis which forms the basis of data
science it helps in creating the
powerful n-dimensional array whenever we
talk about numpy the mention of the
array we cannot do it without the
mention of the powerful n-dimensional
array also number is extensively used in
machine learning when we are creating
machine learning models as in where it
forms the base of other libraries like
sci-fi scikit-learn etc when you start
creating the machine learning models in
data science you will realize that all
the models will have their bases numpy
or pandas also when number is used with
scipy and matplotlib it can be used as a
replacement of matlab now let's look at
a simple example of an array in numpy as
you can see here there are multiple
array manipulation routines like there
are basic examples where you can copy
the values from one array to another we
can give a new shape to an array from
maybe one dimensional we can make it as
a two dimensional array we can return a
copy of the array collapsed into one
dimension now let's look at an example
where this is a jubilee notebook and we
will just create a basic array and
for detailed explanation you can watch
our other videos which targets on these
explanations of each libraries so first
of all whenever we are using any library
in python we have to import it so now
this np is the alias which we will be
using let's create a simple array
let's look what is the type of this
array
so this is an nd array type of array
also let's look what's the shape of this
array
so this is a shape of the array now here
we saw that we can expand the shape of
the array
so this is where you can change the
shape of the array using all those
functions now let's create another using
arrange functions if i give arrange 12
it will give me a 1d array of 12 numbers
like this now we can reshape this array
to 3 comma 4 or we can write it here
itself
so this is how our range function and
the reshape function works for numpy now
let's discuss the next library which is
scipy so this is another free and open
source python library extensively used
in data science for high level
computations so this library as the name
suggests stands for scientific python
and it has around 19 000 comments on
github with an active community of 600
contributors it is extensively used for
scientific and technical computations
also as it extends numpy it provides
many user-friendly and efficient
routines for scientific calculations now
let's discuss about some features of
sci-fi so sci-fi has its collection of
algorithms and functions which is built
on the numpy extension of python
secondly it has various high-level
commands for data manipulation and
visualization also the ndmh function of
scipy is very useful in
multi-dimensional image processing and
it includes built-in functions for
solving differential equations linear
algebra and many more so that was about
the features of sci-fi now let's discuss
its applications so cyber is used in
multi-dimensional image operations it
has functions to read images from disk
into number arrays to write arrays to
discuss images resize images etc solving
differential equations fourier
transforms then optimization algorithms
linear algebra etc let's look at a
simple example to learn what kind of
functions are there inside by here i'm
importing the constants package of scipy
library so in this package it has all
the constants
so here i'm just mentioning c or edge or
any and this library already knows what
it has to fetch like speed of light
planck's constant etc so this can be
used in further calculations data
analysis is an integral part of data
science data scientists spend most of
the day in data munching and then
cleaning the data also hence mention of
pandas is a must in data science life
cycle yes pandas is the most popular and
widely used python library for data
science along with numpy and matplotlib
the name itself stands for python data
analysis with around 17 000 comments on
github and an active community of 1200
contributors it is heavily used for data
analysis and cleaning as it provides
fast flexible data structures like data
frames series which are designed to work
with structured data very easily and
intuitively now let's talk about some
features of pandas so panas offers this
eloquent syntax and rich functionalities
like there are various methods and
pandas like drop n a fill na which gives
you the freedom to deal with missing
data also panas provides a powerful
apply function which lets you create
your own function and run it across a
series of data now forget about writing
those for loops while using pandas also
this library's high level abstraction
over low level numpy which is written in
pure c then it also contains these high
level data structures and manipulation
tools which makes it very easy to work
with pandas like their data structures
and series now let's discuss the
applications of pandas so panas is
extensively used in general data
wrangling and data cleaning then pandas
also finds its usage in edl jobs for
data transformation and data storage as
it has excellent support for loading csv
files into its data frame format then
pandas is used in a variety of academic
and commercial domains including
statistics finance neuroscience
economics web analytics etc then pandas
is also very useful in time series
specific functionality like date range
generation moving window linear
regression date shifting etc now let's
look at a very simple example of how to
create a data frame so data frame is a
very useful data structure in pandas and
it has very powerful functionalities so
here i'm only enlisting important
libraries in data science you can
explore more of our videos to learn
about these libraries in detail so let's
just go ahead and create a data frame
i'm using jupyter notebook again and in
this before using pandas here i'm
importing the pandas library
let me go and run this so in data frame
we can import a file a csv file excel
file so there are many functions doing
these things and we can also create our
own data and put it into data frame so
here i am taking random data and putting
in a data frame also i'm creating an
index and then also giving the column
names so pd is the alias we've given
pandas random data of six by four index
which is taking a range of six numbers
and column name i'm giving as abcd now
let's go ahead and look at it
so here it has created a data frame with
my column names abcd my list has six
numbers zero to five and a random data
of six by four so data frame is just
another table with rows and columns
where you can do various functions over
it also i can go ahead and describe this
data frame to see so it's giving me all
these functionalities where count and
mean and standard deviation etc okay so
that was about pandas now let's talk
about next library and the last one so
matplotlib for me is the most fun
library out of all of them why because
it has such powerful yet beautiful
visualizations we'll see in the coming
slides plot and matplotlib suggests that
it's a plotting library for python it
has around
000 comments on github and a very
vibrant community of 700 contributors
and because of such graphs and plots
that it produces it's majorly used for
data visualization and also because it
provides an object oriented api which
can be used to embed those plots into
our applications let's talk about the
features of matplotlib the pi plot
module of matplotlib provides
matlab-like interface so matplotlib is
designed to be as usable as matlab with
an advantage of being free and open
source also it supports dozens of
backends and output types which means
you can use it regardless of which
operating system you're using or which
output format you wish pandas itself can
be used as wrappers around matplotlibs
api so as to drive matplotlib via
cleaner and more modern apis also when
you start using this library you will
realize that it has a very little memory
consumption and a very good runtime
behavior now let's talk about the
applications of matplotlib it's
important to discover the unknown
relationship between the variables in
your data set so this library helps to
visualize the correlation analysis of
variables also in machine learning we
can visualize 95 confidence interval of
the model just to communicate how well
our model fits the data then matlab
finds its application and outlier
detection using scatter plot etc and to
visualize the distribution of data to
gain instant insights now let's make a
very simple plot to get a basic idea
i've already imported the libraries here
so this function matplotlib inline will
help you show the plots in the jupiter
notebook this is also called a magic
function i won't be able to display my
plots in the jupiter notebook if i don't
use this function i am using this
function in
numpy to fix random state for
reproducibility now i'll take my n as 30
and will assign random values to my
variables so this function is generating
30 random numbers here i'm trying to
create a scatter plot so i want to
decide the area
let's
put this so this is multiplying 30 with
random numbers to the power 2 so that we
get the area of the plot which we will
see in just a minute so using the
scatter function and the alias of
matplotlib as plt i've created this if i
don't use this and i have very small
circles as my scatter plot it's colorful
it's nice so that's one very easy plot i
suggest that you explore more of
matplotlib and i'm sure you will enjoy
it let's create a histogram so i'm using
my the style as gg plot and assigning
some values to these variables any
random values
now we are assigning bars and colors and
alignment to the plot and here we get
the graph so we can create different
type of visualizations and plots and
then work upon them using matplotlib and
it's just that simple so that was about
the leading python libraries in the
field of data science but along with
these libraries data scientists are also
leveraging the power of some other
useful libraries for example like
tensorflow keras is another popular
library which is extensively used for
deep learning and neural network modules
keras drafts both tensorflow and theano
backends so it is a good option if you
don't want to dive into details of
tensorflow then scikit-learn is a
machine learning library it provides
almost all the machine learning
algorithms that you need and it is
designed to interpolate with numpy and
sci-by then we have cbon which is
another library for data visualization
we can say that c bond is an enhancement
of math plot lab as it introduces
additional plot types so let's start
with what is numpy numpy is the core
library for scientific and numerical
computing in python it provides high
performance multi-dimensional array
object and tools for working with arrays
and i'll go a step further and say there
are so many other modules in python
built on numpy so the fundamentals of
numpy are so important to latch onto for
the python so you can understand the
other modules and what they're doing
numpy's main object is a
multi-dimensional array it's a table of
elements usually numbers all of the same
type indexed by a tuple of position
integers in numpy dimensions are called
axes
take a one-dimensional array or we have
remember dimensions are also called axes
you could say this is the first axis
0 1 2 3 4 5 and you can see down here it
has a shape of six why because there's
six different elements in it in the one
dimension array and they usually denote
that as six comma with an empty node on
there and then we have a two dimensional
array where you can see zero one two
three four five six seven and in here we
have two axes or two dimensions and the
shape is two four so if you were looking
at this as a matrix or in other
mathematical functions you can see
there's all kinds of importance on shape
we're not going to cover shape today but
we will cover that in part two did you
know that numpy's array class is called
nd array for numpy data array now we're
going to take a detour here because
we're working in python and two of my
favorite tools in python is the jupiter
notebook and then i like to use that
sitting on top of anaconda and if you
flip over to jupiter.org that's
j-u-p-y-t-e-r dot org you can go in here
you can install it off of here if you
don't want to use the anaconda notebook
but this is the jupiter setup the
documentation on the jupiter jupiter
opens up in your web browser that's what
makes it so nice is it's portable the
files are saved on your computer they do
run in ipython or iron python and you
can create all kinds of different
environments in there which i'll show
you in just a minute i myself like to
use anaconda that's www.anaconda.com
if you install anaconda it will install
the jupiter notebook with the anaconda
separate and you can install jupiter
notebook and it'll run completely
separate from anaconda's jupiter
notebook and you can see here i've now
opened up my anaconda navigator what i
like about the navigator and this is a
fresh install on a new computer which is
always nice i can launch my jupyter
notebook from in here i can bring other
tools so the anaconda does a lot more
and under environments i only have the
one environment and i can open up the
terminal specific to this environment
this one happens to have python37 in it
the most current version as of this
tutorial and the open terminal if you're
going to do your pip installs and stuff
like that for different modules you can
also create different environments in
here so maybe you need a python 3 6
python
you can see we're having a nice
framework like anaconda really helps so
you don't have to track that on your own
in the jupyter notebook in your
different jupyter notebook setups we'll
go ahead and launch this jupyter
notebook and then i've set my browser
window for a default of chrome so it's
going to open up in chrome and you can
see here this opens up a folder on my
computer we have a couple different
options on here remember i set the
environment up as python 3.7 you would
install any additional modules that
aren't already installed in your python
on this and it keeps them separate so
you do have to for each environment
install the separate modules so they
match the environment on there and in
here we have a couple things we can look
up what's running you have your
different clusters again this is i just
installed this on a new machine so i
just have the one a couple things in
here that were run on here recently and
when we go on here is we then have on
the upper right new and from the pull
down menu you'll see python 3 and this
will open up a new window
and now we're in jupiter python so this
is a python window and we'll just do a
print
and this of course is hello world
and we'll run that and it prints out
hello world in the command line there's
a couple special things you have to know
we're not going to do today which is on
graphics if you've never seen this
one of the things you can do is you can
also do a equals hello world and if you
just put the a in there now if you do a
bunch of these where you have a equals
hello world b equals goodbye world and
you put a b a and return b you'll only
run the last one but you can see here if
you put the variable down here it will
show you what's in that variable
and that has to do with the jupiter
notebook inline coding so that's not
basic python that's just jupiter
notebook shorthand which you'll see in a
little bit
so back to our numpy numpy array versus
python list python list being the basic
list in your python why should we use
numpy array when we have python list
well first it's fast the numpy array has
been optimized over years and years by
multiple programmers and it's usually
very quick compared to the basic python
list setup it's convenient so it has a
lot of functionality in there there's
not in the basic python list and it also
uses less memory so it's optimized both
for speed and memory use
and let's go ahead and jump into our
jupyter notebook since we're coding best
way to learn coding is to code just like
the best way to learn how to write is
right and the best way to learn how to
cook is cook so let's do some coding
here today
and just like any modules we have to
import numpy we almost always import it
as np that is such a standard so you'll
see that very commonly we can just run
that and now we have access to our numpy
module inside our python and then the
most common thing of course is to go and
create a number array
and in here we can send it a regular
list
and so we'll go ahead and send this a
regular array let's do one two three to
make it simple and then i'm just going
to type in a and we'll run this
so you can see down here the output is
an array of one two three
and we could also do
print
just a reminder that this is an inline
command so that wouldn't work if you're
using a different editor you can see
that it's an array one two three but
we'll go and leave it as a
kind of a nice feature so you can see
what you're doing really quick in the
jupiter notebook
and just like all your other standard
arrays i can go
a of 0
which is going to be a value of 1. of
course we do a of one you go all the way
through this
i have one has a value of two in it
so whether you're using the numpy array
or the basic python list that's going to
be the same that should all look pretty
familiar and be pretty straightforward
remember the first value is always zero
and when we set on there so let's take a
look why we're using numpy because we
went over the slide a little bit but
let's just take a look and see what that
actually looks like
and what we want to look at is the fact
that it's fast convenient and uses less
memory so let's take a glance at that in
code and see what that actually looks
like when we're writing it in python and
what the differences are
and to do this i'm going to go ahead and
import a couple other modules we're
going to import the time module so we
can time it and we're going to import
the system module so that we can take a
look at how much memory it uses and
we'll go and just run those so those are
imported
so we'll do b equals oh range of 1. yeah
1 thousand is fine
and so that's going to create a list of
one thousand zero to nine hundred ninety
nine remember it starts at zero and it
stops right at the one thousand without
actually going to the one thousand
and let's go ahead and print
and we want system dot get size of
and we'll pick any integer because we
have you know zero to
a thousand we'll just throw one in there
five it doesn't matter because it's
gonna whatever integer we put in there's
gonna generate the same value because
we're looking at the size of how how
much memory it stores an integer in
and then we want to have the length of
the b that's how many integers are in
there
and if we go ahead and execute this and
run this in a line we'll see
oops i did that wrong comma
if we multiply them together
we'll see it generates 28 000 so that's
the size we're looking at is 28 000 i
believe that's bytes that sounds about
right
so let's go ahead and create this in
numpy
and we'll go with c equals np
and this is a range
so that's the number command to do the
same thing that we were just doing in a
list
and we'll also use the same value on
there the 1000 and then once we've
created the
c
value of c for np dot a range let's go
ahead and print
and we can do that by doing c dot size
times c dot
item size
when it's very similar we did before we
did get the size of so the c size is the
size of the array and each item size
just reversed
so it's the size of an integer 5 item
size it's going to be the integers and c
size and let's just take a look and see
what that generates
and wow okay we got 4 000 versus 28 000.
that's a significant difference in
memory how much memory we're using with
the array and then let's go ahead and
take a look at speed let's do um oh
let's do size we tried this with lower
values and it would happen so fast that
the npra kept coming up with zero
because it just rounded it off
so size and let's create an l1
moles
range of size
and we'll do an l2
we'll just set up to the same thing it's
also range
of size on there there we go
and then we can do on a1
equals np dot
a range size
and then let's do an a
equals np dot
a range
we'll keep it the same size
and what we're going to do is we're
going to take these two different arrays
and we're going to perform some basic
functions on them
but let's go ahead and just load these
up now we'll go ahead and run this so
those are all set in memory
except for the typo here
quickly fix that
there we go so these are now all loaded
in here and let's do a start
equals
time dot time
so it's just going to look at my clock
time and see what time it is
and we'll do result equals and let's do
oh let's say we got
an array
and we're going to say
let's do some addition here x
plus y
for x comma y
and
and we'll zip it up here
two different arrays so here's our two
different arrays we're gonna multiply
each of the individual things on here l1
l2
there we go so that should add up each
value so l1 plus l2 each value in each
array
then we want to go ahead and print
and let's say
python list took
and then we'll do
time
dot time
we'll just subtract the start out of
there so time whoops i messed up on some
of the quotation marks on there
okay there we go
time
minus the start
and we'll convert that to seconds so
we'll go uh because in milliseconds or
times one thousand
and let's hit the run on there it's kind
of fun because you also get a view while
we're doing this
of some ways to manipulate the script
and as you can see also my bed typing
there we go okay so we'll go ahead and
run this
and we can see here that the python list
took 34
actually i have to go back and look at
the conversion on there but you can see
it takes roughly 0.34 of a second and we
go ahead and print the result in here
too
let's do that
we'll run that just so you can see what
the what kind of data we're looking at
and we have the zero two four six eight
so it's just adding them together it
looks pretty straight straightforward on
there and if we scroll down to the
bottom of the answer again we see python
list took 46 a little different time on
there depending on what
core because i have this is on an eight
core computer so it just depends on what
core it's running on what else is
pulling on the computer at the time and
let's go back up here and do our start
time
paste that into here
and this time we're going to do a result
equals and this is really cool notice
how elegant this is so straightforward
this is a lot of reason people started
using numpy is because i can add the two
arrays together by simply going a1 plus
a2
it makes a lot of sense both looking at
it and it's just very
convenient remember this slide we're
looking at fast convenient and less
memory so look how convenient that is
really easy to read real easy to see
and i don't know if we don't need to
print the result again so let's just go
ahead and print
the time on here
and we'll borrow this from the top part
because i really am a lazy typer
and this isn't the python list this is
the numpy list or number array
and let's go ahead and see how that
comes out
and we get 2.99
so let's take a look at these two
numbers 46 versus 2.99 so we'll just
round this up to 3. that's a huge
difference that's that's like
more than 10 times faster that's like 15
times roughly at a quick glance i'd have
to go do the math to look at it and it's
going to vary a little bit depending on
what's running in the background the
computer obviously so we've looked at
this and if we go back here we found out
it's much faster
yes there's different going to be
different speeds depending on what
you're doing with the array very
convenient easy to read and it uses less
memory so that's the core of the numpy
that's why a lot of people base so many
other modules on numpy and why it's so
widely used
so we did glance at a couple operations
when we were looking at speed and size
let's dive into a little bit more into
the basic operations
and these are always nice to see i mean
certainly you want to go get a cheat
sheet if you're using it for the first
time you know look things up google is
your friend we did this we're the most
basic numpy dot array or np.array
and we'll go ahead and create an array
let's do
pairs
one comma two
and then let's do a 3 comma 4 and if
we're going to do that let's do 5 comma
6.
there we go and if we go ahead and take
this
and run this i go ahead and do our a
down here so it's in line and i'll print
that out
you can see it makes a nice array for us
so we have a and if you look at that we
have three different objects each with
two values in them and hopefully you're
starting to think well how many
dimensions or indexes is that and you'll
see three by two so let's go ahead and
take a look and let's go how about a dot
in dimensions
speaking of which
we'll run that and we have two
dimensions for each object
and then we can do the item size so a
dot
we saw this earlier we looked up how
many items it was up here where we
wanted to multiply item size times the
actual size of the object so the memory
is being used versus the item size
and we should see four there
memory is compressed down that's always
a good thing
and then the shape the shape is so
important when you're working with data
science and you're moving it from
one format to another
so we have our shape we just talked
about that we have three by two three
rows by two objects in each one
generally i don't look too much at the
size but the dimensions i'm always
looking up and this is nice you can
automate it so you might be converting
something you might need to know how
many dimensions are going into the
next machine learning package so that
you can automatically just have it send
that information over
so we looked at a shape
let's go and create a slightly different
array in p dot array let's go ahead and
just do as our original
setup here
and one of the features we can do which
is really important is we can do d type
equals in this case let's do np
float
64. and so what we've done is converting
all of these into a float and we type in
a
and now instead of having one two three
four five six you see they're all float
values one dot zero there's no actual
zero in there just throws the one dot or
the one period two three period four
period five period six period
and this again data science i don't know
how many times i've had to convert
something from an integer to a float so
that's going to work correctly in the
model i'm using
so very common features to be aware of
and to be able to get around and use
and we'll also do let's just curiosity
item size
we'll go and run that
and we see that it doubled in size so
it's not a huge increase well doubling
is always a big increase in computers
but it's not a huge increase compared to
what it would be if you're running this
in the python list format
and then we did the shape earlier
without having it set to the float64
let's go ahead and do a shape with it
set to 64. and it should be the same
three comma two so it all matches
so we've gone through and remember if
you really if this is all brand new to
you
according to the cambridge study at the
cambridge university if you're learning
a brand new word in a foreign language
the average person has to repeat it
163 times before it's memorized
so a lot of this you build off of it so
hopefully you don't have to repeat it
163 times but we did manage to repeat it
at least twice here if not a little bit
more
and let's go ahead and take this we're
going to look at one more setup on here
and let me just take this last statement
here i'm converting our properties of
our data
and instead of float 64
let's do complex let's just see what
that looks like and let's go and print
that out and run it
and so we now have a complex data set up
and you'll see it's denoted by the one
dot plus zero dot j
and if we flip over here and do a basic
search for numpy data types
better to go to the original web page
but pull up a bunch of these you can see
there's a whole list of different numpy
data types
shorthand complex we have complex
complex 64 complex 128
complex number represented by 264-bit
floats real and imaginary components
one option on there float16 float32
float shorthand for float with 64 most
commonly used and of course all the
different ones that you can possibly put
into your numpy array so we covered a
basic addition up there we're comparing
how fast it runs but some very basic
components how to set up a numpy array
how many dimensions it has item size
data type item again we went to item
size and there's also
the
shape probably one of the more used i
used a shape all the time very commonly
used
and then down here you can see where we
actually created a numpy complex data
type
so let's look at some other features in
numpy one of them is you could do numpy
dot
zeros
and we're gonna do three comma four
there we go and we'll go ahead and run
this and you can see if i do np dot
zeros i create a numpy array of
zeros this is really important i was
building my own neural network and i
needed to create an array where i
initialized the weights
and i want them all to be the same
weight in this case i wanted them to
start off as zero for the particular
project i was working on and there's
other options like you can do numpy ones
and we'll do the same thing three comma
four we'll run that
and you can see i've created a an array
of numpy ones in this case it comes out
as a float array
and then this is an interesting to note
because we have let's go back to our
python and do lrange5
and we'll print the l so as our list
and if i run that
it doesn't create the range until after
the fact until you actually execute it
that's an upgrade in python python27
actually created the array zero one two
three four this one actually creates the
script and then once it's used it then
actually generates the array
and if we do that in numpy a range
remember that from before
and if we do numpy a range 5
and let's do l equals
or we can just leave it as numpy that's
fine there we go just run that
you can see there we actually get an
array zero one two three four for the
value the numpy arrange a range five
generates the actual array
and for part one we're going to do just
one more section on basic
setup
and we're going to concatenation
do a concatenation out example
there we go we're going to do strings
let's take a look at strings what's
going on with there
and let's do
oh let's see print
let's do an np
character something new here
and we're going to add
and then here's our brackets for what
we're going to add oh and let's say
let's do
hello
comma hi
and
in the brackets on there let's create
another one
and this one's going to be
a b c
and we'll do
x y z so we're just creating some
randomly making some up on here and then
we'll go ahead and just print this
if we run that and come down here
and of course make sure all your
brackets are open and closed correctly
and then you can see in here when we
concatenate the example in numpy
it takes the two different arrays that
we set up in there and it combines the
hello with the abc and the high with xyz
and if we can also do something like
print
oh let's do
np character dot
multiply
so there's a lot of different functions
in here again you can look these up it's
probably good to look them all up and
see what they are but it's good to also
just see them in action let's do hello
space comma three
and we'll run this one
and run that without the error you'll
see it does hello hello hello so we
multiplied it by three and we can also
let's just take this whole thing here
instead of retyping it
and we can do character
center so instead of multiply let's do
center
and over here
keep our hello going
take the space out of there
and let's do center at 20
and fill character
equals we'll fill it with dashes
so if we run this
you can see it prints out the hello with
dashes on each side and we keep going um
with that we can also in addition to
doing the fill function we can play with
capitalize we can title we can do
lowercase we can do uppercase we can
split split line strip join these are
all the most common ones and let's go
ahead and just look at those and see
what those look like each one of them
here we're going to do the hello world
all-time favorite of mine i would like
to say hello universe and you can see
here we did a capital h with the world
but so we want to capitalize so
capitalize is the first one in the array
so we get hello world on there and we
can also take this and instead of
capitalizing
another feature in here is title and
let's just change this to how are we
doing
how
are you doing instead of
do you
let's run that
and you can see here because we created
it as a title it capitalizes the first
letter in each word
and in this one we're going to do
character lower
two different examples here we have an
array we have hello world all
capitalized and we have just hello and
you can see that one is an array and one
is just a string if we run that
you get a an array with hello world
lowercase and hello lowercase
and if we're going to do it that way we
can also do it the opposite way there's
also upper
and let's paste those in there and you
can see here we have
character.upper opposite there
python.data and that will do python is
easy
hopefully you're starting to get the
picture that most of the python and the
scripting is very simple
it's when you put the bigger picture
together and starts building these
puzzles and somebody asks you hey i need
the first letter capitalized unless it's
the title and then we have you start
realizing that this can get really
complicated so numpy just makes it
simple and we like that
and so in this case we did python data
it's all uppercase python is easy like
shouting in your messenger python is
easy
and then if you're ever processing text
and tokenizing it a lot of times the
first thing you do is we just split the
text and we're just going to run this in
p dot character dot split are you coming
to the party if we do that returns an
array of each of the individual words
are you coming to the party splitting it
by the spaces
and then if we're going to split it by
spaces we also need to know how to split
it by lines
and just like we have the basic split
command we also have split lines
hello and you'll see here the scoop in
for our new line
and when we run that if you're following
the split part with the words you should
see hello how are you doing the two
different lines are now split apart
and let's just review three more before
we wrap this up commonly used string
variable manipulations we have strip and
in this case we have
nina admin anita and we're going to
strip a off of there let's see what that
looks like
and then you end up with nin diminish it
basically takes up all leading and
trailing letters in this case we're
looking for a
more common would be a space in there
but it might also be punctuation or
anything like that that you need to
remove from your letters and words
and if we're going to strip and clean
data we also need to be able to reformat
it or join it together so you see here
we have a character join we'll go ahead
and run this
and it has on the first one it splits
these letters up by the colon and the
second one by the dash and you can see
how this is really useful if you're
processing in this case a date we have
day month year year month date very
common things to be have to always
switch around and manipulate depending
on what they're going into and what
you're working with
and finally let's look at one last
character string
we're going to do replace
if you're doing misinformation this is
good pulling news articles replacing
is and what in this case we're just
doing here's a good dancer and we're
going to replace is with was
and you can see here he was a good
dancer hopefully that's not because he
had a bad fall he just was from like you
know 1920s and has gotten old
so there we go we covered a lot of the
basics in numpy as far as creating an
array very important stuff here when
you're feeding it in how do we know the
shape of it the size of it what happens
when we convert it from a regular
integer into a float value as far as how
much space it takes we saw that that
doubled it item size you have your in
dimensions and probably the most used is
shape and we'll cover more on shape in
part two so make sure you join us on
part two there's a lot of important
things on shaping in there and setting
them up
we also saw that you can create a zeros
based array you can create one with ones
if we do a range you can see how it is a
lot easier to use to create its own
range or a range as it is in numpy
you saw how easy it was to add two
arrays we saw that earlier just plus
sign then we got into
doing strings and working with strings
and how to concatenate so if you have
two different arrays of strings you can
bring them together we also saw how you
can fill so you can add a nice headline
dash dash dash
we saw about capitalize the first letter
we saw about turning it into a title so
all the first letters are capitalized
doing lowercase on all the letters upper
for all the letters just lower and upper
nice abbreviation we also covered how to
split the character set how to strip it
so if you want to strip all the a's out
from leading a a's and ending a's or
spaces you can do that very easily also
how to join the data sets so here's a
character join option for your strings
and finally we did the character replace
pandas really is a core python module
you need for doing data science and data
processing there's so many other modules
that come off of it there it actually
sits kind of on numpy so if you already
had our numpy array hopefully you've
already gone through the numpy tutorial
one and two so today we're going to
cover what is pandas we'll discuss
series we'll discuss basic operations on
series then we'll get into a data frame
itself basic operations on the data
frame file related operations on a data
frame visualization and then some
practice examples roll up our sleeves
and get some coding underneath there and
let's start with just some real general
what is pandas pandas is a tool for data
processing which helps in data analysis
it provides functions and methods to
efficiently manipulate large data sets
now this is a step down from say using
spark or hadoop in big data so we're not
talking about big data here but we are
talking about pandas when there is some
connections there's like an interface
going on with that so there is
availability but you really should know
your pandas because if you're working in
big data you'll know there's data frames
well pandas is a data frame primarily it
has a couple different pieces we'll look
at here and if you've never worked with
data frames before a data frame is
basically like an excel spreadsheet you
have rows and columns you can access
your data either by the row or the
column and you have an index and
different that kind of set up and we'll
dig more into that as we get deeper into
pandas but think of it as like a giant
excel spreadsheet that's optimized to
run a larger data on your computer
and then i said it that it's a data
frame so the data structures in pandas
are series one dimensional arrays and
then we have data frame two dimensional
array and it really centers around the
data frame the series just happens to be
part of that data frame and here's a
closer look at a pandas series series is
a one-dimensional array with labels it
can contain any data type including
integers strings floats python objects
and more so it's very diverse if you
remember from numpy we studied they had
to be all uniform not in pandas and
pandas we can do a lot more and pen is
actually kind of sits on numpy so you
really need to know both of those if you
haven't done the numpy tutorials and you
can see here we have our index one two
three four five and then our data a b c
d and e very straightforward it's just
two columns and we have a nice index
label and a column label for the data
and then a data frame is a
two-dimensional data structure with
labels we can use labels to locate data
and you can see here we had if we go
back one we had our index one two three
four five so in each one of these series
they would share the same index over
there the row index so you have your row
index df dot index and then you have a
column index df.columns and this should
look like i said this would be really
familiar if you've done any work with
spreadsheets excel so it kind of
resembles that this does make it a lot
easier to manipulate data and add
columns delete columns move them around
same thing with the rows so you have a
lot of control over all of this now
we're of course going to do this in our
jupyter notebook you can use any of your
python editors but i highly suggest if
you haven't installed jupyter and
haven't worked with it it is probably
one of the best ways for easily
displaying a project you're working on i
skip between a lot of different user
interfaces or ides for editing my python
and it's just simply jupiter.org
j-u-p-y-t-e-r.org
and then i always let mine sit on
anaconda anaconda.com
and just real quick we'll open that up
for you oops offline mode don't show me
that again
but you can see here that i have
different tools that i can actually
install in my anaconda including the
jupiter notebook which comes by default
and then i have access to the
environments
and again that's
anaconda.com named after the very large
one of the largest world's largest
snakes and then jupiter notebook in this
case jupiter.org and when we're in our
i'm going to go in here to our jupiter
notebook and we're going to go ahead and
just do new and a python 3
and this will open up a python 3
untitled folder
so diving right in let's go ahead and
give this a title pandas tutorial and
we'll go up to cell and we'll change the
cell type to mark down so it doesn't
execute it as actual code
one of those wonderful tools when you
have jupiter notebooks so you can do
demos with this and let's go ahead and
import
pandas
and usually people just call it pd that
has become such a standard in the
industry so we'll go ahead and run that
now we have our pandas has been imported
into our jupiter notebook
and then oh we can go ahead and let me
do the control plus since it's internet
explorer i can enlarge it very easily so
you have a nice pretty view oops too big
there we go and whenever you're working
with a new module it's good to check
your version of the module in pandas you
just use the in this case pd dot
underscore underscore version underscore
underscore that's actually pretty common
in most of our python modules there's
different ways to look up the version
but that's one of the more common ones
and we'll go ahead and run that we get
0.23.4
and if we go to the pandas site we see
0.23.4 as the latest release
and of course a reminder that if you're
going to environment you need to install
it so you'll need to pip install pandas
if you're using the pip installer we'll
close out of that
and the first thing we're going to do is
we're going to work with series a lot of
stuff you do in series you can then do
on the whole data set we need to do what
create one we need to manipulate it
take pieces of it so query it query it
delete so you can delete different parts
of it so we want to do all those things
with the series and we'll start with the
series and then almost all the code in
fact all the code does transfer right
into
the actual data table so we go from a
series of a single list of one column
and then we'll take that and we'll
transfer that over to the whole table
and we'll start by creating
let's put up there we go
creating a series from
list
and let's just call this arr equals
and we'll do 0 1 2 3 4. if you remember
from our last one we could easily do
r equals
range of 5 which would be 0 to 4. but
we'll do r equals 0 to 4 and we'll call
this s1 and we'll go pd
and
series is capitalized this one always
throws me is which letters do you
capitalize on these modules they're
getting more and more uniform but you
got to watch that with python and we're
just going to go ahead and do arr
so we're just going to take this python
list and we're going to turn it into a
series
and then because we're in jupiter we
don't have to put the print statement we
can just put s1 and it'll print out this
series for us
and let's go ahead and run that and take
a look
and you'll see we have two rows of
numbers so the first one is the index
now it automatically creates the index
starting with zero unless you tell it to
do differently so we get zero index row
zero zero one one two 2 3 3 4 4. and
because it's a series it doesn't need a
title for the column there's only one
column so why title it
and this also lets you know that it's a
data type of integer 64. so we print
this out this is our series our basic
series we've just created
and let's do a second series
pd and we'll use the same
data list and let's go ahead and do
order we'll give it an order
equals oh let's do it this way
let's go
index
equals order
and it helps if we actually give it an
order so we'll do order
equals and let's do one two three four
five so instead of starting with zero
we're going to give it an order starting
with one we're going to run that and
we'll go ahead and print it out down
here s2
and we'll see that we now have an index
of one two three four five and that
represents 0 1 2 3 4 in the series and
we're still data type integer 64. and
very common as you're missing with numpy
arrays is we can import our numpy as np
remember that from our numpy tutorials
we can go ahead and create a numpy out
of random with the random numbers of
five
and let's just see what that end looks
like so we can see what our number looks
like so we have some nice random float
values here two point three three so on
and that's from our last tutorial the
numpy tutorial 1 and 2. and instead of
calling it order let's call it index
and we're going to set our index equal
to a b c d and e
i want to show you that the index
doesn't have to be an integer so it can
be something very different here and
then let's go ahead and create our we'll
just use s2 again and here's our np for
numpy
series capital s
and n is our
np for numpy
pd for pandas there we go switching my
anachronisms so we have pd.series of n
and we're going to do our index
equals our index we just created
and then let's go ahead and see what
that looks like s2 is a print it and
let's run that
and we can see here we have a nice
series going on a b c d and e for our
indexes so instead of it being 0 1 2 3
or 4 we can make this index whatever we
want and you can see the numbers here
going down that we randomly generated
from the number array so we use numpy to
create our
panda series right here
and so continuing on with creating our
series this one i use so often we create
a series from a dictionary so we have
our dictionary in this case we went
ahead and did a of 1 b is 2 c a3 d4 ef5
so each one of those is a key and then a
value and then we're going to use oh
let's use s3 equals pd for pandas
series
and then we want to go ahead and just do
d in here
print out s3 here and let's go ahead and
run this and you can see we got a is one
b is two c is three d is four e is five
and it's still of integer 64 because the
actual data is one two three four five
and it's all integer 64 type 64. and the
last thing we want to do in the creating
section of our series is to go ahead and
modify the index because we're going to
start modifying all this data so let's
start with modifying the index of the
series and if you remember let's do a
print this time s1
i'll go ahead and run this and the
reason i did print is because it only
prints out the last variable so if i put
s1 up here and we're going to do another
variable back down lower it won't print
the first one just the last one and
we're going to go ahead and take s1
the index and we're just going to set it
equal to a new index and obviously
the number of objects in our index has
to equal the number of objects in our
data and then because it's the last
variable we can go ahead and just do an
s1 and let's run that and you can see
how we went from 0 to 0 0 1 2 3 4 as our
index we've now altered it to a b c d
and e
so this would be much more readable or
might be representational of a larger
database you're working with
so cool tools we've covered creating
database based on
a basic array python array we've showed
you how to reset the index
then we showed you how to use a numpy
array so you can put a numpy array in
there it's all the same you know
pd.series a numpy array and then we can
set the index on there and the same
thing with the dictionary so it's very
versatile how it pulls in data and you
can pull in data from different sources
and different setups and create a new
series very easily in the pandas and
then we left on changing your index so
now we have a new index on here
and then we want to go ahead and do some
selection let's do some basic
slicing most common thing you'll
probably do on here we'll just do s1
this notation should start to look
really familiar again this is going to
put an output so i'd usually it doesn't
change s1 this just selects it so we
might do a equals s1 and then print a
and you'll see that it just looks at the
first three zero one two and we can do
the same thing by not having the a in
there i'll go ahead and take that out
but just a reminder that it's not
actually changing s1 it's just viewing
s1 so simple slicing on here and we can
likewise do an append so before we do a
pen let's just do a quick kind of fun
one we'll do two minus one and you'll
see it covers everything but the e of
course you can do minus two on this side
so one another way to select it is to go
how far from the end and likewise we can
do a two here
cde to the end so it starts at the
second one and another way we can do
this is we can do a minus two over here
and that looks at just the last two in
the slice
so you can see how easy it is to slice
the data and of course
there's no reason to do this but you
could select all of them
if you wanted to view all of them on
there up 32 there's not 32 so it's just
going to show the first three there we
go and then we can also append so i can
take and oh let's create another series
and append one to it and if you remember
we had s3 there's our s3 and we have our
s1 we'll go ahead and do s1
and let's go ahead and do
oh let's call it s4
equals s1
append
s3
so we're just going to combine those two
into s4
and if we go ahead and print s4 on here
you'll now see that we have a b c d e a
b c d e zero one two three four one two
three four five because we started the
data at one so very easy to append one
series to the next
and if we're going to append one series
to the next we need to go ahead and drop
or delete one and drop is a key word for
that and let's just do e or index e and
so if i run this
you'll see that it'll print it out and
abcd there's no e
and remember all these changes if i type
in s4 again
you'll see that s4 still has e in it so
this change does not affect the series
unless you tell it to so i'd have to do
like x s4 equals s4.drop e and there's
another way to do that which we'll show
you later on let me just cut this one
out
there we go
all right so we've covered all kinds of
cool tools here we have appending we
have slicing we did all the creating
stuff earlier as you can see here on the
setup how easy it is to manipulate the
series
so next what we want to get into is we
want to get into
operations that happen on the series let
me go ahead and change this cell to
mark down there we go and run that
so series operations what can we do with
the series
and let's start by creating a couple
arrays we'll call it array 1 and we'll
do zero through seven and array two six
through six seven eight nine five i
don't know if we threw the five on the
end let's go ahead and run those so
those load up into jupiter
and uh we'll do this a little backwards
we're gonna do s5 equals a panda series
of array two so i'm doing this in
reverse and then when we do s5 you'll
see that we have zero to four it
automatically assign the index
for our series
and let's go ahead and do the same and
we'll call this s6 and we'll set this
equal to pd series for
our first array
and if we do an s6 down here to print it
out
we'll see something similar i got zero
through six
zero one two three four five seven for
the data so those are two series we just
created series six five and six
and one of the first things we can do is
we can add one series to the next so i
can do s5 dot add s6
and let's see what that generates and
just a quick thing if you never use
pandas what do you think is going to
happen with the fact that this only has
five different values in it and this one
has seven values
so let's see what that does
and we end up with 6 8 10 12 9 and it
goes oh i can't add this there's nothing
there so it gives us a null return very
different than the numpy that would have
given you an error this instead tells
you there's no value here because we
couldn't generate one so we can easily
add s5 dot add s6 and likewise we can do
s5 dot
sub for subtract s6
and we'll run that and on the add the
subtract and you guessed it we're going
to do multiply and divide next again you
can see there's a null values where it
can't subtract the two because there's
no values there to subtract we can also
do s5 multiply mul they're all three
letters on these that's one of the ways
to remember how they figured out the
code for this so remember these are all
three letters mole we'll go ahead and
run this
and you can you can see how they're
multiplied together and then we can also
do the s5 div three letters again
s6
and run that
and you'll see here this goes to
infinity because we have zero in the
wrong position so it actually gives you
a whole different answer here that's
important to notice and then in the null
values because there's no data and it
can't actually produce an answer off of
an old off of missing data and since
we're in data science let's do
s6 median so let's look at the median
data which is simply median sorry for
those who are following the three
letters because median is not three
letters and you can see an s6 is 3.0 and
let's do a print here and we'll do
median or average
s6
and let's print max
comma s6
and just like median there's max value
and if we're going to have a max value
we should also have a minimum value
so let's pop in minimum
we'll go ahead and run this
and you're starting to see something
that would be generated like say an r
where you're starting to get your
different statistics we have a median
value of 3 max value of 7 and a minimum
value of 0. and what it does when it
hits these null values if there is no
values in there because we could still
do that we could actually you know what
let's go up here and do
let's pick this one where we multiplied
let's go s7
equals
i'm going to print the s7 just so i keep
it nice and uniform so i still have my
s7 down there and run it
and then i want to take the s7
because s7 now has null values and an
infinity value and let's see what
happens
this is going to be interesting because
i want to see what it is with infinity
and we end up with a median of 6 maximum
of 27 and minimum of 0. which is correct
it drops those values so when it gets to
there and it doesn't know what to do
with them it just drops those values and
then it computes it on the remaining
data on there so it's important to know
when you're making these computations
you're looking at min and max and median
you're not going to know that there's no
values unless you double check your data
for the null values it's a very
important thing to note on there so just
a real quick
review on there we've done our created
our pd series and we've gone ahead and
done addition subtraction multiplication
division all those are three letters so
sub min div add
and then we looked at median maximum and
minimum so we're going to go ahead and
jump into the next big topic which is to
create a data frame
so now we're going to go from series and
we're going to create a number of series
and bundle them together to make a data
frame
there we go cell type markdown let me go
ahead and run that so we have a nice
title on there it's always good to have
a good title all right so our first data
frame we'll jump in with some stuff that
looks a little complicated we'll break
it down first i'm going to create some
dates
and you know what let's just go ahead
and do this i want you to see what that
looks like what i'm creating here i've
created a series of dates pd date range
and we're going to use these for the
index okay so when you look at this
you'll see that it's just
basically it comes out kind of like a
basic python list or a numpy array
however you want to look at it with our
different dates going down and we've
generated six of them and it's going to
have whatever time it is right now on
your on the thing for the date for the
time that's that time stamp right there
and then you'll see we have 11 19 2008
11 20 11 19 and looking into the future
there so that's all this is is
generating a series of dates that we're
going to use as our index and this is a
pandas command so we have a date range
which is nice that's one of the tools
hidden in there in the pandas that you
can use
and next we're going to use numpy to go
ahead and generate some random numbers
in this case we'll do the
np.random.random in 6 comma 4. you can
look at this as rows and columns as we
move it into the pandas and of course
you could reshape this if you had those
backwards on your data but we want the 6
to match the rows and we have 6 periods
so our indexes should match along with
the rows on there and then you know
before we do the next one let's go ahead
and just print out our numpy arrays and
see what that looks like here we have it
one two three four by one two three four
five six four by six
so it's a nice little setup on there and
since working with data frames can be
very visual let's give our columns we
have four columns and we're going to
give them names a b c and d
so now we have columns on there also and
then let's put this all together in a
data frame and we can actually you know
what let's do this since i did it with
everything else let's go ahead and do
columns and you can see there's our
columns on there
and we'll go ahead and do df1
equals
pandas dot
data frame and note that the d and the f
are capitalized series it was just the s
and i always highlight this because you
don't know how many times these things
get retyped when you forget what's
capitalized on there it's a minor thing
you'll pick it up right away if you do a
lot of it and the first thing we want to
do is we want to go ahead and take our
numpy array because that's what we're
going to create our data frame off of is
the numpy array and then we want our
index equal to our dates so there's our
index in there and then we also have
columns equals columns
and then finally let's see what that
looks like
remember we had all the different data
that just looked like a jumble of data
we have our column names and everything
else our numpy array kind of just a
jumble array over there four by six you
could sort of read it but look how nice
this looks i mean this is you come into
a board meeting you're working with your
shareholders
this is pretty readable this is you know
this is our date this is our a b c d
whatever it is maybe it's one of these
dates has your leads
closures lost leads total dollar made
you know whatever it is fits in a
business maybe it's measurements on some
scientific equipment whether searching
material you know where this is like
higher the temperature low of the day
humidity of the date whatever it is so
you can see that we can really create a
nice clear chart and it looks just like
a spreadsheet you know we have our rows
and we have our columns and we have our
data in there now this one i use all the
time if we're going to create we can
create it like you saw here with our
numpy array very easy to do that and
reshape it you can also create it with a
dictionary array so here we have some
data let me just go down a notch so you
can see all the data on there we have an
animal in this case cat cat snake dog
dog cat snake cat dog we have the age so
we have an array of ages we have the
number of visits and the priority was it
a high priority yes
no
and then we're going to take that we're
going to create some labels we have a b
c d e f g h i and what i want you to
notice on this is we have a title animal
and then we have basically a python list
and these lists they don't necessarily
have to be equal because we can have
non-data you know np.nand numpy array
null value but we want to go ahead and
create labels that are equal to the
number in the list so a
the first cat b the second cat c the
snake d the dog and so on so we'll go
ahead and create our labels which we're
going to use as an index
and we'll call this df let's do it this
way we'll call this df2
equals pd for panda's
data
frame and then we have our data just
like we did before and then we have our
index equals
labels
and if we're going to go from there
let's go ahead and print it out so we
can see what that looks like df2 so
let's go ahead and run that another
again you have a nice very clean chart
to look at we've gone from this mess of
data here to what looks like a very
organized spreadsheet very visual and
easy to read
animal age visits priority and then a
through j cats and all you different
animals so on and so on and then when
you do programming a lot of times it's
important to know what the data types
are so we can simply do df2
d-types
and if we run that we can see that our
animal
is an object because it's just a string
but it comes in as an object age is a
float64 integer 64 and then priority
again is just an object
and exploring this this one's very
popular let's go df2
[Music]
head
and if we print that out the df2 head
returns the first five and we can change
this you don't have to do five you might
want to just look at the top two maybe
you want to look at
let's see let's do six so maybe we'll
look at just the top six in the database
in your data frame
and you can actually this creates
another data frame so i could have a df3
equal to df2 and this now takes the df2
and just the first six values
so if we do df3
run get the same answer
and if we do it the head of the data we
can also do the tail it's the same thing
df tail you can look at the last
we'll just do the tail which by default
does five the last five and of course
you can just look at the last three of
those real quick just to see what's at
the end of the data and this is i used
to tell i love doing the tail of one
because i'll have like the index or
something like that and it will just
show me the last whatever the last entry
was looking at stock values and i might
want to look at just the last five days
of the stock values i can do that with
the data frame tail
and some other key things to look up
are the index so we can do df2.index
and i want you to notice that this isn't
a call function so if i put the brackets
on the end it'll give me an error
because index is not callable it's just
an object in there
so we do
df2.index there's also columns
so we can go ahead and let's do a let's
print this
remember the first one is not going to
show unless i
print it and then df2 column so now we
can see we have our indexes
and we have our columns listed here
df2.columns animal age visits priority
it tells you what kind of object it is
or what kind of data type it is and
they're both object
and then finally df2 dot
values and again there's no brackets on
the end of df2.values
because this is an actual object it's
not a callable function so we'll go
ahead and run that
and it creates just displays a nice
array a very easy way to convert this
back to a numpy array basically so
before i go into the next section let's
just take a quick look at what we
covered so far with the data frame we
came up here we created our data frame
we did it from a numpy array first
setting the columns and the index the
index is setting it up is the same as
when we set up the series so that should
look very familiar so is the whole
format the numpy array the index dates
and the columns columns and remember in
our numpy array we're looking at row
comma column so six rows four columns is
how that reads in the data frame and we
went ahead and also did that from a
dictionary in this case animal was the
column name with all the date data
underneath that column and then age with
that data visits that data priority that
data and then of course we added our
labels in there for our index so there's
no difference in there but it
automatically pulled the column names
important to know when you're dealing
with a data frame and importing a data
frame this way
and then we did looking up d type we
looked at head and tail looking at your
data really quick
we also did index and columns and values
and note these don't have the brackets
on the end
so the next thing we want to do is go
ahead since we're dealing with data
science is we want to go and describe
the data so we have
df2.described to do that and we're going
to manipulate it in just a minute but
let's just see what this generates
and you can see right here we have age
and visits
so looking at our data from up above let
me just go all the way up here
animal age visits priority
and it does a nice job generating your
age versus visits which has all the data
you have your account your means your
standard deviation your minimum value
25 or in this group 50 75 and your
maximum value so this look familiar as a
data science setup with your describe
for a quick look at your data frame data
so let's start manipulating this data
frame moving stuff around and we'll
start with transposing and it is simply
capital t for transpose
and when we run that it flips the
columns and the indexes so now the
indexes are all column names and the
columns are all indexes animal age
visits priority
so if we had come in here with our data
shaped wrong up above where we had a 4x6
we can quickly just swap it if we had it
backwards not a big deal and we can also
sort our data something that you can't
do which is more difficult to do with a
lot of other packages in the data frame
it's really easy to do take our data
frame df2 and we're going to sort
underscore values
buy equals age and so when we run this
you'll see the default is ascending so
we have 0.52 2.53 and everything else is
organized so if you look at your indexes
they've been moved around because each
index moves a whole row not just the one
piece of data is not being sorted so
very quick way to sort by age our
different data in the data frame and in
addition to sorting it we can also slice
the data frame so i could do df2 and
this should look familiar from earlier
we'll just do one
to three so we're going to pull out oops
it does help if i use the df instead of
just d and we're going to pull up just
between one and three so we have no 0
which is a we have b which is 2 or b
which is 1 and c which is 2. so 1 2 and
then it does not include 3 which is the
standard in python and we can even do
something like this we can combine them
which is always fun because remember
this returns a data frame so if i take
df2 dot
sort
values and we'll do by
equals age this is just kind of fun and
then i'm going to slice it
there we go double check my typing and
run it
and now you should see fa because fa are
now 1 and 2 on there
so you can very quickly create a whole
string on here which narrows it you know
that you can sort it then slice it and
do all kinds of fun things with your
data frame we'll just go back to the
original one run there we go and if we
can slice it by row we can also query
the data frame so we can do df2 and this
is a little different because i'm going
to create an array within an array and
in this case we're going to look at oh
let's do
age
comma
visits
so look at the different format in here
we have one to three so we've done this
by slicing by an integer value and then
on here i've done df2 age comma visits
in an array and when i run this
you can see that we get just these two
columns on here we get age and visits so
it's a quick way to select just two
columns or select number of columns
you're working with
and if you stop there we did the slicing
almost identical to slice is i location
which uses the integer location one
comma three
there's a push in pandas to move to this
particular setup
instead of doing just a regular slice
and that's because this can be confusing
when we slice one to three and then we
select agent visits
so there is a push to go ahead and move
to an i location which does the same
thing you can see here bc it's the same
as up above there's also copy command so
we can do df3 equals df2 copy
we're just going to create a straight
copy of it
and of course if we do df3
it'll be the same as the df2 on there so
df3 equals df2.copy
and then let's do df3 dot is null so
we're looking for null values
and this will return a nice map and
you'll see that everything is false
except when you go up here under the cat
or h they had a null there and so if we
go to have a couple up here also
underneath of let's see the dog okay
there's a bunch of nulls in here there's
d up here so let's look at d down here
and you'll see false true there it is
there's our null value so we can create
a quick chart of null values you can use
this to do other things we can leverage
that null value to maybe take an average
or something and fill those null spaces
with data and we can also modify the
location so here's our df3
location
and notice this is location not i
location eye location has i for integer
location uses the
in this case the variables on the left
and what we can do on here and we'll go
and just set this equal to
one
five
and then let's um i'll pick a spot
let's go back up here where we had let's
do f
a just let's see what are we looking at
oh here we go let's do f and h
and up here f is set to age of 2.0 and
we find out that that's incorrect data
so we go ahead and switch to df3
equal and then we're going to print out
our df3
and if we go to f and age it is now 1.5
so we're just changing the value in the
df3 and this is changing the actual data
frame remember a lot of our stuff we do
a slice
and like it returns another data frame
this changes the actual data frame and
that value in the data frame
so we've covered location and eye
location is null making a copy here's
our eye location which is equivalent of
a slice and also selecting columns
so now we want to dive just take a
little detour here and let's look at df3
means
and this is kind of nice because you can
do this you can either do this by as you
can select a single column here by the
way you can just add the column
selection right here like we did before
so we could have age
look up the mean that just creates a
series if i run that there's our age
but if i take that out instead of
selecting it we can do the whole setup
it has age and visits so why doesn't it
have priority or animal
well those are not integers so it's
really hard
they're non-numerical values so what is
the average i guess you could do a
histogram which probably we'll look at
that later on but the only two things we
can really look at is age and visits and
we have the average or the mean on the
age is 3.375
and the mean on visits is 1.9
and let's do df3
visits we'll go and steal the visits
again
and remember all those different
functions we looked at for a series well
we can do those here we can do the sum
so if we run that we'll see that these
sum up to 19
we could also look up minimum if you
remember that from before the minimum is
one
max
so all that functionality is here i'll
just go back to summing it up and adding
it all together
so real quick we've shown you how to
take the series operations and put them
into the data frame and then we can
actually this is interesting one we can
just do df3 sum run and you'll see the
different summations on there
it just combines them i like the way it
just combines the strings on there for
priority and animal we've looked at is
null we've also looked at copying along
with the different slices which we
talked about earlier so let's talk about
strings let's dive into the string setup
on there and let's go ahead and create a
string series string equals pd series
and we just put it right in there we
have a c d a a b a c a popped in a null
value
cow and al i don't know why they picked
cal and al in the background someone
must like those animals and of course we
can just do string if we run that you'll
see
leave the r out we'll get an error but
if we put it in there you'll see that we
have a simple series 0 a 1 c 2 d and it
automatically indexes it 0 to eight
and then we can go string dot lower so
when we're talking about our data frame
in this case or our data series string
in this case we use the string
function str and we're gonna make it
lower and if we go ahead and put the
brackets on there and you'll see that
we've gone from capital a capital c so
on to abc and baca cba cow al they were
all lower case already and of course if
you want to go lower you can also do
upper we'll go ahead and run that and
you can see we now have a c d a a baca
everything's capitalized except for the
null value which is still null alright
so we looked at a few basic string you
can see that string functions upper and
lower we're going to jump into a very
important topic i'm even going to give
it its own
header on here because it's such an
important topic what do you do with
missing values
panda has some great tools for that so
we'll dive into those we'll call we'll
work with df4 and if you remember the df
copy from above we're just going to make
a copy of df3 and let's just take a
quick look at the data we're working
with oops df3 forgot the three on there
there we go
so here we have our cats snakes and dogs
hopefully not all in the same container
because that would be just probably mean
to all of them so we made a copy we're
going to be working with df4 and the
reason we made a copy is we want to go
ahead and fill the data and we just
simply do fill in a and then we're going
to give it the value we want to put in
there we'll give it the value 4. so i
can run in here and you'll see now that
df4
now has where the n a was is filled with
a value of 4. same thing down here
a lot of times we'll compute the mean
first so i might do a mean
age
equals df4
and then we want to go ahead and do age
and dot mean
and then i'll do something like this df4
i only want to select the age and i want
to fill that
with the mean
h
and i run in there and you'll see that
our df4h now has the means in there just
a quick way of showing you how you can
combine these let me go back to our
original one there we go and run that
and keeping with good practices df5
equals df three dot copy
and we'll print our df5 which should be
the original one
and then on the df5 we can now drop our
missing data
i'm going to simply drop in a and we're
going to use how equals any so i'm going
to drop any row that has missing data in
it and you'll see we had d here with
missing data and h and then let's go
ahead and see what df5 looks like when
we do that
there we go and there it is d is gone
and so is h so we create a new data
frame off of this missing those values
now if you have a lot of data dropping
values is a good way to take care of it
because you don't miss some data if you
have not a whole lot of data you're
working with like the iris data set or
something like that or something small
you want to start trying to find a way
to fill that data in so you don't lose
your computational power of the data you
got
so just a quick look at processing null
values
or missing values you can fill them
usually with the means some people use
medium or the mode there's different
ways you can fill it one way is means
and we can also just drop those rows
those are the two main things we do with
missing data
here we go uh we're going to cover next
this is i'd so love data frames for this
file operations
it saved me so much time because they
have so many different tools for
bringing data in and saving data
so we're looking at the data frame file
operations it's really streamlined i
don't know how many times they'll go on
to
different data downloads and they'll
have panda download standard on there
just because it's so widely used
so let's start with the most common file
is a csv so we have df3 to csv or animal
and let me just show you where the
folder is going into
right now i have some untitled and a few
things in here but nothing labeled
animal so we go ahead and run this
and this is now saved the animal to
my hard drive and you can now see the
animal folder up here and if i uh let's
do edit with a notepad oh let's open up
with just a regular notepad there we go
or wordpad if i open that up you can see
it's comma separated our titles they
don't have an index on the categories on
the top and the index comma then all the
different data is separated by commas
standard csv file on there and if we're
going to send it to csv and notice the
format is dot underscore csv
and it's just the name of the file we're
sending it to you can also put the
complete path by default it's going to
go whatever the active directory this
program is running on that's why those
other folders are in there so we have
our df3 to csv and then if we're going
to put it in there we want to also get
it back out and we'll call this one df
underscore animal equals pd read
underscore csv
i always have to remember is 2
underscore csv and read underscore csv i
always want to do like a capital in
there and not the underscore we're going
in here again it's the active directory
so if i now do print out my df animal
and let's just do the ahead we only want
to look at the first three lines so if
we go ahead and run this
we'll see the first three lines and they
should match up here what we saved to
our csv
so very easy to save and import from our
csv files on here
and it turns out df3
also has a 2 xl they actually have a lot
of different formats but you know old
school
excel was real popular for so long still
is we can go ahead and save it as animal
dot xlsx we're going to call the sheet
named sheet 1
and then i can also do df we'll call it
animal 2
animal 2 and this one's going to come
from in the same format on here there we
go so we still have our animal xlsx
the sheet 1 that's where it's coming
from index columns equals none so we're
not going to we're going to suppress the
indexing on the columns n a values and
it'll just assign that 0 1 up on your
indexes so if it says index columns
equals none that's what it does and then
we've added null values because there's
no values in here and we want to just
make sure that they're marked as n a
and we'll go ahead and just print out
the animal animal two there we go and
let's run that let's make this let's
just do the whole thing so we'll go
ahead and run that and it probably
doesn't help that i completely forgot
the read
so animal 2 equals pd.read
excel there we go excel so now we go
ahead and run it
and what we expect is happening here we
have the same data frame on here and if
i flick back to my folder you can now
see that we have the animal one of these
is in excel and one of these is a csv on
here and so there's our two file types
on there and they have other formats
these are just the two most common ones
used and i don't know how many times
i've had stuff from excel i need to pull
out if you've ever played with excel
it's a nightmare in the back end because
of the way they do the
indexing so this just makes it quick and
easy to pull in an excel spreadsheet so
we looked at two different ways to bring
data in and save it to files we've
looked at all kinds of different ways of
manipulating our data set and slicing it
and creating it for our data frame let's
get in there for your visualization
always a big thing at the end because
one it lets you check to see what you
did make sure it looks right and then
also if you're going to show somebody
else it makes it very clear what's going
on if they see something visual so this
is where a really important part of data
science is so let's go ahead and bring
in our tools we're going to do import
numpy as np we want to make sure we have
our amber sign matt plot library inline
this just lets jupiter know that we're
going to print it on this page if you're
using a different ide you don't really
necessarily need that but this does help
it displays correctly in jupyter
notebook and if you remember for earlier
we could create a uh we're gonna call it
ts we're gonna create a pandas which are
cute cuddly creatures versus a pandem
short for pandemonium no so we have ts
equals pd series and we're just gonna
create a random
setup of 50. we'll do an index we'll set
it equal to the panda's date range today
periods equals 50 so the 50 should match
and i want you to notice something here
i did not import the map plot library
why because it's already in there pandas
already has its built-in connection and
interface with matplot library so you
don't have to import it
and we'll go ahead and do ts
equals ts dot
cumulative sum we're gonna do the
cumulative sum so a little reformatting
there and we'll go ahead and plot it and
let's take a look at what that looks
like
so we have a nice graph here we have the
dates on the bottom we set this up so we
have a nice range between in this case
minus four to looks like about two maybe
or one minus four and one
so what we've done here we plotted a
basic series just a single row of data
and we've set indexes on there but we
can also do the whole data frame on
there and let's see what that looks like
so first let's go ahead and create the
data frame we have here random numbers
so we're going to do 50 by 4 and then
we'll go ahead and create columns a b x
and y
just because we can index is the
ts.index on there so we're going to use
the same index as before
just to keep it nice and uniform we've
already generated the dates to go with
it and then we can do just like we did
with the series
we can also do with the data frame
df equals df cumulative sum
so we're going to sum the whole data
frame and then we'll do simply df plot
and let's put that in and let's go ahead
and run this and look how easy and quick
that was to generate a nice graph with
all the different data on there so we
have our shared index we have the shared
columns and then we have the different
data from each one that we can easily
look at and compare so very quick way of
displaying data you can imagine if you
were working in oh i think i mentioned
stock earlier because i've been doing
some analysis of stock lately so you'd
have your date down here and then you
would have stock a stock b stock x y
whatever it is and you can put them all
in one chart and see how they
what they look like next to each other
and this isn't too far off from what
some of those graphs look like and this
is just randomly generated so stock has
a lot of randomness in it which is one
of the reasons i actually play with it
for doing some of my models on for
testing them out
now there are a lot of features in
pandas so we're going to show you one
more thing on here there are some of the
things like i didn't go too deep we
looked at the top two for importing data
from a csv and from an excel spreadsheet
showed you how to quickly plot the data
there's more settings in there you can
do
we're going to do one more thing down
here and this is kind of a fun one
changes to a markdown and run that
so how would you remove repeated data
using pandas
and this is where you have a data set
that comes in and maybe it's feeding
from one location and instead of noting
that it's repeated the date like oh
let's go back to stocks that's a good
visual we have this docs from the 23rd
and it adds another row and it's the
same row it's importing the 23rd again
and again so now you have that data
repeated three times and you need to go
back and figure out how to get rid of it
how do you track that down
so let's start by creating a quick
database or data frame not a database i
keep saying databases a data frame and
we'll just make this data frame has
using our dictionary going in this data
frame only has one data series in it
which is fine so if we do df to print it
out you'll see a one two two two two
four five four five six seven so on so
how would you remove that well there is
a neat feature in data frames called
shift
along with another feature that lets us
select just certain date information and
we'll go with
the location function put that in
brackets remember that from above
location and then in the location let me
just spread this out a little bit so
it's really easy to read in fact i'm
going to go upscale on that since we're
doing some a little bit more complicated
here
what you can see on this on the location
is i have
dfa.shift so this is going to shift up 1
by default you can actually change this
to two or three you can even do a minus
one and it shifts the other way but it's
going to shift up by one by default
that's going to say if that does not
equal
df of a
then we want that and if you look down
here we had one two two two two two when
we run this logic on here and we do the
shift
it now gets rid of all the duplicates so
we went from one two two two two four
four five whatever it was here it is one
two two two four four four five five
five six six six to one two four five
six seven eight and you'll see on the
index it just deletes them out of there
so the index stays the same obviously
you don't want the dates to change if
you're working with an index dated setup
so it just deletes those duplicates out
of there this is just a quick way to
introduce you to one the fact that you
can add logic gates into here and two
the eye location
allows you to use shift so there's the
shift function and then the i location
selects that based on true or false
wow so we've actually covered a lot
today in pandas we've really covered
into the basics of selecting your
different series out of your column out
of your data frame
how to index rows how to slice how to
plot
hopefully you'll take this beyond that
and start combining these different
things and you can create long strings
and really explore your data generate
some nice graphs if you're in jupiter
notebook it's a great demo to show
others
and i didn't know this about jupiter
notebook you can do this in jupyter
notebook and then you can download and i
always i never really looked too closely
at all the downloads
but you downloaded as an html and post
it to your blog so it's got a neat
feature in there but any of this is
really powerful tool all of this is
really powerful tools for doing your
data science today we're going to study
the mat plot library and the python code
so what's in it for you what is matte
plot library types of plots plotting
graphs and sub graphs adding a graph
inside a graph graph parameters title
label legend
line graphs line types color and
transparency canvas grid and axis range
2d plots scatter step bar fill between
radar chart histogram contour image 3d
surface image and then we'll hit a
practice example pie chart
so let's start with what is matte plot
library map plot library is an open
source drawing library which supports
rich drawing types it is used to draw 2d
and 3d graphics
and there are so many packages in the
matplot library we're going to cover the
basics and there are so many packages
that sit on top of the maplight library
that we can't even cover them all today
but we'll hit the main one so you have a
good understanding of what the matplot
library is and what the basics can do
you can understand your data easily by
visualizing it with the help of matplot
library you can generate plots
histograms bar charts and many other
charts with just a few lines of code and
here we have some basic types of plots
you can see here that we'll go into we
have the bar chart the histogram
boy i use a lot of histograms in my
stuff scatter plot line chart pie chart
and area graph
let's start plotting them and to do this
i'm going to be using jupiter notebook
you can use any of your python
interfaces for programming or scripting
and running it of course we here really
like the jupyter notebook for doing
basic a lot of basic stuff because it's
so visual and in our jupyter notebook
which opens up in this case i'm using
google chrome you can go up here to new
and we'll create a new python 3 and set
that up
if you're not familiar with jupyter
notebook we do have a tutorial that
covers some of the basics of that and
you'll look at any of our tutorials i
usually cover a number of them showing
how to set up jupiter and anaconda i
myself use jupiter through anaconda in
fact let's go ahead and open that up and
just take a look at this see what that
looks like you can see your anaconda
navigator if you install it it will
automatically install the jupiter
notebook and that also installs a lot of
other things i know some people like the
qt console for doing python or spyder
i've never used them i actually use
notepad plus plus as one of my editors
and then i use the jupiter notebook a
lot because it's so easy to have a
visual while i'm programming and even
simple script in python i'll take it
from the jupyter notebook and then do a
save as you can always go under file and
you can download as a python program so
that will download it as an actual
python versus the ipython that this
saves it as
so let's go ahead and dive in and see we
got going here and let's go ahead and
put matplot library tutorial and i'm
going to turn this cell into a mark down
so it doesn't actually run it
you can see it has a nice little title
there that's all jupiter notebook
and then from matplot library
let's import
pi lab
back one and then let's go ahead and
just print
we'll go pi lab
and the version let's go ahead and run
this so we're going to import our pi lab
module from the matplot library and we
find out that we're in version 1.15.1
always important to note the version
you're in probably i was reading an
article that said the number one thing
that python programmers struggle with is
remembering what version they're working
in and making sure that they're going
from one platform to the other with the
same version and if we're gonna graph
things i think we need some data to
graph so we're going to import numpy as
np
now if you're not familiar with numpy
definitely go back and check out our
numpy tutorial there's so many different
things you can do with it dealing with
reshaping the data and creating the data
we're just going to use it to create
some data for us and there is a lot of
ways to create data but we're going to
use the np.line space
so we're going to create a numpy array
and the way you read this is we're going
to create numbers between 0 and 10 and
we're going to create 25 of these
numbers so we're just going to divide
that equally up between 0 and 10. and if
we have x coordinates we should probably
have some y coordinates and we'll do
something simple like x times x
plus 2. and let's just take a look we're
going to print x and print
y
let me go ahead and run this
and let's see what we got going on here
so we have our x coordinates which is 0
0.4 0.83 etc and you can look at this as
an xy plot so we have 0 we have 2. we
have
0.416 we have 2.17
and just as a quick reminder we're going
to do print np array x comma y dot
reshape 25 comma 2. and the reason i
want to do this is i want to show you
something here a lot of times a program
returns x comma y and it's an array of x
comma y x comma y x comma y
and so when you're working with the pi
plot
you have to separate it out and reshape
it so if i start off with pairs like
this i can reshape them if i know
there's 25 pairs in there i can switch
the 2 and the 25 and this is kind of
goofy but we'll do it anyways reshape so
i'm going to reshape my 25 by 2 back to
2 by 25
and if i run that you'll see i end up
with the same output as the x y the two
different arrays in here
and this is important that we want x and
y separate
again that's all numpy stuff but it's
important to understand that this is a
format that matplot library works with
it works with an array of x's and they
should match your array of y's so each
one has 25 different entities in it
and then for our basic plotting of this
data it only takes one command to draw
graph of this data and so we use our
from up here where we imported pi lab we
take our pi lab and the keynote under
there is plot for plotting a line and
then we want our x coordinates and our y
coordinates and we'll throw in r and the
r simply means red so we're going to
draw the line in red let me go and run
that you can actually switch this around
if you wanted to do different there's b
for blue we have a lot of fun yellow
hard to see yellow there we go but we'll
go ahead and stick with red
run
and when you're doing presentations with
these try to be consistent you know if
the business and the shareholders send
you a
spreadsheet and they have losses in red
use red for losses in your graph
try to be consistent use green for
profit for money you don't have to
necessarily use green but whatever
they're using whatever the company is
using try to mirror that that way people
aren't going to be confused if you
switch your data around every time one
graph has red for loss and one graph has
blue for loss it gets really confusing
so make sure you're consistent in your
graphs and your coloring and something
to know because we're going to cover
this in a minute this is your canvas
size so we have a canvas here and what
we're going to do next is we're going to
look at sub graphs okay
so let's take our pi lab and create a
sub plot
and one of the things also to know when
we're working with the
matplot library i'm not setting when i
do this this is my drawing canvas the pi
lab so once i've imported the pi lab i'm
drawing my images on there very
important to know and with the subplot
we're going to give it some different
values and we're going to represent by
rows columns and indexes
and let's do one two one so it's going
to be the first row
second column and the index is like you
can stack your graphs and things like
that we don't worry too much about
indexes but rows and columns we want to
go ahead and use row one and column two
and if we're going to have one object we
should probably have two but before we
do that we have to plot data onto the
subplot so the order is very important
and we're going to stick with our x
comma y
and let's do this we're going to add in
a third parameter here remember we did
red we're going to add shorthand dash
dash for dashed lines so this plots the
data into row one column two and if
we're going to do that let's do another
one
pilab.subplot and if we're going to do
row one let's do
column two and index two
and this time we're going to add g for
green and this denotes a style and if
we're going to set up our pi lab subplot
there we go by lab we've got to go ahead
and plot that pi
lab plot
and instead of x y we want y comma x
oops i messed up this is in the wrong
spot there we go we'll move that down
here real quick because that goes in the
plot part so the subplot tells it the
row column and index and the pi plot
tells it what data in this case we
switched them and the color and then the
style shorthand now let's go ahead and
run that
and you'll see it takes this canvas
splits it in two and now we have two
different graphs and we have the red one
with dashed lines and we have the green
one which is has a little stars going up
and if we take this and let's just um
just for fun let's change this and run
that with an index of one it puts them
both on the same index and also gives me
a warning because it's a strange way of
doing two subplots there's this
depreciated there's another way to do it
but most people just ignore that warning
because it's not going to go away
anytime soon now that's using the same
setup what happens if we do instead of
this let's change the column on here and
find out what happens
and if we do the column
it didn't really like that on the setup
it just disappears so let's keep our
column as two and let's change the row
on the second one to two
and run that
and you'll see again it kind of squishes
everything together and causes some
issues so let's take the index so these
need a unique index and you can see here
where i made some changes i said row two
and look what happens when i change to
column two so i now have row two column
two index two i squished it up here so
you could put another graph underneath
is what that does there's all kinds of
different things you really have to just
play with these numbers till you get a
handle on them because
you know we have to repeat it 164 times
according to cambridge university if
it's completely new to you and you can
see right here where we go three
run there we go but you can see it takes
a little bit sometimes to play with
these and get the numbers right
hopefully hit the wrong one that's why
let's go three there three there run
there we go now it's overlapping so i
have this doubled over here on the right
for now we'll just go ahead and leave
this with the
where we have column and row two and the
two different indexes so they appear
nice and neatly side by side
and then as we just saw as we were
flashing through them we can put them on
top of each other
and let me just highlight that and copy
it down here
paste it down there and here we have one
two one and then we'll do one two one
also for this one and that puts the two
subplots directly on top of each other
gives us that warning and you can see we
now have two different sets of data
graphed on top of each other and you can
also see how it did the indexes since
one of them is from 0 to 10 that's the
green one on the x-axis and the other
one is from 0 to 10 on the y-axis so it
took the greatest value of either one
and then used those as a shared value
so let's
next look at operator description and
we'll go ahead and turn this cell into a
markdown and run that so it looks nice
so fig and you remember i talked about
the canvas earlier i briefly mentioned
it we're going to look a little bit more
at the canvas later on but that's what
the figure is fit we're going to add
axes so we're going to initialize the
subplot add the subplot
in rows and columns and all kinds of
different things with this you can do
let's look at that code and see exactly
what's going on and i want you to notice
that there's fig which is the actual
canvas in the matplot library and ax is
commonly used to refer to the subplots
so we're creating subplots you'll see ax
equals plt subplot
earlier we did the pi lab so let's go
ahead and import pi plot from matplot
library and we're going to do it as plt
you'll see that a lot that's really the
standard in the industry is to call it
plt just like pandas as pd and numpy
array as np certainly you can import it
as whatever you want but i would stick
to the standards and we're going to do
the same graph as we did above
with the pi lab but with the plt so if
it looks familiar there's reason we're
doing this because we want to show you
how the figure part works and working
with the canvas goes but we're going to
do the same plot as we did before and
we'll call it fig and we're going to set
that equal to plot figure so there's our
figure or canvas on there and let's
create a variable called axes and we're
going to set that equal to fig dot add
axes
and in this we're going to control the
left right the width the height of the
canvas from zero to one
and so we can go ahead and i'm just
going to put some stuff in there i got
point five point one point eight point
eight so when you're looking at this
this is a zero to one or you could say
fifty percent ten percent eighty eighty
percent but it's a control it's going to
control your left and your right along
with the width and the height so the
width and the height we're gonna use
eighty percent and we're gonna have like
a little indent on the left and the
right and this should look familiar from
above x's dot plot
x comma y
and then let's give it a color how about
red since we're recreating the same
graph let's keep it uniform oops and it
helps if i use a axis instead of ax es i
don't know where that came from but this
looks identical to the one we had up
above so here's our axis plot x comma y
of red
same graph same setup but this time
we've added a variable equal to the
figure dot add axes so our plot figure
is our canvas our axis is what we're
working in and then our axis.plot x
comma y
and again we can draw sub graphs let me
put that down here
just like we did before and a little
different temptation here we're going to
fig comma
axes equal
plt.subplots
and in here it's going to be the number
of rows
we're going to do one row
and columns equals two so if you
remember before that's what we did we
had one row with two different graphs on
it we're going to do the same thing but
know how we did this here's our figure
our canvas and our axes we're going to
create actually two different axes we're
going to create row one column two and
so axis is an array of information so we
can simply do
four
let's do x in axes
this will look familiar x dot plot we're
going to do x comma y we'll go ahead and
make a red
keep everything looking the same
remember nice uniform graphs everything
looks the same and if we go ahead and
run this
you'll see we get two nice side-by-side
graphs so just as we had before the same
look the same setup
and just for fun let's change in columns
to three we'll run that and now you see
we'll have three on there and let's see
if we make it a little bit more
interesting we'll do in rows equals to
two and you can see down here we're
going to get an attribute eric just
trying to scrunch everything together
so it does have a limit how much stuff
you can put in one small space that's
important to know you can fix that by
changing the canvas size which we'll
look at in just a minute and there's
other ways to change it on here but here
we go we can do in rows two and columns
equals one you can see two nice images
right above each other we'll go back to
the original one row two columns side by
side left to right
and
we can also
draw a picture
or graph
inside another graph
that's kind of a fun thing to do it's
important to note that we can layer our
stuff on top of each other which makes
for a really nice presentation
so let's start by uh fig let's create
another figure so we're going to start
over again with our canvas we set that
equal to plt.figure
so there's our new canvas and let's do
axes we'll call it axes one and two axis
one equals fig dot add axes remember
this from earlier
and
this here similar numbers we used before
saying how big this axis is this figure
in the axis is so this is going to be
the big
axes and let's do axes 2 equals
another figure at axes and then
0.2.5.4.3
and if we're going to do this they need
data on them so let's go ahead and plot
some data on our axes so axes1 dot plot
and we'll make this simply x comma y
comma make it red and then let's go
axes2 dot plot and let's reverse them y
comma x comma green there we go doing
what i told you not to do you shouldn't
be swapping axes around and plotting
your data in five different directions
because it's confusing let's go ahead
and run this and see what this looks
like and then let's talk a little bit
about this we talked about the 0.2.5.4.3
and let me just grab the annotation for
that that's left right width and height
so we have in here that this is going to
be left right so here's our left is
point one in point five and we you know
what let's just play with this a little
bit what happens when i change this to
point one moves it way over to the left
so there's our point one so we can make
this point four run that there we go so
you can see how you can move it around
the branches on here 0.2
0.5 is the
left so that's our right so see what
happens when we do point oh let's make
this point one
that actually is they had it down at
left right i thought this was wrong it's
actually how far from the bottom let me
switch that on here bottom there we go
so we had here on this we can go ahead
and put that back to 0.5 and run that
and this is 0.3 let's make this 0.3 also
and that is the width and then of course
there's the height we can make that
really tiny actually let's do 0.2
let's run that and you can see it
changes the height on there we make it
even smaller 0.2 by 8.2 and as you can
see you can get stuck playing with this
to make it look just right it could
sometimes take a little bit
certainly once you have the settings if
you're doing a presentation you try to
keep it uniform unless it doesn't make
sense for the graph you're working on
try to keep the same colors the same
position and the same look and feel and
i mentioned earlier we can adjust the
canvas sides so this is from earlier i
just copied it down below we're going to
re-plot the same data we've been looking
at
and what we can do is we can change the
figure size to 16 by nine let me run
that and show you what that looks like
so it fills the whole screen and then if
you are normally when you're working on
the screen you don't worry too much
about this but we can set the dpi to 300
run that
there it goes this is your dots per inch
and if you are doing an output of this
and you're printing a hard copy you want
the higher quality i would suggest
nothing under 300 if it's a professional
print you might get a little less than
that but whenever i'm doing professional
graphics and printing them out on
something 300 dots per inch is kind of
the minimal on there you can go a lot
higher too but keep in mind the higher
you get the more memory it takes the
more lag time and the more resources you
use so usually 300 is a good
solid number to use your dots per inch
and you can see it drills a nice it
draws a nice large canvas here which is
16 by nine and then the dpi is 300 on
here so it's a little higher quality and
just out of curiosity i wonder how long
it takes to draw something double that
size 600 and you can see here where at
600 dpi it's going to take a while there
it goes just because it's utilizing a
lot more graphics on there and let me
just go back to the 300 now we'll
actually do let's do a 100 you're not
going to see a difference on this
because it is web based graphics are
pretty low
and up here you saw i did this with the
plot figure this works the same if i do
figure axes subplot figure size and then
we'll go ahead and do axes
plot
x comma y comma we'll stick to red
let's go ahead and run this and you
should get almost the same thing here
here's our
axis on the subplot on here with the
fixed size and the dpi let me take this
all out let me just remove all that real
quick run it again there we go now we're
back to our original figure and let's
look at some of the other things you can
do with this
one things we do is we can set a title
for the axis so axis set title you'll
see right here since i put this on the
axis it's the main title for the whole
graph
and if you're going to have a title you
should also label so we can label our x
label and we can set our y label in this
case we're just going to call it x and y
keep it nice and uniform and if we run
this you'll see that we've added a nice
x label and y label whoops where'd they
go and it turns out in this environment
that you have to put it before the title
so let me go ahead and put it before the
title and there's our x y and we run
that and of course we can also do upper
size a little bit you can see what's
going on a little better so here we have
x label x if you come down here you'll
see our x label and our y label we can
of course change this to x
label you can change this to y
would be whatever you want on here of
course and our title graph there we go
run so here we have our title graph our
y label and our x label all set up on
our nice little plot and then before we
move on to the next section let's do one
more thing on here we have a thing
called the legend and we're gonna do
we're gonna set our ax legend label one
label two up here it's a format for it
but let's go down here and actually use
it i'm going to do two different plots
we're going to have axes plot x by x
times x squared and x cubed and if i run
this you'll see it puts two nice graphs
on the setup on there but it's nice to
have a legend telling you what's going
on so for the legend we can actually do
axes since we have the two plots legend
and on here we've created an array
and we have y equals x squared y equals
x cubed you can actually put this as
whatever you want those are just strings
and then location two and let's go ahead
and run this and see what that looks
like and you can see it puts a nice
legend on the upper left hand corner
location two we can do location three
and run it and it drops it down to the
bottom
location one i can't remember where
that's at there we go upper right so
each one of these is a number that
refers to the different locations on the
screen zero kind of have to play with
them or look them up to remember where
they're at but they do work it just kind
of moves around depending on where you
want your legend out on there so on this
section we cover the title of the graph
the y labels and legends this is we're
getting into some starting to look
really fancy here so we now have
something we can actually put out you'll
see the title the graph looks a little
fuzzy so i might in a web setup put the
dpi up a couple notches maybe put it at
200 100 might work fine just so you know
something to notice on here when you're
playing with these different things we
had our subplots dpi equals oh let's do
200 to see what that looks like
so you can see now it's a lot clearer
it's also larger so it's a nice little
feature you can throw in there with your
dpi dots per inch
so the next section is let's look at
some graph features we're going to look
at line color transparency size and a
few more things on here and oops i
forgot the main title so we have our
figure and our axes equals our plot and
subplots and i'm going to do a dpi
equals 150 so the graph comes out nice
and large and easy for you to see and
let's go ahead and do three plots on
here we'll do x by x plus one so it's
just going to be a straight line plot
x plus x plus two
and axis dot plot
x x plus three this looks like we're
doing nearest neighbor setup or showing
how it
located data and putting your lines on
there between the nearest neighbors
there we go so it draws a nice little
graph with three lines on it one of the
things we can do is we can control the
alpha on this oops and you can actually
see the when they did these lines it
automatically pulls in different colors
for your setup so there's some automatic
automatic things going on in there and a
lot of times we do that comma r where
we're going to do color equals red
another notation on here let's go ahead
and run this now we have a bright red
line down there and with the matte plot
library you're not limited to red you
can also use the one of many different
color references as you see here with
the pound sign one one five five dd
which just is just blue and we can do
the same thing with another color on
here which turns out to be green i can
just as easily do this green
blue oops there we go blue and run that
and you'll see here we have red blue and
green and what i want to do is i want to
make this we're going to say what's
called the alpha on this and we're going
to set this equal to 0.5
so this is halfway see-through when i
run this and it's almost going to look
pink because you can see through it and
let's change this just a little bit just
to make this kind of fun let's square it
there we go run it so now we have this
nice square that comes up and you can
see when it crosses it because i plotted
these two lines after it and they have
no alpha the red is behind those lines
or in this case pink because we did the
alpha halfway through so let's go ahead
and do this alpha equals 0.5
and oh you know what instead of squaring
it let's take it to the 0.5 power
that'll be kind of interesting to see
what that does we'll just go to keep it
squared there we go and run that and
let's go back and look at this where it
crosses over and the first thing you see
right here is on the blue it's kind of
light blue now you can see how the two
colors add together you get almost a
purple on there so i can clearly see
where the red crosses the blue line and
then the green just blanks it over
because i didn't do any opaqueness no
alpha on there so this is great if you
have lots of data that crosses over and
you need to be able to track those lines
better and we'll go ahead and do this
0.5 and we'll run that oops i did
equals 0.5 let me go ahead and run that
and so you can see right here now you
can easily see the red line how it
crosses the green and the blue down here
and if we want to we can do this as the
default is one solid so we can change
this all to point eight let me just do
that
oops 58 there we go
run
oops i must have hit a wrong button
there let me try that again i
accidentally get rid of a bracket and
let's go ahead and run that
and we come down here and look at this
you can still see where it passes behind
them but the green dominates and the
blue dominates because we're now at
eighty percent instead of fifty percent
when you can do less that's kind of fun
although at some point the lanes kind of
fade
so point five is usually the best
setting on there we have a nice pastel
here at point three and you can easily
see where they cross over and just like
you can play with the colors we can play
with line width and you know let's do
let's try dpi 100 and see what that
looks like on my screen equals 100 and
we'll go ahead and just take our ax plot
let's do four of these lines just you
can see how they look next to each other
real quick here there we go
if i run this they should all appear the
same it automatically does different
colors on there so let's do color equals
blue
i forgot my quotation marks there we go
and we'll go ahead and just make these
all blue just for purposes of being nice
and uniform and then what i want to do
is i want to do the line
width line width equals
0.25 and let's just copy and paste that
down here
let's do equals one
about 1.5
and let's do one let's make this equal
to 2. let's see what that looks like and
we do that you can see it goes from a
very thin line a 0.5 a 1 our 1.5 and 2
which is twice the width of the one and
if we're going to do different sizes we
had different colors we had our alpha
scheme let's take this whole thing here
let's paste it down here and do another
one
but instead of line width let's look at
styles and something to know here you
can actually abbreviate this with lw so
line width can also be point let's just
do everything 0.2 and let's set up a
line style we'll do the first one dashes
and let me just paste that down here
so i'm not doing a lot of extra typing
there we go
take this out so we have our dashed
we can do a dash dot let's do the dash
dot here and a colon here there we go
and there's a lot of different options
we'll look at a few more as we go down
for different ways of highlighting data
but when you look at this we have
everything as a line width of two and
now we have a straight line we have a
dashed line or a dot dash and a dot dot
dot line
and then another thing we can add on
here is we're going to do here's our ax
plot and we did x let's do x plus um
four so it goes right on the top and do
color black line width 1.5 so it's a
smaller line and we're going to take the
line and we're going to set dashes so
look i've changed some of the notation
here for my line and my ax plot so i can
set my line comma equal to x plot and
then i can change the line settings this
way and when i run this let me run that
on here you'll see the 510 1510
creates a series of dashes
that are buried in link link in this
case they alternate between a short dash
and a long dash we can play with these
numbers curiosity always has me what
happens when you play with the numbers
just to see what they look like let's do
this let's paste this down here i'll do
two of these just because they're kind
of fun to play with and let's change
this from 10 to 3
and we're going to change this one from
to
4. and let's run that
and you can see the differences in the
lines oops very a little bit confusing
on there because i forgot to change the
lines are all on top of each other so
let me change that really quick here and
let's run that and now you can see
here's our original dashed line
alternating when i change these numbers
on the second one the very end value to
three you can see now we have the dashes
of five let's see i'm going to guess
this is a dashes of five skip ten dashes
of 15 skip three and then it goes back
to the beginning dash is five dashes
skip ten fifteen dashes skip three and
of course the last one we just switched
up a little bit it looks a lot more
uniform because i'm using two sets of
ten or if i did something like this and
change it to thirty it really becomes
pronounced as far as the distances
between them and instead of four let's
go oh let's put 30 here also 30 by 30.
there we go really pronounced on that
one and let's look at one more important
group for plotting our data and in this
we're gonna here's our plot we started
with with the x plus one x plus two x
plus three and did it in blue on this
one's three or four different blue lines
and this property we want to add the
actual plots so you can see where the
plots are on the graph and for that we
might have marker equals o and if we run
this you'll see it puts a dot for each
of these and there's 25 dots because we
have 25 x values so we actually have
zero and each of the different values of
x y are then plotted here with the dots
and we don't want to just limit
ourselves to dots
you can also do
plus sign that's another option
dots is most common i'll actually like
the dots the best if we do the plus sign
you can see it puts a nice crosshairs or
a plus sign on there and we can do a
marker there's a number of different
markers you can use
and i think this one was it s is another
one
which is a nice square and that's
actually a good one that's for square o
for
period okay that's just kind of weird so
you can see that probably on these
markers another one is uh number one so
if we run that you'll see we now have
these little hatch marks
and let's take oh let's just go with the
o on this one
by the way this works with square really
nicely some stuff we're gonna do here on
just a second let's do marker
size equals two and change that to five
and run that and you can see here it
puts a nice little tiny dot versus uh
the size dot here this is interesting
because it said two i thought it would
be bigger
but if you do 0.5 it gets even smaller
and let's just do 10 to see what that
looks like run that looks huge so marker
size a lot of these are dependent on the
dpi and the setups there's things that
switch around as far as the way the size
shows up you got to be a little careful
when you change one setting it can
change all the other markers and then
let's take our square on here
and we'll do we had marker size so we
also have marker face we'll set that
equal to red of course we i mean change
the so it's up one notch we'll run that
whoops must have mistyped something on
here and i did it's marker face color
equals red and so when i run that you
can now see i have the squares on there
with the marker face color of course we
can mix and match these
come down here we'll make this instead
of let's make this plus seven and we'll
make this size 15
marker face color
equals
and we'll do what green just because
there we go run very hard to actually
see what's going on there still 25 dots
they kind of overlap as you can see they
print them over each other of course if
we really wanted to make it look
horrible we could just make that really
huge generally though you want something
a little bit smaller and cuter we'll
just try doing it this way there we go
that's too small to even see the face so
four
you can start to see the face on there
around four and maybe an eight eight
might be a good number for this there we
go eight again that all just depends on
what you're trying to show and display
so we've covered a lot of stuff here as
far as our lines we've covered
opaque with our alpha setting on there
give us some nice pastels you can see
how they overlap and how they cross over
we covered the line width different size
on there different formats for the line
itself and these are all you can combine
all these so you can have our line width
equals two line style equals dash you
can bring this down here also to the
markers and then we added markers in
just entered a circle a plus sign the
square a little tick which uses a one
then we had a marker size and a marker
color face and we combine those you see
we get a nice different series
representations we also briefly
mentioned color where you didn't have to
use like in here we used color black
someplace up here and have to find it we
use the actual number for the color as
opposed to i changed them to red and
blue so you get very precise on the
color if you have a very specific color
set that you need to match your website
or whatever you're working on all those
are tools in the matplot library so we
have
one more piece to formatting the graph
so we want to show you and then we have
two big sections we're going to go over
the different graphs that they have
along with a challenge problem so let's
go to the last section we're going to
look at is limits we're going to limit
our data
so this first parameter is going to
paste in there we're going to create our
subplots one two so one row two columns
we're going to do a figure size of 10
comma 5. this should all look familiar
now since we've done a number of them
and we're going to go ahead and plot and
this is an interesting notation you
should notice here our axis zero so one
we've used instead of you can just
iterate through them but they're just an
array so it's an array of zero is still
the axes of the first axes out of two
and we're going to plot x
x squared
x
x cubed line with two so we're gonna go
ahead and just plot two graphs right on
top of each other without doing multiple
plots on here and we'll set the grid
equal to true one here let's go ahead
and run that and you can see here our
two plots with the x value going across
and i'm going to do
something similar and by the way as you
can just if you look at it you can see
the grid on there that's all that is
easier to spot the data going across
we're going to take the same
data for axes one so we have our plot of
x x squared x and x cubed line with two
and this time we're going to take our
axes one and do y limit
it's actually set underscore y limit
this is the y axis so it's going to be
an array of two two values and we'll do
0 comma 60 i'm just making these numbers
up the guys in the back actually made
them up i'm just using their numbers
we're going to set the x limit
and we'll set the x limit as
don't forget our brackets there
two comma five
so it's the same data going in and but
we're setting a limit on it let's go
ahead and run that and let's see what it
comes out of and here we have the y
limit zero to sixty so we're looking at
just the lower part of this curve here
up to here and we have the x limit two
to five so that starts right here at two
and you can see very different graphs
this is kind of nice because you could
actually put one of these on top of the
other if you wanted to draw focus to one
part of a graph remember how we did that
earlier one inside the other but just a
quick note you can easily limit your
graph and re-kind of reshape the way it
looks quite easily and we can also add
that grid down there if you want a grid
we'll run that and add the grid in there
oops i just have to do the grid
beforehand
switch that there we go sometimes the
order on this is really important so you
may double check your order when you're
printing these things out it also helps
if i change it to one so in this case
might not be the order i wonder if we'll
go back here as one there we go so
doesn't matter the order and grid but
you can set the grid for easy viewing
here nice setup on there but you can see
how we can limit the data
so let's start looking at some other 2d
graphs and make this cell a mark down so
we run it as a nice pretty title to it
and let's go ahead and create some data
with an np array we'll do
0 to 5 on here there we go and let's
look at four common
graphs we'll put them side by side so
we'll do a figure our axes equals plot
subplots one four columns and then
figure size hopefully it'll fit nicely
on here it seems to do a pretty good on
here and i'll go and just run that since
we're in there run you'll see i have no
four blank plots on here
and we'll start with axes of zero let's
set title
and we want this to be a scatter plot
a scatter plot just means it has a bunch
of dots on it so here's our axes of zero
dot scatter easy to remember scatter a
bunch of plots on there we'll do our
n or we can do x or n there we go and
let's go ahead and do axes set title
scatter i've already did that we're just
going to do scatter
that's how you do it on there notice how
you create a scatter plot with simply
with the scatter control and we'll do
let's do the variable x
x
plus let's throw some randomness in here
usually scatter plots are i have a lot
of random numbers connected to them
that's why they do them on there and so
the bigger the x gets the bigger the
randomness so 0.25 times the randomness
and what we should end up doing here is
with the scatter plot and you can see as
you go up it just kind of has some
random numbers and moves up and down the
line
but plus just the points so if you
remember from back up here where we did
marker this is plotting basically just
the marker so it's a scatter plot
probably less used is a step plot so for
x is one we'll go ahead and do a step
plot so you can see what that looks like
and this time we'll use our n value
instead of x we generated that end value
up here and so for this we have n
n times 2 our n squared n times 2 n
squared line width equals 2 and if we
run that it creates a nice step up
let's see so we've got a scatter plot
we've got a step
plot let's do a bar plot
and we'll use the same formula in n
squared alignment centered because you
can have them left or right with 0.5 and
alpha if you remember correctly that's
how opaque it is
let's see what that looks like on there
so we have some nice you can see here a
nice bar plot it should look very
similar to the step plot but colored in
and we can change the width let's see
what happens we do 0.9 run and if we
take width out completely
run that you can see it starts coming
together on there and we can change the
alpha we can take the alpha out too and
run that so you know you have the solid
colors and if we take out the center and
run that
everything you really can't see the
shift on here because that's actually
the default on this but these are common
settings for the bar graph let me just
put them back in there there we go
alignment center and alpha now i can't
say i have used the step craft very much
there's certain other certain i guess
domains of expertise require a step
graph but the scatter plot and the bar
graph very common especially the bar
graph and we'll look at histograms here
in just a minute so i use histograms a
lot especially in data science but this
is nice if you have very uh concrete
objects somebody how many people wearing
yellow hats
that kind of thing but if we're going to
do that let's go ahead and do the last
one which i see a lot more in the
sciences certainly using the data
science but more like for mapping i saw
publication on uh solar flares and they
were discussing the energy and so
filling in the graph gives it a very
different luck so we're going to do the
fill between
and it's just like you think it'd be
it's fill between but with a underscore
between them and we'll do x and x
squared and x and x cubed and we'll do
color green and alpha again in case you
had other data you want to plot on there
you can see it forms a nice squared
coming up here and also if you look at
the bottom one is your squared value the
upper line is your cubed value and then
it fills in everything in between
if you remember from calculus this would
be if you had like a car a motor an
efficiency they would talk about the
efficiency going up and the loss and
you're looking for the space or the area
between the two lines so it gives you a
nice visual of that now let's look at a
few more basic two dimensionals so we
have our figure figure size on here
we're going to do a radar chart to be
honest i've never used a radar chart in
business or in data science i can't find
a reason to use one now so the first
line for doing a radar chart we have to
add axes and the figure and with this
this actually creates our oh let's let's
run it so you can see what it creates it
creates a nice looks like you're on a
submarine and you're tracking the hunt
for red october or something like that
and it needs all of these the polar is
the fact that we're doing polar
coordinates
zero zero point six point six has to do
with the size if you take out any of
these things and run them you get just a
box
if you take out the other half you
pretty much get nothing in there and if
you change these numbers and change them
a little bit you can see it gets bigger
they had 0.6 on here i'll go ahead and
leave it as one because that's just kind
of fun that's all about the size on here
the height and the width and then let's
create some data t equals np line space
and this is 0 to 2 times np times pi so
if you remember that is the
distance across and we're going to
generate 100 points
so this is just a thing of data we're
putting together then we simply do an ax
dot plot and in this case let's do t
comma t which would be a diagonal line
on a regular chart and we'll give it a
nice color equals blue
and line width equals three let's see
what that looks like and we can see here
a spiral coming out remember this would
be just a diagonal line on a regular
chart what happens if we take this and
instead of t
time 0.5 there we go
and you can see it slightly alters the
way it spirals out we could do t times
two spirals out a little quicker so it's
kind of just a fun i've like i said i've
never used a
radar chart it's a column but you can
always think of radar submarine kind of
looks like one of those or in an
airplane
and none of this would be completed if
we didn't discuss histograms oh my gosh
do i use a histogram so much and we'll
use our numpy that we have set as np to
generate oh looks like we have a hundred
thousand variables we're going to set
equal to n and of course we create our
figure and our axes subplots 1 2 figure
size 12 14 so we're going to look at two
different variations of the histogram
and we'll set a title default histogram
set our title there and then this is
simply
hist for histogram and we'll just go
ahead and put in our n in there and let
me run this and see what that looks like
and let's talk about what is going on
here
so we generated an array here of data
1000 random arrays it looks like they're
mostly between -4 and 4 and then it adds
up each one it says 0 you have 35 000
that are zero so that's what's most
common on here and we have 20 000 that
are somewhere in this range right here
between the minus two and well it looks
like one and minus two and somewhere
between zero and one there's thirty 000
numbers so all this is saying is this is
how common these variables are and this
gives you this point in so many
directions when you're looking at data
science to go ahead and run your
histogram so you should always have your
histogram and you can always put limits
and all the other different things on
your array just like you did on the
other graphs on there and then we're
going to do a cumulative detailed
histogram
and all it is is a histogram let me just
do that
and we set cumulative equal to true
and bins equal 50. and i really want to
highlight the the cumulative equals true
is important but we can now choose how
many bins we have in the first one it
kind of selected them for us in this
case let me go ahead and run this and
you'll see it has that prints the data
out for us and here's our whoops
must have missed oh there we go it
doesn't help that i put it over the old
one there we go okay
so now you have your default histogram
and then we have a cumulative histogram
and we should have 50 steps in there and
let's just find out if that's true not
so much by counting them i'm not going
to count them if you want to you can
count them let's just change it to 10
and see what happens and we see here we
have now 10 counts of that
and we could set that for five
and run that
and then we have our five on there and
we go ahead and take the cumulative
equals true out just so you can see what
that looks like and let me run that on
here too that looks just like it did
before i think there's what one two
three four five six seven eight they
have eight different bins on here is
what the default came out of
put that back in there run
and so now it should look almost
identical and it does and then we can
put the cumulative back in see what that
looks like with the cumulative
and run that
and we can see how that shifts
everything over and has a slightly
different look
wait it shifts it all to the right no it
doesn't actually shift it to the right
it's cumulative so it's the total of the
different occurrences and so what that
means is like if you consider this like
for the year of rainfall we have like
day one you had a little bit of rain day
two we have more rain and so if you look
at the number this is a hundred thousand
thirty five thousand so it's
accumulative detail the histogram of the
currents as it grows and rainfall is a
good one because that would be a
cumulative histogram of how much rain
occurred throughout the year and we're
going to look at two more graphs we've
already looked at a bunch of them we
looked at our radar graph we've looked
at scatter step bar fill in
basic plots we've looked at different
ways of showing the data you know we can
increase the size of the line the look
the color the alpha setting
so let's look at contour maps let's put
that in there there we go draw a contour
map and before we draw a contour map
we need to go ahead and create data for
it and if you have contours your data is
all going to have three different values
so let's go ahead and create the data
here we have our you'd import your
matplot library your numpy so we have
our numbers array
and we'll import matplot.cm
and that's your color maps so you have
all these different color maps you can
look at there's like hundreds of color
maps so if you don't want to do your own
color you can do your own color map
they're pretty diverse and of course our
plt we're going to our pi plot and to
generate our different data we're going
to create a delta
0.025 and we'll start with x when we're
going to create an array between -3 and
3 and delta increments of 0.025
and we'll have our y we'll do something
similar and then we'll create our x y
into a mesh grid again these are all
numpy commands so if you're not familiar
with these you'll want to go back and
review our numpy tutorial and we'll do
an exponential on here minus x squared
minus y squared for z1 we'll do a z2 so
we have two different areas and z equals
z of 1 minus z2 times 2.
so we've created a number of values here
and let me go ahead and run this and
let's plug that in so you can see where
those values are going so once we've set
these we're going to create our figure
and our x from our plt subplots we're
going to create the variable cs and this
is going to be our contour so right here
cs is our contour surface and we're
feeding it x y and z
if you remember x y we created as our x
and y components using our mesh grid and
you know what let's do this just because
it's kind of good to see this let's go
ahead and print
x
and let's print
y and i always like to do this when i'm
working with something that's either is
really complicated in this case is what
we're looking at or you don't understand
yet so we've created a mesh grid we have
x y and when we're done with this we end
up with here's our x
and this set of values and our y so
those are x and y coordinates and then
we've also created z based on our x and
y so we have x capital x capital y and
capital z is our three components x and
y being the coordinates well z is going
to be our actual height since we're
doing a contour map so we created our
contour map from our x y and z
coordinates we want to go ahead and put
in a c label maybe we want to go ahead
and do a title on here
we'll put that in our set title and this
is a
contour there we go contour map
and let's go ahead and run this and see
what that looks like
and you'll see we generated a nice
little contour map there's different
settings you can play with on this but
you can picture this being you're on a
mountain climb and here we have a line
that's represent zero maybe that's sea
level and then moving on up you have
your contours of 0.5 and then
one and different setups little hills i
guess if it's minus that's like a pit so
i guess you're going down into a pit at
minus five and minus one but on the
other side you can see you're going up
in levels so here's a mountaintop and
here's like a basin of some kind
and in data science this could represent
a lot of things this could also be
representing two different values and
maybe profits and loss i don't know if
i'd ever really do that as a contour map
but i'm sure you can be creative and
find something fun to do with a contour
map and then we're going to look at one
last map which is the 3d map and those
are can be really important as a final
product because they can show so much
additional information that you can't
fit on two-dimensional graphs
there we go draw a 3d image
and so we're going to import from our
mpl toolkits the implant 3d and the axis
3d we're going to import axis 3d this is
what's going to let us work with the 3d
image and this should look familiar
we're going to create another figure
just like we did before figure size 14
by 6 that's a good fit on the screen
we'll go ahead and run that
so we have our figure and let's go ahead
and take our x and we're going to set
that equal to fig dot add subplot that
should also be familiar from earlier and
we're going to work with this sets the
settings for the projection we're going
to use one two one projection 3d and
we'll see what that looks like in just a
minute and we just created some
three-dimensional data here before where
we had x y and z capital x y and z so
we're going to reuse that data we're
just going to use that since it's also
this is also a three-dimensional image
so let's use that for a
three-dimensional graph and we simply do
ax plot underscore
surface
and a capital x
capital y
capital z so there's our data coming in
and we're going to add some settings in
here we're going to do r stride 4 c
stride 4 and line width 0. i'll show you
what that is here in just a minute let's
go ahead and run that so we can see our
graph
and of course it helps if i don't add an
extra comma in there and you can see it
generates this really beautiful
three-dimensional graph
so let's take a little bit time to
explore some of these numbers we have
going in here
we have the r stride 4 the c stride 4
and the projection 3d projection 3d is
the important one because that's telling
us that this is a 3d graph here
so what are these first numbers one two
one let's just change one of these i'm
going to change this to five
and it's going to give me an error let's
change it to one
and that didn't work let's change this
middle one to three instead and you're
going to see how it starts reshaping the
size and how it fits on the screen
and we'll change the first one to two
we'll run that one
and again it's changed the dimensions
and the size and how it fits on here
play with these numbers to get a nice
look and feel for it part of it is the
tilt and the angle
i'll do seven on this one
there we go you can see it really
shifted it there
but again that changes the size now fits
on the canvas
but we'll leave it at the one
two and just so you get a good look at
what we're talking about here this is
column width and index from before
if we do one one one you can see that it
now spreads it out all the way across
uses the whole setup on there so this
has to do with the size and how big you
want it to be now there's one term that
we didn't cover in this yet but we've
used it throughout the whole setup
and i'm just going to type that down
here even though we're not going to go
into detail and that's the term heat
map you might see that it's kind of
starting to lose ground as far as a
common reference but there sure are a
lot of people who still talk about heat
maps what is a heat map well it is
simply a color map that's all it is so
if you ever see the term heat map
that refers to the fact this is in
different colors representing different
heights
that one is in the heat map but you can
see up here we switched into let me go
back up here here we go this one has
different colors for the different
values
a lot of times you'll use like instead
of x and y you might do a heat map
where you have a fourth value and the
fourth value represents the color and so
you'll see this 3d image into nice
colors represented by heat map that's
all it is so if you see the term heat
map that only means we're plotting some
of the data in color to make it stand
out or to give it a fourth dimension in
this case
so we've covered a lot of things on
matplot and that brings us cover all the
basics so that brings us to practice
example and this is going to be the
challenge for you and let me go ahead
and change our cell
cell type mark down and run that so it
looks pretty
practice example write a path python
program to create a pie chart of the
popularity of programming languages
okay excellent
and if you're going to have a challenge
we need some data and i'll just throw in
our import our map library at the
beginning you should do that
automatically and so for our data to
plot we're going to have our languages
we're going to have python we're going
to have java php javascript c sharp c
plus plus so those are six categories
and then we have our popularity oops
misspelling there popularity we'll give
the first one 22.2
java 17.6 and i don't know if these are
real numbers they pulled
my guess is that they might have just
been made up because i don't know if
python's really that much more popular
than the other ones maybe specific to
data science because python is very
popular in data science right now
because it has so many options the only
other program that's highly used
exclusively for data science is r so
python's big and python also does a lot
more it's a full programming language
where r is primarily for data science
they didn't put r in here so we have
python we have java we have our php and
you can see the different values they've
given it or different percentages
and i did add these up does not add up
to 100 it adds up to 71 percent or
something like that
and then we're going to give colors and
we've chosen these guys in the back
brought in these colors i'm not sure
what these colors are we'll find out in
a minute so i'll be exciting but you can
see they're using the actual color
values you can pull off of a color wheel
or something like that you could have
just as easily done blue red green if
you're too lazy to pick the exact colors
and then let's go ahead and solve this
and see we got here we're going to do
something a little fancy just because we
can the first thing we're going to do is
we're going to use a variable called
explode and you'll notice that there's
six variables in here so that matches
our six different categories and the
first one we've done is point one and
then zero zero zero zero zero point one
when we put this in here under the
explode in the plot it will actually
push that square out so it's a really
cool feature to highlight certain
information on a pie chart
and this is simply
plt dot pi
and we're plotting
popularity there we go
and before we add in all the really cool
settings for this let's go ahead and run
it and you'll see we generate a nice
flat pie
not too exciting there and then we'll go
ahead and put in all the extras i talked
about explode we can explode one of the
values out so here's our explode equals
explode labels as languages because we
want to know what the different colors
mean here's our colors equals colors our
auto picture and this is standard print
format so that's a python
setup on there and that's just going to
put the value on the pie slice and then
we're going to add shadow because it
just looks cooler with a shadow gives a
little 3d look and we'll do a start
angle of 140. let's go ahead and run
this and take a look and see what comes
out of that
and look how that changes the whole
setup so here's our labels there's our
value we put on there there's our slice
that's pushed out there's our shadow a
3d effect
and then we started at 140. we could
also rotate this let's just do this
angle
90.
and if we run it
you'll see the blue pi slice has moved
up a little bit we could actually do
actually let's just take the whole
starting triangle out and run it'll
default to zero
this is what it looks like if it
defaulted to zero so depending on where
you want the highlighted slice to appear
usually you want that appear on the left
because people read left to right and so
it draws a focus onto in this case
python and how great python is i'm a
little biased we're teaching a python
tutorial so it should be understandable
that we're looking at python and one
last reference before we close you can
go over to the matplot library dot pi
plot setup and if you go underneath
there the different functions on there
you can look this up on their website
you'll see a full list and this is why
it's so important to go through a
tutorial like this because this list is
just so massive trying to figure out
like here's our bar plot there's a bar h
you can add barbs there's a box plot we
didn't cover
c labels a totally different kind of for
your contour plot you can set up in
there if you go down here we have our
figures we used on there we showed you
the basics how to do the figure you'll
see some
closer references on those
there's a histogram down here hist
there's also the his 2d makes a 2d
histogram plot h lines all of this these
are all the different commands that are
underneath of here and you can see it's
pretty extensive
we've covered all the basic ones so that
you know have a solid ground to look at
these different options so when you come
to these functions some of them are
going to look a little off or not off
will look unfamiliar but you'll still
have the availability to probably
understand most of this and have a basic
understanding of your matplot library
what does a data scientist do these are
some of the activities data acquisition
data preparation data mining data
modeling and then model maintenance we
will talk about each of these in a great
detail but at a very high level the
first step obviously is to get the raw
data which is known as data acquisition
it can be in all kinds of format and
could be multiple sources but obviously
that raw data cannot be used as it is
for performing data mining activities or
data modeling activities so the data has
to be claimed and prepared for using in
the data models or in the data mining
activity so that is the data preparation
then we actually do the data mining
which can also include some exploratory
activities and then if we have to do
stuff like machine learning then you
need to build a machine learning model
and test the model get insights out of
it and then if
the model is fine you deploy it and then
you need to maintain the model because
over a period of time it is possible
that you need to tweak the model because
of change in the process or changing the
data and so on so that all comes under
the model maintenance so let's take
deeper look at each of these activities
let's start with data acquisition so the
stage of data acquisition basically the
data scientist will collect raw data
from all possible sources so this could
be typically an rdbms which is a
relational database or it can also be a
non-rdbms or it could be flat files or
unstructured data and so on so we need
to bring all that data from different
sources if required we need to do some
kind of homogeneous formatting so that
it all fits into
up in a looks at least format from a
format perspective it looks homogeneous
so that may be requiring some kind of
transformation very often this is loaded
into what is known as data warehouse so
this can also be sometimes referred to
as etl or extract transform and load so
a data warehouse is like a common place
where data from different sources is
brought together so that people can
perform data science activities like
reporting or data mining or statistical
analysis and so on so data from various
sources is put in a centralized place
which is known as a data warehouse so
that is also known as etl and in order
to do this there can be data scientists
can take help of some etl tools there
are some existing tools that a data
scientist can take help of like for
example data stage or talent or
informatica these are pretty good tools
for performing these etl activities and
getting the data the next stage now that
you have the raw data into a data
warehouse you still probably are not in
a position to straight away use this
data for performing the data mining
activities so that is where data
preparation comes into play and there
are multiple reasons for that one of
them could be the data is dirty there
are some missing values and so on and so
forth so a lot of time is actually spent
in this particular stage so a data
scientist spends a lot of time almost 60
to 70 percent of the time in
this part of the project or the process
which is data preparation so there are
again within this there can be multiple
sub activities starting from let's say
data cleaning you will probably have
missing values the data there is some
columns the values are missing or the
values are incorrect there are null
values and so on and so forth so that is
basically the data cleaning part of it
then you need to perform certain
transformations like for example
normalizing the data and so on right so
you could probably have to modify a
categorical values into numerical values
and so on and so forth so these are
transformational activities then we may
have to handle outliers so the data
could be such that there are a few
values which are way beyond the normal
behavior of the data for whatever reason
either people have keyed in wrong values
or for some reason some of the values
are completely out of range so those are
known as outliers so there are certain
ways of handling these outliers and
detecting and handling these outliers so
this is a part of what is known as
exploratory analysis so you quickly
explore the data to find out other so
and you can use visual tools like plots
and identify what are the outliers and
see how we can get rid of the outliers
and so on then the next part could be
data integrity data integrity is to
validate for example if there are some
primary keys that all the primary keys
are populated there are some foreign
keys and at least most of the foreign
keys should be populated and otherwise
when we are trying to query the data you
may get wrong values and so on so that
is the data integrity part of it and
then we have what is known as data
reduction sometimes we may have
duplicate values we may have columns
that may be
duplicated because they are coming from
different sources the same values are
there and so on so a lot of this can be
done using what is known as data
reduction and thereby you can reduce the
size of the data drastically because
very often this could be written in data
which can be removed and so on so let's
take a look at what are the various
techniques that are used for data
cleaning so we need to ensure that the
data is valid and it is consistent and
uniform and accurate so these are the
various parameters that we need to
ensure as a part of the data cleaning
process now what are the techniques that
that are used for data cleaning or so we
will see what each of these are in this
particular case and so what is the data
set that we have we have data about a
bank and its customer details so let's
take an example and see how we go about
cleaning the data and in this particular
example we're assuming we are using
python so let's assume we loaded this
data which is the raw file.csv this is
how the customer data looks like and
we will see for example if we take a
closer look at the geography column we
will see that there are quite a few
blank spaces so how do we go about when
we have some blank spaces or if it is a
string value then we put an empty string
here or we just use a space or empty
string if there are numerical values
then we need to come up with a strategy
for example
we put the mean value so wherever it is
missing we find the mean for that
particular column so in this case let's
assume we have credit score and we see
that quite a few of these values are
missing so what do we do here we find
the mean for this column for all the
existing values and we found that the
mean is equal to
638.6 so we kind of write a piece of
code to replace wherever there are blank
values nan is basically like null and
we just go ahead and say fill it with
the mean value so this is the piece of
code we are writing to fill it so all
the blanks or all the null values get
replaced with the mean value now one of
the reasons for doing this is that very
often if you have some such situation
many of your statistical functions may
not even work so that's the reason you
need to fill up these values or either
get rid of these records or fill up
these values with something meaningful
so this is one mechanism which is
basically using a mean there are a few
others as we move forward we can see
what are the other ways for example we
can also say that any missing value in a
particular row if even one column the
value is missing you just drop that
particular row or delete all rows where
even a single column has missing values
so that is one way of dealing now the
problem here can be that if a lot of
data has let's say one or two columns
missing and
we dropped many such rows then overall
you may lose out on let's say 60 of the
data has some value or the other missing
sixty percent of the rows then it may
not be a good idea to delete all the
rows like in that manner because then
you're losing pretty much 60 of your
data therefore your analysis won't be
accurate but if it is only 5 or 10
percent then this will work another way
is only to drop values where or rather
dropped rows where all the columns are
empty which makes sense because that
means that record is of really no use
because it has no information in it so
there can be some situations like that
so we can provide a condition saying
that drop the records where all the
columns are blank or not applicable we
can also specify some kind of a
threshold let's say you have 10 or 20
columns in a row you can specify that
maybe five columns are blank or null
then you drop that record so again we
need to take care that such a condition
such a situation the amount of data that
has been removed or excluded is not
large if it is like maybe five percent
maximum ten percent then it's okay but
by doing this if you're losing out on a
large chunk of data then it may not be a
good idea you need to come up with
something better what else we need to do
next is so the data preparation part is
done so now we get into the data mining
part so what exactly we do in data
mining primarily we come up with ways to
take meaningful decisions so data mining
will give us insights into the data what
is existing there and then we can do
additional stuff like maybe machine
learning and so on to get perform
advanced analytics and so on so one of
the first steps we do is what is known
as data discovery and
which is basically like exploratory
analysis so we can use tools like
tableau for doing some of this so let's
just take a quick look at how we go
about that so tableau is excellent data
mining or actually more of a reporting
or a bi tool and you can download a
trial version of tableau at tableau.com
or there is also tableau public which is
free and you can actually use and play
around however if you want to use it for
enterprise purpose than is a commercial
software so you need to purchase license
and you can then run some of the data
mining activities say your data source
your data is in some excel sheet so you
can select the source as microsoft excel
or any other format and the data will be
brought into the tableau environment and
then it will show you what is known as
dimensions and measures so dimensions
are all the descriptive columns so and
tableau is intelligent enough to
actually identify these dimensions and
measure so measures are the numerical
values so as you can see here customer
id gender geography these are all
dimensions non-numerical values whereas
age balance credit score and so on are
numeric values so they come under
measures so you've got your data into
tableau and then you want to let's say
build a small model and you want to
let's say solve a particular problem so
what is the problem statement all right
let's say we want to analyze why
customers are
leaving the bank which is known as exit
and we want to analyze and see what are
some of the factors for exiting the bank
and we want to let's assume consider
these three of them like let's say
gender credit card and geography these
as a criteria and analyze if these are
in any way impacting or have some
bearing on the customer exiting or the
customer exit behavior okay so let's
use tableau and very quickly we will be
able to find out how these parameters
are affecting all right so let's see so
this is our customer data so from our
excel sheet we have data set about let's
say 10 000 rows and we want to find out
what is the criteria let's start with
gender let's say we want to first use
gender as a criteria so tableau really
offers an easy drag and drop kind of a
mechanism so that makes it really really
easy to perform this kind of analysis so
what we need to do is exited says
whether the customer has exited or not
so it has a value of 0 and 1 and then of
course you have gender and so on so we
will take these two and simply drag and
drop okay so exit it and then we will
put gender and if we drag and drop into
the analysis side of tableau all right
so here what we are doing is we are
showing male female as two different
columns here and zero for people who did
not exist and one for people who exited
and that is color coded so the blue
color means people who did not exist and
this yellow color means people who
detects it all right so now if we pull
the data here create like bar graphs
this is how it would look uh so what is
yellow let's go back so yellow is
who exited and
for the male only
16.45 percent have exited and we can
also draw a reference line that will
help us or even provide aliases so these
are a lot of fancy stuff that is
provided by tableau you can create
aliases and so that it looks good rather
than basic labels and you can also add a
reference line so you add a reference
line something like this from here we
can make out that on an average female
customers exit more than the male
customers right so that is what we are
seeing here on an average so we have
analyzed based on gender we do see that
there is some difference in the male and
female behavior now let's take the next
criteria which is the credit card so
let's see if having a credit card has
any impact on the customer exit behavior
so just like before we drag and drop the
credit card has credit card a column if
we drag and drop here and then we will
see that there is pretty much no
difference between people having credit
card and not having credit card
20.81 percent of people who have no
credit card have exited and similarly
20.18 of people who have credit card
have also exited so the credit card is
not having
much of an impact that's what this piece
of analysis shows last we will basically
go and check how the geography is
impacting so once again we can drag and
drop geography column onto the site and
if we see here there are geographies
like that i think there are about three
geographies like france germany and
spain and
we see that there is some kind of
impact with the geography as well okay
so what we derive from this is that the
credit card is really we can ignore the
credit card variable or feature from our
analysis because that doesn't have any
impact but gender and geography we can
keep and do further analysis okay all
right so what are some of the advantages
of data mining bit more detailed
analysis can help us in predicting the
future trends and it also helps in
identifying customer behavior patterns
okay so you can take informed decisions
because the data is telling you or
providing you with some insights and
then you take a decision based on that
if there is any fraudulent activity data
mining will help in quickly identifying
such a fraud as well and of course it
will also help us in identifying the
right algorithm for performing more
advanced data mining activities like
machine learning and so on all right so
the next activity now that we have the
data we have prepared the data and
performed some data mining activity the
next step is model building let's take a
look at model building so what is model
building if we want to perform a more
detailed data mining activity like maybe
perform some machine learning then you
need to build a model and how do you
build a model first thing is you need to
select which algorithm you want to use
to solve the problem on hand and also
what kind of data that is available and
so on and so forth so you need to make a
choice of the algorithm and based on
that you go ahead and create a model
train the model and so on we look at
data science components there's the
mathematics
statistics
domain expertise
data engineering data visualization and
machine learning when we sum this up in
data science really
this point
in all of this you want to focus on
first is domain expertise
now when you're taking your classes
obviously you want to go through the
mathematics the statistics the data
engineering the data visualization the
machine learning and learning all those
tools
but it really in the job field the
domain expertise comes in
because if you're really good with
business and you go into business with
these tools
then you're able to ask the right
questions and deal with it when we talk
about the tools in data science and
where they sit
there is a data analysis
data analysis focuses more on statistics
and mathematics
where the data science size
where the data science side focuses more
on the machine learning data
visualization and then there's database
management which really focuses on the
data engineering part of it and how to
manage that data in the data flow
you see all these components come
together and then they form the data
science
and we talk about tools in data science
we have sas we have matlab we have sql
you have your apache spark your r table
python right now in the programming
languages python is probably the most
widely used with r coming in a close
second
the reason for that is these are both
open source and anybody can use them we
look at sas and tableau those are two
packages that are paid for which have a
lot of automation behind them so a lot
of the larger companies will pay for
those packages because they help work
out a lot of the the back end stuff
before you even need to use them
and of course we have apache spark
you almost have to know apache spark in
the growing data
lakes today that's your big data how do
you distribute this if you're going to
process it over a large amount of data
we look at data science applications
there's internet search very common you
enter your google thing and it uses the
data science algorithms to figure out
what to return voice assistance
analyzing the voice coming in and
connecting it with whatever patterns
they need to activate so you can ask it
to turn your lights on in the living
room healthcare biggest field growing
right now how do we analyze health data
from a smart watch and figure out how to
know when a disease is being spread
across the world
health care how do we identify
cancer versus non-cancer so we know who
to prioritize and get them in for
surgery where other people might not
need that immediate care
and even identifying
uh problems somebody might have with
their health long before they even
happen what a neat thing to do instead
of waiting until you have a heart attack
to know months ahead of time that you're
having heart conditions
logistics how do we get from point a to
point b
if you ever look at some of the major
distributors they pre-ship things based
on what they guess people are going to
need
this way you get your stuff right in the
mailbox the day after you order it
e-commerce
it's huge in there because you have to
know what kind of marketing we're going
to put out who are we selling to what's
our target audience
robotics one of the funner ones when
you're coming up into the future is how
do we automate the different
tasks we have from self-driving cars
to manufacturing lines to maybe even a
self-robotic chef
in the kitchen so we talk about solving
problems with data science
we have to ask possible questions and
the desired algorithms and these really
are
kind of an overview of some of the
terminology you'll want to know in data
science
so we talk about that how much or how
many we're talking about regression
regression basically means a number if
you've ever seen stock charts you see
[Music]
the guess at what the next sales price
is or buy prices
that's all on your regression side
is it a or b classification
is that a dog or a cat that my photo
took a picture of how is this organized
clustering this is where we take things
that look alike and put them together so
that we can then make predictions on it
how difference is this
just like you have clustering you have
the opposite anomaly detection how do we
find things that don't fit in where the
outliers what are things we might need
to look at that aren't in our model
and what to do next reinforced learning
this is probably the newest market is
how do we set something up whereas the
data comes in it learns from the new
data as to what the next action is going
to take
most of these are combined so when we
talk about regression classification
clustering anomaly detection reinforced
learning
a lot of times when you put your model
together you might have multiple parts
of this we might look at the clustering
of data
and then feed it into a classification
is this a
bad loan to make it the bank or is this
a good loan to give
and from there we might start looking at
when we start clustering these things as
good and bad and what kind of setup is
we then might run it through a
regression model to say hey what is the
amount dollar amount this person
should be allowed to take a loan out
and you can see that all of these start
coming in and then
a lot of the models
reinforced learning
we talk about like bank loans and things
like that once a year
they have to rerun those algorithms and
so that's like a human run reinforced
learning
now we're starting to automate that so
that as the data comes in real time the
models start updating themselves
they start figuring out a way to solve
new problems as they occur
and of course in robotics reinforced
learning is one of the biggest growing
fields
logarithms used in data science linear
regression
logistic regression when you're looking
at both of these
think numbers we're talking regression
models and so linear regression figures
out the best line through the data maybe
it's looking for a curved line
logistic regression starts looking at
data
on a continuum
so that
it goes to an exponential you have a
spot where it might be one or the other
and then you know what it is as it goes
to one side or the other
decision tree
wonderful tool if you
used to call it a hack now it's becoming
mainstream to look at the back end what
made the decision so it's really easy to
trace back to how you arrived at the
decision decision trees are kind of nice
that way
nearest neighbors k nearest neighbors is
your clustering k means clustering
hierarchical clustering so hierarchical
starts dividing them and builds a
hierarchy where the k-means and the
k-nearest neighbor look for things that
kind of connect each other how close are
they in data format
db scan another form of clustering your
data principle component analysis so we
start breaking up and looking at the
different components in our data coming
in these are all algorithms used in data
science and there are more these are
kind of the mainline ones and each one
of these has many settings which you can
play with
to build a better model to predict your
data and where you want it to go let's
go ahead and take a hands-on demo and
just see what does this look like
now i'm going to go ahead and use the
anaconda navigator and the
which is your jupiter notebook
which will then open up in google chrome
this is one of the ides or ways of
editing python code
i like this one because it one protects
my computer and creates its own kind of
container
and two it's got a really nice visual
demo for doing python certainly you can
use a number of other different tools
like pycharm
there's another real popular one you can
actually access pycharm code through the
anaconda navigator now and there's a lot
of other tools on there that each have
their benefit and we come into our
jupiter notebook go ahead and create a
new python i've already done that
and we'll start with a lot logistics
regression model just so you can see
what this looks like in code we'll
actually do two of these
as we go through this and take a look
and see what that code looks like in
python
now the first thing we want to go ahead
and do is
load up all our parts modules that we
need in our python code
i'll go and run that and you'll see here
i'm going to ignore warnings because
some of the stuff we're doing
we're just looking at it and as you go
from one
version of python to one version of
whatever
the site kit or in this case the sc
package
you'll see some warnings come up they're
not really important right now
and then we're going to go ahead and use
the german credit data csv
and so when i run this this is all
loaded up now let's go ahead and just
open up this csv file so you can see
what that looks like
and here it is here's our german credit
data file
we'll go ahead and just open that up
with
let's do
wordpad just fine because it's a word
document
and when we open that up
you can see right here is just a bunch
of comma separated values we have across
the top
it actually has columns on here so our
first row is a bunch of columns
and then of course we look down here
oops i just move stuff around but that's
okay i'm not going to save it and you
can see the values al1 al4 whatever that
means or a14 i guess
and then some sort of numbers on here
and we'll take a closer look when we get
into the program
and looking at the data for right now
we've loaded that under credit df
and at this point i want to just kind of
take a detour back to the life cycle of
data science so we can see how that fits
in there
and so we've already done our data
discovery
we have a little data prep but the data
is pretty clean
it already comes in preset on there
we'll make do a little data preparation
in here we're going to start looking at
exploring the data
analysis and building a data model and
then interpreting the results so really
we're focusing on the last three steps
of this
the data discovery would be asking start
asking questions of what do we want in
there is this going to be
is this going to be a good loan a bad
loan what do we want to get out of this
data where are we going with it that
would be part of the data discovery
and a lot of times that might be a
meeting you have with the management in
the office or whatever
and then data preparation is of course
cleaning the data up making sure you
know where the source came from
all those kind of fun things that go
into making sure you have good data
coming in
we're going to cover mathematics for
machine learning so today's agenda is
going to cover data and its types then
we're going to dive into linear algebra
and its concepts
calculus statistics for machine learning
probability for machine learning
hands-on demos
and of course thrown in there in the
middle is going to be your matrixes and
a few other things to go along with all
this
data and its types
data denotes the individual pieces of
factual information collected from
various sources it is stored processed
and later used for analysis
and so we see here just a huge grouping
of information a lot of tech stuff money
dollar signs numbers
and then you have your performing
analytics to drive insights and
hopefully you have a nice share your
shareholders gather it at the meeting
and you're able to explain it in
something they can understand
so we talk about data types of data
we have in our types of data we have a
qualitative categorical
you think nominal or ordinal
and then you have your quantitative or
numerical which is discrete or
continuous
and let's look a little closer at those
data type vocabulary always people's
favorite is the vocabulary words okay
not mine but let's dive into this what
we mean by nominal
nominal they are used to label various
uh label our variables without providing
any measurable value
country gender race hair color etc
it's something that you either mark true
or false this is a label it's on or off
either they have a red hat on or they do
not
so a lot of times when you're thinking
nominal data
labels
think of it as a true false kind of
setup and we look at ordinal this is
categorical data with a set order or a
scale to it
and you can think of salary range as a
great one
movie ratings etc you see here the
salary rains if you have 10 000 to 20
000 number of employees earning that
rate is 150 20 000 to 30 thousand a
hundred and so forth some of the terms
you'll hear is bucket uh this is where
you have 10 different buckets and you
want to separate it into something that
makes sense into those 10 buckets
and so when we start talking about
ordinal a lot of times when you get down
to the brass bones again we're talking
true false
so if you remember the 10 to 20k range
so forth those would each be either part
of that group or you're not but now
we're talking about buckets and we want
to count how many people are in that
bucket
quantitative numerical data
falls into two classes discrete or
continuous
and so data with a final set of values
which can be categorized class strength
questions answered correctly and runs
hit and cricket a lot of times when you
see this you can think integer and a
very restricted integer i
you can only have 100 questions um on a
test so you can it's very discrete i
only have 100 different values that it
can attain so think usually you're
talking about integers but within a very
small range they don't have an open in
or anything like that
so discrete is very solid
simple to count
set number
continuous on the other hand continuous
data can take any numerical value within
a range so water pressure weight of a
person etc usually we start thinking
about float values where they can get
phenomenally small in their in what
they're worth
and there's a whole series of values
that falls right between discrete and
continuous
you can think of the stock market you
have dollar amounts it's still discrete
but it starts to get complicated enough
when you have like you know jump in the
stock market from 525.33
to
580.67
there's a lot of point values in there
it'd still be called discrete but you
start looking at it as almost continuous
because it does have such a variance in
it now we talk about no we did we went
over nominal and ordinal
almost true false charts and we looked
at quantitative and numerical data which
were starting to get into numbers
discrete you can usually a lot of times
discrete will be put into it could be
put into true false but usually it's not
uh so we want to address this stuff and
the first thing you want to look at is
the very basic which is your algebra so
we're going to take a look at linear
algebra you can remember back when your
euclidean geometry we have a line well
let's go through this we have a linear
algebra is the domain of mathematics
concerning linear equations
and their representations in vector
spaces and through matrixes i told you
we're going to talk about matrix is
uh so a linear equation
is simply
2x plus 4y minus 3z equals 10. very
linear 10x plus 12.4y equals z and now
you can actually solve these two
equations by combining them
and that's we're talking about a linear
equation
in the vectors we have a plus b equals c
now we're starting to look at a
direction
and these values usually think of an x y
z plot
so each one is a direction
and the actual
distance of like a triangle a b is c
and then your matrix can describe all
kinds of things
i find matrixes
confuse a lot of people
not because they're particularly
difficult but because of the magnitude
and the different things they're used
for
and a matrix is a chart
or a you know think of a spreadsheet but
you have your rows and your columns
and you'll see here we have a times b
equals c
very important to know your counts uh so
depending on how the math is being done
what you're using it for making sure you
have the same rows and number of columns
or a single number there's all kinds of
things that play in that that can make
matrixes confusing
but really it has a lot more to do with
what domain you're working in are you
adding in
multiple polynomials where you have like
uh
a x squared plus b y plus you know you
start to see that it can be very
confusing versus a very straightforward
matrix
and let's just go a little deeper into
these because these are such primary
this is what we're here to talk about is
these different math uh mathematical
computations that come up
so we're looking at linear equations
let's dig deeper into that one an
equation having a maximum order of one
is called a linear equation
so it's linear because when you look at
this we have ax plus b equals c which is
a one variable
we have two variable ax plus b y equals
c a x plus b y plus z c z equals d
and so forth but all of these
are to the power of one you don't see x
squared you don't see x cubed so we're
talking about linear equations that's
what we're talking about in their
addition
if you have already dived into say
neural networks you should recognize
this ax plus by plus cz
setup plus the intercept
which is basically your your neural
network each node adding up all the
different inputs and we can drill down
into that most common formula is your y
equals mx plus c
so you have your y
equals the m which is your slope
your x value plus c
which is your
y-intercept you kind of label it wrong
here
threw me for a loop but the the c would
be your y-intercept so when you set x
equal to 0 y equals c and that's that's
your y-intercept right there
uh and that's they just had reversed
value of y when x equals 0 equals the
y-intercept which is c and your slow
gradient line which is your m so it's
your y equals 2x plus 3.
and there's lots of easy ways to compute
this this way this is why we always
start with the most basic one when we're
solving one of these problems and then
of course the
one of the most important takeaways is
the slope gradient of the line
so the slope is very important that m
value
in this case we went ahead and solved
this
if you have y equals 2x plus 3 you can
see how it has a nice line graph here on
the right
so matrixes a matrix refers to a
rectangular representation of an array
of numbers arranged in columns and rows
so we're talking m rows by n columns
here a11 is denotes the element of the
first row in the first column similarly
a12 and it's really pronounced a11 in
this particular setup so it's a row one
column one a 12 is a
row one column two
uh first row and second column and so on
and there's a lot of ways to denote this
i've seen these as like a capital letter
a smaller case a for the top row or i
mean you can see where they can go all
kinds of different directions as far as
the value
you just take a moment to realize
there's need to be some designation as
far as what row it's in and what column
it's in
and we have our basic operations we have
addition so when you think about
addition you have uh
two matrixes of 2 by 2 and you just add
each individual number in that matrix
and then when you get to the bottom you
have in this case the solution is 12 10
plus 2 is 12 5 plus 3 is 8 and so on and
the same thing with subtraction
now again you're counting matrixes you
want to check your
dimensions of the matrix
the shape you'll see shape come up a lot
in programming so we're talking about
dimensions we're talking about the shape
if the two shapes are equal
this is what happens when you add them
together or subtract them
and we have multiplication when you look
at the multiplication you end up with a
very a slightly different setup going
now
if we look at our last one where uh
we're like why
this always gets to me when we get to
matrixes they don't really say why you
multiply matrixes
um you know my first thought is one
times two four times three but if you
look at this we get one times two plus
four times three
one times three plus four times five
uh six times two plus three times three
six times three plus three times five if
you're looking at these matrixes uh
think of this more as an equation
and so we have if you remember we went
back up here for our multiple line
equations let's just go back up a couple
slides where we were looking at a two
variable so this is a two variable
equation ax plus b y equals c
and this is a way to make it very quick
to solve these variables and that's why
you have the matrix and that's why you
do
the multiplication the way they do
and this is the dot product of uh one
times two
plus four times three
one times three plus four times five
uh six times two plus three times three
six times three plus three times five
and it gives us a nice little
14 23 21 and 33 over here which then can
be used and reduced down to a sample
formula as far as solving the variables
as you have enough inputs
and then in matrix operations when
you're dealing with a lot of matrixes uh
now keep in mind multiplying matrixes is
different than finding the product of
two matrixes okay so we're talking about
multiplication we're talking about
solving
for equations when you're finding the
product you are just finding 1 times 2.
keep that in mind because that does come
up i've had that come up a number of
times where i'm altering data and i get
confused as to what i'm doing with it
transpose flipping the matrix over is
diagonal comes up all the time where you
have you still have 12 but instead of it
being 12 8 it's now 12 14
8 21 you're just flipping the columns
and the rows
and then of course you can do an inverse
changing the signs of the values across
this main diagonal
and you can see here we have the inverse
a to the minus 1 and ends up with
instead of 12 8 14 12 is now minus 22
minus 12.
vectors
vector just means we have
a value and a direction
and we have down four numbers here on
our vector
in mathematics a one dimensional matrix
is called a vector
so
if you have your x plot and you have a
single value that values along the x
axis and it's a single dimension
if you have two dimensions you can think
about putting them on a graph you might
have x and you might have y and each
value denotes a direction and then of
course the actual distance is going to
be the hypothesis of that triangle
and you can do that with three
dimensionals x y and z
and you can do it all the way to nth
dimensions so when they talk about the k
means
uh for categorizing and how close data
is together they will compute that based
on the pythagorean theorem so you would
take
the square of each value add them all
together and find the square root and
that gives you a distance
as far as where that point is where that
vector exists or an actual point value
and then you can compare that point
value
to another one it makes a very easy
comparison versus comparing 50 or 60
different numbers
and that brings us up to i gene vectors
and i gene values
hygiene vectors the vectors that don't
change their span while transformation
and i gene values the scalar values that
are associated to the vectors
conceptually
you can think of the vector as your
picture you have a picture it's
two dimensions x and y
and so when you do those two dimensions
and those two values or whatever that
value is
that is that point but the values change
when you skew it and so
if we take and we have a vector a
and that's a set value uh
b is um your is your you have a and b
which is your i gene vector
two is the i gene value so we're
altering
all the values by two that means we're
maybe we're stretching it out one
direction making it tall uh if you're
doing picture editing um that's one of
the places this comes in but you can see
when you're transforming
your different information how you
transform it is then your hygiene value
and you can see here vector after line
transit transition
we have 3a a is the hygiene vector 3 is
the iogene value so a doesn't change
that's whatever we started with that's
your original picture and three uh is
skewing it one direction and maybe uh a
b is being skewed another direction and
so you have a nice tilted picture
because you altered it by those by the
aging values
so let's go ahead and pull up a demo on
linear algebra and to do this i'm going
to go through my trusted anaconda into
my jupiter notebook
and we'll create a new
notebook called linear algebra
since we are working in python we're
going to use our numpy i always import
that as np or numpy array probably the
most popular
module for doing matrixes and things in
given that this is part of a series i'm
not going to go too much into numpy we
are going to go ahead and create two
different variables a for a numpy array
10 15 and b 29
we'll go ahead and run this and you can
see there's our two arrays 10 15 29 and
i went and added a space there in
between
so it's easier to read
and since it's the last line we don't
have to put the print statement on
unless you want we can simply but we can
simply do a plus b so when i run this
we have 10 15 29 and we get 30 24 which
is what you expect 10 plus 20 15 plus 9
you could almost look at this addition
as being
just adding up the columns on here
coming down and if we wanted to do it a
different way we could also do a dot t
plus b dot t
remember that t flips them and so if we
do that we now get them
we now have 30 24 going the other way
we could also do something kind of fun
there's a lot of different ways to do
this
as far as a plus b i can also do a plus
b
dot t
and you're going to see that that will
come out the same the 30 24 whether i
transpose a and b or transpose them both
at the end
and likewise we can very easily subtract
two vectors i can go a minus b
and we run that and we get minus 10 6.
now remember this is the last line in
this particular section that's why not
to put the print around it
and just like we did before
we can transpose either the individual
or we can transpose the main setup and
then we get a minus 10 6 going the other
way
now we didn't mention this in our notes
but you can also do a scalar
multiplication
and just put down the scalar so you can
remember that
uh what we're talking about here is i
have
this array here u
and if i go a
times u
we'll take the value 2 we'll multiply it
by every value in here so 2 times 30 is
60 2 times 15.
and just like we did before
this happens a lot because when you're
doing matrixes you do need to flip them
you get 60 30 coming this way
so in numpy uh we have what they call
dot product
and uh with this this is in a two
dimensional vectors it is the equivalent
of two matrix multiplication remember we
were talking about matrix multiplication
uh where it is the
[Music]
well let's walk through it
we'll go ahead and start by defining two
um
numpy arrays we'll have uh 10 20 25 6 or
our u and our v uh and then we're going
to go ahead and do
if we take
the values
and if you remember correctly
an array like this would be 10 times 25
plus 20 times 6.
we'll go ahead and
print that
there we go
and then we'll go ahead and do the np
dot dot
of u comma
v
and we'll find when we do this we go and
run this
we're going to get
370.
so this is a strain multiplication where
they use it to solve
linear algebra when you have multiple
numbers going across and so this could
be very complicated we could have a
whole string of different variables
going in here but for this we get a nice
value for our dot multiplication
and we did
addition earlier which is just your
basic addition
uh and of course the matrix you can get
very complicated on these or
in this case we'll go ahead and do
um let's create two
complex matrixes
this one is a matrix of um you know 12
10 4 6 4 31. we'll just print out a so
you can see what that looks like here's
print
a
we print a out you can see that we have
2 by 3
layer matrix for a
and we can also put together
always kind of fun when you're playing
with print values
we could do something like this we could
go in here
there we go
we could print a we have it end with
equals a
run
and this kind of gives it a nice look
here's your matrix that's all this is
comma n means it just tags it on the end
that's all all that is doing on there
and then we can simply add in what is a
plus b and you should already guess
because this is the same as what we did
before there's no difference
we do a simple vector addition we have
12 plus 2 is 14 10 plus 8 is 18 and so
on
and just like we did the matrix addition
we can also do a minus b
and do our matrix subtraction
and we look at this we have what 12
minus 2 is 10 10 minus 8 um where are we
oh there we go 8 minus
confusing what i'm looking at i should
have reprinted out the original numbers
but we can see here 12 minus 2 is of
course 10 10 minus 8 is 2
4 minus 46 is minus 42 and so forth so
same as the subtraction as before we
just call it matrix subtraction is
identical
now if you remember up here we had a
scalar addition we're adding just one
number
to a matrix you can also do scalar
multiplication
and so simply if you have a single value
a and you have b which is your array we
can also do a times b
when we run that
you can see here we have 2 times 4 is 8.
5 times 4 is 20 and so forth you're just
multiplying the 4 across each one of
these values
and this is an interesting one that
comes up
a little bit of a brain teaser is matrix
and vector multiplication
and so when we're looking at this
we are
just doing regular arrays it doesn't
necessarily have to be a numpy array
we have a
which has our
array of arrays and b which is a single
array and so we can from here
do the dot
a b
and this is going to return two values
and the first value is that it's you
could say it's like uh
we're doing the
this array b array
first with a and then with a second one
and so it splits it up so you have a
matrix of vector multiplication and you
can mix and match
when you get into really complicated
backend stuff this becomes more common
because you're now you've got layers
upon layers of data and so you'll end up
with a matrix and a set of bolt
vector matrices do you want to multiply
now keep in mind
that if you're doing data science a lot
of times you're not looking at this this
is what's going on behind the scenes so
if you're in
the scikit looking at sk learn where
you're doing linear regression models
this is some of the math that's hidden
behind the scenes that's going on
other times you might find yourself
having to do part of this and manipulate
the data around so it fits right and
then you go back in and you run it
through the psi kit and if we can do
up here where we did a
matrix and vector multiplication we can
also do matrix two matrix multiplication
and if we run this where we have the two
matrixes
you can see we have a very complicated
array that of course comes out on there
for our dot and just to reiterate it we
have our transpose a matrix which is
your dot t
and so if we create a matrix a and we do
transpose it you can see how it flips it
from
5 10 15 20 25 30 to 5 15 25
10 20 30
rows and columns
and certainly with the math this comes
up a lot
it also comes up a lot with xy plotting
when you put in the pi plot you have one
format where they're looking at pairs
and numbers and then they want all of
x's and all y's
so you know the transpose is an
important tool both for your math and
for plotting and all kinds of things
another tool that we didn't discuss
is your identity matrix
and this one is more definition
the identity matrix
we have here one where we just did two
so it comes down as one zero zero one uh
one zero zero zero one zero it creates a
diagonal of one and what that is is when
you're doing your identities you could
be comparing
all your different features to the
different features and how they
correlate and of course when you have
feature one compared to feature one to
itself it is always
one
where
usually it's between zero 1 depending on
how well correlates so when we're
talking about identity matrix that's
what we're talking about right here is
that you create this preset matrix and
then you might adjust these numbers
depending on what you're working with
and what the domain is
and then another thing we can do
to kind of wrap this up we'll hit you
with the most complicated uh
piece of this
puzzle here is an inverse
a matrix
and let's just go ahead and put the um
it's a lengthy description
let's go and put the description this is
straight out of the uh
the website for
numpy
so given a square matrix a here's our
square matrix a which is 2 1 0 0 1 0 1 2
1. keep in mind 3 by 3 is square it's
got to be equal it's going to return the
matrix a inverse satisfying dot a
a inverse so here's our matrix
multiplication
and then of course it equals the dot
yeah a inverse of a
with an identity shape of
a dot shaped 0. this is just reshaping
the identity
that's a little complicated there uh so
we're going to have our here's our array
uh we'll go ahead and run this
and you can see what we end up with
is we end up with an array 0.5 minus
point five and so forth with our two one
one going down two one zero zero one
zero one two one
um
getting into a little deep on the math
understanding
when you need this is probably really is
is what's really important when you're
doing data science
versus uh handwriting this out and
looking up the math and handwriting all
the pieces out you do need to know about
the linear algorithm inverse of a
so if it comes up you can easily pull it
up or at least remember where to look it
up you took a look at the algebra side
of it let's go ahead and take a look at
the calculus side of what's going on
here with the machine learning
so
calculus oh my goodness and differential
equations you got to throw that in there
because that's all part of the
bag of tricks especially when you're
doing large neural networks but also
comes up in many other areas the good
news is most of it's already done for
you in the back end so when it comes up
you really do need to understand from
the data science not data analytics data
analytics means you're digging deep into
actually solving these math equations
and a neural network is just a giant
differential equation
so we talk about calculus
we're going to go ahead
and understand it by talking about cars
versus time and speed
uh so it helps to calculate the
spontaneous rate of change
so suppose we plot a graph of the speed
of a car with respect to time
so as you can see here going down the
highway probably merged into the highway
from an on-ramp so i had to accelerate
so my speed went way up
stuck in traffic
merged into the traffic traffic opens up
and i accelerate again up to the speed
limit
and uh maybe peter's off up there so you
can look at this is as
the speed versus time i'm getting faster
and faster because i'm continually
accelerating and if i hit the brakes you
go the other way
so the rate of change of speed with
respect of time is nothing but
acceleration how fast are we
accelerating
the acceleration is the area between the
star point of x and the end point of
delta x
so we can calculate a simple
if you had x and delta x we could put a
line there and that slope of the line is
our acceleration
now that's pretty easy when you're doing
linear algebra but i don't want to know
it just for that line and those two
points i want to know what across the
whole of what i'm working with
that's where we get into calculus
so we talk about the distance between x
and delta x it has to be the smallest
possible near to zero in order to
approximate the acceleration
so the idea is instead of i mean if you
ever did took a basic calculus class
they would draw bars down here and you
would divide this area up
let's go back up the screen you divide
this area of this time period up into
maybe 10 sections and you'd use that and
you could calculate the acceleration
between each one of those 10 sections
kind of thing
and then we just keep making that space
smaller and smaller until delta x is
almost
infinitesimally small
and so we get a function of a
equals a limit as h goes to 0 of a
function of a plus h minus a function of
a over h and that is you're
computing the slope of the line
we're just computing that slope and
they're smaller and smaller and smaller
samples
and that's what calculus is calculus is
the integral you can see down here we
have our nice uh integral sign looks
like a giant s
and that's what that means is that we've
taken this down to as small as we can
for that sampling
so we're talking about calculus we're
finding the area under the slope is the
main process in the integration
similar small intervals are made of the
smallest possible length of x plus delta
x where delta x approaches almost an
infinitesimally small space
and then it helps to find the overall
acceleration by summing up all the links
together uh so we're summing up all the
accelerations from the beginning to the
end
and so here's our integral we sum of a
of x times d of x
equals a plus c
that is our basic calculus here
so when we talk about multivariate
calculus
multivariate calculus deals with
functions that have multiple variables
and you can see here we start getting
into some very complicated equations um
change in w over change of time
equals change of w over change of z
the differential of z to dx differential
of x to dt it gets pretty complicated uh
it really translates into the
multivariate integration using double
integrals and so you have the the sum of
the sum of f of x of y of d of a equals
the sum from c to d and a to b of f of x
y d x d y equals
the sum of a to b sum of c to d of f x
of y d y d x
understanding the very specifics of
everything going on in here and actually
doing the math is usually calculus 1
calculus 2 and differential equations
so you're talking about three full
length courses to dig into
and solve these math equations
what we want to take from here is we're
talking about calculus uh we're talking
about summing of all these different
slopes and so we're still solving a
linear
expression we're still solving y equals
m x plus b
but we're doing this for infinitesimally
small x's and then we want to sum them
up that's what this integral sign means
the
sum of a of x d of x equals a plus c
and when you see these very complicated
uh multivariate differentiation using
the chain rule
uh when we come in here and we have the
change of w to the change of t equals
the change of w dz
uh and so forth
that's what's going on here that's what
these means we're basically looking for
the area under the curve which really
comes to
how is the change changing speeds going
up how is that changing and then you end
up with a multiple layer so if i have
three layers of neural networks how is
the third layer changing based on the
second layer changing which is based on
the first layer changing and you get the
picture here that now we have a very
complicated
multivariate integration
with integrals
the good news is we can solve this uh
mathematically and that's what we do
when you do neural networks and reverse
propagation uh so the nice thing is that
you don't have to solve this on paper
unless you're a data analysis and you're
working on the back end of integrating
these formulas and building the script
to actually build them so we talk about
applications of calculus it provides us
the tools to build an accurate
predictive model
so it's really behind the scenes we want
to guess that what the change of the
change of the change is
that's a little goofy i i know i just
threw that out there it's kind of a meta
term but if you can guess how things are
going to change then you can guess what
the new numbers are
multivariate calculus explains the
change in our target variable in
relation to the rate of change in the
input variables
so there's our multiple variables going
in there if one variable is changing how
does it affect the other variable
and then in gradient descent calculus is
used to find the local and global maxima
and this is really big uh we're going to
actually going to have a whole section
here on gradient descent because it is
really i mean i talked about neural
networks and how you can see how the
different layers go in there but
gradient descent is one of the most key
things for trying to guess the best
answer to something
so let's take a look at the code behind
gradient descent
and uh before we open up the code let's
just do real quick
gradient descent
let's say we have a curve like this and
most common is that this is going to
represent your error oops
error there we go error
ah hard to read there and i want to make
the error as low as possible
and so what i'm looking at it is i want
to find this line here
which is the minimum value so we're
looking for the minimum
and it does that by
sampling there and then based on this it
guesses it might be someplace here and
it goes hey this is still going down
it goes here and then goes back over
here and then goes a little bit closer
and it's just playing a high low until
it gets to that spot that bottom spot
and so we want to minimize the error
and
on the flip note you could also want to
be maximizing something you want to get
the best output of it
that's simply minus the value
so if you're looking for where the peak
is
this is the same as a negative
for where the valley is i'm looking for
that valley
that's all that is this is a way of
finding it so
the cool thing is um all the heavy
lifting's done i actually
ended up putting together one of these a
while back is when i didn't know about
sidekick and i was just starting
boys a long while back
and
is playing hi low how do you play hi-lo
not get stuck in the valleys
figure out these curves and things like
that well you do that and the back end
is all the calculus and differential
equations to calculate this out
the good news is you don't have to do
those
uh so instead we're going to put
together the code and let's go ahead
and see what we can do with that
so
guys in the back put together a nice
little piece of code here which is kind
of fun
uh some things we're gonna note and this
is this is really important stuff
because when you start doing your data
science and digging into your machine
learning models
you're gonna find these things are
stumbling blocks uh the first one is
current x where do we start at uh keep
in mind
your model that you're working with is
very generic so whatever you use to
minimize it the first question is where
do we start
and we started at this because the
algorithm starts at x equals three
so we arbitrarily picked five
learning rate is uh how many bars to
skip going one way or the other i'm in
fact i'm going to separate that a little
bit because these two are really
important
if we're dealing with something like
this where we're talking about
well here's our here's the function
we're going to use our
gradient of our function
2 times x plus five keep it simple so
that's a function we're going to work
with so if i'm dealing with increments
of a thousand point one is going to be a
very long time and if i'm dealing with
increments of 0.001
uh 0.1 is going to skip over my answer
so i won't get a very good answer
and then we look at precision this tells
us when to stop the algorithm so again
very specific to what you're working on
if you're working with money and
you don't convert it into a float value
you might be dealing with 0.01 which is
a penny that might be your precision
you're working with
and then of course the previous step
size max iterations we want something to
cut out at a certain point usually
that's built into a lot of minimization
functions
and then here's our actual
formula we're going to be working with
and then we come in we go while previous
step size is greater than percent and it
errors is less than max and max iters
let's say that 10 times fast um
we're just saying if it's uh if we're if
we're still greater than our precision
level we still got to keep digging
deeper
and then we also don't want to go past a
thou or whatever this is a million or
ten thousand uh running that's actually
pretty high i almost never do max
iterations more than like a hundred or
two hundred rare occasions you might go
up to four or five hundred if it's
depending on the problem you're working
with uh so we have our previous equals
our current that way we can track
time-wise
uh the current now equals the current
minus the rate times the formula of our
previous x
so now we've generated our new version
previous step size equals the absolute
current previous
so we're looking for the change in x
errors equals iterations plus one that's
so we know to stop if we get too far
and then we're just going to print the
local minimum occurs at
x on here and if we go ahead and run
this
you can see right here it gets down to
this point and it says hey
local minimum is minus
3.3222 for this particular series we
created
this is created off of our formula here
lambda x2 times x plus 5. now
when i'm running this stuff
you'll see this come up a lot
in with the sk learn kit
and one of the nice reasons of breaking
this down the way we did is i could go
over those top pieces
those top pieces are everything when you
start looking at these minimization tool
kits in built-in code
and so from
we'll just do it's actually
docs
dot
scipy.org
and we're looking at
the psi kit
there we go
optimize minimize
you can only minimize one value you have
the function that's going in this
function can be very complicated
so we used a very simple function up
here
it could be
there's all kinds of things that could
be on there and there's a number of
methods to solve this as far as how they
shrink down
and your x not there's your there's your
start value so your function your start
value
um
there's all kinds of things that come in
here that you can look at which we're
not going to
optimization automatically creates
constraints bounds
some of this it does automatically but
you really the big thing i want to point
out here is you need to have a starting
point you want to start with something
that you already know is mostly the
answer
if you don't then it's going to have a
heck of a time trying to calculate it
out
or you can write your own little script
that does this and does a high low
guessing and tries to find the max value
that brings us to statistics what this
is kind of all about is figuring things
out a lot of vocabulary and statistics
ah so statistics well i guess it's all
relative it's definitely not an edel
class
so a bunch of stuff going on statistics
statistics concerns with the collection
organization analysis interpretation
and presentation of data
that is a mouthful um so we have from
end to end
where does it come from is it valid what
does it mean how do we organize it
how do we analyze it then you got to
take those analysis and interpret it
into something that people can use kind
of reduce it to
understandable
and nowadays you have to be able to
present it if you can't present it then
no one else is going to understand what
the heck you did
so we look at the terminologies
there is a lot of terminologies
depending on what domain you're working
in
so clearly if you're working in
a domain that deals with
viruses and t cells and and
how does you know where does that come
from you're studying the different
people then you can have a population
if you are working with
mechanical gear
you know a little bit different if
you're looking for the wobbling
statistics to know when to replace a
rotor on a machine or something like
that that can be a big deal you know we
have these huge fans that turn
in our sewage processing systems and so
those fans they start to wobble and hum
and do different things that the sensors
pick up at one point do you replace them
instead of waiting for it to break in
which case it costs a lot of money
instead of replacing a bushing you're
replacing the whole fan unit
an interesting project that came up for
our city a while back
so population all objects are
measurements whose properties are being
observed uh so that's your population
all the objects it's easy to see it with
people because we have our population
enlarged
but in the case of the sewer fans we're
talking about the fan units that's the
population of fans that we're working
with
you have a parameter a matrix that is
used to represent a population or
characteristic
you have your sample a subset of the
population studied you don't want to do
them all because then you don't have a
if you come up with a conclusion for
everyone you don't have a way of testing
it so you take a sample
sometimes you don't have a choice you
can only take a sample of what's going
on you can't
study the whole population
and a variable a metric of interest for
each person or object in a population
types of sampling
we have a probabilistic approach
selecting samples from a larger
population using a method based on the
theory of probability
and we'll go into a little bit more
deeper on these we have random
systematic stratified and then you have
a non-probabilistic approach selecting
samples based on the subjective judgment
of the researcher rather than random
selection it has to do with convenience
trying to reach a quota
or snowball
and they're very biased that's one of
the reasons you'll see this big stamp on
that says biased so you gotta be very
careful on that
so probabilistic sampling uh when we
talk about a random sampling we select
random size samples from each group or
category so we it's as random as you can
get we talk about systematic sampling
we're selecting random size samples from
each group or category with a fixed
periodic interval
uh so we kind of split it up this would
be like a time set up or our different
categories
and you might ask your question what is
a category or a group
if you look at i'm going to go back a
window let's say we're studying
economics of different of an area
we know pretty much that based on their
culture where they came from
they might need to be separated and so
uh and why i say separated i don't mean
separated from their place where they
live i mean as far as the analysis we
want to look at the different groups and
make sure they're all represented
so if we had like an eighty percent uh
of a group that is hispanic and or
indian and also in that same area we
have twenty percent twenty percent who
are uh let's call our expatriates they
left america and they're nice and
your caucasian group we might want to
sample a group that is representative of
both
so we're talking about stratified
sampling and we're talking about groups
those are the groups we're talking about
and that brings us to stratified
sampling selecting approximately equal
size samples from each group or category
this way we can actually separate the
categories and give us an insight into
the different cultures and how that
might affect them in that area
so you can see these are very very
different kind of
depends on what you're working with
as far as your data and what you're
studying
and so we can see here just a little bit
more we have selecting 25 employees from
a company of 250 employees randomly
don't care anything about them what
groups are in which office they're in
nothing
and we might be selecting one employee
from every 50 unique employees in a
company of 250 employees
and then we have selecting one employee
from every branch in the company office
so we have all the different branches
there's our group or categories by the
branch and the category could depend on
what you're studying so it has a lot of
variation on there
you see this kind of grouping and
categorizing is also used to generate a
lot of misinformation
so if you only study one group and you
say this is what it is
then everybody assumes that's what it is
for everybody and so you've got to be
very careful of that and it's very
unethical thing to kind of do
so types of statistics we talk about
statistics
we're going to talk about descriptive
and inferential statistics
there are so many different terms and
statistics to break it up
so we so we're talking about a
particular
setup
so we're talking about descriptive and
inferential uh statistics
the base of the word describe
is pretty solid you're describing the
data what does it look like
with inferential statistics we're going
to take that from the small population
to a large population so if you're
working with a drug company you might
look at the data and say these people
were helped by this drug
they did uh 80 better
as far as their health or 80 percent
better survival rate than the people
um
who did not have the drug so we can
infer that that drug will work in the
greater populace and will help people so
that's where you get your inferential so
we are predicting how it's going to
affect the greater population
so descriptive statistics it is used to
describe the basic features of data and
form the basis of quantitative analysis
of data
so we have a measure of central
tendencies we have your mean median and
mode
and then we have a measure of spread
like your range your interquartile range
your variance and your standard
deviation
and we're going to look at all these a
little deeper here in a second
but one of them you can think of is
how it the data difference
differences you know what's the max min
range all that stuff is your spread and
anything that's just a single number is
usually your central
tendencies measure of central tendencies
so we talk about the mean it is the
average of the set of values considered
what is the average outcome of whatever
is going on
and then your median
separates the higher half and the lower
half of data
so where's the center point of all your
different data points
so your mean might have some a couple
really big numbers that skew it
so that the average is much higher than
if you took those outliers out where the
median would by separating the high from
the low might give you a much lower
number you might look at and say oh
that's that's odd why is the average so
much higher than the median well it's
because you have some outliers or why is
it so much lower
and then the mode is the most frequent
appearing value this is really
interesting if you're studying economics
and how people are doing you might find
that the most common
income like in the u.s was
1.24 000 a year
where the average was closer to 80 000
and it's like wow what a difference well
there's some people have a lot of money
and so that skews that way up so the
average person is not making that kind
of money and then you look at the median
income and you're like well the median
income is a little bit closer to the
average so it does create a very
interesting way of looking at the data
again these are all
central tendencies single numbers you
can look at for the whole spread of the
data
and we look at the measure of central
tendencies the mean is the average marks
of a students in a classroom so here we
have the mean sum of the marks of the
students total number of students and as
we talked about the median
if we have
0 through 10 and we take half the
numbers and put them on one side of the
line half the numbers on the other side
of the line
we end up with 5 in the middle and then
the mode what mark was scored by most of
the students in a test
in a simple case where most people
scored like an 82 percent and got
certain problems wrong easy to figure
out uh not so easy when you have
different areas where like you have like
the um oh let's go back to economy a
little bit more difficult to calculate
if you have a large group that scores
that makes 30 000
and a slightly bigger group that makes
26 000 so what do you put down for the
mode certainly there's a number of ways
to calculate that and there's actually
different variations depending on what
you're doing
so now we're looking at a measure of
spread uh range what's the difference
between the highest and the lowest value
first thing you want to look at you know
it's we had everybody in the test score
between 60 and 100 percent somebody got
100 or maybe 60 to 90 it was so hard
that a lot of people could not get 100
percent
um you have your
interquartile range quartiles divide a
rank ordered data set into four equal
parts
very common thing to do as part of all
the basic packages whether you're
working in
data frames with pandas whether you're
working in scala whether you're working
in r
you'll see this come up where they have
range your min your max and then it'll
have your interquartile range how does
it look like in each quarter of data
variance measures how far each number in
the set is from the mean and therefore
from every other number in the set
uh so you have like how much turbulence
is going on in this data
and then the standard deviation
it is the measure of the variance or the
dispersion of a set of values from the
mean
and you'll usually see if i'm doing a
graph i might have the value graphed
and then based on the the error i might
graph graph the standard deviation in
the error on the graph as a background
so you can see how far off it is
so standard deviation is used a lot
so measurement of spread
marks of a student out of a hundred we
have here from 50 to 63 or 50 to 90.
so the range maximum marks minimum marks
we have 90 to 45 and the spread of that
is 45 90 minus 45. and then we have the
interquartile range using the same marks
over there you can see here where the
median is
and then there's the first quarter the
second quarter and the third quarter
based on splitting it apart by those
values
and to understand the variance and
standard deviation we first need to find
out the mean uh so here's our our you
know calculating the average there we
end up at approximately 66 for the
average and then we look at that the
variance once we know the means we can
do equals the marks minus the mean
squared
why is it squared
because one you want to make sure it's
you don't have like if you if you're
putting all this stuff together you end
up with an error as far as one's
negative one's positive one's a little
higher one's a little lower
uh so you always see
the squared value and over the total
observations and so the standard
deviation equals the square root of the
variance which is approximately 16.
and if you were looking at
a predictable model you would be looking
at the deviation based on the error how
much error does it have
that's again
really important to know if your if your
prediction is predicting something
what's the chance of it being way off or
just a little bit off
now that we've looked at the tools as
far as some of the basics for doing your
statistics and what we're talking about
let's go ahead and pull up a little demo
and show you what that looks like in
python code
so you can get some little hands-on here
for that let's go in back into our
jupiter notebook in python now almost
all of this you can do in numpy last
time we worked in numpy this time we're
going to go ahead and use pandas
and if you remember from pandas on here
this is basically a data frame rows
columns let's just go ahead and do a
print
df.head
and run that
and you can see we have the name jane
michael william rosie hanna sat on their
salaries on here and of course instead
of having to do all those hand
calculations and add everything together
and divide by the total
we can do something very simple on this
like use the command mean in pandas and
so if i go ahead and do this print df
pick our column salary because we want
to find the means of that calorie
we want to find the means of that column
and we go and print this out and you can
see that the
average income on here is 71 000.
uh and let's just go ahead and do this
we'll go ahead and put in
means
and if we're going to do that we also
might want to find the median
and the median is
very similar
except it actually is just median we're
used to means in average it's kind of
interesting that those are they use the
two different words
there can be in some computation slight
differences but for the most part the
means is the average uh and then the
median
oops just put a
median here
do you have salary that way it displays
a little better we can see the median is
000. so the halfway mark is
significantly below the average
why because we have somebody in here
makes 189 000. darn you rosie for
throwing off our numbers
but that's something you'd want to
notice this is this is the difference
between these is huge and so is what is
the meaning behind that when you're
studying a populist and looking at
the different data coming in and of
course we also want to find out hey
what's the most uh common
income that people make
in this little tiny sample and so we'll
go ahead and do the mode
and you can see here with the mode uh
it's at 50 000.
so this is this is very telling that
most people are making 50 000
the middle point is at 54 000. so half
the people are making more than that
what that tells me is that if the most
common income is below the median
then
there's a few there's a scale there's a
lot of high salaries going up but
there's some really low salaries in
there
and so this trend which is very common
in statistic when you're analyzing
the economy and different people's
income is pretty common and the bigger
difference between these is also
very important when we're studying
statistics
and when you hear someone just say hey
the average income was you might start
asking questions at that point why
aren't you talking about the median
income why aren't you talking about the
mode the most common income what are you
hiding
uh and if you're doing these analysis
you should be looking at these saying
hey why are these discrepancies why are
these so different and of course with
any analysis it's important to find out
the minimum
and the maximum so we'll go ahead it's
just simply
dot min
it'll pull up your minimum and then dot
max pulls up the maximum
pretty straightforward on as far as
translating it and knowing which you
know what the
lowest value what your highest value is
here
which you'll use to generate like a
spread later on and real quick on no
mode uh note that it puts mode 0. like i
said there's a couple different ways you
can compute the mode
although the standard one is pretty good
we can of course do the range which is
your max minus your min so now we have a
range of 149 000 between the
upper end and the lower end and you
might want to be looking up the
individual values on all of these but it
turns out there is a describe
feature in pandas
and so in pandas we can actually do df
salary describe and if we do this you
can see we have that there's seven
setups here's our mean
our standard deviation which we didn't
compute yet which would just be a dot
std
and you got to be a little careful
because when it computes it it looks for
axes and things like that
we have our minimum value and here's our
quartiles
our maximum value and then of course the
name salary
so these are the these are the basic
statistics you can pull them up and like
just describe
this is a dictionary so i could actually
do something like
in here i could actually go
count
and run and now it just prints the count
so because this is a dictionary you can
pull any one of these values out of here
it's kind of a quick and dirty way to
pull all the different information and
then split it up and depending on what
you need
now if i just walked in and gave you
this information
in a meeting
at some point you would just kind of
fall asleep
that's what i would do anyway
so we want to go ahead and see about
graphing it here and we'll go ahead and
put it into a histogram and plot that
graph on it
of the salaries and let's just go ahead
and put that in here so
we do our map plot inline remember
that's a jupiter's notebook thing
a lot of the new version of the matplot
library does it automatically
but just in case i always put it in
there import matplot library piplot is
plt that's my plotting
and then we have our data frame i don't
i guess i really don't need to respell
the data frame
maybe we could just remind ourselves
what's in it so we'll go ahead and just
print
df that way we still have it
and then we have our salary df salary
salary.plot history title salary
distribution color gray
plot ax v line salary the mean value so
we're going to take the mean value
color violet
line style dash this is just all making
it pretty
what color dashed line line width of 2
that kind of thing
and the median and let's go ahead and
run this just so you can see we're
talking about
and so up here we are taking on our plot
so here's the data here's our our data
frame print it out so you can see it
with the salaries we'll look at the
salary distribution and just look at
this the way the salary is distributed
you have our
in this case we did let's see we had red
for the median
we have violet
for our average or mean
and you can just see how it really
i mean here's our outlier here's our
person who makes a lot of money here's
the
average and here's the median
and so as you look at this you can say
wow
based on the average it really doesn't
tell you much about what people are
really taking home all it does is tell
you how much money is in this you know
what the average salary is
so
some of the things you want to take away
in addition to this is that it's very
easy to plot
an ax v line
these are these up and down lines for
your markers
and as you just display the data i mean
you can add all kinds of things to this
and get really complicated keeping it
simple is pretty straightforward i look
at this and i can see we have a major
outlier out here we can definitely do a
histogram and stuff like that
but you know pictures worth a thousand
words
what you really want to make sure you
take away is that we can do a basic
describe
which pulls all this information out and
we can print any of the individual
information from the describe
because this is a dictionary
and so if we want to go ahead and look
up
the mean value we can also do describe
mean so if you're doing a lot of
statistics
being able to
[Music]
it doesn't have the print on there so
it's only going to print the last one
which happens to be the mean
you can very easily reference any one of
these and then you can also if you're
doing something a little bit more
complicated and you don't need just the
basics you can come through and pull any
one of the individual
references from the from the pandas on
here so now we've had a chance to
describe our data
let's get into inferential statistics
inferential statistics allows you to
make predictions or inferences from data
and you can see here we have a nice
little picture movie ratings and
[Music]
if we took this group of people and said
hey how many people like the movie
dislike it can't say and then you ask
just a random person who comes out of
the movie who hasn't been in this study
you can infer that 55 chance of saying
liked
35 chance of saying disliked or a 10 or
11 percent chance of can't say so that's
real basics of what we're talking about
you're going to infer that the next
person is going to follow these
statistics uh so let's look at point
estimation uh it is a process of finding
an approximate value for a population's
parameter like mean
or average from random samples of the
population
let's take an example of testing
vaccines for covid19
vaccines and flu bugs all that it's a
pretty big thing of how do you test
these out and make sure they're going to
work on the populace
a group of people are chosen from the
population medical trials are performed
results are generalized for the whole
population so here's a protected there's
our small group up here where we've
selected them we run medical trials on
them and then the results work for the
population
nice diagram with the arrows going back
and forth in the very scary coveted
virus in the middle of one
and let's take a look at the
applications of inferential statistics
very central is what they call
hypotheses testing
and the confidence interval which go
with that and then as we get into
probability we get into our binomial
theorem our normal distribution in
central limit theorem
hypothesis testing hypothesis testing is
used to measure the plausibility of a
hypothesis
assumption by using sample data
now
when we talk about theorems
theory
hypothesis
keep in mind that if you are in a
philosophy class
theory
is the same as hypothesis where theorem
is a scientific
statement that is something that has
been proven
although it is always up for debate
because in science we always want to
make sure things are up to debate so
hypothesis is the same as a
philosophical class calling a theory
where theory in science is not the same
theory in science says this has been
well proven gravity is a theory
so if you want to debate the theory of
gravity try jumping up and down if you
want to have a theory about why the
economy is collapsing in your area
that is a philosophical debate
very important i've heard people mix
those up and it is a pet peeve of mine
when we talk about hypotheses testing
the steps involved in hypotheses testing
is first we formulate a hypothesis
we figure out the right test to test our
hypothesis we execute the test and we
make a decision
and so when you're talking about
hypothesis you're usually trying to
disprove it if you can't disprove it
and it works for all the facts then you
might call that a theorem at some point
so in a use case uh let's consider an
example we have four students we're
given a task to clean a room every day
it sounds like working with my kids they
decided to distribute the job of
cleaning the room among themselves they
did so by making four chits which has
their names on it and the name that gets
picked up has to do the cleaning for
that day
rob took the opportunity to make chits
and wrote everyone's name on it so
here's our four people nick rob emlia
imlia and summer
now rick emilia and summer are asking us
to decide whether rob has done some
mischief in preparing the chits i.e
whether rob has written his name on one
of the chit
for that we will find out the
probability of rob getting the cleaning
job on first day second day third day
and so on till 12 days
the probability of rob getting the job
decreases every day ie his turn never
comes up then definitely he has done
some mischief while making the chits
so the probability of rob not doing work
on day one is uh three out of four
there's a 0.75 chance that he didn't do
work
two days three fourths times three
fourths equals point five six
three days you have 3 4 3 4 3 4 which
equals 0.42
when you get to day 12 it's 0.032 which
is less than 0.05
remember this 0.05 that comes up a lot
when we're talking about
certain values when we're looking at
statistics
rob is cheating as he was consecutive
days that's a very high probability when
on day 12 he still hasn't gotten the job
cleaning the room
so we come up to our important important
terminologies
we have null hypothesis
a general statement that states that
there is no relationship between two
measured phenomena or no association
among the groups
hypothesis
contrary to the null hypothesis it
states whenever something is happening a
new theory is preferred instead of an
old one and so the two hypotheses go
hand in hand uh so your null this is
always interesting in in when talking
about data science and the math behind
it
it's about proving that the things have
no correlation null hypothesis says
these two have zero relation to each
other where the alternative hypothesis
says hey we found a relation this is
what it is
we have p-value the p-value is a
probability of finding the observed or
more extreme results when the null
hypothesis of a study question is true
and the t-value it is simply the
calculated difference represented in
units of standard error the greater the
magnitude of t the greater the evidence
against the null hypothesis and you can
look at the t values being specific to
the test you're doing
where the p value is derived from your t
value and you're looking for what they
call the five percent or the 0.05
showing that it has a high correlation
so
digging in deeper let's assume that a
new drug is developed with the goal of
lowering the blood pressure more than
the existing drug
and this is a good one because the null
value here isn't that you don't have any
drug the null value here is that it's
better than the existing drug the new
drug doesn't lower the blood pressure
more than the existing drug now if we
get that
that says our null hypothesis is correct
there is no correlation and the new drug
is not doing its job the alternative
hypothesis the new drug does
significantly lower the blood pressure
more than the existing drug
yay we got a new drug out there and
that's our alternative hypothesis or the
h1 or ha
and we look at the p value results from
the evidence like medical trial showing
positive results which will reject the
null hypothesis
and again they're looking for
a 0.05 or 5 percent and the t value
comparing all the positive test results
and finding means of different samples
in order to test hypothesis so this is
specific to the test how what percentage
of increase did they have
and this leads us to the confidence
intervals
a confidence interval is a range of
values we are sure our true values of
observations lie in
let's say you asked a dog owner around
you and asked them how many cans of food
do you buy for your per year for your
dog
through calculations you got to know
that the on an average around 95 percent
of the people bought around 200 to 300
cans of food hence we can say that we
have a confidence interval of two three
hundred where ninety five percent of our
values lie in that spring data spread
uh and this the graph really helps a lot
so you can start seeing what you're
looking at here we have the 95 percent
you have your peak in this case it's a
normal distributions here the nice bell
curve equal on both sides it's not
asymmetrical and 95 percent of all the
values lie within a very small range and
then you have your outliers the 2.5
percent going each way
so we touched upon hypothesis uh we're
going to move into probability so you
have your hypothesis once you've
generated your hypothesis we want to
know the probability of something
occurring probability is a measure of
the likelihood of an event to occur any
event can be predicted with total
certainty and can only be predicted as a
likelihood of its occurrence so any
event cannot be predicted with total
certainty can only be predicted as a
likelihood of its occurrence
score prediction how good you're going
to do in whatever
sport you're in weather prediction stock
prediction
if you've studied physics and chaos
theory even the location of the chair
you're sitting on has a probability that
it might move three feet over
granted that probability is one in like
uh uh i think we calculated as under one
in trillions upon trillions so it's the
better the probability the more likely
it's going to happen there are some
things that have such a low probability
that we don't see them so we talk about
random variable a random variable is a
variable whose possible values are
numerical outcomes of a random phenomena
so uh we have the coin tossed how many
heads will occur in the series of 20
coin flips probably you know the on
average they're 10 but you really can't
know because it's very random how many
times a red ball is picked from a bag of
balls if there's equal number of red
balls and blue balls and green balls in
there how many times the sum of digits
on two dice
results are five each
um
so you know there's how often you're
gonna roll two fives on your paradigms
so in a use case uh let's consider the
example of rolling two dice we have a
random variable outcome equals y you can
take values two three four five six
seven eight nine ten eleven twelve
so we have a random variable and a
combination of dice
and instead of looking at how many times
both dice for row five let's go ahead
and look at total sum of five and you
have in as far as your random variables
you can have a one four equals five four
one two three three two
so four of those rolls can be four if
you look at all the different options
you have four of those random rolls can
be a five
and if we look at the total
number which happens to be 36 different
options
uh you can see that we have four out of
36 chance every time you roll the dice
that you're gonna roll a total of five
you can have an outcome of five
and uh we'll look a little deeper as to
what that means but you could think of
that at what point if someone never
rolls a five or they always roll a five
can you say hey that person's probably
cheating
we'll look a little closer at the math
behind that but let's just consider this
is one of the cases is rolling two dice
and gambling
there's also binomial distribution it is
the probability of getting success or
failure as an outcome in an experiment
or trial that is repeated multiple times
and the key is is by meaning two
binomial uh so passing or failing an
exam winning or losing a game and
getting either head or tails so if you
ever see binomial distribution it's
based on a
true false kind of setup you win or lose
let's consider a use case and let's
consider the game of football between
two clubs
barcelona and dortmund the teams will
have to play a total of four matches and
we have to find out the chances of
barcelona winning the series
so we look at the total games and we're
looking at five different games or
matches
let's say that the winning chance for
barcelona is 75 percent or 0.75
that means that each game they have a 75
chance that they're going to win that
game and losing chances are 25 percent
or 0.25
clearly 0.75 plus 0.25 equals 1. so that
accounts for 100 of the game probability
for getting k wins in in matches is
calculated
and we we're talking like so if you have
five games and you want to know if i
play
how many wins in those five games should
i get what's a percentage on those and
the probability for getting k wins and
in matches is calculated by p x equals k
equals n c k p to the k q to the n minus
k
here p is the probability of success and
q is the probability of failure and so
we can do total games of n equals five
where k equals zero one two three four
five
p which is the chance of winning is
point seven five q the chance of losing
equals 1 minus p
which equals 1 minus 0.075 which equals
0.25 the probability that barcelona will
lose all of the matches can then just
plug in the numbers
and we end up with a .0009
so very small chance they're going to
lose all their matches
and we can plug in the value for two
matches probability that barcelona will
win at least two matches is
.0878 and of course we can go on to the
probability that barcelona will win
three matches the 0.26 and course four
matches and so on and it's always nice
to take this information
and let's find the accumulated discrete
probabilities for each of the outcomes
where barcelona has won three or more
matches x equals three x equals four x
equals five
and we end up with the p equals point
two six four plus point three 0.395 plus
237 which equals 0.89
in reality
the probability of barcelona winning the
series is much higher than 0.75
and it's always nice to
put out a nice graph so you can actually
see the number of wins to the
probability and how that pans out with
our binomial case
continuing in our important terminology
location the location of the center of
the graph depends on the mean value and
this is some very important things so
much of the data we look at and when you
start looking at probabilities almost
always has a normalized look like the
graph in the middle
but you do have left skewed where the
data is skewed off to the left and you
have more stuff happening off to the
left and you have right skewed data
and so when this comes up and these
probabilities come up where they're
skewed it's really important to take a
closer look at that
mostly you end up with a normalized set
of data but you got to also be aware
that sometimes it's a skewed data
and then the height height of the slope
inversely depends upon the standard
deviation
so you can see down here the standard
deviation is really large it kind of
squishes it out and if the standard
deviation is small then most of your
data is going to hit right there in the
middle you can have a nice peak
and so being aware of this that you
might have a probability that fits
certain data but it has a lot of
outliers so if you have a really high
standard deviation
if you're doing stock market analysis
this means your predictions are probably
not going to make you much money
where if you have a very small deviation
you might be right on target and set to
become a millionaire
which leads us to the z-score z-score
tells you how far from the mean a data
point is it is measured in terms of
standard deviations from the mean around
68 percent of the results are found
between one standard deviation around 95
percent of the results are found between
two standard deviations
and you read the symbols of course they
love to throw some greek letters in
there we have mu minus two sigma
mu is just a quick way it's a kind of
funky u it just means the mean
uh and then the sigma is the standard
deviation and that's the o with the
little arrow off to the right or the
little
wagy tail going up the o with it with
the line on it
so mu minus two sigma
is your
uh 95 percent of the results are found
between two standard deviations
central limit theorem
this goes back to the skew if you
remember we were looking at the skew
values on this previous slide have left
skewed normalized and right skewed when
we're talking about it being skewed or
not skewed the distribution of the
sample means will be approximately
normally distributed evenly distributed
not skewed
if you take large random samples from
the population with the mean mu and the
standard deviation sigma with
replacement
and you can see here
of course we have our
mu minus two sigma and the spread down
here the mean the median and the mode
and so you're talking about very large
populations
these numbers should come together and
you shouldn't have a skewed value if you
do that's a flag that something's wrong
that's why this is so important to be
aware of what's going on with your data
where your samples are coming from
and the math behind it
and if we're going to do all this we got
to jump into conditional probability
the conditional probability of an event
a is the probability that the event will
occur
given the knowledge that an event b has
already occurred and you'll see this as
bayes theorem bayes base
and this is red
i mean you have these funky looking
little
p
brackets a b
this is the probability of a being true
while b is already true
and you have the probability of b being
true when a is already true so p b of a
probability of a being true divided by
the probability of b being true
and we talk about bayes theorem which
occurred back in the 1800s when he
discovered this this is such an
important formula and it's really it's
not if you actually do the math you
could just kind of do
x y equals j k and then you divide them
out and you're going to see the same
math but it works with probabilities
which makes it really nice
and so if you have a set you might have
eight or nine different studies going on
in different areas different people have
done the studies they brought them
together
if we look at today's covered virus the
virus spread
certainly the studies done in china
versus the studies the way they're done
in the u.s
that data is different in each of those
studies but if you can find a place
where it overlaps
where they're studying the same thing
together you can then compute the
changes that you need to make in one
study to make them equal
and this is also true if you have a
study of
one group and you want to find out more
about it so this formula is very
powerful and it really has to do with
the data collection part of the math and
data science and understanding where
your data is coming from and how you're
going to combine different studies in
different
groups and we're going to go into a use
case let's find out the chance of a
person getting lung disease due to
smoking
and this is kind of interesting the way
they word this
let's say that according to medical
report provided by the hospital states
that around 10 percent of all patients
they treated suffered lung disease
so we have kind of a generic medical
report
they further found out
by a survey that 15 of the patients that
visit them smoke
so we have 10 percent that are lung
disease and
15 percent of the patients smoke
and finally 5 of the people continued
smoke even when they had lung disease
not the brightest choice
but you know it is an addiction so it
can be really difficult to kick and so
we can look at the probability of a uh
prior probability of 10 people having
lung disease
and then probability b probability that
a patient smokes is 15 percent
uh and the probability of b
if b then a the probability of a patient
smokes even though they have lung
disease is 5
and probability of a is b probability
that the patient will have lung disease
if they smoke and then when you put the
formulas together you get a nice
solution here you get the probability of
a of b probability that the patient will
have lung disease if they smoke
and you can just plug the numbers right
in and we get a 3.33 percent chance
hence there is a 3.33 chance that a
person who smokes will get a lung
disease
so we're going to pull up a little
python code i'm always my favorite roll
up the sleeves
keep in mind we're going to be doing
this um kind of like the back end way
so that you can see what's going on and
then later on we're going to create
we'll get into another demo which shows
you some of the tools are already
pre-built for this
let's start by creating a set so we're
going to create a set with curly braces
this means that our set has
only unique values so you have a list
uh you have your tuples which can never
change and then you have
in this case the the set so four seven
you can't create a four seven comma four
it'll delete the four outs it's only
unique values
and if you use dictionaries
quick reminder this should look familiar
because it is a dictionary we have a
value and that value is assigned to or
that key is assigned to a value
so you could have a key value set up as
a dictionary so it's like a dictionary
without the value it's just the keys and
they all have to be unique
and if we run this we have a set of four
seven
we can also take a list a regular
setup and i'm going to go ahead and just
throw in another number in here four
and run it uh and you can see here if i
take my list one two three four four
and i convert it to a set and here it is
my set from list equals set my list
the result is one two three four so it
just deletes that last four right out of
there
and with the sets you can also go in
there and
print here is my set my set
three is in the set and then if you do
three in my set
that's going to be a logic function
uh and one in my set six is not in the
set and so forth if we run this
we get three is in the set true one is
in the set false because three five
seven is another one
six is in the set
six is not in the set so not in my set
you can also use this with the list we
could have just used three five seven
and it would have
the same response on there is three and
usually you do if three is in but three
in my set is still works on just a
regular list
and we'll go ahead and do a little
iteration we're going to do kind of the
dice one remember
one two three four five six and so we're
going to bring in an iteration tool and
import product as product
and i'll show you what that means in
just a second so we have our two dice we
have dice a
and it's going to be a set of values
they can only have one value for each
one that's why they put it in a set
and if you remember from range it is up
to seven so this is going to be one two
three four five six it will not include
the seven and the same thing for our
dice b
and then we're going to do is we're
going to create a list
which is the product
of a and b so what's a plus b
and if we go ahead and run this it'll
print that out and you'll see
in this case when they say product
because it's an iteration tool
we're talking about creating a tuple of
the two
so we've now created a tuple of all
possible outcomes of the dice where dice
a is one two three one to six and dice b
is one to six and you can see one to one
one to two one to three and so forth
you remember we had a slide on this
earlier where we talked about
the different all the different outcomes
of a dice
we can play around with this a little
bit uh we can do in dice equals two divi
dice faces one two three four five six
uh another way of doing what we did
before and then we can create an event
space
where we have a set which is the product
of the dice faces
repeat equals indice and we'll go ahead
and just run this
and you can see here it just again puts
it through all the different possible
variables we can have
and then if we wanted to take the same
set on here and print them all out like
we had before
we can just go through for outcome and
event space outcome and equals
so the event space is creating
a sequence and as you can see here when
we print it out it stacks them versus
going through and putting them in a nice
line
and we'll go ahead and do something
let's go print
since we have the end printing with a
comma that just means it's just gonna
it's not gonna hit the return going down
to the next line
uh and we'll go ahead and do the length
of our event space uh there'll be an
important variable we're going to want
to know in a minute
and of course if i get carried away with
my typing of length we'll print it twice
and it'll give me an error
so we have 36 different possible
variations here
and we might want to calculate something
like
what about the multiple of 3 what if we
want to have
the probability of the multiple of 3 in
our
setup and so we can put together the
code for the outcome and event space of
x y equals outcome
if x plus y
remainder 3. so we're going to divide by
3 and look at the remainder and it
equals 0.
then it's a favorable outcome we're
going to pop that outcome on the end
there
and we'll turn it into a set so the
favor outcome equals a set not necessary
because we know it's not going to be
repeating itself but just in case we'll
go ahead and do that
and if we want to print out the outcome
we can go ahead and see what that looks
like and you can see here these are all
multiples of three one plus two is three
five plus four is nine which divided by
three is three and so forth
and just like we looked up the length of
the one before let's go ahead and print
the length
of our
f outcome
so we can see what that looks like
there we go
and of course i did forget to add the
print in the middle because we're
looping through and putting an end on
the on the setup on there so we're going
to put the print in there and if i run
this you can see
we end up with 12. so we have 36 total
options
uh we have 12 that are multiple that add
up to a multiple of three
and we can easily conv compute the
probability of this
uh by simply taking the length
of our favorable outcome over the length
of the event space
and if we print it out let me put that
in there
probability
last lines we just type it in we end up
with a 0.3333 chance
that's roughly a third
and we want to make this look nice so
let's go ahead and put in another line
there the probability of getting the sum
which is a multiple of 3 is
0.3333
we can compute the same thing for five
dice
and if we do this for five dice and go
and run it
uh you can see we just have a huge
amount of choices
so just goes on and on down here and we
can look at
the
length of the event space
and we have over 7
choices that's a lot of choices
and if we want to ask the question like
we did above uh
what is the sum where the sum is a
multiple of 5 but not a multiple of 3.
we can go through all of these different
options and then
you can see here
d1 d2 d3 d4 d5 equals the outcome
and if you add these all together and
they're
division by five does not have a
remainder of zero
but the remainder is also of a division
by three is not equal to zero
so the multiple of five is equal to zero
but the multiple three is not we can
just depend that on here and then we can
look at that uh favorable outcome
we'll go ahead and set that and we'll
just take a look at this what's our
length
of our favorable outcome
it's always good to see what we're
working with and so we have 904 out of
and then of course we can just do a
simple division to get the probability
on here what's the probability that
we're going to roll
a multiple of 5 when you add them
together
but not a multiple of 3.
and so we're just going to divide those
two numbers and you can see here we get
point one one six two five five or
eleven point six two percent
and so you can really have a nice visual
that this is not really complicated math
right here on probabilities
it's just how many options do you have
and how many of those are you possibly
going to be able to come up with with
the solution you're looking for
and this leads us to a confusion matrix
a confusion matrix is a table which is
used to describe the performance of a
classification model on a set of test
data for which the true values are known
and so you'll see on the left we have
the predicted
and the actual
and we have a negative uh false negative
positive true positive
and then we have false positive and true
negative and you can think of this as
your predicted model what does that mean
that means if you divided your data and
you used two-third of this to create the
model
you might then test it against an actual
case for the last third to see how well
it comes out how many times was it
true positive versus a
false positive it gave a false positive
response
and you can imagine in medical
situations this is a pretty big deal you
don't want to give a false positive so
you might adjust your model accordingly
so you don't have a false positive say
with the covet virus test it'd be better
to have a false negative and they go
back and get retested than to have 30
false positives where then the test is
pretty much invalid
so in a use case like cancer prediction
let's consider an example where a cancer
prediction model is put to the test for
its accuracy and precision
actual result of a person's medical
report is compared with the prediction
made by the machine learning model
and so you can see here here's our
actual predicted whether they have
cancer or not you know cancer a big one
you don't want to have a
false positive i mean a false negative
in other words you don't want to have it
tell you that you don't have cancer when
you do so that would be something you'd
really be looking for in this particular
domain you don't want a false negative
and this is again you know you've
created a model you have hundreds of
people or thousands of pieces of data
that come in
there's a real famous case study where
they have the imagery and all the
measurements they take and there's about
36 different measurements they take
and then if you run the a basic model
you want to know just how accurate it is
how many negative results do you have
that are either telling people they have
cancer that don't or telling people that
don't have cancer that they do and then
we can take these numbers and we can
feed them into our accuracy our
precision and our recall
so accuracy precision and recall
accuracy metric to measure how
accurately the results are predicted
and this is your
total
true where you got the right results you
add them together the true positive the
two negative
over all the results so what percentage
of them were accurate versus what we're
wrong
we're talking about precision is a
metric to measure how many of the
correctly predicted cases are actually
turned out to be positive
so we have a precision on
true positive again if you're talking
about like uh covet testing with the
viruses uh you really want this to be a
high number you want this true
that to be the center point where you
might have the opposite if you're
dealing with cancer where you want no
false negatives
so this is your metric on here precision
is your test positive
true positive plus
false positive
and then your recall how many of the
actual positive cases we were able to
predict quickly with our model
so test positive is the test positive
plus the
false negative on there let's look at an
example of a common use for linear
regression profit estimation of a
company if i was going to invest in a
company i would like to know how much
money i could expect to make so we'll
take a look at a venture capitalist firm
and try to understand which companies
they should invest in so we'll take the
idea that we need to decide the
companies to invest in we need to
predict the profit the company makes and
we're going to do it based on the
company's expenses and even just a
specific expense in this case we have
our company we have the different
expenses so we have our rnd which is
your research and development we have
our marketing
we might have the location we might have
what kind of administration is going
through based on all this different
information we would like to calculate
the profit now in actuality there's
usually about 23 to 27 different markers
that they look at if they're a heavy
duty investor we're only going to take a
look at one basic one we're going to
come in and for simplicity let's
consider a single variable r and d and
find out which companies to invest in
based on that so we take r d and we're
plotting the profit based on the r d
expenditure how much money they put into
the research and development and then we
look at the profit that goes with that
we can predict a line to estimate the
profit so we draw a line right through
the data when you look at that you can
see how much they invest in the rnd as a
good marker as to how much profit
they're going to have we can also note
that companies spending more on r d make
good profit so let's invest in the ones
that spend a higher rate in their r d
what's in it for you first we'll have an
introduction to machine learning
followed by machine learning algorithms
these will be specific to linear
regression and where it fits into the
larger model then we'll take a look at
applications of linear regression
understanding linear regression and
multiple linear regression finally we'll
roll up our sleeves and do a little
programming in use case profit
estimation of companies let's go ahead
and jump in
let's start with our introduction to
machine learning along with some machine
learning algorithms and where that fits
in with linear regression let's look at
another example machine learning based
on the amount of rainfall how much would
be the crop yield so we hear we have our
crops we have our rainfall and we want
to know how much we're going to get from
our crops this year so we're going to
introduce two variables independent and
dependent the independent variable is a
variable whose value does not change by
the effect of other variables and is
used to manipulate the dependent
variable it is often denoted as x in our
example rainfall is the independent
variable this is a wonderful example
because you can easily see that we can't
control the rain but the rain does
control the crop so we talk about the
independent variable controlling the
dependent variable let's define
dependent variable as a variable whose
value change when there is any
manipulation the values of the
independent variables it is often
denoted as y and you can see here our
crop yield is dependent variable and it
is dependent on the amount of rainfall
received now that we've taken a look at
a real life example let's go a little
bit into the theory and some definitions
on machine learning and see how that
fits together with linear regression
numerical and categorical values let's
take our data coming in and this is kind
of random data from any kind of project
we want to divide it up into numerical
and categorical so numerical is numbers
age salary
height where categorical would be
a description the color a dog's breed
gender categoricals limited to very
specific items where numerical is a
range of information now that you've
seen the difference between numerical
and categorical data let's take a look
at some different machine learning
definitions we look at our different
machine learning algorithms we can
divide them into three areas supervised
unsupervised reinforcement we're only
going to look at supervised today
unsupervised means we don't have the
answers we're just grouping things
reinforcement is where we give positive
and negative feedback to our algorithm
to program it and it doesn't have the
information until after the fact but
today we're just looking at supervised
because that's where linear regression
fits in in supervised data we have our
data already there and our answers for a
group and then we use that to program
our model and come up with an answer the
two most common uses for that is through
the regression and classification now
we're doing linear regression so we're
just going to focus on the regression
side and in the regression we have
simple linear regression we have
multiple linear regression and we have
polynomial linear regression now on
these three simple linear regression is
the examples we've looked at so far
where we have a lot of data and we draw
a straight line through it multiple
linear regression means we have multiple
variables remember where we had the
rainfall and the crops we might add
additional variables in there like how
much food do we give our crops when do
we harvest them those would be
additional information add in to our
model and that's why be multiple linear
regression and finally we have
polynomial linear regression that is
instead of drawing a line we can draw a
curved line through it now that you see
where regression model fits into the
machine learning algorithms and we're
specifically looking at linear
regression let's go ahead and take a
look at applications for linear
regression let's look at a few
applications of linear regression
economic growth used to determine the
economic growth of a country or a state
in the coming quarter can also be used
to predict the gdp of a country product
price can be used to predict what would
be the price of a product in the future
we can guess whether it's going to go up
or down or should i buy today housing
sales to estimate the number of houses a
builder would sell and what price in the
coming months score predictions cricket
fever to predict the number of runs a
player would score in the coming matches
based on the previous performance i'm
sure you can figure out other
applications you could use linear
regression for so let's jump in and
let's understand linear regression and
dig into the theory
understanding linear regression
linear regression is the statistical
model used to predict the relationship
between independent and dependent
variables by examining two factors
the first important one is which
variables in particular are significant
predictors of the outcome variable and
the second one that we need to look at
closely is how significant is the
regression line to make predictions with
the highest possible accuracy if it's
inaccurate we can't use it so it's very
important we find out the most accurate
line we can get since linear regression
is based on drawing a line through data
we're going to jump back and take a look
at some euclidean geometry the simplest
form of a simple linear regression
equation with one dependent and one
independent variable is represented by y
equals
m times x plus c and if you look at our
model here we plotted two points on here
x1 and y1 x2 and y2 y being the
dependent variable remember that from
before and x being the independent
variable so y depends on whatever x is m
in this case is the slope of the line
where m equals the difference in the y 2
minus y 1 and x 2 minus x 1. and finally
we have c which is the coefficient of
the line or where it happens to cross
the zero axis
let's go back and look at an example we
used earlier of linear regression we're
going to go back to plotting the amount
of crop yield based on the amount of
rainfall and here we have our rainfall
remember we cannot change rainfall and
we have our crop yield which is
dependent on the rainfall so we have our
independent and our dependent variables
we're going to take this and draw a line
through it as best we can through the
middle of the data and then we look at
that we put the red point on the y axis
is the amount of crop yield you can
expect for the amount of rainfall
represented by the green dot so if we
have an idea what the rainfall is for
this year and what's going on then we
can guess how good our crops are going
to be and we've created a nice line
right through the middle to give us a
nice mathematical formula let's take a
look and see what the math looks like
behind this
let's look at the intuition behind the
regression line now before we dive into
the math and the formulas that go behind
this and what's going on behind the
scenes
i want you to note that when we get into
the case study and we actually apply
some python script that this math you're
going to see here is already done
automatically for you you don't have to
have it memorized it is however good to
have an idea what's going on so if
people reference the different terms
you'll know what they're talking about
let's consider a sample data set with
five rows and find out how to draw the
regression line we're only going to do
five rows because if we did like the
rainfall with hundreds of points of data
that would be very hard to see what's
going on with the mathematics so we'll
go ahead and create our own two sets of
data and we have our independent
variable x and our dependent variable y
and when x was 1 we got y equals 2 when
x was
2 y was 4 and so on and so on if we go
ahead and plot this data on a graph we
can see how it forms a nice line through
the middle you can see where it's kind
of grouped going upwards to the right
the next thing we want to know is what
the means is of each of the data coming
in the x and the y the means doesn't
mean anything other than the average so
we add up all the numbers and divide by
the total so 1 plus 2 plus 3 plus 4 plus
5 over 5 equals 3. and the same for y we
get 4. if we go ahead and plot the means
on the graph we'll see we get 3 comma 4
which draws a nice line down the middle
a good estimate
here we're going to dig deeper into the
math behind the regression line now
remember before i said you don't have to
have all these formulas memorized or
fully understand them even though we're
going to go into a little more detail
how it works and if you're not a math
wiz and you don't know if you've never
seen the sigma character before which
looks a little bit like an e that's
opened up that just means summation
that's all that is so when you see the
sigma character it just means we're
adding everything in that row and for
computers this is great because as a
programmer you can easily iterate
through each of the x y points and
create all the information you need so
in the top half you can see where we've
broken that down into pieces and as it
goes through the first two points it
computes the squared value of x the
squared value of y and x times y and
then it takes all of x and adds them up
all of y adds them up all of x squared
adds them up and so on and so on and you
can see we have the sum of equal to 15
the sum is equal to 20 all the way up to
x times y where the sum equals 66. this
all comes from our formula for
calculating a straight line where y
equals the slope times x plus the
coefficient c so we go down below and
we're going to compute more like the
averages of these and we'll explain
exactly what that is in just a minute
and where that information comes from is
called the square means error but we'll
go into that in detail in a few minutes
all you need to do is look at the
formula and see how we've gone about
computing it line by line instead of
trying to have a huge
set of numbers pushed into it and down
here you'll see where the slope m equals
and then the top part if you read
through the brackets you have the number
of data points times the sum
of x times y which we computed one line
at a time there and that's just the 66
and take all that and you subtract it
from the sum of x times the sum of y and
those have both been computed so you
have 15 times 20. and on the bottom we
have the number of lines times the sum
of x squared easily computed as 86 for
the sum minus i'll take all that and
subtract the sum of x squared and we end
up as we come across with our formula
you can plug in all those numbers which
is very easy to do on the computer you
don't have to do the math on a piece of
paper or calculator and you'll get a
slope of 0.6 and you'll get your c
coefficient if you continue to follow
through that formula you'll see it comes
out as equal to 2.2 continuing deeper
into what's going behind the scenes
let's find out the predicted values of y
for corresponding values of x using the
linear equation where m equals 0.6 and c
equals 2.2 we're going to take these
values
and we're going to go ahead and plot
them we're going to predict them so y
equals 0.6 times where x equals 1 plus
2.2 equals 2.8 so on and so on and here
the blue points represent the actual y
values and the brown points represent
the predicted y values based on the
model we created the distance between
the actual and predicted values is known
as residuals or errors
the best fit line should have the least
sum of squares of these errors also
known as e-square if we put these into a
nice chart where you can see x
and you can see why what we actual
values were and you can see why i
predict it you can easily see where we
take y minus y predict it and we get an
answer what is the difference between
those two and if we square that y minus
y prediction squared we can then sum
those squared values that's where we get
the 0.64 plus the 0.36 plus 1 all the
way down until we have a summation
equals 2.4 so the sum of squared errors
for this regression line is 2.4 we check
this error for each line and conclude
the best fit line having the least e
square value in a nice graphical
representation we can see here where we
keep moving this line through the data
points to make sure the best fit line
has the least square distance between
the data points and the regression line
now we only looked at the most commonly
used formula for minimizing the distance
there are lots of ways to minimize the
distance between the line and the data
points like sum of squared errors sum of
absolute errors root mean square error
etc what you want to take away from this
is whatever formula is being used you
can easily using a computer programming
and iterating through the data calculate
the different parts of it that way these
complicated formulas you see with the
different summations and absolute values
are easily computed one piece at a time
up until this point we've only been
looking at two values x and y well in
the real world it's very rare that you
only have two values when you're
figuring out a solution so let's move on
to the next topic
multiple linear regression let's take a
brief look at what happens when you have
multiple inputs so in multiple linear
regression we have uh well we'll start
with the simple linear regression where
we had y equals m plus x plus c and
we're trying to find the value of y now
with multiple linear regression we have
multiple variables coming in so instead
of having just x we have x1 x2 x3 and
instead of having just one slope each
variable has its own slope attached to
it as you can see here we have m1 m2 m3
and we still just have the single
coefficient so when you're dealing with
multiple linear regression you basically
take your single linear regression and
you spread it out so you have y equals
m1 times x1 plus m2 times x2
so on all the way to m to the nth x to
the nth and then you add your
coefficient on there implementation of
linear regression now we get into my
favorite part let's understand how
multiple linear regression works by
implementing it in python if you
remember before we were looking at a
company and just based on its rnd trying
to figure out its profit we're going to
start looking at the expenditure of the
company we're going to go back to that
we're going to predict his profit but
instead of predicting it just on the r d
we're going to look at other factors
like administration costs marketing
costs and so on and from there we're
going to see if we can figure out what
the profit of that company is going to
be to start our coding we're going to
begin by importing some basic libraries
and we're going to be looking through
the data before we do any kind of linear
regression we're going to take a look at
the data to see what we're playing with
then we'll go ahead and format the data
to the format we need to be able to run
it in the linear regression model and
then from there we'll go ahead and solve
it and just see how valid our solution
is so let's start with importing the
basic libraries now i'm going to be
doing this in anaconda jupiter notebook
a very popular ide i enjoy it's such a
visual to look at and so easy to use um
just any id for python will work just
fine for this so break out your favorite
python ide so here we are in our jupiter
notebook let me go ahead and paste our
first piece of code in there and let's
walk through what libraries we're
importing first we're going to import
numpy as in p and then i want you to
skip one line and look at import pandas
as pd these are very common tools that
you need with most of your linear
regression the numpy which stands for
number python is usually denoted as np
and you have to almost have that for
your sk learn toolbox you always import
that right off the beginning pandas
although you don't have to have it for
your sklearn libraries it does such a
wonderful job of importing data setting
it up into a data frame so we can
manipulate it rather easily and it has a
lot of tools also in addition to that so
we usually like to use the pandas when
we can and i'll show you what that looks
like the other three lines are for us to
get a visual of this data and take a
look at it so we're going to import
matplotlibrary.pipelot
as plt and then seaborn as sns seaborn
works with the matplot library so you
have to always import matplot library
and then seaborn sits on top of it and
we'll take a look at what that looks
like you could use any of your own
plotting libraries you want there's all
kinds of ways to look at the data these
are just very common ones and the
seaborn is so easy to use it just looks
beautiful it's a nice representation
that you can actually take and show
somebody and the final line is the amber
scion map plot library inline that is
only because i'm doing an inline ide my
interface in the anaconda jupiter
notebook requires i put that in there or
you're not going to see the graph when
it comes up let's go ahead and run this
it's not going to be that interesting so
we're just setting up variables in fact
it's not going to do anything that we
can see but it is importing these
different libraries and setup the next
step is load the data set and extract
independent and dependent variables now
here in the slide you'll see companies
equals pd.read csv and it has a long
line there with the file at the end 1000
companies.csv you're going to have to
change this to fit whatever setup you
have and the file itself you can request
just go down to the commentary below
this video and put a note in there and
simply learn we'll try to get in contact
with you and supply you with that file
so you can try this coding yourself so
we're going to add this code in here and
we're going to see that i have companies
equals pd.reader underscore csv and i've
changed this path to match my computer c
colon slash simply learn slash 1000
underscore companies dot csv and then
below there we're going to set the x
equals to companies under the i location
and because this is companies as a pd
data set i can use this nice notation
that says take every row that's what the
colon the first colon is comma except
for the last column that's what the
second part is or we have a colon minus
one and we want the values set into
there so x is no longer a data set a
pandas data set but we can easily
extract the data from our pandas data
set with this notation and then y we're
going to set equal to the last row well
the question is going to be what are we
actually looking at so let's go ahead
and take a look at that and we're going
to look at the companies dot head which
lists the first five rows of data and
i'll open up the file in just a second
so you can see where that's coming from
but let's look at the data in here as
far as the way the pandas sees it when i
hit run you'll see it breaks it out into
a nice setup this is what panda is one
of the things pandas is really good
about is it looks just like an excel
spreadsheet you have your rows and
remember when we're programming we
always start with zero we don't start
with one so it shows the first five rows
zero one two three four and then it
shows your different columns r d spend
administration marketing spend state
profit it even notes that the top are
column names it was never told that but
pandas is able to recognize a lot of
things that they're not the same as the
data rows why don't we go ahead and open
this file up in a csv so you can
actually see the raw data so here i've
opened it up as a text editor and you
can see at the top we have rnd spend
comma administration comma marketing
spin comma state comma profit carriage
return i don't know about you but i'd go
crazy trying to read files like this
that's why we use the pandas you could
also open this up in an excel and it
would separate it since it is a comma
separated variable file but we don't
want to look at this one we want to look
at something we can read rather easily
so let's flip back and take a look at
that top part the first five row now as
nice as this format is where i can see
the data to me it doesn't mean a whole
lot maybe you're an expert in business
and investments and you understand what
uh 165 349 dollars and 20 cents compared
to the administration cost of a hundred
and thirty six thousand eight hundred
ninety seven dollars and eighty cents so
on so on it helps to create the profit
of 192 261 and 83 cents that makes no
sense to me whatsoever no pun intended
so let's flip back here and take a look
at our next set of code where we're
going to graph it so we can get a better
understanding of our data and what it
means so at this point we're going to
use a single line of code to get a lot
of information so we can see where we're
going with this let's go ahead and paste
that into our notebook and see what we
got going and so we have the
visualization and again we're using sns
which is pandas as you can see we
imported the map plot library dot pi
plot as plt which then the seaborn uses
and we imported the seaborn as sns and
then that final line of code helps us
show this in our
inline coding without this it wouldn't
display and you could display it to a
file and other means and that's the
matte plot library in line with the
amber sign at the beginning so here we
come down to the single line of code
seaborne is great because it actually
recognizes the panda data frame so i can
just take the companies dot core for
coordinates and i can put that right
into the seaborn and when we run this we
get this beautiful plot and let's just
take a look at what this plot means if
you look at this plot on mine the colors
are probably a little bit more purplish
and blue than the original one we have
the columns and the rows we have r and d
spending we have administration we have
marketing spending and profit and if you
cross index any two of these since we're
interested in profit if you cross index
profit with profit it's going to show up
if you look at the scale on the right
way up in the dark why because those are
the same data they have an exact
correspondence so r and d spending is
going to be the same as rnd spending and
the same thing with administration costs
so right down the middle you get this
dark row or dark um diagonal row that
shows that this is the highest
corresponding data that's exactly the
same and as it becomes lighter there's
less connections between the data so we
can see with profit obviously profit is
the same as profit and next it has a
very high correlation with r d spending
which we looked at earlier and it has a
slightly less connection to marketing
spending and even less to how much money
we put into the administration so now
that we have a nice look at the data
let's go ahead and dig in and create
some actual useful linear regression
models so that we can predict values and
have a better profit now that we've
taken a look at the visualization of
this data we're going to move on to the
next step instead of just having a
pretty picture we need to generate some
hard data some hard values so let's see
what that looks like we're going to set
up our linear regression model in two
steps the first one is we need to
prepare some of our data so it fits
correctly and let's go ahead and paste
this code into our jupiter notebook and
what we're bringing in is we're going to
bring in the sklearn pre-processing
where we're going to import the label
encoder and the one hot encoder to use
the label encoder we're going to create
a variable called label encoder and set
it equal to capital l label capital e
encoder this creates a class that we can
reuse for transferring the labels back
and forth now about now you should ask
what labels are we talking about let's
go take a look at the data we processed
before and see what i'm talking about
here if you remember when we did the
companies dot head we printed the top
five rows of data we have our columns
going across we have column zero which
is r and d spending column one which is
administration
column two which is marketing spending
and column three is state
and you'll see under state we have new
york california florida now to do a
linear regression model it doesn't know
how to process new york it knows how to
process a number so the first thing
we're going to do is we're going to
change that new york california and
florida and we're going to change those
to numbers that's what this line of code
does here x equals and then it has the
colon comma 3 in brackets the first part
the colon comma means that we're going
to look at all the different rows so
we're going to keep them all together
but the only row we're going to edit is
the third row and in there we're going
to take the label coder and we're going
to fit and transform the x also the
third row so we're going to take that
third row we're going to set it equal to
a transformation and that transformation
basically tells it that instead of
having a
new york it has a zero or one or a two
and then finally we need to do a one hot
encoder which equals one hot inc or
categorical features equals three and
then we take the x and we go ahead and
do that equal to one hot encoder fit
transform x to array this final
transformation preps our data force so
it's completely set the way we need it
is just a row of numbers even though
it's not in here let's go ahead and
print x and just take a look at what
this data is doing you'll see you have
an array of arrays and then each array
is a row of numbers and if i go ahead
and just do row 0 you'll see i have a
nice organized row of numbers that the
computer now understands we'll go ahead
and take this out there because it
doesn't mean a whole lot to us it's just
a row of numbers
next on setting up our data we have
avoiding dummy variable trap this is
very important why
because the computer is automatically
transformed our header into the setup
and it's automatically transferring all
these different variables so when we did
the encoder the encoder created two
columns and what we need to do is just
have the one because it has both the
variable and the name that's what this
piece of code does here let's go ahead
and paste this in here and we have x
equals x colon comma one colon all this
is doing is removing that one extra
column we put in there when we did our
one hot encoder and our label encoding
let's go ahead and run that and now we
get to create our linear regression
model and let's see what that looks like
here and we're going to do that in two
steps the first step is going to be in
splitting the data
now whenever we create a predictive
model of data we always want to split it
up so we have a training set and we have
a testing set that's very important
otherwise we'd be very unethical without
testing it to see how good our fit is
and then we'll go ahead and create our
multiple linear regression model and
train it and set it up let's go ahead
and paste this next piece of code in
here and i'll go ahead and shrink it
down a size or two so it all fits on one
line so from the sk learn module
selection we're going to import train
test split and you'll see that we've
created four completely different
variables we have capital x train
capital x test smaller case y train
smaller case y test
that is the standard way that they
usually reference these when we're doing
different uh models you usually see that
a capital x and you see the train and
the test and the lowercase y what this
is is x is our data going in that's our
rnd spin our administration or marketing
and then why which we're training is the
answer that's the profit because we want
to know the profit of an unknown entity
that's what we're going to shoot for in
this tutorial the next part train test
split we take x and we take y we've
already created those x has the columns
with the data in it and y has a column
with profit in it and then we're going
to set the test size equals point two
that basically means twenty percent
so twenty 20 of the rows are going to be
tested we're going to put them off to
the side so since we're using a thousand
lines of data that means that 200 of
those lines we're going to hold off to
the side to test for later and then the
random state equals zero we're going to
randomize which ones it picks to hold
off to the side we'll go ahead and run
this it's not overly exciting so setting
up our variables but the next step is
the next step we actually create our
linear regression model now that we got
to the linear regression model we get
that next piece of the puzzle let's go
ahead and put that code in there and
walk through it so here we go we're
going to paste it in there and let's go
ahead and since this is a shorter line
of code let's zoom up there so we can
get a good look and we have from the
sklearn
linear underscore model we're going to
import linear regression now i don't
know if you recall from earlier when we
were doing all the math let's go ahead
and flip back there and take a look at
that do you remember this where we had
this long formula on the bottom and we
were doing all this summarization and
then we also looked at setting it up
with the different lines and then we
also looked all the way down to multiple
linear regression where we're adding all
those formulas together all of that is
wrapped up in this one section so what's
going on here is i'm going to create a
variable called regressor and the
regressor equals the linear regression
that's a linear regression model that
has all that math built in so we don't
have to have it all memorized or have to
compute it individually and then we do
the regressor dot fit in this case we do
x train and y train because we're using
the training data x being the data in
and y being profit what we're looking at
and this does all that math for us so
within one click and one line we've
created the whole linear regression
model and we fit the data to the linear
regression model and you can see that
when i run the regressor it gives an
output linear regression it says copy x
equals true fit intercept equals true in
jobs equal one normalize equals false
it's just giving you some general
information on what's going on with that
regressor model now that we've created
our linear regression model let's go
ahead and use it and if you remember we
kept a bunch of data aside so we're
going to do a y predict variable and
we're going to put in the x test and
let's see what that looks like scroll up
a little bit paste that in here
predicting the test set results so here
we have y predict equals regressor dot
predict x test going in and this gives
us y predict now because i'm in jupiter
inline i can just put the variable up
there and when i hit the run button
it'll print that array out i could have
just as easily done print y predict so
if you're in a different ide that's not
an inline setup like the jupiter
notebook you can do it this way print y
predict and you'll see that for the 200
different test variables we kept off to
the side it's going to produce 200
answers this is what it says the profit
are for those 200 predictions but let's
don't stop there let's keep going and
take a couple look we're going to take
just a short detail here and calculating
the coefficients and the intercepts this
gives us a quick flash at what's going
on behind the line we're going to take a
short detour here and we're going to be
calculating the coefficient and
intercepts so you can see what those
look like what's really nice about our
regressor we created is it already has a
coefficients for us we can simply just
print regressor dot coefficient
underscore when i run this you'll see
our coefficients here and if we can do
the regressor coefficient we can also do
the regressor intercept and let's run
that and take a look at that this all
came from the multiple regression model
and we'll flip over so you can remember
where this is going into where it's
coming from you can see the formula down
here where y equals m1 times x1 plus m2
times x2 and so on and so on plus c the
coefficient so these variables fit right
into this formula y equals slope one
times column one variable plus slope two
times column two variable all the way to
the m into the n and x to the n plus c
the coefficient or in this case you have
minus eight point eight nine to the
power of 2 etc etc times the first
column and the second column and the
third column and then our intercept is
the minus 1 0 3 0 0 9 point boy it gets
kind of complicated when you look at it
this is why we don't do this by hand
anymore this is why we have the computer
to make these calculations easy to
understand and calculate now i told you
that was a short detour and we're coming
towards the end of our script as you
remember from the beginning i said if
we're going to divide this information
we have to make sure it's a valid model
that this model works and understand how
good it works so calculating the r
squared value that's what we're going to
use to predict how good our prediction
is and let's take a look what that looks
like in code and so we're going to use
this from sklearn.com
we're going to import r2 score that's
the r squared value we're looking at the
error so in the r2 score we take our y
test versus our y predict
y test is the actual values we're
testing that was the one that was given
to us so we know are true the why
predict of those 200 values is what we
think it was true and when we go ahead
and run this we see we get a 0.9352
that's the r2 score now it's not exactly
a straight percentage so it's not saying
it's 93 percent correct but you do want
that in the upper 90s oh and higher
shows that this is a very valid
prediction based on the r2 score and if
r-squared value of 0.91 or 9-2 as we got
on our model remember it does have a
random generation involved this proves
the model is a good model which means
success yay we successfully trained our
model with certain predictors and
estimated the profit of the companies
using linear regression what is logistic
regression let's say we have to build a
predictive model or a machine learning
model to predict whether the passengers
of the titanic ship have survived or not
the shipwreck so how do we do that so we
use logistic regression to build a model
for this how do we use logistic
regression so we have the information
about the passengers their id whether
they have survived or not their class
and name and so on and so forth and we
use this information where we already
know whether the person has survived or
not that is the labeled information and
we help the system to train based on
this information with based on this
labeled data this is known as label data
and during the process of building the
model we probably will remove some of
the non-essential parameters or
attributes here we only take those
attributes which are really required to
make these predictions and once we train
the model we run new data through it
whereby the model will predict whether
the passenger has survived or not so
let's see what we will learn in this
video we will talk about what is
supervised learning and we will go into
details about classification which is
one of the techniques for supervised
learning and then we will further focus
on logistic regression is which is one
of the algorithms for performing
classification especially binary
classification then we will compare
linear and logistic regression and what
are some of the logistic regression
applications and finally we will end
with a use case or a demo of actual
python code for doing logistic
regression in jupyter notebook all right
so let's start with what is supervised
learning supervised learning is one of
the two main types of machine learning
methods here we use what is known as
labeled data to help the system learn
this is very similar to how we human
beings learn so let's say you want to
teach a child to recognize an apple how
do we do that we never tell the child
okay this is an apple has a certain
diameter on the top certain diameter at
the bottom
this has a certain rgb color no we just
show an apple to the child and tell the
child this is apple and then next time
when we show an apple child immediately
recognizes yes this is an app supervised
learning works very similar on the
similar lines so where does logistic
regression fit into the overall machine
learning process machine learning is
divided into two types mainly two types
there is a third one called
reinforcement learning but we will not
talk about that right now so one is
supervised learning and the other is
unsupervised learning unsupervised
learning uses techniques like clustering
and association and supervised learning
uses techniques like classification and
regression now supervised learning is
used when you have labeled data you have
historical data then you use supervised
learning when you don't have labeled
data then you used unsupervised learning
it's in supervised learning there are
two types of techniques that are used
classification and regression based on
what is the kind of problem we have
solved let's say we want to take the
data and classify it it could be binary
classification like a zero or a one an
example of classification we have just
seen whether the passenger has survived
or not survived like a zero or one that
is known as binary classification
regression on the other hand is you need
to predict a value what is known as a
continuous value classification is for
discrete values regression is for
continuous values let's say you want to
predict a share price or you want to
predict the temperature that will be
there what will be the temperature
tomorrow that is where you use
regression whereas classification are
discrete values is will the customer buy
the product or will not buy the product
will you get a promotion or you will not
get a promotion i hope you're getting
the idea or it could be multi-class
classification as well let's say you
want to build an image classification
model so the image classification model
would take an image as an input and
classify into multiple classes whether
this image is of a cat or a dog or an
elephant or a tiger so there are
multiple classes so not necessarily
binary classification so that is known
as multi-class classification so we are
going to focus on classification because
logistic regression is one of the
algorithms used for classification now
the name may be a little confusing in
fact whenever people come across
logistic regression it always causes
confusion because the name has
regression in it but we are actually
using this for performing classification
okay so yes it is logistic regression
but it is used for classification and in
case you are wondering is there
something similar for regression yes for
regression we have linear regression
keep that in mind so linear regression
is used for regression logistic
regression is used for classification so
in this video we are going to focus on
supervised learning and within
supervised learning we are going to
focus on classification and then within
classification we are going to focus on
logistic regression algorithm so first
of all classification so what are the
various algorithms available for
performing classification the first one
is decision tree there are of course
multiple algorithms but here we will
talk about a few decision trees are
quite popular and very easy to
understand and therefore they use for
classification then we have k nearest
neighbors this is another algorithm for
performing classification and then there
is logistic regression and this is what
we are going to focus on in this video
and we are going to go into little bit
of details about logistic regression all
right what is logistic regression as i
mentioned earlier positive regression is
an algorithm for performing binary
classification so let's take an example
and see how this works let's say your
car has not been serviced for quite a
few years and now you want to find out
if it is going to break down in the near
future so this is like a classification
problem find out whether your car will
break down or not so how are we going to
perform this classification so here's
how it looks if we plot the information
along the x and y axis x is the number
of years since the last service was
performed and why is the probability of
your car breaking down and let's say
this information was this data rather
was collected from several car users
it's not just your car but several car
users so that is our labeled data so the
data has been collected and
for for the number of years and when the
car broke down and what was the
probability and that has been plotted
along x and y axis so this provides an
idea or from this
graph we can find out whether your car
will break down or not we'll see how so
first of all the probability can go from
zero to one as you all aware probability
can be between zero and one and as we
can imagine it is intuitive as well as
the number of years are on the lower
side maybe one year two years or three
years till after the service the chances
of your car breaking down are very
limited right so for example chances of
your car breaking down the probability
of your car breaking down within two
years of your last service are 0.1
probability similarly 3 years is maybe
0.3 and so on but as the number of years
increases let's say if it was six or
seven years there is almost a certainty
that your car is going to break down
that is what this graph shows so this is
an example of a application of the
classification algorithm and we will see
in little details how exactly logistic
regression is applied here one more
thing needs to be added here is that the
dependent variable's outcome
is discrete so if we are talking about
whether the car is going to break down
or not so that is a discrete value the y
that we are talking about the dependent
variable that we are talking about what
we are looking at is whether the car is
going to break down or not yes or no
that is what we are talking about so
here the outcome is discrete and not a
continuous value so this is how the
logistic regression curve looks let me
explain a little bit what exactly how
exactly we are going to
determine the class at the outcome
rather so for a logistic regression
curve a threshold has to be said saying
that because this is a probability
calculation remember this is a
probability calculation and the
probability itself will not be zero or
one but based on the probability we need
to decide what the outcome should be so
there has to be a threshold like for
example 0.5 can be the threshold let's
say in this case so any value of the
probability below 0.5 is considered to
be 0 and any value above 0.5 is
considered to be 1. so an output of
let's say 0.8 will mean that the car
will break down so that is considered as
an output of one and let's say
an output of 0.29 is considered as zero
which means that the car will not break
down so that's the way logistic
regression works now let's do a quick
comparison between logistic regression
and linear regression because they both
have the term regression in them so it
can cause confusion so let's try to
remove that confusion so what is linear
regression linear regression is a
process
is once again an algorithm for
supervised learning however here you're
going to find a continuous value you're
going to determine a continuous value it
could be the price of a real estate
property it could be your hike how much
hike you're going to get or it could be
a stock price these are all continuous
values these are not discrete compared
to a yes or no kind of a response that
we are looking for in logistic
regression so this is one example of a
linear regression let's say the hr team
of a company tries to find out what
should be the salary hike of an employee
so they collect all the details of their
existing employees their ratings and
their salary hikes what has been given
and that is the
labeled information that is available
and the system learns from this it is
trained and it learns from this label
information so that when a new employees
information is fed based on the rating
it will determine what should be the
height so this is a linear regression
problem and a linear regression example
now salary is a continuous value you can
get 5000 500
5600 it is not discrete like a cat or a
dog or an apple or a banana these are
discrete or a yes or no these are
discrete values right so this way you
are trying to find continuous values is
where we use linear regression so let's
say just to extend on the scenario we
now want to find out whether this
employee is going to get a promotion or
not so we want to find out that is a
discrete problem right a yes or no kind
of a problem in this case we actually
cannot use linear regression even though
we may have labeled data so this is the
label data so based on the employee
rating these are the ratings and then
some people got the promotion and this
is the ratings for which people did not
get promotion that is a no and this is
the rating for which people got
promotion we just plotted the data about
whether a person has got an employer has
got promotion or not yes no right so
there is nothing in between and what is
the employees rating okay and ratings
can be continuous that is not an issue
but the output is discrete in this case
whether employee got promotion yes no
okay so if we try to plot that and we
try to find a straight line this is how
it would look and as you can see it
doesn't look very right because looks
like there will be lot of errors this
root mean square error if you remember
for linear regression would be very very
high and also the the values cannot go
beyond zero or beyond one so the graph
should probably look somewhat like this
clipped at zero and 1 but still the
straight line doesn't look right
therefore instead of using a linear
equation we need to come up with
something different and therefore the
logistic regression model looks somewhat
like this so we calculate the
probability and if we plot that
probability not in the form of a
straight line but we need to use some
other equation we will see very soon
what that equation is then it is a
gradual process right so you see here
people with some of these ratings are
not getting any promotions and then
slowly uh
at certain rating they get promotion so
that is a gradual process and
this is how the math behind logistic
regression looks so we are trying to
find the odds for a particular event
happening and this is the formula for
finding the odds so the probability of
an event happening divided by the
probability of the event not happening
so p if it is the probability of the
event happening probability of the
person getting a promotion and divided
by the probability of the person not
getting a promotion that is one minus p
so this is how you measure the odds now
the values of the odds range from 0 to
infinity so when this probability is 0
then the odds will the value of the odds
is equal to 0 and when the probability
becomes 1 then the value of the odds is
1 by 0 that will be infinity but the
probability itself remains between 0 and
1. now this is how an equation of a
straight line so y is equal to beta 0
plus beta 1 x where beta0 is the y
intercept and beta 1 is the slope of the
line if we take the odds equation and
take a log of both sides then this would
look somewhat like this and the term
logistic is actually derived from the
fact that we are doing this we take a
log of dx by 1 minus px this is an
extension of the calculation of odds
that we have seen right and that is
equal to beta 0 plus beta 1 x which is
the equation of the straight line and
now from here if you want to find out
the value of p x you will see we can
take the exponential on both sides and
then if we solve that equation we will
get the equation of p x like this p x is
equal to 1 by 1 plus e to the power of
minus beta0 plus beta 1 x and recall
this is nothing but the equation of the
line which is equal to y y is equal to
beta 0 plus beta 1 x so that this is the
equation also known as the sigmoid
function and this is the equation of the
logistic regression all right and if
this is plotted this is how the sigmoid
curve is obtained
so let's compare linear and logistic
regression how they are different from
each other let's go back so linear
regression is solved or used to solve
regression problems and logistic
regression is used to solve
classification problems so both are
called regression but linear regression
is used for solving regression problems
where we predict continuous values
whereas logistic regression is used for
solving classification problems where we
have had to predict discrete values the
response variables in case of linear
regression are continuous in nature
whereas here they are categorical or
discrete in nature and
linear regression helps to estimate the
dependent variable when there is a
change in the independent variable
whereas here in case of logistic
regression it helps to calculate the
probability or the possibility of a
particular event happening and linear
regression as the name suggests is a
straight line that's why it's called
linear regression whereas logistic
regression is a sigmoid function and the
curve is the shape of the curve is s
it's an s-shaped curve this is another
example of application of logistic
regression in weather prediction whether
it's going to rain or not drain now keep
in mind both are used in weather
prediction if we want to find the
discrete values like whether it's going
to rain or not rain that is a
classification problem we use logistic
regression but if we want to determine
what is going to be the temperature
tomorrow then we use linear regression
so just keep in mind that in weather
prediction we actually use both but
these are some examples of logistic
regression so we want to find out
whether it's going to be rain or not
it's going to be sunny or not but it's
going to snow or not these are all
logistic regression examples a few more
examples classification of objects this
is a again another example of logistic
regression now here of course one
distinction is that these are
multi-class classification so logistic
regression is not used in its original
form but it is used in a slightly
different form so we say whether it is a
dog or not a dog i hope you understand
so instead of saying is it a dog or a
cat or an elephant we convert this into
saying so because we need to keep it to
binary classification so we say is it a
dog or not a dog is it a cat or not a
cat so that's the way logistic
regression can be used for classifying
objects otherwise there are other
techniques which can be used for
performing multi-class classification in
healthcare logistic regression is used
to find the survival rate of a patient
so they take multiple parameters like
trauma score and age and so on and so
forth and they try to predict the rate
of survival all right now finally let's
take an example and see how we can apply
logistic regression to predict the
number that is shown in the image so
this is actually a live demo i will take
you into jupiter notebook and
show the code but before that let me
take you through a couple of slides to
explain what we are trying to do so
let's say you have an eight by eight
image and the image has a number one two
three four and you need to train your
model to predict what this number is so
how do we do this so the first thing is
obviously in any machine learning
process you train your model so in this
case we are using logistic regression so
and then we provide a training set to
train the model and then we test how
accurate our model is with the test data
which means that like any machine
learning process we split our initial
data into two parts training set and
test set with the training set we train
our model and then with the test set we
test the model then we get good accuracy
and then we use it for for inference
right so that is typical methodology of
training testing and then deploying of
machine learning models so let's uh take
a look at the code and see what we are
doing so i will not go line by line but
just take you through some of the blocks
so first thing we do is import all the
libraries and then we basically take a
look at the images and see what is the
total number of images we can display
using matplotlib some of the images are
a sample of these images and
then we split the data into training and
test as i mentioned earlier and we can
do some exploratory analysis and
then we build our model we train our
model with the training set and then we
test it with our test set and find out
how accurate our model is using the
confusion matrix the heat map and use
heat map for visualizing this and i will
show you in the code what exactly is the
confusion matrix and how it can be used
for finding the accuracy in our example
we got we get an accuracy of about 0.94
which is pretty good or 94 which is
pretty good all right so what is the
confusion matrix this is an example of a
confusion matrix and
this is used for identifying the
accuracy of a
classification model or like a logistic
regression model so the most important
part in a confusion matrix is that first
of all this as you can see this is a
matrix and the size of the matrix
depends on how many outputs we are
expecting right
so
the most important part here is that the
model will be most accurate when we have
the maximum numbers in its diagonal like
in this case that's why it has almost 93
94 percent because the diagonal should
have the maximum numbers and the others
other than diagonals the cells other
than the diagonal should have very few
numbers so here that's what is happening
so there is a two here there are there
is a one here but most of them are along
the diagonal this what does this mean
this means that the
number that has been fed is zero and the
number that has been detected is also
zero so the predicted value and the
actual value are the same so along the
diagonals that is true which means that
let's let's take this diagonal right if
the maximum number is here that means
that like here in this case it is 34
which means that 34 of the images that
have been fed or rather actually there
are two misclassifications in there so
36 images have been fed which have
number four and out of which 34 have
been predicted correctly as number four
and one has been predicted as number
eight and another one has been predicted
as number nine so these are two
misclassifications okay so that is the
meaning of saying that the maximum
number should be in the diagonal so if
you have all of them so for an ideal
model which has let's say 100 accuracy
everything will be only in the diagonal
there will be no numbers other than zero
in all other cells so that is like a
hundred percent accurate model okay so
that's uh just of how to use this matrix
how to use this confusion matrix i know
the name uh is a little funny sounding
confusion matrix but actually it is not
very confusing it's very straightforward
so you are just plotting what has been
predicted and what is the labeled
information or what is the actual data
that's also known as the ground truth
sometimes okay these are some fancy
terms that are used so predicted label
and the actual name that's all it is
okay yeah so we are showing a little bit
more information here so 38 have been
predicted and here you will see that all
of them have been predicted correctly
there have been 38 zeros and the
predicted value and the actual value is
exactly the same whereas in this case
right it has there are i think 37 plus 5
yeah 42 have been fed the images 42
images are of digit 3 and
the accuracy is only 37 of them have
been accurately predicted three of them
have been predicted as number seven and
two of them have been predicted as
number eight and so on and so forth okay
all right so with that let's go into
jupiter notebook and see how the code
looks so this is the code in
in jupiter notebook for logistic
regression in this particular demo what
we are going to do is train our model to
recognize digits
which are the images which have digits
from let's say 0 to 5 or 0 to 9 and
and then we will see how well it is
trained and whether it is able to
predict these numbers correctly or not
so let's get started so the first part
is as usual we are importing some
libraries that are required and
then the last line in this block is to
load the digits so let's go ahead and
run this code then
here we will visualize the shape of
these digits so we can see here if we
take a look this is how the shape is
by 64. these are like eight by eight
images so that's that's what is
reflected in this shape now from here
onwards we are basically once again
importing some of the libraries that are
required like numpy and matplot and we
will take a look at
some of the sample images that we have
loaded so this one for example creates a
figure and then we go ahead and take a
few sample images to see how they look
so let me run this code and so that it
becomes easy to understand so these are
about five images sample images that we
are looking at zero one two three four
so this is how the image is this is how
the data is okay and
based on this we will actually train our
logistic regression model and then we
will test it and see how well it is able
to recognize so the way it works is the
pixel information so as you can see here
this is an 8 by 8 pixel kind of a
image and
the each pixel whether it is activated
or not activated that is the information
available for each pixel now based on
the pattern of this activation and
non-activation of the various pixels
this will be identified as a zero for
example right similarly as you can see
so overall each of these numbers
actually has a different pattern of the
pixel activation and that's pretty much
that our model needs to learn uh for
which a number what is the pattern of
the activation of the pixels right so
that is what we are going to train our
model okay so the first thing we need to
do is to split our data into training
and test data set right so whenever we
perform any training we split the data
into training and tests so that the
training data set is used to train the
system so we pass this probably multiple
times
and then we test it with the test data
set and the split is usually in the form
of the and there are various ways in
which you can split this data it is up
to the individual preferences in our
case here we are splitting in the form
of 23 and 77 so when we say test size as
20 20.23
that means 23 percent of that entire
data is used for testing and the
remaining 77 percent is used for
training so there is a readily available
function which is
called train test split so we don't have
to write any special code for the
splitting it will automatically split
the data based on the proportion that we
give here which is test size so we just
give the test size automatically
training size will be determined and
we pass the data that we want to split
and the the results will be stored in x
underscore train
and y underscore train for the training
data set and what is x underscore train
these are these are the features right
which is like the independent variable
and why underscore train is the label
right so in this case what happens is we
have the input value which is or the
features value which is in x underscore
train and since this is labeled data for
each of them each of the observations we
already have the label information
saying whether this digit is a zero or a
one or a two so that that's this is what
will be used for comparison to find out
whether the the system is able to
recognize it correctly or there is an
error for each observation it will
compare with this right so this is the
label so the same way x underscore train
y underscore train is for the training
data set x underscore test y underscore
test is for the test data set okay so
let me go ahead and execute this code as
well and then we can go and check
quickly what is the how many entries are
there
and in each of this so x underscore
train the shape is 13 83
by 64 and y underscore train has 1383
because there is nothing like the second
part is not required here and then x
underscore test shape
we see is four one four so actually
there are 414 observations in test and
1383 observations in train so that's
basically what these four lines of code
are are saying okay then we import the
logistic regression library and
which is a part of scikit learn so
we we don't have to implement the
logistic regression process itself we
just call this the function and let me
go ahead and execute that so that
we have the logistic regression library
imported now we create an instance of
logistic regression right so logistic
regr is a is an instance of logistic
regression and then we use that for
training our model so let me first
execute this code so these two lines so
the first line basically creates an
instance of logistic regression model
and then the second line
is where we are passing our data the
training data set and this is our the
the predictors and
this is our target we are passing this
data set to train our model all right so
once we do this in this case the data is
not large but by and large the training
is what takes usually a lot of time so
we spend in machine learning
activities in machine learning projects
we spend a lot of time for the training
part of it okay so here the data set is
relatively small so it was pretty quick
so all right so now our model has been
trained using the training data set and
we want to see how accurate this is so
what we'll do is we will test it out in
probably faces so let me first try out
how well this is working for
one image okay i will just try it out
with one image my the first entry in my
test data set and see whether it is uh
correctly predicting or not so
and in order to test it so for training
purpose we use the fit method there is a
method called fit which is for training
the model and once the training is done
if you want to test for a particular
value new input you use the predict
method okay so let's run the predict
method and we pass this particular image
and
we see that the
shape is or the prediction is four so
let's try a few more let me see for the
next 10
seems to be fine so let me just go ahead
and test the entire data set okay that's
basically what it will do so now we want
to find out how accurately this has
performed so we use the score method to
find what is the percentages of accuracy
and we see here that it has performed up
to 94 percent to accurate okay so that's
on this part now what we can also do is
we can um also see this accuracy using
what is known as a confusion matrix so
let us go ahead and try that as well
so that we can also visualize how well
this model has
done
so let me execute this piece of code
which will basically import some of the
libraries that are required and
we we basically create a confusion
matrix and instance of confusion matrix
by running confusion matrix and passing
these values so we have so this
confusion underscore matrix method takes
two parameters one is the y underscore
test and the other is the prediction so
what is the y underscore test these are
the labeled values which we already know
for the test data set and predictions
are what the system has predicted for
the test data set okay so this is known
to us
and this is what the system has
the model has generated so we kind of
create the confusion matrix and we will
print it and this is how the confusion
matrix looks as the name suggests it is
a matrix
and
the key point out here is that the
accuracy of the model is determined by
how many numbers are there in the
diagonal the more the numbers in the
diagonal the better the accuracy is
okay and first of all the total sum of
all the numbers in this whole matrix is
equal to the number of observations in
the test data set that is the first
thing right so if you add up all these
numbers that will be equal to the number
of
observations in the test data set and
then out of that the maximum number of
them should be in the diagonal that
means the accuracy is pretty good if the
the numbers in the diagonal are less and
in all other places there are a lot of
numbers uh which means the accuracy is
very low the diagonal indicates a
correct prediction that this means that
the actual value is same as the
predicted value here again actual values
same as the predictive value and so on
right so the moment you see a number
here that means the actual value is
something and the predicted value is
something else right similarly here the
actual value is something and the
predicted value is something else so
that is basically how we read the
confusion matrix now how do we find the
accuracy you can actually add up the
total values in the diagonal so it's
like 38 plus 44 plus 43 and so on and
divide that by the total number of test
observations that will give you the
percentage accuracy using a confusion
matrix now let us visualize this
confusion matrix in a slightly more
sophisticated way uh using a heat map so
we will create a heat map with some
we'll add some colors as well it's uh
it's like more visually visually more
appealing so that's the whole idea so if
we let me run this piece of code and
this is how the heat map looks
and as you can see here the diagonals
again are all the values are here most
of the values so which means reasonably
this seems to be reasonably accurate and
yeah basically the accuracy score is 94
percent this is calculated as i
mentioned by adding all these numbers
divided by the total test values or the
total number of observations in test
data set okay so this is the confusion
matrix for logistic regression
all right so now that we have seen the
confusion matrix let's take a quick
sample and see how well the system has
classified and we will take a few
examples of the data so if we see here
we we picked up randomly a few of them
so this is uh number four which is the
actual value and also the predicted
value both are four
this is an image of zero so the
predicted value is also zero actual
value is of course zero
then this is the image of 9
so this has also been predicted
correctly 9 and actual value is 9 and
this is a image of 1 and again this has
been predicted correctly as like the
actual value okay so this was a quick
demo of logistic regression how to use
logistic regression to identify
images
what is a decision tree let's go through
a very simple example before we dig in
deep decision tree is a tree shaped
diagram used to determine a course of
action each branch of the tree
represents a possible decision or
current or reaction let's start with a
simple question how to identify a random
vegetable from a shopping bag so we have
this group of vegetables in here and we
can start off by asking a simple
question is it red and if it's not then
it's going to be the purple fruit to the
left probably an eggplant if it's true
it's going to be one of the red fruits
is the diameter greater than 2 if false
is going to be a what looks to be a red
chili and if it's true it's going to be
a bell pepper from the capsicum family
so it's a capsicum
problems that decision tree can solve so
let's look at the two different
categories the decision tree can be used
on it can be used on the classification
the true false yes no and it can be used
on regression where we figure out what
the next value is in a series of numbers
or a group of data in classification the
classification tree will determine a set
of logical if-then conditions to
classify problems for example
discriminating between three types of
flowers based on certain features in
regression a regression tree is used
when the target variable is numerical or
continuous in nature we fit the
regression model to the target variable
using each of the independent variables
each split is made based on the sum of
squared error
before we dig deeper into the mechanics
of the decision tree let's take a look
at the advantages of using a decision
tree and we'll also take a glimpse at
the disadvantages the first thing you'll
notice is that it's simple to understand
interpret and visualize it really shines
here because you can see exactly what's
going on in a decision tree little
effort is required for data preparation
so you don't have to do special scaling
there's a lot of things you don't have
to worry about when using a decision
tree it can handle both numerical and
categorical data as we discovered
earlier and non-linear parameters don't
affect its performance so even if the
data doesn't fit an easy curved graph
you can still use it to create an
effective decision or prediction
if we're going to look at the advantages
of a decision tree we also need to
understand the disadvantages of a
decision tree the first disadvantage is
overfitting overfitting occurs when the
algorithm captures noise in the data
that means you're solving for one
specific instance instead of a general
solution for all the data high variance
the model can get unstable due to small
variation in data low bias tree a highly
complicated decision tree tends to have
a low bias which makes it difficult for
the model to work with new data
decision tree important terms before we
dive in further we need to look at some
basic terms we need to have some
definitions to go with our decision tree
and the different parts we're going to
be using we'll start with entropy
entropy is a measure of randomness or
unpredictability in the data set for
example we have a in this case we do
animals in this in different kinds of
animals and this data set is considered
to have a high entropy you really can't
pick out what kind of animal it is based
on looking at just the four animals as a
big clump of entities so as we start
splitting it into subgroups we come up
with our second definition which is
information gain information gain it is
a measure of decrease in entropy after
the data set is split so in this case
based on the color yellow we've split
one group of animals on one side as true
and those who aren't yellow as false as
we continue down the yellow side we
split based on the height true or false
equals 10 and on the other side height
is less than 10 true or false and as you
see as we split it the entropy continues
to be less and less and less and so our
information gain is simply the entropy
e1 from the top and how it's changed to
e2 in the bottom and we'll look at the
deeper math although you really don't
need to know a huge amount of math when
you actually do the programming in
python because they'll do it for you but
we'll look on the actual math of how
they compute entropy finally we went
into the different parts of our tree and
they call the leaf node leaf node
carries the classification or the
decision so it's the final end at the
bottom the decision node has two or more
branches this is where we're breaking
the group up into different parts and
finally you have the root note the top
most decision note is known as the root
node
how does a decision tree work wonder
what kind of animals i'll get in the
jungle today maybe you're the hunter
with the gun or if you're more into
photography you're a photographer with a
camera so let's look at this group of
animals and let's try to classify
different types of animals based on
their features using a decision tree so
the problem statement is to classify the
different types of animals based on
their features using a decision tree the
data set is looking quite messy and the
entropy is high in this case so let's
look at a training set or a training
data set and we're looking at color
we're looking at height and then we have
our different animals we have our
elephants our giraffes our monkeys and
our tigers and there of different colors
and shapes let's see what that looks
like and how do we split the data we
have to frame the conditions that split
the data in such a way that the
information gain is the highest note
gain is the measure of decrease in
entropy after splitting so the formula
for entropy is the sum that's what this
symbol looks like that looks like kind
of like a e funky e of k where i equals
1 to k k would represent the number of
animals the different animals in there
where value or p
value of i would be the percentage of
that animal times the log base 2 of the
same the percentage of that animal let's
try to calculate the entropy for the
current data set and take a look at what
that looks like and don't be afraid of
the math you don't really have to
memorize this math just be aware that
it's there and this is what's going on
in the background and so we have three
giraffes two tigers one monkey two
elephants a total of eight animals
gathered and if we plug that into the
formula we get an entropy that equals
three over eight so we have three
giraffes a total of eight times the log
usually they use base two on the log so
log base two of three over eight plus in
this case i say it's yellow fence two
over eight two elephants over total of
eight times log base two two over eight
plus one monkey over total of eight log
base two one over 8 and plus 2 over 8 of
the tigers log base 2 over 8. and if we
plug that into our computer our
calculator i obviously can't do logs in
my head we get an entropy equal to 0.571
the program will actually calculate the
entropy of the data set similarly after
every split to calculate the gain now
we're not going to go through each set
one at a time to see what those numbers
are we just want you to be aware that
this is a formula or the mathematics
behind it gain can be calculated by
finding the difference of the subsequent
entropy values after a split now we'll
try to choose a condition that gives us
the highest gain we will do that by
splitting the data using each condition
and checking that the gain we get out of
them the condition that gives us the
highest gain will be used to make the
first split can you guess what that
first split will be just by looking at
this image as a human is probably pretty
easy to split it let's see if you're
right if you guessed the color yellow
you're correct let's say the condition
that gives us the maximum gain is yellow
so we will split the data based on the
color yellow if it's true that group of
animals goes to the left if it's false
it goes to the right the entropy after
the splitting has
decreased considerably however we still
need some splitting of both the branches
to attain an entropy value equal to zero
so we decide to split both the nodes
using height as the condition since
every branch now contains single label
type we can say that entropy in this
case has reached the least value and
here you see we have the giraffes the
tigers the monkey and the elephants all
separated into their own groups this
tree can now predict all the classes of
animals present in the dataset with a
hundred percent accuracy that was easy
use case loan repayment prediction let's
get into my favorite part and open up
some python and see what the programming
code in the scripting looks like in here
we're going to want to do a prediction
and we start with this individual here
who's requesting to find out how good
his customers are going to be whether
they're going to repay their loan or not
for his bank and from that we want to
generate a problem statement to predict
if a customer will repay loan amount or
not and then we're going to be using the
decision tree algorithm in python let's
see what that looks like and let's dive
into the code in our first few steps of
implementation we're going to start by
importing the necessary packages that we
need from python and we're going to load
up our data and take a look at what the
data looks like so the first thing i
need is i need something to edit my
python and run it in so let's flip on
over and here i'm using the anaconda
jupiter notebook now you can use any
python ide you like to run it in but i
find the jupiter notebooks really nice
for doing things on the fly and let's go
ahead and just paste that code in the
beginning and before we start let's talk
a little bit about what we're bringing
in and then we're going to do a couple
things in here we have to make a couple
changes as we go through this first part
of the import the first thing we bring
in is numpy as np that's very standard
when we're dealing with mathematics
especially with uh very complicated
machine learning tools you almost always
see the numpy come in for your num your
number it's called number python it has
your mathematics in there in this case
we actually could take it out but
generally you'll need it for most of
your different things you work with and
then we're going to use pandas as pd
that's also a standard the pandas is a
data frame setup and you can liken this
to taking your basic data and storing it
in a way that looks like an excel
spreadsheet so as we come back to this
when you see np or pd those are very
standard uses you'll know that that's
the pandas and i'll show you a little
bit more we explore the data in just a
minute then we're going to need to split
the data so i'm going to bring in our
train test and split and this is coming
from the sk learn package cross
validation in just a minute we're going
to change that and we'll go over that
too and then there's also the sk.tree
import decision tree classifier that's
the actual tool we're using remember i
told you don't be afraid of the
mathematics it's going to be done for
you well the decision tree classifier
has all that mathematics in there for
you so you don't have to figure it back
out again and then we have
sklearn.metrics
for accuracy score we need to score our
setup that's the whole reason we're
splitting it between the training and
testing data and finally we still need
the sklearn import tree and that's just
the basic tree function is needed for
the decision tree classifier and finally
we're going to load our data down here
and i'm going to run this and we're
going to get two things on here one
we're going to get an error and two
we're going to get a warning let's see
what that looks like so the first thing
we had is we have an error why is this
error here well it's looking at this it
says i need to read a file and when this
was written
the person who wrote it
this is their path where they stored the
file
so let's go ahead and fix that
and i'm going to put in here my file
path i'm just going to call it full file
name and you'll see it's on my c drive
and this is very lengthy setup on here
where i stored the data2.csv
file
don't worry too much about the full path
because on your computer it'll be
different the data.2 csv file was
generated by simplylearn
if you want a copy of that you can
comment down below
and request it here in the youtube
and then if i'm going to give it a name
full file name
i'm going to go ahead and change it here
to full
file name so let's go ahead and run it
now and see what happens
and we get a warning
when you're coding
understanding these different warnings
and these different errors that come up
is probably the hardest lesson to learn
so let's just go ahead and take a look
at this and use this as a opportunity to
understand what's going on here
if you read the warning it says the
cross validation is depreciated so it's
a warning on it's being removed
and it's going to be moved in favor of
the model selection
so if we go up here we have
sklearn.cross validation and if you
research this and go to the sklearn site
you'll find out that you can actually
just swap it right in there with
model selection
and so when i come in here and i run it
again
that removes a warning
what they've done is they've had two
different developers develop it in two
different branches
and then they decided to keep one of
those and eventually get rid of the
other one that's all that is and very
easy and quick to fix
before we go any further i went ahead
and opened up the data
from this file remember the the data
file we just loaded on here the data
underscore2.csv
let's talk a little bit more about that
and see what that looks like both as a
text file because it's a comma separated
variable file and in a spreadsheet
this is what it looks like as a basic
text file you can see at the top they've
created a header and it's got one two
three four five columns and each column
has data in it and let me flip this over
because we're also going to look at this
uh in an actual spreadsheet so you can
see what that looks like and here i've
opened it up in the open office calc
which is pretty much the same as excel
and zoomed in and you can see we've got
our columns and our rows of data a
little easier to read in here we have a
result yes yes no we have initial
payment last payment credit score
house number if we scroll way down
we'll see that this occupies a thousand
and one lines of code or lines of data
with the first one being a column and
then one thousand lines of data
now as a programmer
if you're looking at a small amount of
data i usually start by pulling it up in
different sources so i can see what i'm
working with
but in larger data you won't have that
option it'll just be too too large so
you need to either bring in a small
amount that you can look at it like
we're doing right now or we can start
looking at it through the python code so
let's go ahead and move on and take the
next couple steps to explore the data
using python let's go ahead and see what
it looks like in python to print the
length and the shape of the data so
let's start by printing the length of
the database we can use a simple lin
function from python
and when i run this you'll see that it's
a thousand long and that's what we
expected there's a thousand lines of
data in there if you subtract the column
head
this is one of the nice things when we
did the
balance data from the panda read csv
you'll see that the header is row zero
so it automatically removes a row
and then shows the data separate it does
a good job sorting that data out for us
and then we can use a different function
and let's take a look at that
and again we're going to utilize the
tools in panda
and since the balance underscored data
was loaded as a panda data frame
we can do a shape on it and let's go
ahead and run the shape and see what
that looks like
what's nice about this shape is not only
does it give me the length of the data
we have a thousand lines it also tells
me there's five columns so we were
looking at the data we had five columns
of data and then let's take one more
step to explore the data using python
and now that we've taken a look at the
length and the shape let's go ahead and
use the pandas module for head another
beautiful thing in the data set that we
can utilize so let's put that on our
sheet here and we have print data set
and balance data dot head and this is a
pandas print statement of its own so it
has its own print feature in there and
then we went ahead and gave a label for
a print job here of data set just a
simple print statement
and we run that
let's just take a closer look at that
let me zoom in here
there we go
pandas does such a wonderful job of
making this a very clean
readable data set so you can look at the
data you can look at the column headers
you can have it when you put it as the
head
it prints the first five lines of the
data
and we always start with zero so we have
five lines we have 0 1 2 3 4 instead of
1 2 3 4 5.
that's a standard scripting and
programming set as you want to start
with the zero position and that is what
the data head does it pulls the first
five rows of data puts in a nice format
that you can look at and view very
powerful tool to view the data so
instead of having to flip and open up an
excel spreadsheet or open office cal or
trying to look at a word doc where it's
all scrunched together and hard to read
you can now get a nice open view of what
you're working with we're working with a
shape of a thousand long five wide so we
have five columns and we do the full
data head you can actually see what this
data looks like the initial payment last
payment credit scores house number so
let's take this now that we've explored
the data and let's start digging into
the decision tree so in our next step
we're going to train and build our data
tree and to do that we need to first
separate the data out we're going to
separate into two groups so that we have
something to actually train the data
with and then we have some data on the
side to test it to see how good our
model is remember with any of the
machine learning you always want to have
some kind of test set to to weigh it
against so you know how good your model
is when you distribute it let's go ahead
and break this code down and look at it
in pieces
so first we have our x and y
where do x and y come from well x is
going to be our data
and y is going to be the answer or the
target you can look at it source and
target
in this case we're using x and y to
denote the data in and the data that
we're actually trying to guess what the
answer is going to be and so to separate
it we can simply put in x equals the
balance of the data.values the first
brackets
means that we're going to select all the
lines
in the database so it's all the data
and the second one says we're only going
to look at columns one through five
remember we start with zero zero is a
yes or no and that's whether the loan
went default or not so we want to start
with one if we go back up here that's
the initial payment and it goes all the
way through the house number
well if we want to look at one through
five we can do the same thing for y
which is the answers
and we're going to set that just equal
to the zero row so it's just the zero
row and then it's all rows going in
there so now we've divided this into two
different data sets
one of them with the
data going in and one with the answers
next we need to split the data
and here you'll see that we have it
split into four different parts
the first one is your x training your x
test your y train your y test
simply put we have x going in where
we're going to train it and we have to
know the answer to train it with
and then we have x test where we're
going to test that data and we have to
know in the end what the y was supposed
to be
and that's where this train test split
comes in that we loaded earlier in the
modules this does it all for us and you
can see they set the test size equal to
0.3 so that's roughly 30 percent will be
used in the test and then we use a
random state so it's completely random
which rows it takes out of there and
then finally we get to actually build
our decision tree and they've called it
here clf underscore entropy that's the
actual decision tree or decision tree
classifier and in here they've added a
couple variables which we'll explore in
just a minute and then finally we need
to fit the data to that so we take our
clf entropy that we created and we fit
the x train and since we know the
answers for x-trade or the y-train we go
ahead and put those in and let's go
ahead and run this and what most of
these sklearn modules do is when you set
up the variable in this case we set the
clf entropy called decision tree
classifier it automatically prints out
what's in that decision tree there's a
lot of variables you can play within
here and it's quite beyond the scope of
this
tutorial to go through all of these and
how they work but we're working on
entropy that's one of the options we've
added that is completely a random state
of 100 so 100 percent and we have a max
depth of three now the max depth if you
remember above when we were doing the
different graphs of animals means it's
only going to go down three layers
before it stops and then we have minimal
samples of leaves as five so it's going
to have at least five leaves at the end
so i'll have at least three splits i'll
have no more than three layers and at
least five end leaves with the final
result at the bottom now that we've
created
our decision tree classifier not only
created it but trained it let's go ahead
and apply it and see what that looks
like so let's go ahead and make a
prediction and see what that looks like
we're going to paste our predict code in
here
and before we run it let's just take a
quick look at what's it's doing here
we have a variable y predict that we're
going to do
and we're going to use our
variable clf entropy that we created
and then you'll see dot predict and it's
very common in the sk learn modules
that their different tools have the
predict when you're actually running a
prediction
in this case we're going to put our x
test data in here
now if you delivered this for use and
actual commercial use and distributed it
this would be the new loans you're
putting in here to guess whether the
person is going to be pay them back or
not
in this case so we need to test out the
data and just see how good our sample is
how good of our tree does at predicting
the loan payments and finally since
anaconda jupiter notebook is it works as
a command line for python we can simply
put the y predict e n to print it i
could just as easily put the print
and put brackets around y predict en to
print it out we'll go ahead and do that
it doesn't matter which way you do it
and you'll see right here that runs a
prediction this is roughly 300 in here
remember it's 30 percent of a thousand
so you should have about 300 answers in
here
and this tells you which each one of
those lines of our test went in there
and this is what our y predict came out
so let's move on to the next step we're
going to take this data and try to
figure out just how good a model we have
so here we go since sklearn does all the
heavy lifting for you and all the math
we have a simple line of code to let us
know what the accuracy is and let's go
ahead and go through that and see what
that means and what that looks like
let's go ahead and paste this in and let
me zoom in a little bit
there we go so you have a nice full
picture
and we'll see here we're just going to
do a print accuracy is
and then we do the accuracy score
and this was something we imported
earlier if you remember at the very
beginning let me just scroll up there
real quick so you can see where that's
coming from
that's coming from here down here from
sklearn.metrics
import accuracy score
and you could probably run a script make
your own script to do this very easily
how accurate is it how many out of 300
did we get right and so we put in our y
test that's the one we ran the predict
on and then we put in our y predict e n
that's the answers we got and we're just
going to multiply that by a hundred
because this is just going to give us an
answer as a decimal and we want to see
it as a percentage
let's run that and see what it looks
like
and if you see here we got an accuracy
of 93.6667
so when we look at the number of loans
and we look at how good our model fit we
can tell people it has about a 93.6
fitting to it so just a quick recap on
that we now have accuracy set up on here
and so we have created a model that uses
the decision tree algorithm to predict
whether a customer will repay the loan
or not the accuracy of the model is
about 94.6 percent the bank can now use
this model to decide whether it should
approve the loan request from a
particular customer or not and so this
information is really powerful we may
not be able to as individuals understand
all these numbers because they have
thousands of numbers that come in but
you can see that this is a smart
decision for the bank to use a tool like
this to help them to predict how good
their profit's going to be off of the
loan balances and how many are going to
default or not today we're going to be
looking at random forest one of the many
powerful tools in the machine learning
library before we dive into the topic
let's start by looking at a few of the
uses for random forest currently today
is used in remote sensing
for example they're used in the etm
devices if you're a space buff that's
the enhanced thermatic mapper they use
on satellites which see far outside the
human spectrum for looking at land
masses and they acquire images of the
earth's surface the accuracy is higher
and training time is less than many
other machine learning tools out there
also object detection multi-class object
detection is done using random forest
algorithms a good example is a traffic
where you're trying to sort out the
different cars buses and things and it
provides a better detection in
complicated environments they're very
complicated up there and then we have
another example connect and let's take a
little closer look at connect connect
they use a random forest as part of the
game console
and what it does is it tracks the body
movements and it recreates it in the
game
let's see what that looks like
we have a user who performs a step in
this case it looks like elvis presley
going there
that is then recorded so the connect
registers the movement
and then it marks the user based on
accuracy it looks like we have uh prints
going on this one
from uh elvis press leader prince that's
great
uh so mark's user based on the accuracy
if we look at that a little closer we
have a training set to identify body
parts where are the hands where the feet
what's going on with the body
that then goes into a random forest
classifier that learns from it
once we've trained the classifier
and then identifies the body parts while
the person's dancing it's able to
represent that in a computer format and
then based on that it scores the game
and how accurate you are as being elvis
presley or prince in your dancing let's
take an overview of what we're going to
cover today what's in it for you we're
going to start with is what is machine
learning we're not going to go into
detail on that we're going to
specifically look how the random force
fits in the machine learning hierarchy
then we're going to look at some
applications of random forest what is
classification which is his primary use
why use random force what's the benefits
of it and how does it actually come
together what is random forest and then
we'll get into random forest and the
decision tree how all that's like the
final step and how it works and finally
we'll get some python code in there and
we'll use the case the iris flower
analysis now if you don't know what any
of these terms mean or where we're going
with this don't worry we're going to
cover all the basics and have you up and
running and even having doing some basic
script in python by the end let's take a
closer look at types of machine learning
specifically we're going to look at
where the decision tree fits in with the
different machine learning packages out
there we'll start with the basic types
of machine learning there's supervised
learning where you have lots of data and
you're able to train your models there's
unsupervised learning where it has to
look at the data and then divide it
based on its own algorithms without
having any training and then there's
reinforcement learning where you get a
plus or negative if you have the answer
correct this particular tool belongs to
the supervised learning let's take a
closer look at that what that means in
supervised learning supervised learning
falls into two groups classification and
regression we'll talk about regression a
little later in how that differs this
particular format goes underneath
classification so we're looking at
supervised learning and classification
in the machine learning tools
classification is a kind of problem
where in the outputs are categorical in
nature like yes or no true or false or
zero or one in that particular framework
there's the knn where the nn stands for
nearest neighbor nave bays
the decision tree which is part of the
random forest that we're studying today
so why random forest it's always
important to understand
why we use this tool over the other ones
what are the benefits here and so with
the random forest the first one is
there's no overfitting if you use of
multiple trees reduce the risk of
overfitting training time is less
overfitting means that we have fit the
data so close to what we have as our
sample that we pick up on all the weird
parts
and instead of predicting the overall
data you're predicting the weird stuff
which you don't want
high accuracy runs efficiently in large
database for large data it produces
highly accurate predictions
in today's world of big data this is
really important and this is probably
where it really shines this is where why
random forest really comes in it
estimates missing data data in today's
world is very messy so when you have a
random forest it can maintain the
accuracy when a large proportion of the
data is missing what that means is if
you have data that comes in from five or
six different areas and maybe they took
one set of statistics in one area
and they took a slightly different set
of statistics in the other so they have
some of the same same shared data but
one is missing like the number of
children in the house if you're doing
something over demographics and the
other one is missing the size of the
house it will look at both of those
separately and build two different trees
and then it can do a very good job of
guessing
which one fits better even though it's
missing that data let us dig deep into
the theory of exactly how it works
and let's look at what is a random
forest random forest or random decision
forest is a method that operates by
constructing multiple decision trees the
decision of the majority of the trees is
chosen by the random forest as a final
decision and this uh we have some nice
graphics here we have a decision tree
and they actually use a real tree to
denote the decision tree which i love
and given a random some kind of picture
of a fruit this decision tree decides
that the output is it's an apple and we
have a decision tree two where we have
that picture of the fruit goes in and
this one decides that it's a lemon and
the decision three tree gets another
image and it decides it's an apple and
then this all comes together in what
they call the random forest and this
random forest then looks at it and says
okay i got two votes for apple one vote
for lemon the majority is apples so the
final decision is
apples to understand how the random
forest works we first need to dig a
little deeper and take a look at the
random forest and the actual decision
tree and how it builds that decision
tree in looking closer at how the
individual decision trees work we'll go
ahead and continue to use the fruit
example since we're talking about trees
and forests a decision tree is a tree
shaped diagram used to determine a
course of action each branch of the tree
represents a possible decision
occurrence or reaction so in here we
have a bowl of fruit and if you look at
that it looks like they switch from
lemons to oranges we have oranges
cherries and apples and the first
decision of the decision tree might be
is a diameter greater than or equal to
three and if it says false it knows that
they're cherries because everything else
is bigger than that so all the cherries
fall into that decision so we have all
that data we're training
we can look at that we know that that's
what's going to come up
is the color orange well goes hmm orange
or red well if it's true
then it comes out as the orange and if
it's false that leaves apples
so in this example it sorts out the
fruit in the bowl or the images of the
fruit a decision tree these are very
important terms to know because these
are very central to understanding the
decision tree when working with them the
first is entropy
everything on the decision tree and how
it makes those decision is based on
entropy entropy is a measure of
randomness or unpredictability in the
data set
then they also have information gain
the leaf node the decision node and the
root node we'll cover these other four
terms as we go down the tree but let's
start with entropy
so starting with entropy we have here a
high amount of randomness what that
means is that whatever's coming out of
this decision if it was going to guess
based on this data
it wouldn't be able to tell you whether
it's a lemon or an apple it would just
say it's a fruit
so the first thing we want to do is we
want to split this apart and we take the
initial data set we're going to set
create a data set 1 and a data set 2 we
just split it into and if you look at
these new data sets after splitting them
the entropy of each of those sets is
much less
so for the first one whatever comes in
there it's going to sort that data and
it's going to say okay if this data goes
this direction it's probably an apple
and if it goes into the other direction
it's probably a lemon so that brings us
up to information gain it is the measure
of decrease in the entropy after the
data set is split what that means in
here is that we've gone from
one set which has a very high entropy to
two lower sets of entropy and we've
added in the values of e1 for the first
one and e2 for the second two which are
much lower and so that information gain
is increased greatly in this example and
so you can find that the information
grain simply equals
decision e1
minus e2 as we're going down our list of
definitions we'll look at the leaf node
and the leaf node
carries the classification or the
decision
so we look down here to the leaf node we
finally get to our set one or our set
two
when it comes down there and it says
okay this object's gone into set one
if it's gone into set one
it's going to be split by some means and
we'll either end up with apples on the
leaf node or a lemon on the leaf node
and on the right it'll either be an
apple or lemons those leaf nodes are
those final decisions or classifications
that's the definition of leaf node in
here if we're going to have a final leaf
where we make the decision we should
have a name for the nodes above it and
they call those decision nodes
a decision node decision node has two or
more branches and you can see here where
we have the
five apples and one lemon and in the
other case the five lemons in one apple
they have to make a choice of which tree
it goes down
based on some kind of measurement or
information given to the tree
and that brings us to our last
definition the root node the top most
decision node is known as the root node
and this is where you have all of your
data and you have your first decision it
has to make or the first split in
information
so far we've looked at a very general
image
with the fruit being split let's look
and see exactly what that means to split
the data and how do we make those
decisions on there
let's go in there and find out how does
a decision tree work so let's try to
understand this and let's use a simple
example and we'll stay with the fruit we
have a bowl of fruit and so let's create
a problem statement and the problem is
we want to classify the different types
of fruits in the bowl based on different
features the data set in the bowl is
looking quite messy and the entropy is
high in this case so if this bowl was
our decision maker it wouldn't know what
choice to make it has so many choices
which one do you pick apple
grapes or lemons and so we look in here
we're going to start with the dra a
training set
so this is our data that we're training
our data with and we have a number of
options here we have the color and under
the color we have red yellow purple
we have a diameter
three three one three three one and we
have a label apple lemon grapes apple
lemon grapes and how do we split the
data we have to frame the conditions to
split the data in such a way that the
information gain is the highest
it's very key to note that we're looking
for the best gain we don't want to just
start sorting out the smallest piece in
there we want to split it the biggest
way we can and so we measure this
decrease in entropy that's what they
call it entropy there's our entropy
after splitting and now we'll try to
choose a condition that gives us the
highest gain we will do that by
splitting the data using each condition
and checking the gain that we get out of
them the conditions that give us the
highest gain will be used to make the
first split so let's take a look at
these different conditions we have color
we have diameter and if we look
underneath that we have a couple
different values we have diameter equals
three color equals yellow red diameter
equals one and when we look at that
you'll see over here we have one two
three four threes that's a pretty hardy
selection so let's say the condition
gives us a maximum gain of three so we
have the most pieces fall into
that range so our first split from our
decision node is we split the data based
on the diameter is it greater than or
equal to three if it's not that's false
it goes into the grape bowl and if it's
true it goes into a bowl fold of lemon
and apples the entropy after splitting
has decreased considerably so now we can
make two decisions if you look at
they're very
much
less chaos going on there this note has
already attained an entropy value of 0
as you can see there's only one kind of
label left for this branch so no further
splitting is required for this node
however this node on the right is still
requires a split to decrease the entropy
further so we split the right node
further based on color if you look at
this if i split it on color that pretty
much cuts it right down the middle it's
the only thing we have left in our
choices of color and diameter too and if
the color is yellow it's going to go to
the right bowl and if it's false it's
going to go to the left bowl so the
entropy in this case is now zero so now
we have three bowls with zero entropy
there's only one type of data in each
one of those bowls so we can predict a
lemon with a hundred percent accuracy
and we can predict the apple also with
100 accuracy along with our grapes up
there so we've looked at kind of a basic
tree in our forest but what we really
want to know is how does a random forest
work as a whole so to begin our
random forest classifier let's say we
already have built three trees and we're
going to start with the first tree that
looks like this just like we did in the
example this tree looks at the diameter
if it's greater than or equal to three
it's true otherwise it's false so one
side goes to the smaller diameter one
side goes to larger diameter and if the
color is orange it's going to go to the
right true we're using oranges now
instead of lemons and if it's red it's
going to go to the left false we build a
second tree very similar but split
differently instead of the first one
being split by a diameter this one when
they created it if you look at that
first bowl it has a lot of red objects
so it says is the color red because
that's going to bring our entropy down
the fastest and so of course if it's
true it goes to the left if it's false
it goes to the right and then it looks
at the shape false or true and so on and
so on and tree three is the diameter
equal to one and it came up with this
because there's a lot of cherries in
this bowl so that would be the biggest
split on there is is the diameter equal
to one that's going to drop the entropy
the quickest and as you can see it
splits it into true if it goes false and
they've added another category does it
grow in the summer and if it's false
it goes off to the left if it's true it
goes off to the right let's go ahead and
bring these three trees you can see them
all in one image so this would be three
completely different trees categorizing
a fruit and let's take a fruit now let's
try this and this fruit if you look at
it we've blackened it out you can't see
the color on it so it's missing data
remember one of the things we talked
about earlier is that a random forest
works really good if you're missing data
if you're missing pieces so this fruit
has an image but maybe the person had a
black and white camera when they took
the picture and we're going to take a
look at this and it's going to have they
put the color in there so ignore the
color down there but the diameter equals
three we find out it grows in the summer
equals yes and the shape is a circle and
if you go to the right you can look at
what one of the decision trees did this
is the third one is the diameter greater
than equal to 3 is the color orange well
it doesn't really know on this one but
if you look at the value and say true
and go to the right tree 2 classifies it
as cherries is a color equal red
is the shape of circle true it is a
circle so this would look at it and say
oh that's a cherry and then we go to the
other classifier and it says is the
diameter equal one well that's false
does it grow in the summer true so it
goes down and looks at as oranges so how
does this random forest work the first
one says it's an orange
the second one said it was a cherry and
the third one says it's an orange
and you can guess if you have two
oranges and one says it's a cherry
when you add that all together the
majority of the vote says orange so the
answer is it's classified as an orange
even though we didn't know the color and
we're missing data on it i don't know
about you but i'm getting tired of fruit
so let's switch and i did promise you
we'd start looking at a case example and
get into some python coding today we're
going to use the case the iris flower
analysis
this is the exciting part as we roll up
our sleeves and actually look at some
python coding before we start the python
coding we need to go ahead and create a
problem statement wonder what species of
iris do these flowers belong to let's
try to predict the species of the
flowers using machine learning in python
let's see how it can be done so here we
begin to go ahead and implement our
python code and you'll find that the
first half of our implementation is all
about organizing and exploring the data
coming in let's go ahead and take this
first step which is loading the
different modules into python and let's
go ahead and put that in our favorite
editor whatever your favorite editor is
in this case i'm going to be using the
anaconda jupiter notebook which is one
of my favorites certainly there's
notepad plus plus and eclipse and dozens
of others or just even using the python
terminal window any of those will work
just fine to go ahead and explore this
python coding so here we go let's go
ahead and flip over to our jupiter
notebook and i've already opened up a
new
page for python 3 code and i'm just
going to paste this right in there and
let's take a look and see what we're
bringing into our python the first thing
we're going to do is from the
sklearn.datasets
import load iris now this isn't the
actual data this is just the module that
allows us to bring in the data the load
iris and the iris is so popular it's
been around since 1936 when ronald
fisher published a paper on it and
they're measuring the different parts of
the flower and based on those
measurements predicting what kind of
flower it is and then if we're going to
do a random forest classifier we need to
go ahead and import a random forest
classifier from the sklearn module so
sklearn.ensemble import random force
classifier and then we want to bring in
two more modules
and these are probably the most commonly
used modules in python and data science
with any of the
other modules that we bring in and one
is going to be pandas we're going to
import pandas as pd pd is a common term
used for pandas and pandas is basically
creates a data format for us where when
you create a pandas data frame it looks
like an excel spreadsheet and you'll see
that in a minute when we start digging
deeper into the code panda is just
wonderful because it plays nice with all
the other modules in there and then we
have numpy which is our numbers python
and the numbers python allows us to do
different mathematical sets on here
we'll see right off the bat we're going
to take our np and we're going to go
ahead and seed the randomness with it
with 0. so
np.random.seed is seating that is 0.
this code doesn't actually show anything
we're going to go ahead and run it
because i need to make sure i have all
those loaded and then let's take a look
at the next module on here the next six
slides including this one are all about
exploring the data remember i told you
half of this is about looking at the
data and getting it all set so let's go
ahead and take this code right here the
script and let's get that over into our
jupyter notebook and here we go we've
gone ahead and run the imports and i'm
going to paste the code down here
and let's take a look and see what's
going on the first thing we're doing is
we're actually loading the iris data and
if you remember up here we loaded the
module that tells it how to get the iris
data now we're actually assigning that
data to the variable iris and then we're
going to go ahead and use the df to
define data frame
and that's going to equal pd and if
remember that's pandas as pd so that's
our pandas
and panda data frame and then we're
looking at iris data
and columns equals iris feature names
and we're going to do the df head and
let's run this you can understand what's
going on here
the first thing you want to notice is
that our df has created what looks like
an excel spreadsheet
and in this excel spreadsheet we have
set the columns so up on the top you can
see the four different columns and then
we have the data iris.data down below
it's a little confusing without knowing
where this data is coming from so let's
look at the bigger picture and i'm going
to go print i'm just going to change
this for a moment and we're going to
print all of iris and see what that
looks like
so when i print all the virus i get this
long list of information
and you can scroll through here and see
all the different titles on there
what's important to notice is that first
off there's a brackets at the beginning
so this is a python dictionary
and in a python dictionary you'll have a
key or a label and this label pulls up
whatever information comes after it so
feature names which we actually used
over here under columns is equal to an
array of sepal length steeple width
pedal length pedal width these are the
different names they have for the four
different columns and if you scroll down
far enough you'll also see data down
here oh goodness it came up right
towards the top and data is equal to the
different data we're looking at now
there's a lot of other things in here
like target we're going to be pulling
that up in a minute and there's also the
names the target names which is further
down and we'll show you that also in a
minute let's go ahead and set that back
to the head
and this is one of the neat features of
pandas and panda data frames
is when you do df.head or the
pandadataframe.head it'll print the
first five lines of the dataset in there
along with the headers if you have it in
this case we have the column header set
to iris features and in here you'll see
that we have 0 1 2 3 4 in python most
arrays always start at 0. so when you
look at the first five it's going to be
zero one two three four not one two
three four five so now we've got our
iris data imported into a data frame
let's take a look at the next piece of
code in here and so in this section here
of the code we're gonna take a look at
the target and let's go ahead and get
this into our notebook this piece of
code so we can discuss it a little bit
more in detail so here we are in our
jupiter notebook i'm going to put the
code in here and before i run it i want
to look at a couple things going on so
we have
df species
and this is interesting because right
here you'll see where i have df species
in brackets which is uh the key code for
creating another column and here we have
iris.target now these are both in the
pandas setup on here so in pandas we can
do either one i could have just as
easily done iris and then in brackets
target depending on what i'm working on
both are
acceptable let's go ahead and run this
code and see how this changes and what
we've done is we've added the target
from the iris data set
as another column on the end
now what species is this is what we're
trying to predict so we have our data
which tells us the answer for all these
different pieces and then we've added a
column with the answer that way when we
do our final setup we'll have the
ability to program our neural network to
look for these this different data and
know what a setosa is
or a vera color which we'll see in just
a minute or virginica those are the
three that are in there and now we're
going to add one more column i know
we're organizing all this data over and
over again it's kind of fun there's a
lot of ways to organize it what's nice
about putting everything onto one
data frame is i can then do a printout
and it shows me exactly what i'm looking
at and i'll show you where you where
that's different where you can alter
that and do it slightly differently but
let's go ahead and put this into our
script up to debt now and here we go
we're going to put that down here
and we're going to run that
and let's talk a little bit about what
we're doing now we're exploring data
and
one of the challenges is knowing how
good your model is did your model work
and to do this we need to split the data
and we split it into two different parts
they usually call it the training and
the testing and so in here we're going
to go ahead and put that in our database
so you can see it clearly and we've set
it df remember you can put brackets this
is creating another column is train so
we're going to use part of it for
training and this equals np remember
that stands for numpy.random.uniform
so we're generating a random number
between 0 and 1. and we're going to do
it for each of the rows that's where the
length df comes from so each row gets a
generated number and if it's less than
0.75 it's true and if it's greater than
0.75 it's false this means we're going
to take
of the data roughly because there's a
randomness involved and we're going to
use that to train it and then the other
25 we're going to hold off to the side
and use that to test it later on so
let's flip back on over and see what the
next step is so now that we've labeled
our database for which is training and
which is testing
let's go ahead and sort that into two
different variables train and test and
let's take this code and let's bring it
into our project and here we go let's
paste it on down here and before i run
this let's just take a quick look at
what's going on here is we have up above
we created remember there's our def dot
head which prints the first five rows
and we've added a column is train at the
end and so we're going to take that
we're going to create two variables
we're going to create two new data
frames one's called train
one's called test 75 in train 25 percent
and test
and then to sort that out
we're going to do that by doing df our
main original data frame with the iris
data in it
and if df is trained equals true
that's going to go in the train and if
df is trained equals false it goes in
the test
and so when i run this
we're going to print out the number in
each one let's see what that looks like
and you'll see that it puts 118 in the
training module and it puts 32 in the
testing module which lets us know that
there was 150 lines of data in here so
if you went and looked at the original
data you could see that there's 150
lines and that's roughly 75 and one and
25 percent for us to test our model on
afterward so let's jump back to our code
and see where this goes in the next two
steps
we want to do one more thing with our
data and that's make it readable to
humans
i don't know about you but i hate
looking at zeros and ones
so let's start with the features and
let's go ahead and
take those and make those readable to
humans and let's put that in our code
let's see here we go paste it in
and you'll see here we've done a couple
very basic things we know that the
columns in our data frame again this is
a panda thing the df columns
and we know the first four of them zero
one two three that'd be the first four
are going to be the features or the
titles of those columns and so when i
run this
you'll see down here that it creates an
index sepa length sepa width pedal
length and pedal width and this should
be familiar because if you look up here
here's our column titles going across
and here's the first four
one thing i want you to notice here is
that when you're in a command line
whether it's jupiter notebook or you're
running command line in the terminal
window
if you just put the name of it it'll
print it out this is the same as doing
print
features
and the short hand is you just put
features in here if you're actually
writing a code
and saving the script and running it by
remote you really need to put the print
in there but for this when i run it
you'll see it gives me the same thing
but for this we want to go ahead and
we'll just leave it as features because
it doesn't really matter and this is one
of the fun thing about jupiter notebooks
is i'm just building the code as we go
and then we need to go ahead and create
the labels for the other part so let's
take a look and see what that
for our final step in prepping our data
before we actually start running the
training and the testing is we're going
to go ahead and convert the species on
here into something the computer
understands so let's put this code into
our script and see where that takes us
all right here we go we've set y equal
to pd dot factorize
train species of zero
so let's break this down just a little
bit we have our pandas right here pd
factorize what is factorized doing i'm
going to come back to that in just a
second
let's look at what train species is
and why we're looking at the group 0 on
there
and let's go up here and here is our
species
remember this on that we created this
whole column here for species
and then it has setosa setosa setosa
setosa and if you scroll down enough
you'd also see virginica and vera color
we need to convert that into something
the computer understands zeros and ones
so the train species
of zero because this is in the format of
a of an array of arrays so you have to
have the zero on the end
and then species is just that column
factorize goes in there looks at the
fact that there's only three of them so
when i run this you'll see that y
generates an array that's equal to in
this case it's the training set and it's
zeros ones and twos representing the
three different kinds of flowers we have
so now we have something the computer
understands and we have a nice table
that we can read and understand and now
finally we get to actually start doing
the predicting so here we go
uh we have
two lines of code oh my goodness that
was a lot of work to get to two lines of
code but there is a lot in these two
lines of code so let's take a look and
see what's going on here and put this
into our full script that we're running
and let's paste this in here and let's
take a look and see what this is we have
we're creating a variable clf and we're
going to set this equal to the random
forest classifier and we're passing two
variables in here and there's a lot of
variables you can play with as far as
these two are concerned they're very
standard
in jobs all that does is to prioritize
it not something to really worry about
usually when you're doing this on your
own computer you do in jobs equals two
if you're working in a larger or big
data and you need to prioritize it
differently this is what that number
does is it changes your priorities and
how it's going to run across the system
and things like that and then the random
state is just how it starts
zero is fine for here
but let's go ahead and run this
we also have clf.fit train features
comma y and before we run it let's talk
about this a little bit more clf
dot fit so we're fitting we're training
it we are actually creating our random
forest classifier right here this is the
code that does everything and we're
going to take our training set remember
we kept our test off to the side and
we're going to take our training set
with the features and then we're going
to go ahead and put that in and here's
our target the y
so the y is 0 1 and 2 that we just
created and the features is the actual
data going in that we put into the
training set let's go ahead and run that
and this is kind of an interesting thing
because it printed out the random force
classifier
and everything around it
and so when you're running this in your
terminal window or in a script like this
this automatically treats us like just
like when we were up here and i typed in
y and i printed out y instead of print y
this does the same thing it treats this
as a variable and prints it out but if
you're actually running your code that
wouldn't be the case and what is printed
out is it shows us all the different
variables we can change and if we go
down here you can actually see in jobs
equals two
you can see the random state equals zero
those are the two that we sent in there
you would really have to dig deep to
find out all these the different
meanings of all these different settings
on here some of them are
self-explanatory if you kind of think
about it a little bit like max features
is auto so all the features that we're
putting in there is just gonna
automatically take all four of them
whatever we send it it'll take some of
them might have so many features because
you're processing words there might be
like 1.4 million features in there
because you're doing legal documents and
that's how many different words are in
there at that point you probably want to
limit the maximum features that you're
going to process and leaf nodes that's
the endnotes remember we had the fruit
and we're talking about the leaf nodes
like i said there's a lot in this we're
looking at a lot of stuff here so you
might have in this case there's probably
only think three leaf nodes maybe four
you might have thousands of leaf nodes
at which point you do need to put a cap
on that and say okay it can only go so
far and then we're going to use all of
our resources on processing this and
that really is what most of these are
about is limiting the process and making
sure we don't overwhelm a system and
there's some other settings in here
again we're not going to go over all of
them warm start equals false warm start
is if you're programming it one piece at
a time externally since we're not we're
not going to have like we're not going
to continually train this particular
learning tree and again like i said
there's a lot of things in here that
you'll want to look up more detail from
the sk learn
and if you're digging in deep and
running a major project on here for
today though all we need to do is fit
our train our features and our target y
so now we have our training model what's
next if we're going to create a model
we now need to test it remember we set
aside the test feature test group 25 of
the data so let's go ahead and take this
code and let's put it into our script
and see what that looks like okay here
we go
and we're going to run this
and it's going to come out with a bunch
of zeros ones and twos which represents
the three type of flowers the setosa the
virginica and the versacolor and what
we're putting into our predict is the
test features
and i always kind of like to know what
it is i am looking at
so real quick we're going to do test
features and remember features is an
array
of simple length simple width pedal
length pedal width so when we put it in
this way it actually loads all these
different columns that we loaded into
features so if we did just features let
me just do features in here so you can
see what features looks like
this is just playing with the with
panda's data frames you'll see that it's
an index so when you put an index in
like this
into
test features into test
it then takes those columns and creates
a panda data frames from those columns
and in this case
we're going to go ahead and put those
into our predict
so we're going to put each one of these
lines of data
the 5.0 3.4
0.2 and we're going to put those in and
we're going to predict what our new
forest classifier is going to come up
with and this is what it predicts it
predicts 0 0 0 1 2 1 1 2 2 2
and and again this is the
flower type satosa virginica and
versacolor so now that we've taken our
test features
let's explore that let's see exactly
what that data means to us so the first
thing we can do with our predicts is we
can actually generate a different
prediction model when i say different
we're going to view it differently it's
not that the data itself is different so
let's take this next piece of code and
put it into our script
so we're pasting it in here and you'll
see that we're doing uh predict and
we've added underscore proba for
probability so there's our clf.predict
probability so we're running it just
like we ran it up here but this time
with this we're going to get a slightly
different result and we're only going to
look at the first 10.
so you'll see down here instead of
looking at all of them
which was what 27 you'll see right down
here that this generates a much larger
field on the probability and let's take
a look and see what that looks like
and what that means
so when we do the predict underscore
prabha
for probability it generates three
numbers so we had three leaf nodes at
the end and if you remember from all the
theory we did
this is the predictors the first one is
predicting a one
for setosa it predicts a zero for
virginica and it predicts a zero for
versa color and so on and so on and so
on and let's um you know what i'm going
to change this just a little bit let's
look at 10
to 20 just because we can
and we start to get a little different
of data and you'll see right down here
it gets to this one this line right here
and this line has 0 0.5 0.5
and so if we're going to vote and we
have two equal votes it's going to go
with the first one so it says setosa
gets zero votes virginica gets .5 votes
versacolor gets 0.5 votes but let's just
go with the virginica since these two
are equal and so on and so on down the
list you can see how they vary on here
so now we've looked at both how to do a
basic predict of the features and we've
looked at the predict probability
let's see what's next on here so now we
want to go ahead and start mapping names
for the plants we want to attach names
so that it makes a little more sense for
us and this we're going to do in these
next two steps we're going to start by
setting up our predictions and mapping
them to the name so let's see what that
looks like
and let's go ahead and paste that code
in here and run it and this goes along
with the next piece of code so we'll
skip through this quickly and then come
back to it a little bit so here's iris
dot target names
and
if you remember correctly this was the
the names that we've been talking about
this whole time the setosa virginica
versus color and then we're going to go
ahead and do the prediction again we've
run we could have just set a variable
equal to this instead of re-running it
each time but we're going to run it
again clf dot predict test features
remember that returns the zeros the ones
and the twos and then we're going to set
that equal to predictions so this time
we're actually putting it in a variable
and when i run this
it distributes it it comes out as an
array and the array is setosa satosa
satosa satosa setosa we're only looking
at the first five we could actually do
let's do the first 25 just so we can see
a little bit more on there and you'll
see that it starts mapping it to all the
different flower types the versa color
and the virginica in there and let's see
how this goes with the next one so let's
take a look at the top part of our
species in here and we'll take this code
and put it in our script
and let's put that down here and paste
it there we go and we'll go ahead and
run it
and let's talk about both these sections
of code here
and how they go together
the first one is our predictions and i
went ahead and did predictions through
twenty five let's just do five
and so we have setosa satoshi satosa
satoshi that's what we're predicting
from our test model
and then we come down here we look at
test species i remember i could have
just done test dot species dot head and
you'll see it says setosa satosa setosa
setosa and they match
so the first one is what our
forest is doing
and the second one is what the actual
data is now is we need to combine these
so that we can understand what that
means we need to know how good our
forest is how good it is at predicting
the features so that's where we come up
to the next step which is lots of fun
we're going to use a single line of code
to combine our predictions and our
actuals so we have a nice chart to look
at and let's go ahead and put that in
our script in our jupiter notebook here
let's see let's go ahead and paste that
in and then i'm gonna because i'm on the
jupiter notebook i can do a control
minus so you can see the whole line
there
there we go resize it
and let's take a look and see what's
going on here we're going to create in
pandas remember pd stands for pandas
and we're doing a cross tab this
function takes two sets of data
and creates a chart out of them so when
i run it you'll get a nice chart down
here
and we have the predicted species
so across the top you'll see the setosa
versus color virginica and the actual
species setosa versacolor virginica and
so the way to read this chart and let's
go ahead and take a look on how to read
this chart here when you read this chart
you have setosa where they meet you have
versus color where they meet and you
have virginica where they meet and
they're meeting where the actual and the
predicted agree
so this is the number of accurate
predictions so in this case it equals
30. if you had 13 plus 5 plus 12 you get
30. and then we notice here where it
says virginica but it was supposed to be
versacolor this is inaccurate so now we
have two two inaccurate predictions and
30 accurate predictions so we'll say
that the model accuracy is 93 that's
just 30 divided by 32 and if we multiply
by a hundred we can say that it is 93
percent accurate so we have a 93 percent
accuracy with our model i did want to
add one more quick thing in here on our
scripting before we wrap it up so let's
flip back on over to my script in here
we're going to take this line of code
from up above i don't know if you
remember it but predix equals the iris
dot target underscore names
so we're going to map it to the names
and we're going to run the prediction
and we read it on test features but you
know we're not just testing it we want
to actually deploy it so at this point i
would go ahead and change this
and this is an array of arrays this is
really important when you're running
these to know that
so you need the double brackets and i
could actually create data maybe let's
just do two flowers so maybe i'm
processing more data coming in and we'll
put two flowers in here
and then i actually want to see what the
answer are is so let's go ahead and type
in preds and print that out and when i
run this
you'll see that i've now predicted two
flowers that maybe i measured in my
front yard as versacolor and versacolor
not surprising since i put the same data
in for each one
this would be the actual
end product going out to be used on data
that you don't know the answer for
so that's going to conclude our
scripting part of this today we're going
to cover the k nearest neighbors like
referred to as k n n and k n is really a
fundamental place to start in the
machine learning it's the basis of a lot
of other things and just the logic
behind it is easy to understand and
incorporated in other forms of machine
learning so today what's in it for you
why do we need k n n
what is k n
how do we choose the factor k
when do we use k n n
how does k n algorithm work
and then we'll dive in to my favorite
part the use case predict whether a
person will have diabetes or not that is
a very common and popular used data set
as far as testing out models and
learning how to use the different models
in machine learning by now we all know
machine learning models make predictions
by learning from the past data available
so we have our input values our machine
learning model builds on those inputs of
what we already know and then we use
that to create a predicted output
is that a dog little kid looking over
there watching the black cat cross their
path no deer you can differentiate
between a cat and a dog based on their
characteristics
cats
cats have sharp claws uses to climb
smaller length of ears meows and purrs
doesn't love to play around dogs they
have dull claws bigger length of ears
barks loves to run around you usually
don't see a cat running around people
although i do have a cat that does that
where dogs do and we can look at these
we can say we can evaluate the sharpness
of the claws how sharp brother claws
and we can evaluate the length of the
ears and we can usually sort out cats
from dogs based on even those two
characteristics
now tell me if it is a cat or a dog not
question usually little kids know cats
and dogs by now unless they live a place
where there's not many cats or dogs so
if we look at the sharpness of the claws
the length of the ears and we can see
that the cat has smaller ears and
sharper claws than the other animals its
features are more like cats it must be a
cat sharp claws length of ears and it
goes in the cat group because knn is
based on feature similarity we can do
classification using knn classifier so
we have our input value the picture of
the black cat it goes into our trained
model and it predicts that this is a cat
coming out so what is knn what is the k
n algorithm
k nearest neighbors is what that stands
for is one of the simplest supervised
machine learning algorithms mostly used
for classification so we want to know is
this a dog or is not a dog is it a cat
or not a cat it classifies a data point
based on how its neighbors are
classified knn stores all available
cases and classifies new cases based on
a similarity measure and here we gone
from cats and dogs right into wine
another favorite of mine k n stores all
available cases and classifies new cases
based on a similarity measure and here
you see we have a measurement of sulfur
dioxide versus the chloride level and
then the different wines they've tested
and where they fall on that graph based
on how much sulfur dioxide and how much
chloride k and k n is a perimeter that
refers to the number of nearest
neighbors to include in the majority of
the voting process and so if we add a
new glass of wine there red or white we
want to know what the neighbors are in
this case we're going to put k equals 5.
we'll talk about k in just a minute a
data point is classified by the majority
of votes from its five nearest neighbors
here the unknown point would be
classified as red since four out of five
neighbors are red
so how do we choose k
how do we know k equals five i mean
that's what's the value we put in there
so we're going to talk about it how do
we choose a factor k k n algorithm is
based on feature similarity choosing the
right value of k
is a process called parameter tuning and
is important for better accuracy so at k
equals three we can classify we have a
question mark in the middle as either a
as a square or not is it a square or is
it in this case a triangle and so if we
set k equals to three we're going to
look at the three nearest neighbors
we're going to say this is a square and
if we put k equals a 7 we classify as a
triangle depending on what the other
data is around and you can see as the k
changes depending on where that point is
that drastically changes your answer and
we jump here we go how do we choose the
factor of k you'll find this in all
machine learning choosing these factors
that's the face you get he's like oh my
gosh did i choose the right k did i set
it right my values in whatever machine
learning tool you're looking at so that
you don't have a huge bias in one
direction or the other and in terms of k
n n the number of k if you choose it too
low the bias is based on it's just two
noises it's it's right next to a couple
things and it's going to pick those
things and you might get a skewed answer
and if your k is too big then it's going
to take forever to process so you're
going to run into processing issues and
resource issues so what we do the most
common use and there's other options for
choosing k is to use the square root of
n so it is a total number of values you
have you take the square root of it in
most cases you also if it's an even
number so if you're using uh like in
this case squares and triangles if it's
even you want to make your k value odd
that helps it select better so in other
words you're not going to have a balance
between two different factors that are
equal so usually take the square root of
n and if it's even you add one to it or
subtract one from it and that's where
you get the k value from that is the
most common use and it's pretty solid it
works very well when do we use knn we
can use knn when data is labeled so you
need a label on it we know we have a
group of pictures with dogs dogs cats
cats data is noise free and so you can
see here when we have a class and we
have like underweight 140 23 hello kitty
normal that's pretty confusing we have a
high variety of data coming in so it's
very noisy and that would cause an issue
data set is small so we're usually
working with smaller data sets where you
might get into a gig of data if it's
really clean doesn't have a lot of noise
because k n is a lazy learner i.e it
doesn't learn a discriminative function
from the training set so it's very lazy
so if you have very complicated data and
you have a large amount of it you're not
going to use the knn but it's really
great to get a place to start even with
large data you can sort out a small
sample and get an idea of what that
looks like using the knn and also just
using for smaller data sets k n works
really good how does a k n algorithm
work consider a data set having two
variables height in centimeters and
weight in kilograms and each point is
classified as normal or underweight so
we see right here we have two variables
you know true false they're either
normal or they're not they're
underweight on the basis of the given
data we have to classify the below set
as normal or underweight using knn so if
we have new data coming in this says 57
kilograms and 177 centimeters is that
going to be normal or underweight to
find the nearest neighbors we'll
calculate the euclidean distance
according to the euclidean distance
formula the distance between two points
in the plane with the coordinates x y
and a b is given by distance d equals
the square root of x minus a squared
plus y minus b squared and you can
remember that from the two edges of a
triangle we're computing the third edge
since we know
the x side and the y side let's
calculate it to understand clearly so we
have our unknown point and we placed it
there in red and we have our other
points where the data is scattered
around the distance d1 is the square
root of 170 minus 167 squared plus 57
minus 51 squared which is about 6.7 and
distance 2 is about 13. and distance 3
is about 13.4 similarly we will
calculate the euclidean distance of
unknown data point from all the points
in the data set and because we're
dealing with small amount of data that's
not that hard to do it's actually pretty
quick for a computer and it's not really
complicated mass you can just see how
close is the data based on the euclidean
distance hence we have calculated the
euclidean distance of unknown data point
from all the points as shown where x1
and y1 equal 57 and 170 whose class we
have to classify so now we're looking at
that we're saying well here's the
euclidean distance who's going to be
their closest neighbors now let's
calculate the nearest neighbor at k
equals three and we can see the three
closest neighbors puts them at normal
and that's pretty self-evident when you
look at this graph it's pretty easy to
say okay what you know we're just voting
normal normal normal three votes for
normal this is going to be a normal
weight so majority of neighbors are
pointing towards normal hence as per k n
algorithm the class of 57 170 should be
normal so a recap of knn positive
integer k is specified along with a new
sample we select the k entries in our
database which are closest to the new
sample we find the most common
classification of these entries this is
the classification we give to the new
sample so as you can see it's pretty
straightforward we're just looking for
the closest things that match what we
got so let's take a look and see what
that looks like in a use case in python
so let's dive into the predict diabetes
use case so use case predict diabetes
the objective predict whether a person
will be diagnosed with diabetes or not
we have a data set of 768 people who
were or were not diagnosed with diabetes
and let's go ahead and open that file
and just take a look at that data and
this is in a simple spreadsheet format
the data itself is comma separated very
common set of data and it's also a very
common way to get the data and you can
see here we have columns a through i
that's what one two three four five six
seven eight
eight columns with a particular
attribute and then the ninth column
which is the outcome is whether they
have diabetes as a data scientist the
first thing you should be looking at is
insulin well you know if someone has
insulin they have diabetes because
that's why they're taking it and that
could cause issue in some of the machine
learning packages but for a very basic
setup this works fine for doing the k n
and the next thing you notice is it
didn't take very much to open it up i
can scroll down to the bottom of the
data there's 768.
it's pretty much a small data set you
know at 769 i can easily fit this into
my ram on my computer i can look at it i
can manipulate it and it's not going to
really tax just a regular desktop
computer you don't even need an
enterprise version to run a lot of this
so let's start with importing all the
tools we need and before that of course
we need to discuss what ide i'm using
certainly can use any particular editor
for python but i like to use for doing
very basic visual stuff the anaconda
which is great for doing demos with the
jupiter notebook and just a quick view
of the anaconda navigator which is the
new release out there which is really
nice you can see under home i can choose
my application we're going to be using
python36 i have a couple different
versions on this particular machine if i
go under environments i can create a
unique environment for each one which is
nice and there's even a little button
there where i can install different
packages so if i click on that button
and open the terminal i can use a simple
pip install to install different
packages i'm working with let's go ahead
and go back under home and we're going
to launch our notebook and i've already
you know kind of like
the old cooking shows i've already
prepared a lot of my stuff so we don't
have to wait for it to launch because it
takes a few minutes for it to open up a
browser window in this case i'm going to
it's going to open up chrome because
that's my default that i use and since
the script is pre-done you'll see have a
number of windows open up at the top the
one we're working in and since we're
working on the k n predict whether a
person will have diabetes or not let's
go and put that title in there
and i'm also going to go up here and
click on cell actually we want to go
ahead and first insert a cell below and
then i'm going to go back up to the top
cell and i'm going to change the cell
type to markdown that means this is not
going to run as python it's a markdown
language so if i run this first one it
comes up in nice big letters which is
kind of nice remind us what we're
working on and by now you should be
familiar with doing all of our imports
we're going to import the pandas as pd
import numpy as np pandas is the pandas
data frame and numpy is a number array
very powerful tools to use in here so we
have our imports so we've brought in our
pandas our numpy our two general python
tools and then you can see over here we
have our train test split by now you
should be familiar with splitting the
data we want to split part of it for
training our thing and then training our
particular model and then we want to go
ahead and test the remaining data to see
how good it is pre-processing a standard
scalar preprocessor so we don't have a
bias of really large numbers remember in
the data we had like number of
pregnancies isn't going to get very
large where the amount of insulin they
take can get up to 256 so 256 versus 6
that will skew results so we want to go
ahead and change that so they're all
uniform between minus 1 and 1. and then
the actual tool this is the k neighbors
classifier we're going to use
and finally the last three are three
tools to test all about testing our
model how good is it we just put down
test on there and we have our confusion
matrix our f1 score and our accuracy so
we have our two general python modules
we're importing and then we have our six
modules specific from the sklearn setup
and then we do need to go ahead and run
this so these are actually imported
there we go and then move on to the next
step and so in this set we're going to
go ahead and load the database we're
going to use pandas remember pandas is
pd and we'll take a look at the data in
python we looked at it in a simple
spreadsheet but usually i like to also
pull it up so we can see what we're
doing so here's our data set equals
pd.read csv that's a pandas command and
the diabetes folder i just put in the
same folder where my ipython script is
if you put in a different folder you
need the full length on there we can
also do a quick length of the data set
that is a simple python command len for
length we might even let's go ahead and
print that we'll go print and if you do
it on its own line link that data set
the jupyter notebook it'll automatically
print it but when you're in most of your
different setups you want to do the
print in front of there and then we want
to take a look at the actual data set
and since we're in pandas we can simply
do data set head and again let's go
ahead and add the print in there
if you put a bunch of these in a row you
know the data set 1 head data set two
head it only prints out the last one so
i usually always like to keep the print
statement in there but because most
projects only use one data frame panda's
data frame doing it this way doesn't
really matter the other way works just
fine and you can see when we hit the run
button we have the 768 lines which we
knew and we have our pregnancies it's
automatically given a label on the left
remember the head only shows the first
five lines so we have zero through four
and just a quick look at the data you
can see it matches what we looked at
before we have pregnancy glucose blood
pressure all the way to age and then the
outcome on the end and we're going to do
a couple things in this next step we're
going to create a list of columns where
we can't have zero there's no such thing
as zero skin thickness or zero blood
pressure zero glucose uh any of those
you'd be dead so not a really good
factor if they don't if they have a zero
in there because they didn't have the
data and we'll take a look at that
because we're going to start replacing
that information with a couple of
different things and let's see what that
looks like so first we create a nice
list as you can see we have the values
talked about glucose blood pressure skin
thickness
and this is a nice way when you're
working with columns is to list the
columns you need to do some kind of
transformation on a very common thing to
do and then for this particular setup we
certainly could use the there's some
panda tools that will do a lot of this
where we can replace the n a but we're
going to go ahead and do it as a data
set column equals dataset column.replace
this is this is still pandas you can do
a direct there's also one that's that
you look for your nan a lot of different
options in here but the nan
numpy n a n is what that stands for is
none it doesn't exist so the first thing
we're doing here is we're replacing the
zero with a numpy none there's no data
there that's what that says that's what
this is saying right here so put the
zero in and we're going to place zeros
with no data so if it's a zero that
means the person's well hopefully not
dead hope they just didn't get the data
the next thing we want to do is we're
going to create the mean which is the
integer from the data set from the
column dot mean where we skip n a's we
can do that that is a pandas command
there the skip n a so we're going to
figure out the mean of that data set and
then we're going to take that data set
column and we're going to replace all
the p n a n with the means why did we do
that we could have actually just uh
taken this step and gone right down here
and just replaced zero and skip anything
were except you could actually there's a
way to skip zeros and then just replace
all the zeros but in this case we want
to go ahead and do it this way so you
can see that we're switching this to a
non-existent value then we're going to
create the mean well this is the average
person so if we don't know what it is if
they did not get the data and the data
is missing one of the tricks is you
replace it with the average what is the
most common data for that this way you
can still use the rest of those values
to do your computation and it kind of
just brings that particular value of
those missing values out of the equation
let's go ahead and take this and we'll
go ahead and run it doesn't actually do
anything so we're still preparing our
data if you want to see what that looks
like we don't have anything in the first
few lines just not going to show up but
we certainly could look at a row let's
do that let's go into our data set with
printed data set
and let's pick in this case let's just
do
glucose and if i run this this is going
to print all the different glucose
levels going down and we thankfully
don't see anything in here that looks
like missing data at least on the ones
it shows you can see you skipped a bunch
in the middle that's what it does if you
have too many lines in jupiter notebook
it'll skip a few and go on to the next
in a data set let me go and remove this
and we'll just zero out that and of
course before we do any processing
before proceeding any further we need to
split the data set into our train and
testing data that way we have something
to train it with and something to test
it on and you're going to notice we did
a little something here with the pandas
database code there we go my drawing
tool we've added in this right here
off the data set and what this says is
that the first one in pandas this is
from the pd pandas it's going to say
within the data set we want to look at
the eye location and it is all rows
that's what that says so we're going to
keep all the rows but we're only looking
at 0 column 0 to 8. remember column 9
here it is right up here we printed it
in here is outcome well that's not part
of the training data that's part of the
answer yes column nine but it's listed
as eight number eight so zero to eight
is nine columns so uh eight is the value
and when you see it in here zero this is
actually zero to seven it doesn't
include the last one and then we go down
here to y which is our answer and we
want just the last one just column eight
and you can do it this way with this
particular notation and then if you
remember we imported the train test
split
that's part of the sklearn right there
and we simply put in our x and our y
we're going to do random state equals
zero you don't have to necessarily seat
it that's a seed number i think the
default is one when you seed it i'd have
to look that up and then the test size
test size is 0.2 that simply means we're
going to take 20 of the data and put it
aside so that we can test it later
that's all that is and again we're going
to run it not very exciting so far we
haven't had any print out other than to
look at the data but that is a lot of
this is prepping this data once you prep
it the actual lines of code are quick
and easy and we're almost there with the
actual writing of our knn we need to go
ahead and do a scale the data if you
remember correctly we're fitting the
data in a standard scalar which means
instead of the data being from you know
five to 303 in one column and the next
column is one to six we're going to set
that all so that all the data is between
minus one and one that's what that
standard scalar does keeps it
standardized and we only want to fit the
scalar with the training set but we want
to make sure the testing set is the x
test going in is also transformed so
it's processing it the same so here we
go with our standard scalar we're going
to call it sc underscore x for the
scalar and we're going to import the
standard scalar into this variable and
then our x train equals sc underscore x
dot fit transform so we're creating the
scalar on the x train variable and then
our x test we're also going to transform
it so
we've trained and transformed the x
train and then the x test
isn't part of that training it isn't
part of that of training the transformer
it just gets transformed that's all it
does and again we're going to go and run
this if you look at this we've now gone
through these steps all three of them
we've taken care of replacing our zeros
for key
columns that shouldn't be zero and we
replace that with the means
of those columns that way that they fit
right in with our data models we've come
down here we split the data so now we
have our test data and our and then
we've taken and we've scaled the data so
all of our data going in no no we don't
we don't train the y part the y train
and y test that never has to be trained
it's only the data going in that's what
we want to train in there then define
the model using k neighbors classifier
and fit the train data in the model so
we do all that data prep and you can see
down here we're only going to have a
couple lines of code where we're
actually building our model and training
it that's one of the cool things about
python and how far we've come it's such
an exciting time to be in machine
learning because there's so many
automated tools let's see before we do
this let's do a quick length of and
let's do y we want let's just do length
of y
and we get 768 and if we import
math we do math dot
square root let's do y
train there we go it's actually supposed
to be x train
before we do this let's go ahead and do
import math and do math square root
length of y test and when i run that we
get
12.409 i want to show you where this
number comes from we're about to use 12
is an even number so if you know if
you're ever voting on things remember
the neighbors all vote don't want to
have an even number of neighbors voting
so we want to do something odd and let's
just take one away we'll make it 11. let
me delete this out of here this one the
reasons i love jupiter notebook is you
can flip around and do all kinds of
things on the fly so we'll go ahead and
put in our classifier we're creating our
classifier now and it's going to be the
k neighbors classifier n neighbors equal
11. remember we did 12 minus 1 for 11 so
we have an odd number of neighbors p
equals 2 because we're looking for is it
are they diabetic or not and we're using
the euclidean metric there are other
means of measuring the distance you
could do like square square means values
all kinds of measure this but the
euclidean is the most common one and it
works quite well it's important to
evaluate the model let's use the
confusion matrix to do that and we're
going to use the confusion matrix
wonderful tool and then we'll jump into
the f1 score
and finally accuracy score which is
probably the most commonly used quoted
number when you go into a meeting or
something like that so let's go ahead
and paste that in there and we'll set
the cm equal to confusion matrix why
test y predict so those are the two
values we're going to put in there and
let me go ahead and run that and print
it out and the way you interpret this is
you have the y predicted which would be
your title up here you could do let's
just do p r e d
predicted across the top
and actual going down actual
it's always hard to write in here actual
that means that this column here down
the middle that's the important column
and it means that our prediction said 94
and prediction in the actual agreed on
94 and 32 this number here
the 13 and the 15 those are what was
wrong so you could have like three
different if you're looking at this
across three different variables instead
of just two you'd end up with a third
row down here in the column going down
the middle so in the first case we have
the the and i believe the zero has a 94
people who don't have diabetes the
prediction said that 13 of those people
did have diabetes and were at high risk
and the 32 that had diabetes it had
correct
but our prediction said another 15 out
of that 15 it classified as incorrect so
you can see where that classification
comes in and how that works on the
confusion matrix then we're going to go
ahead and print the f1 score let me just
run that and you see we get a 0.69 in
our f1 score
the f1
takes into account both sides of the
balance of false positives where if we
go ahead and just do the accuracy
account and that's what most people
think of is it looks at just how many we
got right out of how many we got wrong
so a lot of people when you're a data
scientist and you're talking to other
data scientists they're going to ask you
what the f1 score the f score is if
you're talking to the general public or
the decision makers in the business
they're going to ask what the accuracy
is and the accuracy is always better
than the f1 score but the f1 score is
more telling it lets us know that
there's more false positives than we
would like on here but 82 percent not
too bad for a quick flash look at
people's different statistics and
running an sk learn and running the k n
n the k nearest neighbor on it so we
have created a model using knn which can
predict whether a person will have
diabetes or not or at the very least
whether they should go get a checkup and
have their glucose checked regularly or
not the print accuracy score we got the
0.818 was pretty close to what we got
and we can pretty much round that off
and just say we have an accuracy of 80
percent tells us it is a pretty fair fit
in the model what is k-means clustering
k-means clustering is
an unsupervised learning algorithm in
this case you don't have labeled data
unlike in supervised learning so you
have a set of data and you want to group
them and as the name suggests you want
to put them into clusters which means
objects that are similar in nature
similar in characteristics need to be
put together so that's what k means
clustering is all about the term k is
basically is a number so we need to tell
the system how many clusters we need to
perform so if k is equal to two there
will be two clusters if k is equal to
three three clusters and so on and so
forth that's what the k stands for and
of course there is a way of finding out
what is the best or optimum value of k
for a given data we will look at that so
that is k means clustering so
let's take an example k-means clustering
is used in many many scenarios but let's
take an example of cricket the game of
cricket let's say you received
data of a lot of players from maybe all
over the country or all over the world
and this data has information about
the runs scored by the people ordered by
the player and the wickets taken by the
player and based on this information we
need to cluster this data into two
clusters batsman and bowlers so this is
an interesting example let's see how we
can perform this so we have the data
which consists of primarily two
characteristics which is the runs
and the weekends so the bowlers
basically take wickets and the batsmen
score runs
there will be of course a few bowlers
who can
score some runs and similarly there will
be some batsmen who will who would have
taken a few wickets but with this
information we want to cluster those
players into batsmen and bowlers so how
does this work let's say this is how the
data is so there are information there
is information on the y-axis about the
run scored and on the x-axis about the
wickets taken by the players so if we do
a quick plot this is how it would look
and
when we do the clustering we need to
have the clusters like shown in the
third diagram rtms we need to have a
cluster which consists of people who
have scored high runs which is basically
the batsman and then we need a cluster
with people who have taken a lot of
wickets which is typically the bowlers
there may be a certain amount of overlap
but we will not talk about it right now
so with k-means clustering we will have
here that means k is equal to two and we
will have two clusters which is batsman
and bowlers so how does this work the
way it works is the first step in
k-means clustering is the allocation of
two centroids randomly so two points are
assigned as so-called centroids so in
this case we want two clusters which
means k is equal to two so two points
have been randomly assigned as centroids
keep in mind
these points can be anywhere there are
random points they are not initially
they are not really the centroids
centroid means it's a central point of a
given data set but in this case when it
starts off it's not really the centroid
okay so these points though in our
presentation here we have shown them one
point closer to these data points and
another closer to these data points they
can be assigned randomly anywhere okay
so that's the first step the next step
is to determine the distance of each of
the data points
from each of the
randomly assigned centroids so for
example we take this point and find the
distance from the centroid and the
distance from this centroid this point
is taken and the distance is found from
this centroid and the center and so on
and so forth so for every point the
distance is measured from both the
centroids
and then
whichever distance is less that point is
assigned to that centroid so for example
in this case visually it is very obvious
that all these data points are assigned
to this centroid and all these data
points are assigned to this centroid and
that's what is represented here in blue
color and in this yellow color the next
step is to actually determine
the central point or the actual centroid
for these two clusters so we have this
one
initial cluster this one initial cluster
but as you can see these points are not
really the centroid centroid means it
should be the central position of this
data set central position of this data
set so that is what needs to be
determined as the next step so the
central point of the actual centroid is
determined and the original randomly
allocated centroid is repositioned to
the actual centroid of this new clusters
and this process is actually repeated
now what might happen is some of these
points may get reallocated in our
example that is not happening probably
but it may so happen that the distance
is found between each of these data
points once again with these centroids
and if there is if it is required some
points may be reallocated we will see
that in a later example but for now we
will keep it simple so this process is
continued till the centroid
repositioning stops and that is our
final cluster so this is our so after
iteration we come to this position this
situation where the centroid doesn't
need any more repositioning and that
means our algorithm has converged
convergence has occurred and we have the
cluster two clusters we have the
clusters with a centroid so this process
is repeated the process of calculating
the distance and repositioning the
centroid is repeated till the
repositioning stops which means that the
algorithm has converged and we have the
final cluster with the data points and
the centroids so this is what you're
going to learn from this session we will
talk about the types of clustering what
is k-means clustering application of
k-mains clustering k-means clustering is
done using distance measure so we will
talk about the common distance measures
and then we will talk about how k-means
clustering works and go into the details
of k-means clustering algorithm and then
we will end with a demo and a use case
for k-means clustering so let's begin
first of all what are the types of
clustering there are primarily two
categories of clustering hierarchical
clustering and then partitional
clustering and each of these categories
are further subdivided into
agglomerative and divisive clustering
and k-means and fuzzy c means clustering
let's take a quick look at what each of
these types of clustering are
in hierarchical clustering the clusters
have a tree-like structure and
hierarchical clustering is further
divided into agglomerative and divisive
agglomerative clustering is a bottom-up
approach we begin with each element as a
separate cluster and merge them into
successively larger clusters so for
example we have a b c d e f we start by
combining b and c from one cluster d e
and e form one more then we combine d e
and f one more bigger cluster and then
add b c to that and then finally a to it
compared to that divisive clustering or
divisive clustering is a top down
approach we begin with the whole set and
proceed to divide it into
successively smaller clusters so we have
abcdef we first take that as a single
cluster and then break it down
into a b c d
e and f
then we have partitional clustering
split into two subtypes k means
clustering and fuzzy c means in k-means
clustering the objects are divided into
the number of clusters mentioned by the
number k that's where the k comes from
so if we say k is equal to 2 the objects
are divided into two clusters c1 and c2
and the way it is done is the features
or characteristics are compared and all
objects having similar characteristics
are clubbed together so that's how k
means clustering is done we will see it
in more detail as we move forward and
fuzzy c means is very similar to k means
in the sense that it clubs objects that
have similar characteristics together
but while in k-means clustering two
objects cannot belong to or any object a
single object cannot belong to two
different clusters in c means objects
can belong to more than one cluster so
that is the primary difference between
k-means and fuzzy c means
so what are some of the applications of
k-means clustering k-means clustering is
used in a variety of examples or variety
of business cases in real life starting
from academic performance diagnostic
systems search engines and wireless
sensor networks and many more so let us
take a little deeper look at each of
these examples academic performance so
based on the scores of the students
students are categorized into a b c and
so on clustering forms a backbone of
search engines when a search is
performed the search results need to be
grouped together the search engines very
often use clustering to do this
and similarly in case of wireless sensor
networks the clustering algorithm plays
the role of finding the cluster heads
which collects all the data in its
respective cluster so clustering
especially k means clustering uses
distance measure so let's take a look at
what is distance measure so while these
are the different types of clustering in
this video we will focus on k-means
clustering so distance measure tells
how similar some objects are so the
similarity is measured using what is
known as distance measure and what are
the various types of distance measures
there is euclidean distance there is
manhattan distance then we have squared
euclidean distance measure and cosine
distance measure these are some of the
distance measures supported by k-means
clustering let's take a look at each of
these
what is euclidean distance measure this
is nothing but the distance between two
points so we have learnt in high school
how to find the distance between two
points this is a little sophisticated
formula for that but we know a simpler
one is square root of y2 minus y1 whole
square plus x2 minus x1 whole square so
this is an extension of that formula so
that is the euclidean distance between
two points what is the squared euclidean
distance measure it's nothing but the
square of the euclidean distance the
name suggests so instead of taking the
square root we leave the square as it is
and then we have manhattan distance
measure in case of manhattan distance it
is the sum of the distances across the
x-axis and the y-axis
and note that we are taking the absolute
value so that the negative values don't
come into play so that is the manhattan
distance measure then we have cosine
distance measure in this case we take
the angle between the two vectors formed
by joining the points from the origin so
that is the cosine distance measure okay
so that was a quick overview about the
various distance measures that are
supported by k-means now let's go and
check how exactly k-means clustering
works
okay so this is how k-means clustering
works this is like a flowchart of the
whole process there is a starting point
and then we specify the number of
clusters that we want now there are a
couple of ways of doing this
we can do by trial and error so we
specify a certain number maybe k is
equal to 3 or 4 or 5 to start with and
then as we progress we keep changing
until we get the best clusters or there
is a technique called elbow technique
whereby we can determine the value of k
what should be the best value of k how
many clusters should be formed so once
we have the value of k we specify that
and then the system will assign that
many centroids so it picks randomly that
to start with randomly that many points
that are considered to be the centroids
of these clusters and then it measures
the distance of each of the data points
from these centroids and assigns those
points to the corresponding centroid
from which the distance is minimum so
each data point will be assigned to the
centroid which is closest to it and
thereby we have k number of initial
clusters however this is not the final
clusters the next step it does is
for the new groups for the clusters that
have been formed it calculates the main
position thereby calculates the new
centroid position the position of the
centroid moves compared to the randomly
allocated one so it's an iterative
process once again the distance of each
point is measured from this new centroid
point and if required the data points
are reallocated to the new centroids and
the mean position or the new centroid is
calculated once again if the centroid
moves then the iteration continues which
means the convergence has not happened
the clustering has not converged so as
long as there is a movement of the
centroid this iteration keeps happening
but once the centroid stops moving which
means that the cluster has converged or
the clustering process has converged
that will be the end result so now we
have the final position of the centroid
and the data points are allocated
accordingly to the closest centroid i
know it's a little difficult to
understand from this simple flowchart so
let's do a little bit of visualization
and see if we can explain it better
let's take an example if we have a data
set for a grocery shop so let's say we
have a data set for a grocery shop and
now we want to find out how many
clusters this has to be spread across
so how do we find the optimum number of
clusters there is a technique called the
elbow method so when these clusters are
formed there is a parameter called
within sum of squares
and the lower this value is the better
the cluster is that means
all these points are very close to each
other so we use this within sum of
squares as a measure to find the optimum
number of clusters that can be formed
for a given data set so we create
clusters or we let the system create
clusters of a variety of numbers maybe
of 10
10 clusters and for each value of k the
within ss is measured and the value of k
which has the least amount of within ss
or wss that is taken as the optimum
value of k so this is the diagrammatic
representation so we have on the y axis
the within sum of squares or wss and on
the x-axis we have the number of
clusters so as you can imagine if you
have k is equal to 1 which means all the
data points are in a single cluster the
within s value will be very high because
they are probably scattered all over the
moment you split it into two there will
be a drastic fall in the within ss value
that's what is represented here but then
as the value of k increases the decrease
the rate of decrease
will not be so high it will continue to
decrease but probably the rate of
decrease will not be high so that gives
us an idea so from here we get an idea
for example the optimum value of k
should be
either 2 or 3 or at the most 4 but
beyond that
increasing the number of clusters is not
dramatically changing the value in wss
because that pretty much gets stabilized
okay now that we have got the value of k
and let's assume that these are our
delivery points the next step is
basically
to assign two centroids randomly so
let's say c1 and c2 are the centroids
assigned randomly now the distance of
each
location from the centroid is measured
and each point is assigned to the
centroid which is closest to it so for
example
these points are very obvious that these
are closest to c1 whereas this point is
far away from c2 so these points will be
assigned which are close to c1 will be
assigned to c1 and these points or
locations which are close to c2 will be
assigned to c2 and then so this is the
how the initial grouping is done this is
part of c1 and this is part of c2 then
the next step is to calculate the actual
centroid of this data because remember
c1 and c2 are not the centroids they
have been
randomly assigned points and only thing
that has been done was the data points
which are closest to them have been
assigned
but now in this step the actual centroid
will be calculated which may be for each
of these data sets somewhere in the
middle so that's like the main point
that will be calculated and the centroid
will actually be positioned
or repositioned there
same with c2
so the new centroid for this group is c2
in this new position and c1 is in this
new position once again the distance of
each of the data points is calculated
from these centroids now remember it's
not necessary that the distance still
remains the or each of these data points
still remain in the same group by
recalculating the distance it may be
possible that some points get
reallocated like so you see this
so this point earlier was closer to c2
because c2 was here
but after recalculating repositioning it
is observed that this is closer to c1
than c2 so this is the new grouping so
some points will be reassigned and again
the centroid will be calculated and if
the centroid doesn't change so that is
the repetitive process iterative process
and if the centroid doesn't change once
the centroid stops changing that means
the algorithm has converged and this is
our final cluster with this as the
centroid c1 and c2 as the centroids
these data points as a part of each
cluster so i hope this helps in
understanding the whole process
iterative process of k-means clustering
so let's take a look at
the k-means clustering algorithm let's
say we have x1 x2 x3 n number of points
as our inputs and we want to split this
into k clusters or we want to create k
clusters so the first step is to
randomly pick k points and call them
centroids they are not real centroids
because centroid is supposed to be a
center point but they are just called
centroids and we calculate the distance
of each and every input point from each
of the centroids so the distance of x1
from c1 from c2 c3 each of the distances
we calculate and then find out which
distance is the lowest and assign x1 to
that particular random centroid repeat
that process for x2 calculate its
distance from each of the centroids c1
c2 c3 up to ck and find which is the
lowest distance and assign x2 to that
particular centroid same with x3 and so
on so that is the first round of
assignment that is done now we have k
groups because there are we have
assigned the value of k so there are k
centroids
and so there are k groups all these
inputs have been split into k groups
however remember we picked the centroids
randomly so they are not real centroids
so now what we have to do we have to
calculate the actual centroids for each
of these groups which is like the mean
position which means that the position
of the randomly selected
centroids will now change
and they will be
the main positions of this newly formed
k groups and once that is done we once
again repeat this process of calculating
the distance right so this is what we
are doing as a part of step four we
repeat step two and three so we again
calculate the distance of x1
from the centroid c1
c2 c3 and then c which is the lowest
value and assign x1 to that
calculate the distance of x2 from c1 c2
c3 or whatever
up to ck and find whichever is the
lowest distance and assign x2 to that
centroid and so on in this process there
may be some reassignment x1 pro was
probably assigned to cluster c2 and
after doing this calculation maybe now
x1 is assigned to c1 so that kind of
reallocation may happen so we repeat the
steps 2 and 3 till the position of the
centroids don't change or stop changing
and that's when we have convergence
so let's take a detailed look at it at
each of these steps so we randomly pick
k cluster centers we call them centroids
because they are not initially they are
not really the centroids so we let us
name them c1 c2 up to ck and then step
two we assign each data point to the
closest center so what we do we
calculate the distance of each x value
from each c value so the distance
between
x1 c1 distance between x1 c2 x1 c3 and
then we find which is the lowest value
right that's the minimum value we find
and assign x1 to that particular
centroid then we go next to x2 find the
distance of x2 from c1 x2 from c2 x2
from c3 and so on up to ck and then
assign it to the point or to the
centroid which has the lowest value and
so on so that is step number two in step
number three we now find the actual
centroid for each group so what has
happened as a part of step number two
we now have all the points all the data
points
grouped into k groups because we we
wanted to create k clusters right so we
have k groups each one may be having a
certain number of input values and they
need not be equally distributed by the
way based on the distance we will have k
groups but remember the initial values
of the c1 c2 were not really the
centroids of these groups right we
assigned them randomly so now in step 3
we actually calculate the centroid of
each group which means the original
point which we thought was the centroid
will shift to the new position which is
the actual centroid for each of these
groups okay and we again calculate the
distance so we go back to step two which
is what we calculate again the distance
of each of these points from the newly
positioned centroids and if required we
reassign these points to the new
centroids so as i said earlier there may
be a reallocation so we now have a new
set or a new group we still have k
groups
but the number of items and the actual
assignment may be different from what
was in step
two here okay so that might change then
we perform step three once again to find
the new centroid of this new group so we
have again a new set of clusters new
centroids and new assignments
we repeat this step two again once again
we find and then it is possible that
after iterating through three or four or
five times the centroid will stop moving
in the sense that when you calculate the
new value of the centroid that will be
same as the original value or there will
be very marginal change so that is when
we say convergence has occurred and that
is our final cluster that's the
formation of the final cluster
all right so let's see a couple of demos
of k-means clustering we will actually
see some live demos in
python notebook using pattern notebook
but before that let's find out what's
the problem that we are trying to solve
the problem statement is let's say
walmart wants to open a chain of stores
across the state of florida and
it wants to find the optimal store
locations now the issue here is if they
open too many stores close to each other
obviously they will not make profit
but
if they if the stores are too far apart
then they will not have enough sales
so how do they optimize this now
for an organization like walmart which
is an e-commerce giant they already have
the addresses of their customers in
their database so they can actually use
this information or this data and use
k-means clustering to find the optimal
location now before we go into the
python notebook and show you the live
code
i wanted to take you through very
quickly a summary of the code in the
slides and then we will go into the
python notebook so in this
block we are basically
importing all the required libraries
like numpy
matplotlib and so on
and we are loading the data that is
available in the form of let's say the
addresses
for simplicity sake we will just take
them as some data points then the next
thing we do is quickly do a scatter plot
to see
how they are
related to each other with respect to
each other so in the scatter plot we see
that there are a few distinct groups
already being formed so you can actually
get an idea about how the cluster would
look and how many clusters what is the
optimal number of clusters and then
starts the actual
k-means clustering process
so we will assign
each of these points to the centroids
and then check whether they are the
optimal distance which is the shortest
distance and assign each of the points
data points to the centroids and then go
through this iterative process till the
whole process converges and finally we
get an output like this so we have four
distinct clusters
and
which is if we can say that this is how
the population is probably distributed
across florida state and
the centroids are
like the location where the store should
be the optimum location where the store
should be so that's the way we determine
the best locations for the store and
that's how we can help walmart find the
best locations for their stores in
florida so now let's
take this into python notebook let's see
how this looks when we are running
running the code live all right so this
is the code for k-means clustering in
jupiter notebook we have a few examples
here which we will demonstrate how
k-means clustering is used and even
there is a small implementation of
k-means clustering as well okay so let's
get started okay so this block is
basically importing the various
libraries that are required like
matplotlib and numpy and so on and so
forth which would be used as a part of
the code then we are going and creating
blobs which are similar to clusters now
this is a very neat feature which is
available in scikit-learn make blobs is
a nice feature which creates clusters of
data sets so that's a wonderful
functionality that is readily available
for us to create some test data kind of
thing okay so that's exactly what we are
doing here we are using make blobs and
we can specify
how many clusters we want so centers we
are mentioning here so it will go ahead
and so we just mentioned four so it will
go ahead and create some test data for
us
and this is how it looks as you can see
visually also we can figure out that
there are four distinct classes or
clusters in this data set and that is
what make blobs actually
provides
now from here onwards we will basically
run the standard k-means functionality
that is readily available so we really
don't have to implement k-means itself
the k-means functionality or the
function is readily available you just
need to feed the data and we'll create
the clusters so this is the code for
that
we import k-means and then we create an
instance of k-means and we specify the
value of k this n underscore clusters is
the value of k remember k means in k
means k is basically the number of
clusters that you want to create and it
is a
integer value so this is where we are
specifying that so we have k is equal to
and so that instance is created we take
that instance and as
with any other machine learning
functionality fit is what we use the
function or the method rather fit is
what we use to
train the model here there is no real
training kind of thing but that's the
call okay so we are calling fit and what
we are doing here we are just passing
the data so x has these values the data
that has been created right so that is
what we are passing here
and
this will go ahead and create the
clusters and
then we are using
after doing uh fit we run the predict
which uh basically assigns for each of
these observations which cluster where
it belongs to all right so it will name
the clusters maybe this is cluster one
this is 2 3 and so on or i will actually
start from 0 cluster 0 1 2 and 3 maybe
and then for each of the observations it
will assign based on which cluster it
belongs to it will assign a value so
that is stored in
y underscore k means when we call
predict that is what it does
and we can take a quick look at these uh
y underscore k means or with the cluster
numbers that have been assigned for each
observation so this is the cluster
number assigned for observation 1 maybe
this is for observation 2 observation 3
and so on so we have how many about i
think 300 samples right so all the 300
samples there are 300 values here each
of them the cluster number is given and
the cluster number goes from 0 to 3. so
there are four clusters so the numbers
go from 0 1 2 3. so that's what is seen
here okay now so this was a quick
example of generating some dummy data
and then clustering that okay and this
can be applied if you have proper data
you can just load it up into x for
example here and then run the game so
this is the central part of the k-means
clustering program example so you
basically create an instance and you
mention how many customers you want by
specifying this parameter and underscore
clusters and that is also the value of k
and then pass the data to get the values
now the next section of this code is the
implementation of a k-means now this is
kind of a rough implementation of the
k-means algorithm so we will just walk
you through i will walk you through the
code uh at each step what it is doing
and then we will see a couple of more
examples of how k-means clustering can
be used in maybe some real-life examples
real-life use cases all right so in this
case here what we are doing is basically
implementing the k means clustering and
there is a function or a library
calculates for a given two pairs of
points it will
calculate the the distance between them
and see which one is the closest and so
on so this is like this is pretty much
like what k means does right so it
calculates the distance of each point or
each data set from predefined centroid
and then based on whichever is the
lowest this particular data point is
assigned to that centroid so that is
basically available as a standard
function and we will be using that here
so as explained in the slides the first
step that is done in case of k-means
clustering is to randomly assign some
centroids so as a first step we randomly
allocate a couple of centroids which we
call here we are calling as centers
and then we put this in a loop and we
take it through an iterative process
for each of the data points we first
find out using this function pairwise
distance argument for each of the points
we find out which one which center or
which randomly selected centroid
is the closest and accordingly we assign
the data or the data point to that
particular centroid or cluster and once
that is done for all the data points
we calculate the new centroid by finding
out the mean position which is the
center position right so we calculate
the new centroid and then we check if
the new centroid is the coordinates or
the position is the same as the previous
centroid the positions we will compare
and if it is the same that means the
process has converged so remember we do
this process till the centroids or the
centroid doesn't move anymore right so
the centroid gets relocated each time
this reallocation is done so the moment
it doesn't change anymore the position
of the centroid doesn't change anymore
we know that convergence has occurred so
till then so you see here this is like
an infinite loop while true is an
infinite loop it only breaks when the
centers are the same the new center and
the old center positions are the same
and once that is done we return the
centers and the labels now of course as
explained this is not a very
sophisticated and advanced
implementation very basic implementation
because one of the flaws in this is that
sometimes what happens is the centroid
the position
will
keep moving but in the change will be
very minor so in that case
also with that is actually convergence
right so for example the change is
0.0001 we can consider that as
convergence otherwise what will happen
is this will either take forever or it
will be never ending so that's a small
flaw here so that is something
additional checks may have to be added
here but again as mentioned this is not
the most sophisticated implementation uh
this is like a kind of a rough
implementation of the k-means clustering
okay so if we execute this code this is
what we get as the output so this is the
definition of this particular function
and then we call that find underscore
clusters and we pass our data x and the
number of clusters which is four
and if we run that and plot it this is
the output that we get so this is of
course each cluster is represented by a
different color so we have a cluster in
green color yellow color and so on and
so forth and these big points here these
are the centroids this is the final
position of the centroids and as you can
see visually also this appears like a
kind of a center of all these points
here right similarly this is like the
center of all these points here and so
on so this is the example or this is an
example of a implementation of k means
clustering
and
next we will move on to see a couple of
examples of how k means clustering is
used in maybe some real life scenarios
or use cases in the next example or demo
we are going to see how we can use
k-means clustering to perform color
compression we will take a couple of
images so there will be two examples and
we will try to use k-means clustering to
compress the colors this is a common
situation
in image processing when you have an
image with millions of
colors but then you cannot render it on
some devices which may not have enough
memory so that is the
scenario where where something like this
can be used
so
before again we go into the python
notebook let's take a look at quickly
the the code
as usual we import the libraries and
then we import the image and
then we will flatten it so the reshaping
is basically we have the image
information is stored in the form of
pixels and if the image is like for
example 427 by 640 and it has three
colors so that's the overall dimension
of the of the initial image we just
reshape it and
then feed this to our algorithm
and this will then create clusters
of only 16 clusters so this this colors
there are millions of colors and now we
need to bring it down to 16 colors so we
use k is equal to 16
and
this is how when we visualize this is
how it looks there are these are all
about 16 million possible colors the
input color space has 16 million
possible colors and we just
sub compress it to 16 color so this is
how it would look when we compress it to
16 colors and this is how the original
image looks and
after compression to 16 colors this is
how the new image looks as you can see
there is not a lot of
information that has been lost
though the image quality is definitely
reduced a little bit
so this is
an example which we are going to now see
in python notebook let's go into the
python node and once again as always we
will import some libraries and
load this image called
flower dot jpg okay so let me load that
and this is how it looks this is the
original image which has i think 16
million colors and
this is the shape of this image which is
basically what is the
shape is nothing but the overall size
right so this is 427 pixel by 640 pixel
and then there are three layers which is
this three basically is for rgb which is
red green blue so color image will have
that right so that is the shape of this
now what we need to do is data let's
take a look at how data is looking so
let me just create a new cell and show
you
what is in data basically we have
captured this information
so data is what let me just show you
here
all right so
let's take a look at
china what are the values in china and
if we see here this is how the data is
stored this is nothing but the pixel
values okay so this is like a matrix and
each one has about four for this 427 by
640 pixels all right so this is how it
looks now the issue here is these values
are large the numbers are large so we
need to normalize them to between zero
and one right so that's why we will
basically create one more variable which
is data which will contain the values
between zero and 1 and the way to do
that is divide by 255 so we divide china
by 255 and we get the new values in data
so let's just run this piece of code and
this is the shape so we now have also
yeah what we have done is we changed
using reshape we converted into the
three-dimensional into a two-dimensional
data set and let us also take a look at
how
let me just insert
probably a cell here and take a look at
how data is looking all right so this is
how data is looking and now you see this
is
the values are between zero and one
right so if you earlier noticed in case
of china the values were large numbers
now everything is between zero and one
this is one of the things we need to do
all right so after that the next thing
that we need to do is to visualize this
and
we can take random set of maybe 10 000
points and plot it and check and see how
this looks let us just plot this
and so this is how the original the
color the pixel distribution is these
are two plots one is red against green
and another is red against blue and this
is the original distribution of the
color so then what we will do is we will
use k means clustering to create just 16
clusters for the various colors and then
apply that to the image now
what will happen is since the data is
large because there are millions of
colors using regular k-means may be a
little time consuming so there is
another version of k-means which is
called mini batch gaming so we will use
that which is which processes in the
overall concept remains the same but
this basically processes it in smaller
batches that's the only thing okay so
the results will pretty much be the same
so let's go ahead and execute this piece
of code and also visualize this so that
we can see that there are this is how
the 16 colors
would look
so this is red against green and this is
red against blue there is uh quite a bit
of similarity between this original
color schema and the new one right so it
doesn't look very very completely
different or anything like that now we
apply this the newly created colors to
the image and we can take a look uh how
this is looking now we can compare both
the images so this is our original image
and this is our new image so as you can
see there is not a lot of information
that has been lost it pretty much looks
like the original image yes we can see
that for example here there is a little
bit uh it appears a little dullish
compared to this one right because we
kind of took off some of the finer
details of the color but
overall the high level information has
been maintained at the same time the
main advantage is that now this can be
this is an image which can be rendered
on a device which may not be that very
sophisticated now let's take one more
example with a different image in the
second example we will take an image of
the summer palace in china and we repeat
the same process this is a high
definition color image with millions of
colors and also
three dimensional
now we will reduce that to 16 colors
using k means clustering
and
we do the same process like before we
reshape it and then we cluster the
colors to 16 and then we render the
image once again and we will see that
the color the quality of the image
slightly deteriorates as you can see
here this has much finer details in this
which are probably missing here but then
that's the compromise because there are
some devices which may not be able to
handle this kind of high density images
so let's run this chord in python
notebook all right so let's apply the
same technique for another picture which
is
even more intricate and has probably
much complicated color schema so this is
the image now once again we can take a
look at the shape which is 427 by 640 by
and this is the new data would look
somewhat like this compared to the
flower image so we have some new values
here
and we will also bring this as you can
see the numbers are much big so we will
much bigger so we will now have to
scale them down to values between 0 and
1 and that is done by
dividing by 255 so let's go ahead and do
that
and reshape it okay so we get a
two-dimensional matrix
and we will then as a next step we will
go ahead and visualize this how it looks
does the 16 colors
and this is basically how it would look
16 million colors and
now we can
create the clusters
out of this the 16
k means clusters we will create so this
is how the distribution of the pixels
would look with 16 colors
and then we go ahead and
apply this
and visualize how it is looking for
with the new just the 16 color so once
again as you can see this looks much
richer in color but at the same time and
this probably doesn't have as we can see
it doesn't look as rich as this one but
nevertheless the information is not lost
the shape and all that stuff and this
can be also rendered on a slightly a
device which is probably
not that sophisticated okay so that's
pretty much it so we have seen two
examples of how color compression can be
done using k-means clustering
and we have also seen in the previous
examples of how to implement k-means the
code to roughly how to implement k-means
clustering and we use some sample data
using
blob to just execute the k-means
clustering
now you'll notice here
we've got we're using pandas whoops drew
it through the pandas and we're going to
go ahead and read it as a pandas data
frame
and of course pandas sits on numpy so a
lot of stuff you do with pandas can go
right into numpy very easily
and the reason i bring this up is
because pandas has a lot of tools in
there for just looking at the data real
quick and easy
and so the first one we want to go ahead
and do is do credit dot df or credit
underscore df our data we read in info
and just see what that looks like
and when we go ahead and print this out
you can see here we have um
13 columns
remember we were looking at our data and
it had those that
row you couldn't read across the top
then it has non-null count how many
values don't have null what kind of
objects are they they're an object an
integer
different things like that and we look
at object is it a checking account this
is probably text on here
duration how long credit history
amount savings account present employee
employed sense
so a lot of different numbers coming in
here and these are just the columns
we're looking at
and if you're going to look at the
columns it's kind of nice to actually
look at the data
and so we'll use the pandas to go ahead
and print it out just like you would on
a spreadsheet
hard to see them all on here but you can
see we have here's our row across the
top because panda does such a good job
sorting out columns
and the actual data
checking account a11 a12 a14
not sure what that means
duration how long they've had it credit
history
i'm not sure what the a33 or a34 means
i'm sure it has a special meaning on
there
the amount here's our savings account
and all the information on that
and this is actually a very
much more easy to read view than what we
had before
as far as like that text file when
you're just looking at data through the
database sometimes those can be really
hard to read this you can really see and
if i take it down a notch i can get all
the columns in here we're going to keep
it zoomed in just so we can see that
what's going on a little easier
and then we can also do
credit df.i location the ilocation
feature in the pandas
is going to go ahead and do rows 0
through 5 and we're going to look at
columns 1 through 7. and let's go ahead
and just run that and you can see right
here
how we just split it up so it's really
easy to manipulate our data and get a
smaller view of different parts of the
data as we're going through it
and just like we can look at the first
seven columns we can also look at the
last seven columns
same kind of format we're looking at
rows 0 through 5 column 7 to the end if
you leave the number out there
and you can see we can easily now look
at this on a smaller screen
much better for displaying those are
just tricks to help you display
your information so that when you
present this in front of a group of
people
it makes it very easy to read or you
just copy this out and put it into a
document that kind of thing
and then we also like to go ahead and do
like credit status value counts and
things like that
again we're just looking at the
different
sets of information on here
and in
our pandas data frame value counts as
we're looking at unique values so
there's a lot of unique values in here
that's
700 and 300
that's a significantly diverse set of
data
and if we look at the data one of the
things we're looking at is the
uh status 0 1 0 0 1
and i'm going to guess that that means
that it is either default or not default
so that's probably what we're going to
want to look for
hopefully you've had your
specialty and domain remember we talked
about the different parts of data
science
domain is what field it is in
this would be in banks and loans
and so if we want to figure out what the
status of a new loan is
we're going to separate the status out
and so if we take our x features equals
a list of the columns that's all this is
credit underscore df dot columns
we remove status
and then we go ahead and this will print
our features out and you can see it's
everything but the status on the end
because that's what we want to predict
we want to predict the new data whether
that status is 0 or 1 or not and next we
want to do a little bit more data
preparation we're going to go ahead and
encode
and we're going to take an inco credit
df we're going to create that off of our
set up on here
and you're gonna ask well what are we
encoding on here when we go up to here
let me just go back all the way
when we're looking at all this
information up here
you can see there's
object
well
if i'm doing a prediction and
something's just a random object it
doesn't really mean anything there's no
numbers to process
and so when we come down a little
further
we can see down here that we are looking
at
a65 i'm not sure what a65 means
we're looking at a93 personal status
we're looking at a143 these aren't
actual numbers there's some kind of
code that the bank put in probably
and so for our model they really don't
mean anything unless we convert them to
numbers
and you convert them to numbers by
literally creating a bunch of yes no's
so instead of thinking it as
as
a173 and a172 as being 0 1 and if you
had an a7 174 maybe 0 1 2 you would
think of this as a label a173 is true or
false
and then you'd have another label
a172 as true or false
so for every unique job in here that it
becomes another feature added in and
it's on or off it's true or false that's
what this
encoding is doing
and we'll go ahead and list our encoding
as it comes out
and if you come up here
you can see it did exactly what i was
describing we've now encoded it so
here's checking account a13 checking
account
a12 31. here's all of our
checking account numbers so there was
three of them uh here's our credit
history a31 a32 833 34.
again the computer has no idea of
knowing what those are all it knows is
those are each unique features and the
same thing with the
savings account 862 and so on going down
uh and so once we have our nice list of
there we can go ahead and do
pull this in here we go let's look at
our new data set
and if we go ahead and run the new data
set we have our income credit df
checking and we're just going to look at
these and look at the head this is just
the first few of these so we can see
what it actually looks like in the data
and just like i said it's now
0 0 zero zero one one zero zero
this first column is just the count zero
one two three four that's not part of
the data uh but you can see here
that it just puts a check mark of one uh
because it's an ac
a12 and we have a checking account ac
a14 where it's also a check mark of one
going across
so we've done a little data preparation
uh we've come in here and done some
exploratory data analysis
and now we want to start building our
data model and we'll kind of go back and
forth between exploratory data analysis
and data model and then interpreting the
results on this
and so when we go ahead and import our
stats models as api
as sm
now a lot of times we use the
sk learner the scikit models in this one
we're going to go ahead and use the sm
model from stats models which is pretty
common for doing a very basic logistics
regression model and then from the
scikit we're going to have our trained
test split
with any data you want to go ahead and
train your model and then you need
something to test it on some unknown
data so you can see how well you did
very common in your in your setting up
your models is to split it up into your
training set and your
testing set
and what i want you to notice on here is
we have x train well what is x train
that's all the columns except for the
last one which was the status was it
default or was it
in good standing
and then of course our x test is part of
the data we're going to split that up
by 0.3 so 30 percent of the data is
going to be
30 of our rows
are going to be put in the x test and
the y train and y test is just the
status and then we create our
once we've created our data and split it
up we go and create our model and it's a
logit we're just going to call it logit
but you can a lot of times you end up
seeing logic model
with logit
it equals the sm.logit x train
y train x train in sk learn it's always
x train y train
uh but in the
stats model it's reversed on there uh
and then they go ahead and run the fit
so we load the data up and then we fit
it
and then we can go ahead and summarize
that model and see what it looks like
let's go ahead and run that
it takes it just a moment
uh and we get a nice summary of our data
again we're still looking at the data
and we have um takes just a moment to to
kind of feed through and you can
certainly see where we have our
coefficient
which has to do with the weights in the
model
standard error that's very important as
we look at this coefficient and how it
affects the model
p is greater than the absolute value of
z 0.025 these are all your statistical
notes on here
so as you look at these you might look
at like how big is a standard error
that's one of the big ones that i
usually look at
as we go up
and we start looking at the different
things
the higher the error the less
the more we want to be a little careful
of it the lower the error the better in
more general terms they also have
dealing with the model and its
iterations you can see some general
status on here how many iterations did i
have to go through uh before i was able
to come up with the numbers because it
kind of guesses it's playing a high-low
game and it takes it six iterations
until it finds what it considers the
best fit uh and you can see there's more
information up here as far as when it
converts how it converts and so on now
when we have our
summary up there
one of the questions starts coming in
remember i told you we're looking at
like our standard error and you know how
these numbers all are telling us how
important each one of these features is
in running our prediction and if you
have a ton of features
and some of them are
just kind of all over the place all they
do is create noise
so we really want to get rid of them
they also cause issues in that if you're
running a huge amount of data and you
have to rerun this model over and over
again
this can really text your time and so
you're losing both time money and your
results might not be as good because
they might be weighted based on some of
these very fuzzy numbers
uh so we're going to look at significant
variables and put together a little
routine for that again we're
we've come in if you remember from
back here uh we're still in kind of an
exploratory data analysis and data
modeling they kind of go hand in hand
sometimes we haven't quite got to
interpreting the results and running
predictions
and so we'll go ahead and build this
thing on here it looks at the
lm values so that's coming up here where
this was generated
i'd have to actually look that up for
the this particular model because i
usually use the
sk learn version of this
uh so as we look at this we're going to
look at the p-values
of our variables
and basically we're looking to see how
good the p-values are if they're less
than or equal to 0.05 we probably
those are probably solid values
and if they're greater than that then
probably we're not interested in them
and so let's go ahead and run this and
we see that when we pull out all the
values that are less than or equal to
0.05 for the p values and if we go up
here
here we go here's our p i knew it was up
here i just wasn't seeing it correctly
so you can probably see duration that's
going to be good amount 0.01 that looks
good instance instant
inst rate
which i'm guessing is the percentage
rate or the interest
it's trying to say in inst and interest
at the same time
so we have our interest rate and all
that if we come down here we see
duration amount
our instant rate age
checking account a13 checking account
a14
credit history a34 savings account 65.
these are our primary features these
ones are related when we look at the
data
these are the ones that are going to
predict whether it's a good or bad loan
and so now that we know which ones work
we want to go ahead and create our
recreate our
sm model or our final logit model and
you'll see here we now have the x-tray
the y-train and then instead of the
x-train it's x-train significant
variables right there
so all we're doing is is running this
just on the significant variables in the
setup and we'll go ahead and fit it and
you can see here you can actually
double bracket and do it all in one line
up above we had to do it in the two
lines this is how the
setup is for this particular module
and then we'll go ahead and do a final
legit summary and just see what that
looks like
and we can see here here's our p scores
remember they're all supposed to be
under point o
underneath the 0.05 these are all under
0.05
you can see up here are different
statuses as far as how it ran it still
took six iterations to go through the
data
the date and so forth and now that we
have a solid model
uh and let's if you remember correctly
let me flip back on over here we've done
our data modeling uh we've created a
solid model and so now we need to
actually run a prediction
so that we can interpret the results and
weigh in on that and see how good they
are
and so for that i'm going to go ahead
and let's find it over here
why
predict
so we have our model that we created we
want to go ahead and create our y
predict
and it's based on our final object and
here's the magic word predict or dot
predict
and so this is where we're going to come
in and actually get our predictions on
here
that our model comes up and remember
we're testing um
x test is going in there's our x test
and it's only the significant variables
so we've created our model now we want
to push in our test version that's never
seen this data before so this is all new
and then we're just going to take a
random sample to see what it looks like
uh what do those predictions look like
in this random sample we're just looking
at 10 of these
and you can see here is the actual
number it says 0.08 gives us a 1
0.07
this is our probability number which is
i would have to actually look to see
whether
higher or lower is better
i'm guessing the closer
to zero the better it is but i'm not
completely sure on that i have to
actually look up on and see with this
particular framework
but you can see the actual prediction
one zero zero zero so i guess this is a
good loan a bunch of defaults and some
good loans that's what it predicts it's
going to come out as now just looking at
the data
you know it's confusing this is you have
different models they have different
setup they have the
predicted probability comes out on this
and other models it doesn't so you
really need a tool
to dig deeper into the setup to
understand what this means
and so what we're going to do is we're
going to take our predicted values which
you can see right here has an actual
predicted probability
and then we're going to go ahead and
insert on there
from a sample let me just run this
because it'll make a lot more sense we
have our actual value and our predicted
value so this is what we predicted
and this is the actual setup
if we just look at this right off the
bat we can see that we predicted zero
and this was a one
these all came out correct
uh number 332 came out correct 917 was
an actual they were good on their loan
they predicted it's going to be a
default
you start to see that there's some
variance so how do we measure that how
do we know whether our model was any
good or not
well for that we're going to go ahead
and load up
a nice graph and we'll use
for our graph we'll import matplot
library pi plot
and seaborn seaborn sits on matplot
library
and this
matplot library inline is just because
i'm using jupyter notebook with the new
version i'm in it doesn't even need it
but i tend to leave it in for older
versions
and then we rope import from our sk
learn metrics this is your scikit
scikit is the main package and sk learn
is how it looks on here
and we'll go ahead and
run that so it's nicely loaded
and then we'll go ahead and create a
little routine
in just a moment here
to print this out so we can see what
that looks like
and this metrics
it's kind of a fun metrics because it it
tells you like how many you have correct
on the correct one
how many you had wrong on the wrong one
um and this top part is just all
a draw routine
so it comes in here and has our actual
and are predicted as our cm metrics it
breaks it up
puts it into the heat map the sn heat
map gives it some colors
add some labels
and then we go ahead and show it and
we're just going to dump that in there
and run that
and you can spend forever building
graphics is so much fun
we come in here we have bad credit good
credit
we have bad credit good credit we have
predicted label
and so when you look at this you can see
here it had
on the good credit
it tells you how well it predicted it
and how many false
positive it has
and on our bad credit
um here we have bad credit bad credit it
said 30 of those
were bad credit it predicted them bad
credit
while 21 were good credit that it
predicted would be bad credit
and then we have here we have 188 that
were good credit
uh but the actual va then it had 61
there were bad credit that it said were
predicted good credit
uh so at this point you look at this and
you'd say well if i'm predicting uh
these are
this is our good credit here let me flip
this on over here and this is our
bad credit
there we go
so we have bad credit good credit you
start looking at and you say okay can we
afford that many defaults after five
years or whatever it is and so those are
the questions you start asking is does
this model work good enough to predict
whether we should give these people
loans or not you're always going to have
somebody default on them and again that
starts going into domain
banking domain something i don't know
very much about
clearly i know whether i default on a
loan or not which i don't and i try very
hard not to and then if we're going to
draw the chart which is
really nice to have just a clear visual
chart
metrics also has our classification
report and you can see these are just
the numbers we're looking at
they let us know the precision
our f score and recall and all that
stuff on here you can just print a
straight up metrics classification
report now we looked at a regression
model let's go ahead and look at a
clustering model to see what that looks
like and we'll go ahead and create a new
python on there
and this is going to be our
clustering setup let me flip this off
and square and done some exploratory
data analysis
and now we want to start building our
data model and we'll kind of go back and
forth between exploratory data analysis
and data model and then interpreting the
results on this
and so when we go ahead and import our
stats models as api
as sm
now a lot of times we use the
sk learner the scikit models in this one
we're going to go ahead and use the sm
model from stats models which is pretty
common for doing a very basic logistics
regression model and then from the
scikit we're going to have our trained
test split
with any data you want to go ahead and
train your model and then you need
something to test it on some unknown
data so you can see how well you did
very common in your day in your setting
up your models is to split it up into
your training set and your
testing set and what i want you to
notice on here is we have x train well
what is x train that's all the columns
except for the last one which was the
status was it default or was it
in in good standing
and then of course our x test is part of
the data we're going to split that up
by point three so thirty percent of the
data is going to be
thirty percent of our rows are going to
be put in the x test and the y train and
y test is just the status and then we
create our um once we've created our
data and split it up we go and create
our model and it's a logit we're just
going to call it logit but a lot of
times you end up seeing logic model
with logit
it equals the sm logit x train
y train x train in sk learn it's always
x train y train
uh but in the
stats model it's it's reversed on there
uh and then they go ahead and run the
fit so we load the data up and then we
fit it
uh and then we can go ahead and
summarize that model and see what it
looks like let's go ahead and run that
it takes it just a moment
uh and we get a nice summary of our data
again we're still looking at the data um
and we have
uh takes just a moment to to kind of
feed through and you can certainly see
where we have our coefficient
which has to do with the weights in the
model
standard error that's very important as
we look at this coefficient and how it
affects the model
p is greater than the absolute value of
z 0.025 these are all your statistical
notes on here
so as you look at these you might look
at like how big is a standard error
that's one of the big ones that i
usually look at
as we go up
and we start looking at the different
things
the higher the error the less
the more we want to be a little careful
of it the lower the error the better in
more general terms they also have
dealing with the model and its
iterations you can see some general
status on here how many iterations that
i have to go through uh before i was
able to come up with the numbers because
it kind of guesses it's playing a
high-low game and it takes it six
iterations until it finds what it
considers the best fit and you can see
there's more information up here as far
as when it converts how it converts and
so on now when we have our
summary up there
one of the questions starts coming in
remember i told you we're looking at
like our standard error and you know how
these numbers all are telling us how
important each one of these features is
in running our prediction and if you
have a ton of features
and some of them are
just kind of all over the place all they
do is create noise
so we really want to get rid of them
they also cause issues in that if you're
running a huge amount of data and you
have to rerun this model over and over
again
this can really text your time and so
you're losing both time money and your
results might not be as good because
they might be weighted based on some of
these very fuzzy numbers
uh so we're going to look at significant
variables and put together a little
routine for that again we're
we've come in if you remember from
back here
we're still in kind of an exploratory
data analysis and data modeling they
kind of go hand in hand sometimes we
haven't quite got to interpreting the
results in running predictions
and so we'll go ahead and build this
thing on here it looks at the
lm values so that's coming up here where
this was generated
i have to actually look that up for the
this particular model because i usually
use the
sk learn version of this
so as we look at this we're going to
look at the p values
of our variables and basically we're
looking to see how good the p values are
if they're less than or equal to 0.05 we
probably
those are probably solid values
and if they're greater than that then
probably we're not interested in them
and so let's go ahead and run this and
we see that when we pull out all the
values that are less than or equal to
0.05 for the p-values and if we go up
here
here we go here's our p i knew it was up
here i just wasn't seeing it correctly
so you can probably see duration that's
going to be good
amount 0.01 that looks good instance
instant
inst rate
which i'm guessing is the percentage
rate or the interest um it's trying to
say in inst and interest at the same
time
so we have our interest rate and all
that if we come down here we see
duration amount
our instant rate age
checking account a13 checking account
a14
credit history a34 savings account 65.
these are our primary features these
ones are related when we look at the
data
these are the ones that are going to
predict whether it's a good or bad loan
and so now that we know which ones work
we want to go ahead and create our
recreate our
sm model or our final logit model and
you'll see here we now have the
x-tray the y-train and then instead of
the x-train it's x-train significant
variables right there
so all we're doing is is running this
just on the significant variables in the
setup and we'll go ahead and fit it and
you can see here you can actually
double bracket and do it all in one line
up above we had to do it in the two
lines which is how the
setup is for this particular module
and then we'll go ahead and do a final
legit summary and just see what that
looks like
and we can see here here's our p scores
remember they're all supposed to be
under 0.0
um underneath the 0.05 these are all
under 0.05
you can see up here are different
statuses as far as how it ran it still
took six iterations to go through the
data um the date and so forth and now
that we have a solid model
uh and let's if you remember correctly
let me flip back on over here we've done
our data modeling
we've created a solid model and so now
we need to actually run a prediction
so that we can interpret the results and
weigh in on that and see how good they
are and so for that i'm going to go
ahead and let's find it over here
why
predict
so we have our model that we created we
want to go ahead and create our y
predict and it's based on our final
object and here's the magic word predict
or dot predict
and so this is where we're going to come
in and actually get our predictions on
here
that our model comes up and remember
we're testing
x test is going in there's our x test
and it's only the significant variables
so we've created our model now we want
to push in our test version that's never
seen this data before
so this is all new and then we're just
going to take a random sample to see
what it looks like
what do those predictions look like
in this random sample we're just looking
at 10 of these
and you can see here is the actual
number it says 0.08 gives us a 1.07
this is our probability number which is
i would have to actually look to see
whether
higher or lower is better
i'm guessing the closer to
zero the better it is but i'm not
completely sure on that i have to
actually look up on and see with this
particular framework
uh but you can see the actual prediction
one zero zero zero so i guess this is a
good loan a bunch of defaults and some
good loans that's what it predicts it's
going to come out as now just looking at
the data
you know it's confusing this is you have
different models they have different
setup they have the
predicted probability comes out on this
and other models it doesn't so you
really need a tool
to dig deeper into the setup to
understand what this means
and so what we're going to do is we're
going to take our predicted values which
you can see right here has an actual
predicted probability
and then we're going to go ahead and
insert on there
from a sample let me just run this
because it'll make a lot more sense we
have our actual value and our predicted
value so this is what we predicted and
this is the actual setup
if we just look at this right off the
bat we can see that we predicted zero
and this was a one
these all came out correct
uh number 332 came out correct 917 was
an actual they were good on their loan
they predicted it's going to be a
default
you start to see that there's some
variants so how do we measure that how
do we know whether our model was any
good or not
well for that we're going to go ahead
and
load up
a nice graph and we'll use
for our graph we'll import matplot
library pi plot
and seaborn seaborn sits on matplot
library
and this
matplot library inline is just because
i'm using jupiter notebook with the new
version i'm in it doesn't even need it
but i tend to leave it in for older
versions
and then we rope import from our sk
learn metrics
this is your scikit
scikit is the main package and sklearn
is how it looks on here
and we'll go ahead
and run that so it's nicely loaded
and then we'll go ahead and create a
little routine
in just a moment here
to print this out so we can see what
that looks like
and this metrics
it's kind of a fun matrix because it it
tells you like how many you have correct
on the correct one
how many you had wrong on the wrong one
and this top part is just all
a draw routine so it comes in here and
has our actual and our predicted as our
cm metrics it breaks it up
puts it into the heat map the sn heat
map gives it some colors
add some labels
and then we go ahead and show it and
we're just going to dump that in there
and run that
and you can spend forever building
graphics is so much fun
we come in here we have bad credit good
credit
uh we have bad credit good credit we
have predicted label
and so when you look at this you can see
here it had
on the good credit
it tells you how well it predicted it
and how many false
positive it has
and on our bad credit
here we have bad credit bad credit it
said 30 of those
were bad credit it predicted them bad
credit
while 21 were good credit that it
predicted would be bad credit
and then we have here we have 188 that
were good credit
uh but the actual val and then it had 61
there were bad credit that it said were
good were predicted good credit
uh so at this point you'd look at this
and you'd say well
if i'm predicting
uh
these are
this is our good credit here let me flip
this on over here
and this is our
bad credit
there we go
um so we have bad credit good credit you
start looking that and you say okay can
we afford that many defaults after five
years or whatever it is
and so those are the questions you start
asking is does this model work good
enough to predict whether we should give
these people loans or not you're always
going to have somebody default on them
and again that starts going into domain
banking domain something i don't know
very much about
clearly i know whether i default on a
loan or not which i don't and i try very
hard not to and then if we're going to
draw the chart which is
really nice to have just a clear visual
chart
metrics also has our classification
report
and you can see these are just the
numbers we're looking at
they let us know the precision
uh our f score and recall and all that
stuff on here you can just print a
straight up metrics classification
report now we looked at a regression
model uh let's go ahead and look at a
clustering model to see what that looks
like and we'll go ahead and create a new
group
python on there
and this is going to be our
clustering setup let me flip this off
and switch on over to my clustering menu
in this case we're going to be looking
at k means clustering
so let's just put that up here okay
means
clustering
now the last one was a regression model
so it figured out coefficients for lines
you can go back to your old euclidean
geometry
or the algebra expression for a slope on
a line y equals mx plus b or whatever
and it
goes on from there as far as finding
distances and
figuring out the lines on there this is
a little bit different we talk about
clustering it uses similar
ideas but it has to do with edges
two points and how do you figure out a
distance between two points and what
does that mean
now you'll see here we have our pandas
pd our numpy as np our matplot library
seaborn sits on matplot libraries we
talked about
they've added some parameters here as
far as colors and then we did an inline
for the map plot library again that's
not really necessary even in the new
version of the
jupiter notebook in the old version
jupiter notebook if you didn't do that
it would just kind of hang or disappear
and then we're going to import some data
it's important to have our
data set up in here
and instead of looking at this and
guessing what the data is
usually open up the csv file at this
time let's just go ahead and print it
under the df head
because really those those text files
are so messy and you look at the df head
and it's easy to look at
whoops had a path issue there um so
college data
it's a csv so automatically knows
there's a dot csv on there
and we can see here that they downloaded
from a number of colleges
abilene christian university adelphi
university adrian college
and then it has whether it's private
i'm guessing yes or no
apps i'm not sure what that is
acceptance rate
applications i'm betting and then the
acceptance rate enrollment
top ten percent top two five percent
undergrad so on so these are just
statistics based on
the college their college getting into a
college
and just like we did before let's
explore the data if you can remember
from the chart we were looking at we're
going through our data discovery data
preparation
uh and exploratory data analysis so
we're really kind of looking at the data
and what do we have here what came in
at this point the data's already been
prepared we're not doing a whole lot as
far as
getting rid of null values and finding
out whether it's bad data or good data
and that kind of thing and data
discovery would be figuring out which
data to send so that we've already done
so we're going to do the exploratory
data
jump into data modeling and interpret
the results just like we did with the
other one
and we'll go ahead and use the panda
tool to get the info
df you'll see df very commonly it just
stands for data frame a lot of people
use it as a generic setup when they
import from pandas
and so we have our info and you can see
right here uh
non-null numbers here's our count so
each one of these has 777 non-null
values
and again here's our type of data we're
dealing with
and if you remember from last time
here's an object
this is our yes or no everything else
looks like it's integer we do have a
float value here
uh integer integer
floats and integers usually they're when
you're running them on a prediction
they're pretty interchangeable in a lot
of cases but whether it's private true
or false that's pretty important on here
the fact that they could probably be
switched to a 0 or 1
is pretty helpful also
and if we're going to look at all that
data we can go ahead and describe it so
there's our data frame describe
and you have the same thing here's our
count all these should be 777.
we have the mean value so you can
actually look at what our average is
standard deviation
uh minimum different uh quartiles 25 50
the third quartile that so on
and of course our max value on there min
and max
and as we explore the data we can do a
lot of fun things on here
we're going to use our seaborn
and we're going to look at
room and board versus graduation date
we're going to add this is going to be a
heat map so we're going to add
whether it's a private college or not
how it fits the size the aspect ratio
and all that that's what this line is
here seabourn
you can almost do your own class on
matplot library and seaborn because
there's so many features in there but
when you look at the very basics you can
throw up some data
and have a nice colorful map set up
and here we have our graduation rate
compared to room and board costs
and in private or
public
so you can see that the graduation rate
uh compared to room and board hit play
interesting thought how much should i
spend on room and board
uh am i going to graduate the more i
spend on room and board and you can see
numbers go up there on graduation rate
and you can see that the
graduation rate tends to go way up for
your private schools
and the room and board also goes
continues to grow on private schools
kind of thing it's kind of just a fun
heat map
and we can explore other things in our
doing our heat maps
we can look at
out state
whether it's out of state undergrad
private again is one of our setups on
here
and you can see here that
for undergrad uh there certainly is a
lot more
public schools and whether it's out of
state um interestingly enough the
out-of-state number goes way up how many
people coming from out of state into the
school for the private schools
just kind of fun things if you're trying
to figure out where you're going to go
maybe you'd want to do this for picking
a bachelor's degree or a master's degree
or something or
certainly you could also plot this with
fun locations and download information
on
tourism sites if you're traveling that
kind of thing you do the same kind of
thing with
and we'll go ahead and throw out another
map on here
let me go and run this
this is a slightly different setup on
here with the out of state
and so we're running let's see pull this
up
uh bins 20
the bins is each how many uh
bins are you going to split it into
and this is kind of a fun one where you
can see private versus public
we have how many out of state
and
i'd have to look this up to see what
they picked on here
oh there we go okay so you can see we
have another chart that has to do with
the out of state and the number of
students coming in and private and
public
so a lot of different setups on here as
we dig into the different
graphing
so at this point we've just been kind of
looking at
the graphs on here let's go ahead and
import our
cluster our k-means cluster
and you can see here we have we're going
to call it km i guess for k-means or
maybe it's k means model i always label
mine with model
equals k means in clusters equals 2
random state equals 90.
and so where when we cluster it we're
only going to cluster into two groups
that's what this this is meaning here um
across the different settings on there
and then we're going to go ahead and fit
and we're going to drop private
uh so we're not we're not going to be
looking at whether it's a private or
public school we're just going to go
ahead and
run the cluster on there
and then once we run the cluster on
there we can actually look at cluster
centers let's go ahead and do that on
this
we talk about k means let me run this
boom there we go
so we have
all these different columns and each of
those columns has the center and we
start looking how the data comes
together on those centers that's what
all these numbers this is the hidden
stuff behind the clusters on here
and so we can now do maybe we'll create
a little converter here
if private equals yes return one else
return zero
we're going to run our cluster private
and apply the converter
and then we'll go ahead and print that
out let me just show you what that looks
like so you can see what we're doing
here
and then we go ahead and do df cluster
we'll create a new column on here
private apply converter
and we can see here it creates some
private apps except
we've just added on to our data frame on
here
and we did that so that we can run the
confusion matrix
make sure we import our confusion matrix
we're going to do a classification
report confusion matrix and we'll go
ahead and run this on our clustering
and as you can see here as we're
predictions
here's our confusion matrix up here just
like we had on the other setup where it
has how many
false true false false
true false and false false
as your accuracy and our setup on there
this is really uh if you're looking at
which where you want to go
maybe looking at where you want to go in
a i think more of a tourism thing but um
for colleges this is a great way for
looking for a bachelor's or a master's
uh coming in here and you can start
finding out which one you want to go to
based on this accuracy whether it's
private or public
or how many graduations are on there
so we looked at a couple examples went
through some of the parts of the cycle
whether using a k-means or linear
regression model
and certainly this cycle and these
models you start to see that there are
some similarities we're doing the same
thing and each model has
a better setup depending on what you're
trying to accomplish on there
reinforcement learning by simply learn
my name is richard kirschner with the
simply learn team that's
www.simplylearn.com
get certified get ahead
we're going to cover reinforcement
learning today and what's in it for you
we'll start with why reinforcement
learning we'll look at what is
reinforcement learning
we'll see what the different kinds of
learning strategies are that are being
used today in computer models under
supervised versus unsupervised versus
reinforcement
we'll cover important terms specific to
reinforcement learning
we'll talk about markov's decision
process and we'll take a look at a
reinforcement learning example well
we'll teach a tic-tac-toe how to play
why reinforcement learning training a
machine learning model requires a lot of
data which might not always be available
to us
further the data provided might not be
reliable learning from a small subset of
actions will not help expand the vast
realm of solutions that may work for a
particular problem
you can see here we have the robot
learning to walk
very complicated setup when you're
learning how to walk and you'll start
asking questions like if i'm taking one
step forward and left what happens if i
pick up a 50 pound object how does that
change how a robot would walk
these things are very difficult to
program because there's no actual
information on it until it's actually
tried out learning from a small subset
of actions will not help expand the vast
realm of solutions that may work for a
particular problem
and we'll see here it learned how to
walk this is going to slow the growth
that technology is capable of machines
need to learn to perform actions by
themselves and not just learn off humans
and you see the objective climate
mountain
a real interesting point here
is that as human beings we can go into a
very unknown environment
and we can adjust for it and kind of
explore and play with it
most of the models the non-reinforcement
models in computer machine learning
aren't able to do that very well there's
a couple of them that can be used or
integrated see how it goes
is what we're talking about with
reinforcement learning so what is
reinforcement learning
reinforcement learning is a sub-branch
of machine learning that trains a model
to return an optimum solution for a
problem by taking a sequence of
decisions by itself
consider a robot learning to go from one
place to another
the robot is given a scenario must
arrive at a solution by itself the robot
can take different paths to reach the
destination
it will know the best path by the time
taken on each path it might even come up
with a unique solution all by itself
and that's really important is we're
looking for unique solutions we want the
best solution but you can't find it
unless you try it so we're looking at
our different
systems our different model we have
supervised versus unsupervised versus
reinforcement learning and with the
supervised learning that is probably the
most controlled environment we have a
lot of different supervised learning
models whether it's linear regression
neural networks
there's all kinds of things in between
decision trees
the data provided is labeled data with
output values specified
and this is important because we talk
about supervised learning you already
know the answer for all this information
you already know the picture has a
motorcycle in it so you're supervised
learning you already know that
the outcome for tomorrow for you know
going back a week you're looking at
stock
you can already have like the graph of
what the next day looks like so you have
an answer for it
and you have labeled data which is used
you have an external supervision and
solves problems by mapping labeled input
to no one output
so very controlled
unsupervised learning and ensuring
learning is really interesting because
it's now taking part in many other
models they start with and you can
actually insert an unsupervised learning
model
in almost either supervised or
reinforcement learning is part of the
system which is really cool
data provided is unlabeled data the
outputs are not specified machine makes
its own predictions
used to solve association with
clustering problems unlabeled data is
used no supervision solves problems by
understanding patterns and discovering
output
so you can look at this and you can
think um some of these things go with
each other they belong together so it's
looking for what connects in different
ways and there's a lot of different
algorithms that look at this
when you start getting into those are
some really cool images that come up
of what unsupervised learning is how it
can pick out say
the area of a donut
one model i'll see the area of the donut
and the other one will divide it into
three sections based on this location
versus what's next to it so there's a
lot of stuff that goes in with
unsupervised learning
and then we're looking at reinforcement
learning probably the biggest industry
in today's market in machine learning or
growing market it's very it's very
infant stage
as far as how it works and what's going
to be capable of
the machine learns from its environment
using rewards and errors used to solve
reward based problems
no predefined data is used no
supervision
follows trail and error problem solving
approach
so again we have a random first you
start with a random i try this it
works and this is my reward doesn't work
very well maybe or maybe it doesn't even
get you where you're trying to get it to
do and you get your reward back and then
it looks at that and says well let's try
something else
and it starts to play with these
different things finding the best route
so let's take a look at important terms
in today's reinforcement model
and this has become pretty standardized
over the last few years
so these are really good to know
we have the agent
agent is the model that is being trained
via reinforcement learning so this is
your actual uh entity that has however
you're doing it whether you're using a
neural network or a
cue table or whatever combination
thereof
this is the actual agent that you're
using this is the model
and you have your environment
the training situation that the model
must optimize to is called its
environment
and you can see here i guess we have a
robot who's trying to get chest full of
gems or whatever and that's the output
and then you have your action this is
all possible steps that can be taken by
the model and it picks one action and
you can see here it's picked three
different routes to get to the chest of
diamonds and gems
we have a state the current position
condition returned by the model
and you could look at this uh if you're
playing like a video game this is the
screen you're looking at so when you go
back here
the environment is a whole
game board so if you're playing one of
those mobius games
you might have the whole game board
going on uh but then you have your
current position where are you on that
game board what's around that what's
around you um if you were talking about
a robot the environment might be moving
around the yard
where it is in the yard and what it can
see what input it has in that location
that would be the current position
condition returned by the model and then
the reward to help the model move in the
right direction it is rewarded points
are given to it to appraise some kind of
action
so yeah you did good or didn't do as
good trying to maximize the reward and
have the best reward possible
and then policy policy determines how an
agent will behave at any time it acts as
a mapping between action and present
state
this is part of the model what what is
your action that you're you're going to
take what's the policy you're using to
have an output from your agent
one of the reasons they separate
policy as its own entity
is that you usually have a prediction
of a different options
and then the policy well how am i going
to pick the best based on those
predictions i'm going to guess at
different options
and we'll actually weigh those options
in and find the best option we think
will work
so it's a little tricky but the policy
thing is actually pretty cool how it
works
let's go and take a look at a
reinforcement learning example
and just in looking at this we're going
to take a look consider what a dog
that we want to train
so the dog would be like the agent so
you have your your puppy or whatever
and then your environment is going to be
the whole house or whatever it is where
you're training them
and then you have an action we want to
teach the dog to fetch
so action equals fetching
and then we have a little biscuit so we
can get the dog to perform various
actions by offering incentives such as a
dog biscuit as a reward
the dog will follow a policy to maximize
this reward and hence will follow every
command and might even learn new actions
like begging by itself
uh so yeah you know so we start off with
fetching it goes oh i get a biscuit for
that it tries something else you get a
handshake or begging or something like
that and goes oh this is also reward
based and so it kind of explores things
to find out what will bring his biscuit
and that's very much like how reinforced
model goes as it
looks for different rewards how do i
find can i try different things and find
a reward that works
the dog also will want to run around and
play an explorer's environment
this quality of model is called
exploration so there's a little
randomness going on in exploration
and explores new parts of the house
climbing on the sofa doesn't get a
reward in fact it usually gets kicked
off the sofa
so let's talk a little bit about
markov's decision process uh markov's
decision process
is a reinforcement learning policy used
to map a current state to an action
where the agent continuously interacts
with the environment to produce new
solutions and receive rewards
and you'll see here's all of our
different uh vocabulary we just went
over we have a reward our state our
agent our environment interaction and so
even though the environment kind of
contains everything um
that you really when you're actually
writing the program your environment's
going to put out a reward in state that
goes into the agent
the agent then looks at this state or it
looks at the reward usually
first and it says okay i got rewarded
for whatever i just did or it didn't get
rewarded
and it looks at the state
and then it comes back and if you
remember from
policy the policy comes in
and then we have a reward the policy is
that part that's connected at the bottom
and so it looks at that policy and it
says hey
what's a good action that will probably
be similar to what i did or
sometimes they're completely random but
what's a good action that's going to
bring me a different reward
so taking the time to just understand
these different pieces as they go
is pretty important in most of the
models today um and so a lot of them
actually have templates
based on this you can pull in and start
using
pretty straightforward as far as once
you start seeing how it works
you can see your environment sends it
says hey this is the agent did this if
you're a character in a game this
happened and it shoots out a reward in a
state the agent looks at the reward
looks at the new state and then takes a
little guess and says i'm going to try
this action and then that action goes
back into the environment
it affects the environment the
environment then changes depending on
what the action was
and then it has a new state and a new
reward that goes back to the agent
so in the diagram shown we need to find
the shortest path between node a and d
each path has a reward associated with
it and the path with a maximum reward is
what we want to choose
the nodes a b c d denote the nodes to
travel from node uh a to b
is an action reward is the cost of each
path and policy is each path taken and
you can see here a can go uh to b
or a can go to c right off the bat or
can go right to d
and if explored all three of these
you would find that a going to d was a
zero reward
a going to c and d would generate a
different reward
or you could go a c b d there's a lot of
options here and so when we start
looking at this diagram you start to
realize
that even though today's reinforced
learning models do really good at
finding an answer they end up trying
almost all the different directions you
see
and so they take up a lot of work uh or
a lot of processing time for
reinforcement learning they're right now
in their infant stage and they're really
good at solving simple problems and
we'll take a look at one of those in
just a minute in the tic-tac-toe game
but you can see here uh once it's gone
through these and it's explored it's
going to find the a c d
is the best reward it gets a full 30
points for it
so let's go ahead and take a look at a
reinforcement learning
demo
in this demo we're going to use
reinforcement learning to make a
tic-tac-toe game you'll be playing this
game against the machine learning model
and we'll go ahead we're doing it in
python so let's go ahead and go through
i always not always actually have a lot
of python tools let's go through
anaconda which will open up a jupiter
notebook seems like a lot of steps but
it's worth it to keep all my stuff
separate and it's also has a nice
display when you're in the jupiter
notebook for doing python
so here's our anaconda navigator i open
up the notebook which is going to take
me to a webpage and i've gone in here
and created a new python folder in this
case i've already done it and enabled it
to change the name to tic-tac-toe and
then for this example
we're going to go ahead and
import a couple things we're going to
import numpy as np we'll go ahead and
import pickle numpy of course is our
number array and then pickle is just a
nice way sometimes for
storing different information different
states that we're going to go through on
here
and so
we're going to create a class called
state we're going to start with that
and there's a lot of lines of code to
this class that we're going to put in
here
don't let that scare you too much
there's not as much here
it looks like there's going to be a lie
here but there really is just a lot of
setup going on in the in our class state
and so we have up here we're going to
initialize it
we have our board
it's a tic tac toe board so we're only
dealing with nine spots on the board
we have player one player two
is end we're gonna create a board hash
uh we'll look at that in just a minute
we're just gonna store some information
in there symbol player equals one
um so there's a few things going on as
far as the initialization
uh then something simple we're just
going to get the hash
of the board you get the information
from the board on there which is
columns and rows
we want to know when a winner occurs so
if you get three in a row that's what
this whole section here is for
let me go ahead and scroll up a little
bit
and you can get a copy of this code if
you send a note over to simplylearn
we'll send you over
this particular file and you can play
with it yourself and see how it's put
together
i don't want to spend a huge amount of
time on this because this is just some
real general python coding
but you can see here we're just going
through all the rows
and you add them together and if it
equals three three in a row same thing
with columns
diagonal so you gotta check the diagonal
that's what all this stuff does here is
it just goes through the different areas
actually let me go ahead and put
there we go
and then it comes down here and we do
our sum and it says true
minus three just says did somebody win
or is it a tie
so you gotta add up all the numbers on
there anyway just in case they're all
filled up
and next we also need to know available
positions um these are ones that don't
no one's ever used before this way when
you try something or the computer tries
something uh it's not going to give it
an illegal move that's what the
available positions is doing
then we want to update our state
and so you have your position going in
we're just sending in the position that
you just chose and you'll see there's a
little user interface we put in there we
can
pick the row and column in there
and again
i mean this is a lot of code uh so
really it's kind of a thing you'd want
to go through and play with a little bit
and just read through it get a copy of
it a great way to understand how this
works
and here is a given reward
um so we're going to give a reward
result equals self winner
this is one of the hearts of what's
going on here
is we have a result self.winner
so if there's a winner then we have a
result that the result equals one here's
our feedback
uh if it doesn't equal one then it gets
a zero so it only gets a reward in this
particular case
if it wins
and that's important to know because
different
uh systems of reinforced learning
do rewarding a lot differently depending
on what you're trying to do this is a
very simple example with a
three by three board
imagine if you're playing a video game
certainly you only have so many actions
but your environment is huge you have a
lot going on in the environment and
suddenly a reward system like this
is going to be just
is going to have to change a little bit
it's going to have to have different
rewards and different setup and there's
all kinds of advanced ways to do that as
far as weighing you add weights to it
and so
they can add the weights up depending on
where the reward comes in so it might be
that you actually get a reward in this
case you get the reward at the end of
the game
and i'm spending just a little bit of
time on this because this is an
important thing to note but there's
different ways to add up those rewards
it might have like if you take a certain
path
the first reward
is going to be weighed a little bit less
than the last reward because the last
reward is actually winning the game or
scoring or whatever it is
so this reward system gets really
complicated on some of the more advanced
setups
in this case though
you can see right here that they give a
a 0.1 and a 0.5 reward
just for getting picking the right value
and something that's actually valid
instead of picking an invalid value so
rewards again that's like key it's huge
how do you
feed the rewards back in
then we have a board reset that's pretty
straightforward it just goes back and
resets the board at the beginning
because it's going to try out all these
different things while it's learning
it's going to do it by trial and error
so you have to keep resetting it
and then of course there's the play we
want to go ahead and play rounds equals
depends on what you want to do on here
you can set this
different you can obviously set that to
higher level but this is just going to
go through and you'll see in here
that we have player 1 and player 2.
this is this is the computer playing
itself
one of the more powerful ways to learn
to play a game
or even learn something that isn't a
game is to have two of these models
that are basically trying to beat each
other and so they always they keep
finding explore new things this one
works for this one so this one tries new
things
it beats this we've seen this in um
chess i think was a big one where they
had the two players in chess with
reinforcement learning uh it was one of
the ways they trained one of the top
computer chess playing algorithms
so this is just what this is it's going
to choose an action it's going to try
something and the more it try stuff
the more we're going to record the hash
we actually have a board hash where they
self get the hash
set up on here where it stores all the
information
and then once you get to a win
one of them wins it gets the reward
uh then we go back and reset and try
again and then kind of the fun part we
actually get down here is we're going to
play
with a human so we'll get a chance to
come in here and see what that looks
like
when you put your own information in
and then it just comes in here and does
the same thing it did above it gives it
a reward for its things
or sees if it wins or ties
looks at available positions all that
fun of fun stuff
and then finally we want to show the
board
so it's going to print the board out
each time
really
as an integration is not that exciting
what's exciting
uh in here is one looking at this reward
system whoops play one more up the
reward system is really the heart of
this how do you reward the different
setup and the other
one is when it's playing it's got to
take an action
and so
what it chooses for an action is also
the heart of reinforcement learning how
do we choose that action
and those are really
key to right now where reinforcement
learning is
in
today's technology is
figuring this out
how do we reward it and how do we guess
the next best action so we have our
environment and you can see the
environment is we're going to be or the
state
which is kind of like what's going on
we're going to return the state
depending on what happens
we want to go ahead and create our agent
uh in this case our player so each one
is let me go and grab that
until we look at a class player um
this is where a lot of the magic is
really going on is what how is this
player figuring out how to maneuver
around the board and then the board of
course returns a state
that it can look at and reward uh so we
want to take a look at this we have uh
name uh self-state this is class player
and when you say class player we're not
talking about a human player we're
talking about um just
the computer players
and this is kind of interesting so
remember i told you depending on what
you're doing there's going to be a decay
gamma um
explorate
these are what i'm talking about is how
do we train it
as you try different moves it gets to
the end the first move is important but
it's not as important as the last one
and so you could say that the last one
has the heaviest weight and then as you
as you get there the first one to see
the first move gives you a five reward
the second gives you a two reward and
the third one gives you a 10 reward
because that's the final ending you got
it the 10 is going to count more than
the first step
and here's our we're going to get the
board information coming in and then
choose an action this was the second
part that i was talking about that was
so important
so once you have your training going on
we have to do a little randomness and
you can see right here is our np random
uniform so it's picking out a
random number
take a random action
this is going to just pick which row and
which column it is
um and so choosing the action
this one you can see we're just doing
random states um choice length of
positions action position
and then it skips in there and takes a
look at the board uh for p in positions
it's actually storing the different
boards each time you go through
so it has a record of what it did so it
can properly weigh the values
and this simply just depends a hash
state what's the last state appended to
the
to our states on here
here's our feedback
rewards the reward comes in and it's
going to take a look at this and say is
it none
what is the reward and here is that
formula remember i was telling you about
up here
that was important because it has
decay gamma times the reward
this is where
as it goes through each step
and this is really important this is
this is kind of the heart of this of
what i was talking about earlier uh you
have step one
and this might have a reward of two
you have step two i should probably
should have done abc this has a step
three
step four
and so on until you get to step in
and this might have a reward of ten
so reward a ten
we're going to add that but we're not
adding uh let's say this one right here
let's say this reward here right before
10 was
let's say it's also 10. it just makes
the
math easy
so we had 10 and 10.
we had 10 this is 10 and 10 n whatever
it is
but it's time it's 0.9
so instead of putting a full 10 here
we only do 9 that's a
0.9
times
10.
and so this formula
as far as the decay times the reward
minus the cell state value
it basically adds in it says here's one
or here's two i'm sorry i should have
done this abc would have been easier uh
so the first move goes in here and it
puts two in here
uh then we have our self
setup on here you can see how this gets
pretty complicated in the math but this
is really the key is how do we train
our states and we want the the final
state the win to get the most points if
you win you get most points
and the first step gets the least amount
of points
so you're really training this almost in
reverse you're training you're training
it from the last place where you have
like it says okay this is now i was need
to sum up my rewards
and i want to sum them up going in
reverse and i want to find the answer in
reverse kind of an interesting
play on the mind when you're trying to
figure this stuff out
and of course we want to go ahead and
reset the board down here
save the policy
load policy
these are the different things that are
going in between the agent and the state
to figure out what's going on
let's go ahead and load that up
and then finally we want to go ahead and
create a human player
and the human player is going to be a
little different
in that
you choose an action row and column
here's your action
if action is
if action in positions meaning positions
that are available
uh you return the action
if not it just keeps asking you until
you get the action that actually works
and then we're going to go ahead and
append to the hash state which we don't
need to worry about because it returns
the action up here
and feed forward
again this is because it's a human
at the end of the game bat propagate and
update state values
this part isn't being done because
it's not programming
the model the model is getting its own
rewards
so we've gone ahead and loaded this in
here
so here's all our pieces and the first
thing we want to do
is set up p1 player 1 uh p2 player 2
and then we're going to send our players
to our state so now it has p1 p2
and it's going to play and it's going to
play 50 000 rounds
now we can probably do a lot less than
this and it's not going to get the full
results in fact you know what uh let's
go ahead and just do five
just to play with it because i want to
show you something here
oops
somewhere in there i forgot to load
something
there we go
i must have forgot to run this run
oops forgot a reference there for the
board rows and columns three by three
there is actually in the state it
references that we just tack it on on
the end it was supposed to be at the
beginning
uh so now i've only set this up
with um
let's see where we go in here i've only
set this up to train
five times
and the reason i did that is we're going
to
come in and actually play it and then
i'm going to change that and we can see
how it differs on there
there we go and then you make it through
a run and we're going to go ahead and
save the policy
so now we have our player 1 and our
player 2 policy
the way we set it up it has two separate
policies loaded up in there
and then we're going to come in here and
we're going to do player 1 is going to
be the computer experience rate 0 load
policy 1
human player human and we're going to go
ahead and play this i remember only went
through it
just one round of training in fact
minimal training and so it puts an x
there and i'm going to go ahead and do
row 0
column 1.
you can see this is very
basic on here
and
so i put in my zero and then i'm gonna
go zero block it zero
zero
and you can see right here it let me win
uh just like that i was able to win zero
two
and
whoo human wins
so i only trained it five times we're
going to run this again
and this time
instead of five let's do 5000 or 50 000
i think that's what the guys in the back
had
and this takes a while to train it
this is where reinforcement learning
really falls apart
look how simple this game is we're
talking about a three by three set of
columns
and so for me to train it on this
i could do a q table which would take
which would go much quicker
you could build a quick q table with
almost all the different options on
there
and
you would probably get a the same result
much quicker
we're just using this as an example
so when we look at reinforcement
learning you need to be very careful
what you apply it to it sounds like a
good deal until you do like a large
neural network
where you're doing you set the neural
network to a learning increment of one
so every time it goes through it learns
and then you do your actions you pick
from the learning
setup and you actually try actions on
the learning setup until you get what
you think is going to be the best action
so you actually feed what you think is
right back through the neural network
there's a whole layer there which is
really fun to play with
and then it has an output well think of
all those processes i mean that is just
a huge amount of work it's going to do
let's go ahead and skip ahead here give
it a moment it's going to take a
minute or two to go ahead and run
now to train it
we went ahead and let it run and it took
a while this just took um i got a pretty
powerful processor and it took about
five minutes plus to run it
and we'll go ahead and
run our player setup on here oops it
brought in the last
whoops abroad in the last round so give
me just a moment to re
do the policy save there we go i forgot
to save the policy back in there
and then go ahead and run our player
again
so we've saved the policy then we want
to go ahead and load the policy for p1
as the computer
and we can see the computer's gone in
the bottom right corner i'm going to go
ahead and go one one which is the center
and it's gone right up the top and if
you ever played tic tac toe you know the
computer has me but we'll go ahead and
play it out
row zero
column two
there it is and then it's gone here and
so i'm going to go ahead and go row zero
one
two
no zero one there we go and column zero
that's where i want it
oh and it says okay you your action
there we go boom
uh so you can see here we've got a
didn't catch the win on this it said tie
kind of funny they didn't catch the win
on there
but if we play this a bunch of times
you'll find it's going to win more and
more the more we train it the more the
reinforcement happens
this lengthy training process
is really the stopper on reinforcement
learning
as this changes reinforcement learning
will be one of the more powerful
packages evolving over the next decade
or two
in fact i would even go as far as to say
it is the most important
machine learning tool and artificial
intelligence tool out there
as it learns not only a simple tic tac
toe board but we start learning
environments and the environment would
be like in language if you're
translating a language or something from
one language to the other so much of it
is lost if you don't know the context
it's in what the environments it's in
and so being able to attach environment
and context and all those things
together is going to require
reinforcement learning to do
so again if you want to get a copy of
the tic tac toe board it's kind of fun
to play with uh run it you can test it
out you can do
you know test it for different uh values
you can switch from p1 computer
uh where we loaded the policy one to
load the policy two and just see how it
varies there's all kinds of things you
can do on there
welcome to q learning
my name is richard kirschner with the
simply learn team
www.simplylearn.com get certified get
ahead
what's in it for you today an
introduction to reinforcement learning
what is q learning some important terms
bellman equation steps in q learning a
quick
recap so we're going to go back and do a
reinforcement learning recap and you'll
remember we have our agent our action
our environment and our reward
and the state
and so reinforcement learning is a
branch of machine learning that trains a
model to come to an optimum solution for
a problem
by taking decisions by itself
so we look at it we analyze the data
make decisions solve problems
it consists of an environment
which an agent will interact with to
learn to reach a goal or perform an
action
you see here we have the dog
and the action equals fetching
and the first thing
you're going to notice here and i'll
talk a little bit more about this
is that our action is kind of a
singularity
the action isn't a regression type model
where we're looking at float numbers
or we're trying to predict something
or doing a reinforcement learning where
we're trying to guess the value of the
stock market where you have
5.33 5.33
this is very a little bit different and
you'll see why q learning is so powerful
but also where it falls short
the agent is also given reward if the
action performed by it is bringing is
closer to the goal is leading to the
goal this is done to train the model in
the right direction you have a reward of
a hopefully a doggy cookie and action
equals fetching so it gets a reward it
gets to go fetch the ball
reinforcement learning can be divided
based on whether the machine uses a
model to learn or learns by itself
so reinforcement learning it's model
based learn the model given model
and you can think of neural networks i
think are the most common right now used
for reinforcement learning there
certainly are a lot of other options out
there
but you have
this black box and you go back and you
send the error back up and it trains it
based on how much of an error the error
could be computed based on maybe a
maximum reward
subtraction or something like that so
the closer you get to uh the maximum
reward the better
and so we talk about a model free
you have your policy optimization and
your q learning
and
this is kind of the cool thing about q
learning is it can do it's very powerful
on on certain things making it very
quick and easy to do a reinforcement
learning so what is q learning q
learning is reinforcement learning
policy which will fill the next best
action given a current state it chooses
this action at random and aims to
maximize the reward
and so you can see here's our standard
reinforcement learning graph
by now if you're doing any reinforcement
learning
you should
be familiar with this where you have
your agent your agent takes an action
the action affects the environment
and then the environment sends back the
reward or the feedback and the state
it's the new state the agent's in where
is it at on the chess board where is it
at in the video game
if your robot's out there picking trash
up off the side of the road where is it
at on the road
consider an ad recommendation system
usually when you look up a product
online
you get ads which will suggest the same
product over and over again
using q learning
we can make an ad recommendation system
which will suggest related products to
our previous purchase
the reward will be if user clicks on the
suggested product
and again you can see
you might have a lot of products on your
web advertisement or your pages but it's
still not a float number it's still a
set number and that's something to be
aware of when you're using q learning
and you can see here that if you have a
hundred people clicking on ads
and you click on one of the ads it might
go in there and say okay this person
clicked on this ad
what is the best set of ads based on
clicking on this ad or these two ads
afterwards based on where they are
browsing
so let's go ahead and look at some
important terms when we talk about cue
learning we have states the state s
represents the current position of an
agent in an environment
the action the action a is the step
taken by the agent when it is particular
state
rewards for every action the agent will
get a positive or negative reward
and again uh when we talk about states
we're usually not with when you're using
a q table you're not usually talking
about float variables you're talking
about true false
and we'll take a closer look at that in
a second
and episodes when an agent ends up in a
terminating state and can't take a new
action
this might be if you're playing a video
game your character stepped in and is
now dead or whatever
q values used to determine how good an
action a taken at a particular state s
is q a of s
and temporal difference a formula used
to find the q value by using the value
of the current state and action and
previous state in action
and various i mean there's bellman's
equation which basically is the equation
that
kind of covers what we just looked at in
all those different terms
the bellman equation is used to
determine the values of a particular
state and deduce how good it is to be
and take that state the optimal st the
optimal state will give us the highest
optimal value
factor influencing q values the current
state and action that's your sa so your
current state and your action
then you have your previous date in
action which is your s
i guess prime i'm not sure how they
reference that s prime a prime so this
is what happened before
uh then you have a reward for action so
you have your r reward
and you have your maximum expected
future reward
and you can see there's also a learning
rate put in there and a discount rate
so we're looking at these just like any
other model we don't want to have an
absolute
final value on here we don't want to if
you do absolute values instead of taking
smaller steps
you don't really have that approach to
the solution you just have a jump and
then pretty soon if you jump one
solution out that's what's going to be
the new solution whichever one jumps up
really high first
um kind of ruining the whole idea of
doing a random selection i'll i'll go
into the random selection in just a
second steps in q learning
step one create an initial q table with
all values initialized to zero
again we're looking at
zero one uh so are you you know here's
our action we start we're an idle we
took a wrong action we took a correct
action and int
and then we have our actions fetching
sitting and running
of course we're just using the dog
example and choose an action and perform
it update values in the table and of
course when we're choosing an action
we're going to kind of do something
random and just randomly pick one so you
start out and you sit and you have then
then depending on that
action you took you can now update the
value for sitting after you start from
start to sitting
get the value of the reward and
calculate the value the value q value
using the bellman equation
and so now we attach a reward to sitting
and we attach all those rewards we
continue the same until the table is
filled with or an episode ends
and you and my machine is going to come
back to the random side of this and
there's a few different formulas i use
for the random
setup to pick it i usually look whatever
q model i'm using do their standard one
because someone's usually gone in and
done the math
for the optimal
spread
but you can look at this if i have
running has a reward of 10 sitting as a
reward is seven fetching has a reroll or
a five
um
just kind of without doing like a a
means to you know using the bell curve
for the means value and like i said
there's some math you can put in there
to pick so that you're more like so that
running has even a higher chance
but even if you're just going to do an
average on this
you could do an average a random number
by adding them all together
so you get 10 plus 7 plus 5 is
22 you could do 0 to 22 or 0-21 but 1-22
1-5 would be fetching uh and so forth
you know the last 10.
so you can just look at this as what
percentage are you going to go for that
particular option
and then that gets your random setup in
there and then as you slowly increment
these up
uh you see that
if you're idle
where's one here we go sitting at the
end
if you're at the end of wherever you're
at sitting gets a reward of one
um where's the good one on here oh wrong
action running for a wrong action gets
almost no reward so that becomes very
very less likely to happen
but it still might happen it still might
have a percentage of coming up and
that's where the random programming and
q learning comes in the below table
gives us an idea action has been taken
in how positively correct action or
negatively wrong action it is going to
affect the next state
so let's go ahead and dive in and pull
up a little piece of code and see what
this looks like
[Music]
in python
in this demo we'll use q learning to
find the shortest path between two given
points
if getting your learning started is half
the battle what if you could do that for
free visit skill up by simply learn
click on the link in the description to
know more
if you've seen my videos before
i like to do it in the
anaconda jupiter notebook
setup just because it's really easy to
see and it's a nice demo
and so here's my anaconda this one i'm
actually using
python36 environment that i set up in
here
and we'll go ahead and launch the
jupiter notebook on this
and once we're in our jupiter notebook
which has the kernel loaded with python3
we'll go ahead and create a new python 3
folder in here
and we'll call this
q
learning
and to start this demo
let's go ahead and import our numpy
array we'll just run that so it's
imported
and like a lot of these uh model
programs when you're building them you
spend a lot of time putting it all
together
um
and then you end up with this really
short answer at the end
and we'll we'll take a look at that as
we come into it so we go ahead and start
with our location to state uh so we have
l1 l2 these are our nine locations one
to nine
and then of course the state is going to
be zero one two three four it's just a
mapping of our location to a integer on
there
and then we have our actions our actions
are simply uh moving from
one location
to another so i can go to i can go to
location zero i can go to location one
two three four five six seven eight
so these are my actions i can choose
these are the locations of our state
and if you remember earlier i mentioned
that the limitation is that you you
don't want to put in
a continually growing table because you
can actually create a dynamic q table
where you continually add in new values
as they arise
because
if you have float values this just
becomes infinite and then you're
remembering your computer's gone or you
know does it's not going to work
at the same time you might think well
that kind of really limits the the q uh
learning setup
but there are ways to use it in
conjunction with other systems
and so you might look at
well i do
i've been doing some work in stock
and one of the questions that comes out
is to buy or sell the stock
and the state coming in
might be
you might take a concrete we call
buckets
where anything that you predict is going
to return more than a certain amount of
money
the error for that stock that you've had
in the past you put those in buckets and
suddenly you start putting creating
these buckets you realize you do have a
limited amount of information coming in
you no longer have a float number you
now have
bucket one two three and four
and then you can take those buckets
put them through a q learning table
and come up with the best action which
stock should i buy it's like gambling
stock is pretty much gambling if you're
doing day trading you're not doing long
term
investments and so you can start looking
at it like that a lot of the
current fees say that the best
algorithms used for day traders redoing
it on your own
is really to ask the question do i want
to trade the stock yes or no and now you
have it in a q learning table and now
you can take it to that next level and
you can see where that can be a really
powerful tool at the end of doing a
basic linear regression model or
something
what is the best investment and you
start getting the best reward on there
and the so if we're going to have
rewards these rewards we just create
it says if basically if you're uh this
should match our q table because it's
going to be
you have your state and you have your
action across the top if you remember
from the dog
and so we have whatever state we're in
going down and then the next action and
what the reward is for it
and of course if you were actually doing
a
something more connected your reward
would be based on
the actual environment it's in
and then we want to go ahead and create
a state to location
so we can map the indexes
so just like we defined our rewards
we're going to go and do state to
location
and you can see here it's a dictionary
set up for location state and location
to state with items and
we also need to
define what we want for learning rates
you remember
we had our two different rates
as far as like learning from the past
and learning from the current so we'll
go ahead and set those to
0.75 and the alpha set to 0.9
and we'll see that when we do the
formula
and of course any of this code send a
note to our simply learn team they'll
get you a copy of this code
on here let's go ahead and pull
there we go
the next two sections
since we're going to keep it short and
sweet
here we go so let's go ahead and create
our agent um so our agent
is going to have our initialization
where we send it all the information uh
we'll define ourself gamma equals gamma
we could have just set the gamma rate
down here instead of submitting it
it's kind of nice to keep them separate
because you can play with these numbers
on our self alpha
then we have our location state we'll
set that in here we have our choice of
actions
we're going to go ahead and just embed
the rewards right into the agent
so obviously this would be coming from
somewhere else
instead of from
self-generated and then a self state to
location equals our state to location
dictionary
and we go ahead and create a q learning
table and i went ahead and just set the
q learning table up to
zero to zero what what what the setup is
location to state how many of them are
there
and this just creates an array of zero
to zero set up on there
and then the big part is the training we
have our rewards new equals a copy of
self.rewards
ending state equals the self-location
state in location so this is whatever we
end up at rewards new equals ending
state plus ending state equals 999. just
kind of goes
to a dead end
and
we start going through iterations
and we'll go ahead let's do this
uh so this we're going to come back and
we're going to call call it on here let
me just erase that
switch it to an arrow
there we go
so what we're doing is we're going to
send in here to train it we're going to
say hey
i want to iterate through this a
thousand times
and see what happens now this part would
actually be
instead of iterating you might have your
external environment and they're going
back and forth and you iterate through
outside of here
but just for ease of use our agent is
going to come in here and iterate
through this
sometimes i'll put this iteration in
here
and i'll have it call the environment
and say hey this is what i did what's
the next state and the environment does
this thing right in here as i iterate
through it
and then we want to go ahead and pick a
random state to start with
that's what's going on here you have to
start somewhere
and then you have your playable actions
we're going to start with just an empty
thing for playable actions and we'll
fill that up
so that's what choices i have
and so we're going to iterate through
the rewards matrix to get the states
directly reachable from the randomly
chosen current state assign those states
to a list named playable actions
and so you can see here we have range
nine i usually use length of whatever
i'm looking at which is our locations
or states as they are
we have a reward so we want to look at
the current the rewards uh the new
reward
is our
is in our chart here of rewards
underscore new uh current state
um
plus j
j being what is the next date we want to
try
and so we go ahead and do our playable
actions and we append j
and so we're doing is we're randomly
trying different things in here to see
what's going to generate a better
reward and then of course we go ahead
and choose our next state
so we have our random choice playable
actions
and if you remember
i mentioned on this let me just go ahead
and let's do a free form
when we were talking about the next
state
this right here just does a random
selection
instead of a random
you might do something where
whatever the best selection is
which might be option three
here and then so you can see that it
might use a bell curve and then option
two over here might have a bell curve
like this oops
and we start looking at these averages
and these spreads
or we can just add them all together and
pick the one that kind of goes in all of
those
so those are some of the options we have
in here we just go with a random choice
that's usually where you start play with
it
um and then we have our
reward section down here
and so we want to go ahead and find well
in this case the temporal difference
uh so you have your rewards new
plus the self gamma and this is the
formula we were looking at
this is bellman's equation here
so we have our current value our
learning rate our discount rate involved
in there the reward system coming in for
that
and we can add it all together
this is of course our
maximum expected future setup in here
so this is all of our our bellman's
equation that we're looking at here
and then we come up in here and we
update our q table that's all this is on
this one
and that's right here we have
self-cue current state next date and we
add in our alpha because we don't want
to we don't want to train all of it at
once in case there's slight differences
coming in there we want to slowly
approach the answer and then we have our
route equals the start location
and next location equals start location
so we're just incrementing we took a
step forward
and then finally
remember i was telling you how we're
going to do all this and just have some
simple thing at the end or just
generates a simple path
we're going to go ahead and and get the
optimal route we want to find the best
route in here
and so we've created a definition for
the optimal route down here
scroll down for that
and we get the optimal route we go ahead
and put the information in including the
q table self
uh start location in location next
location route queue and it says while
next location is not equal to in
location so while we can still go
our start location equals self location
to state start location so we already
have our best value for the start
location
uh the next state looks at the q table
and says hey what's uh the next one with
the best value and then the next
location we go ahead and pull that in
and we just append it that's what's
going on down here
and then our start location equals the
next location and we just go through all
the steps and we'll go ahead and run
this and now that we have our q table
our
q agent loaded
we're going to go ahead and take our q
agent
load them up with our alpha gamma that
we set up above
along with the location step action
reward state to location
and
uh our goal is to
plot a course between l9 and l1
and we're going to go through a hundred
a thousand iterations on here and so
when i run that it runs pretty quick
uh why is this so fast um
if you've been running neural networks
and you've been doing all these other
models you sit here and wait a long time
well we're very small amount of data
these are all integers these aren't
float values there's not a the math is
not heavy on the on the processing end
and this is where cue tables are so
powerful if you have a small amount of
information coming in you very quickly
get an answer off of this even though we
went through it a thousand times to
train it and you'll see here we have l
nine eight five two and one and that's
based on our reward table we had set up
on there and this is the shortest path
going between these different uh setups
in here
and if you remember on our reward table
you can see that if you start here you
can go to here there's places you can't
go that's how this reward table was set
up so i can only go to certain places
so kind of a little maze set up in there
and you can play with it this is really
fun
set up to play with
and you can see how you can take this
whole code and you can like i was saying
earlier you can embed it into another
setup and model and predictions where
you put things into buckets and you're
trying to guess the best investment the
best course of action
long as you can take that course of
action and
reduce it down to a yes no
or if you're using text
you can use a one hot encoder which word
is next there's all kinds of things you
can do with a cue table
depending on just how much information
you're putting in there
so that wraps up our demo in this demo
we've found the shortest distance
between two paths based on whatever
rules or state rewards we have to get
from point a to point b and what
available actions there are
hi everyone welcome to this exciting
session by simplyloan today we have a
really interesting topic for you
in this video we'll be analyzing the
upcoming united states presidential
election using twitter sentiment
analysis in python
in the course of this session
we will understand in brief about the
upcoming election the candidates
fighting the 2020 u.s election and throw
light on the result of the 2016 u.s
election
we look at the election forecast by some
of the popular news agencies
as well as poll analysis websites such
as 538
before we begin
i want to make it clear that this video
is solely for learning purposes
we had simply learned do not lean
towards any party in the united states
or are buyers towards any candidate the
analysis is based on what people have
tweeted and we will understand the mood
and sentiment of the public
the main objective of this video is to
help you understand how to extract
tweets from twitter handles using python
libraries
store it in a csv file and perform
textual analysis
the results obtained are purely based on
the data that we have collected
let's begin
the battle for the 2020 u.s presidential
election has begun with the 59th united
states presidential election scheduled
to be held on the 3rd of november 2020
this will decide who will be in the
white house for the next 4 years
all 435 seats in the united states house
of representatives 35 of 100 seats in
the united states senate and office of
the president of the united states will
be contested
both the republican party and the
democratic party have nominated their
respective president and vice
presidential candidates
the incumbent president donald trump is
the republican nominee
while the 47th vice president of the
united states joe biden is the
democratic party's nominee
the current vice president mike pence is
the republican party's vice presidential
nominee and is running for a second term
in office
senator kamala harris of california was
chosen by joe biden as his running mate
on 11th of august 2020.
now
let's see the results of the last u.s
presidential election in
2016. the republican ticket of
businessman donald trump and indiana
governor mike pence had defeated the
democratic ticket of former secretary of
state hillary clinton and u.s senator
from virginia tim kaine
donald trump received a total of 304
electoral votes while hillary clinton
got 227 electoral votes
a significant number of central states
in the united states were swept by the
republican party
it was surprising to see that donald
trump getting nearly 46.4 popular vote
as compared to hillary clinton who got
48.5 votes
donald trump's victory came after
crucial wins in the battleground streets
of florida ohio iowa north carolina and
pennsylvania
will donald trump be re-elected to the
white house or are we going to see a new
president and vice president of the
united states is the big question
let's see what our pollsters have to say
and what has been their forecast for the
upcoming election
according to 538
donald trump has not gained ground since
the final debate on 22nd of october
at this moment joe biden is favored to
win the election and he leads in both
national and state pools
the economist is analyzing polling
economic and demographic data to predict
the u.s elections
their model thinks joe biden is very
likely to beat donald trump in the
electoral college as per their forecast
joe biden has 96 percent chance of
winning the electoral college and this
99 percent chance of biden winning the
most votes the democrats have 75 chance
of controlling the senate while the
republicans have around 25 percent
the democrats are highly likely to keep
their majority in the house of
representatives now according to the
guardian
joe biden is leading donald trump in the
national polls for the presidential
election
but to keep in mind this does not
guarantee the democratic candidate joe
biden's victory
hillary clinton also had a clear lead
over donald trump in the polls for
almost the entire 2016 campaign she
ended up losing the electoral college
now the bbc forecast tells that biden is
leading national presidential polls with
51 percent
he has hovered around 50 in recent
months and has had a 10 point lead on
occasions
so clearly joe biden is set to be the
next u.s president
let's wait and watch what happens on the
3rd of november
the voters of america will decide on 3rd
of november whether donald trump remains
in the white house for another 4 years
let's perform a twitter sentiment
analysis to understand the sentiments of
people tweeting about donald trump and
joe biden by tagging them in their
tweets
we have our code implemented already
i'll run through each line of code and
explain our analysis in detail the
objective is to check the polarity of
each tweet to figure out if it's
positive negative or neutral we'll
compare the tweets of donald trump and
joe biden to see who people are favoring
the most
finally we learn to create a word cloud
i have already extracted the tweets and
stored them in two separate csv files
it takes some time to fetch 10 000
tweets hence it won't be possible for me
to show it to you live
if you want to know how we extracted the
tweets for donald trump and joe biden
then please put your email id in the
comments section of the video we'll
share the code file and the source file
with you
now you would need to install the tweep
library fetch the twitter keys and
access tokens and then authenticate the
twitter api
i have extracted 5000 tweets each for
donald trump and joe biden converted
into a data frame and stored it in a csv
file
so let me open and show you both the
files
so here is my data set for donald trump
on the top you can see trump underscore
data 5000 which means there are 5000
tweets here
the first column
has the number of tweets it starts from
zero and goes all the way to 4999
the next column
is the text column which has the content
of the tweet
you can see
they have tagged at the rate real donald
trump
there are links as well there are
special characters like emoticons
and the third column is the user
which means
it's the username
who had put that tweet
similarly
i have another data for biden you can
see these are
for joe biden
and here you can see the content they
have tagged kamala harris also
similarly we have the username
now let me take you straight to my
jupyter notebook where i have
implemented the code
okay so first and foremost let's import
all the required libraries so we have
the numpy library for numerical
computation then we have the pandas
library for data manipulation next we
are importing two libraries matplotlib
and c bond for data visualization
then we have
text blob and word cloud
to get the sentiment and to build the
word cloud
and finally we are importing the plotly
library for creating graphs
let me run this cell
in the current cell we'll import the
data sets using read underscore csv
function present in the pandas library
so i have passed in my
location where the data file is so i
have placed it on my desktop
and
the index underscore col parameter or
column parameter refers to the columns
to be used as the row labels of the data
frame here 0 indicates that the first
column will be used
as row labels
let me run it
ok now we have imported both the data
files
let me go ahead and
print the shape of one of the data
frames
so i'll write print
let's say we'll check the shape of
biden data frame so i'll write print
biden dot shape
i'll hit shift enter
you can see there are 5000 rows and
there are two columns one is the text
column and the next column is the user
column
now let me
go ahead and print the head of the data
sets
so the head function will return the
first five rows
i'll write
trump
dot head
you can see these are the first
five rows from the trump
data frame and similarly if you want to
check for biden i can write biden dot
head
you can see it here
now you can also use the info method
so let me
show you that you can write drum dot
info
and this is the result so it tells there
are 5000 entries from 0 to 4999
there are two columns
these are the number of
rows
and similarly you have the data types
okay
moving ahead in the next cell i am
displaying the 200th tweet present in
the trump data frame so i have my data
frame name mentioned then i have my text
column
and inside one more square bracket i
have put 200 which means i want to see
what's there in the
200th row
if i hit enter
so you can see this was the tweet fake
fake president
next
let me show you
the tweet number 1000 for biden so i'll
write
biden
and inside square brackets i'll give the
text column
and
the number is 1000
if i hit shift enter
so this is the tweet
now
the text blob function
is used in natural language processing
the sentiment property returns a named
tuple in the form of sentiment
in brackets polarity and subjectivity
let's check the sentiment of the 200th
tweet made for donald trump
if i hit shift enter
you can see this was the polarity
now minus 0.39
means
the polarity was negative and you can
see the subjectivity is around
0.933
similarly
let's check for biden's tweet number
so i'll write
text
blob which is my function name
and inside
brackets i'll give biden
then
pass in my column name that is text and
i'll give the row number which is 1000
and then i'll give the
parameter
or the attribute sentiment
if i hit shift enter you can see the
polarity and the subjectivity
now moving ahead
here
i have defined a function that will add
another column called polarity to our
two data frames trump and biden
let me run this
okay
in the next cell
i have used the apply function that will
return the polarity based on the tweets
you can see we have the apply function
this might take some time to run it okay
we are done now
let me now display the top five rows of
the data frame
so
what i'll do is i'll click on this cell
go to insert and i'll hit
insert cell below
let's do one more
okay now here
i'll display the head of the data frame
once again so that you can see the
polarity column added
you can see it here
so for donald trump
we have the polarity you can see the
tweet and the polarity
now 0.0 which means these are neutral
minus is negative and anything that's in
positive value
indicates it's a
positive tweet or it has positive
polarity
similarly let's see for biden
i'll write biden.head
okay so here you can see the
polarity for biden
now this point five means it's a
positive tweet
okay
now
i want to create another column called
expression where we will classify the
tweets as positive negative or neutral
based on the polarity value
so i have used the np dot where function
and the condition we have here is
if polarity is greater than 0 it's a
positive tweet else if it is less than 0
it's a negative to it and if the
polarity is equal to 0 it means it's a
neutral tweet
let me run this
okay
so here you can see we have the column
called expression and it has classified
the polarity based on negative
neutral
as well as positive
similarly let's do the same for biden
data frame as well
okay
before moving ahead if you want to get
access to the source code and the data
sets we have used in this demo then
please put your email address in the
chat section
we'll send it to you via mail
also please subscribe to simply learn
channel and hit the bell icon to never
miss an update from simply loan
in the next cell of code
we have another function that will
basically help us creating a bar plot
based on the expression column from both
the data frames
so this is my user defined function name
and it has two parameters reviews and
title
you can see we have
grouped the expression column and found
out the count using the count function
then we have created or converted it
into a list
similarly
below you can see here we have defined
the
color for the bars using rgb values
now let me run it
okay
so we have successfully created our user
defined function
now let me go ahead and call the
function and pass in my two parameters
reviews and title so here we have the
function name
and
under reviews we have the data frame
name trump and the title we have given
is analysis for trump
let me run this
okay
so you can see we have a horizontal
bar plot on the top you can see the
title of the plot which is analysis for
trump
and as per the tweets it has classified
as positive neutral or negative
if i hover over you can see there were
2831 neutral tweets
1211 positive tweets and similarly there
were
958 negative tweets for donald trump
now
let me call that function once again so
i'll write exp underscore graph
which is my function name
then i'll pass in my
parameters this time i'll take biden and
the title i'll put is
analysis
for
biden
if i run it
okay
you can see the plot for biden now
if i hover over
there were 1290 positive tweets for
biden
and
747 negative tweets
okay
let's
scroll down
now let me check the number of rows that
have polarity equal to zero
the number of rows that have polarity
less than zero and greater than zero for
both the data frames using the
dot shape attribute
so first we have
for trump now equal to equal to zero
means
we are checking the total number of
neutral tweets
you can see the result
now let's check for biden we have the
result below
let me run it
okay
now
we'll drop those columns that have a
polarity equal to zero from both the
data frames and display the shape you
can see
we have the condition mentioned
and we have also used the drop function
so all the neutral tweets will be
deleted
and i am printing the shape of the data
frame
there you go
so out of the 5000 tweet it has deleted
all the neutral tweets or dropped all
the neutral treats and this is the final
result
in the current cell
we have defined another function called
balanced underscore data
now this will help us get an equal
number of rows and columns and delete a
specified number of rows
let me run it
all right
now
i'll call that function to delete 169
rows from the trump's data frame and 37
rows from biden's data frame this will
help us subset the data frames
you can see
we have now
2000 tweets from each of the data frames
up next we'll create some visualizations
to analyze the textual data
so first i'm using the c-bond library
and creating
a distribution plot for donald trump
if i hit shift enter
you can see this is the distribution
plot thus
there are bars at the back and there is
a trend line
okay
similarly let me now create a box plot
so this is
a box plot here you can see there are
some outliers now let me add
a few cells below so that i can show
that plot for biden
so i'll write sns
dot
i'll use the function
dist plot
and under this plot i'll give
biden underscore
subset
and
i'll pass in my column that is polarity
let me run it
so this is the distribution plot for joe
biden
and now
let me also create the box plot so i'll
use the
c bond library and the box plot function
i'll pass in my data frame which is
biden underscore subset
and i'll give my column name that is
polarity
i'll run it
so here you can see the box plot for joe
biden
let me tell you how you can create a
cross table using the group by function
so before coming to this cell of code
let me insert cell above
okay
now using group by function you can
create a cross table
so i'll use
the trump underscore subset data frame
and
then i'll give my group by function
and inside group by function i'll give
my expression column
and i'll
count the number of expressions
if i run this
you can see this is a cross table
similarly you can do it for
joe biden as well
i'll just replace the
names i'll write biden
and the rest is the same
you can see
this is the cross table for biden
underscore subset
now moving ahead
let's find the polarity percentage for
negative and positive tweets
to do this i have defined a function
called
poll underscore percent
and we have two parameters declared
subset and total
let me run this
okay
now here
i am calling the above defined function
and printing the polarity percentage for
biden and trump
and i have mentioned my two parameters
subset
and the total number
so these are the values moving ahead
now let's create a bar graph that will
show the negative and positive polarity
percentage for donald trump and joe
biden
let me hit shift enter
you can see we have a
really good bar graph now if i hover the
mouse cursor you can see
donald trump had 27.825
percent of positive tweets
and
22.17 negative
similarly joe biden had
31.6 positive tweets
and
18.4 negative tweets
now we want to find the public sentiment
based on trump and biden tweets
let me run this two cells first
okay
now for donald trump the total positive
polarity is a combination of trump's
total positive percentage and biden's
negative percentage
similarly
for joe biden the total positive
polarity is a combination of guidance
total positive percentage and
trump's negative percentage
let me run this
you can see the result here
next
let's plot a horizontal bar graph to
visualize the public sentiment
we have our x and y labels defined
we also have set our bar colors with the
help of rgb values
and we have the title as well
now if i go up you can see this is the
public sentiment
so
26.88
is the percentage that is in favor of
joe biden and for donald trump you have
23.11
now coming down
now in the next cell of code
we have a user defined function that
will basically plot a table which has
the most positive tweets for donald
trump and joe biden
the condition we are checking is that
the polarity should be equal to one
so if it's close to one or equal to one
which means
the tweet has positive polarity
let me run it
okay now let me go ahead and call the
function now
let me scroll over to the top
you can see
these are the top five positive tweets
for donald trump
and
here you can see the top five positive
tweets for joe biden
likewise
let's check the polarity for most
negative tweets here the condition will
be the polarity should be
equal to -1 which means it's highly
negative
let me run it
okay
now
let's go ahead and call the function
negative tweets so i'll write n e g
underscore
tweets
and then inside bracket i'll give my
parameters
which is trump underscore subset
and then
i'll give my title as
negative
tweets
for
donald trump
okay
now
let's copy this
we'll also check for joe biden so i'll
just replace this with
biden
and let's say
negative to it for
joe biden
let's run it
okay
if i go on top here you can see
the top
negative tweets for donald trump and
similarly we have the
top five negative tweets for
joe biden
all right
finally
let's see how to create a word cloud
now word cloud is a method to show which
words are most frequently occurring
among the given text
i have defined a function called
word cloud you can see here and it has
two parameters data and title
inside
the built-in function or the word cloud
function we have
mentioned the max font size
the maximum words
scale value there's also background
color which is white
okay
let's run it
now this will create
a word cloud
so let me go ahead and
call the word cloud function and pass in
the arguments
so i'll write
word cloud which is my user defined
function
and i'll give my parameters
trump underscore subset
comma i'll give my title as
word
cloud
for
donald trump
let's see donald trump tweet
replies
okay
similarly
let's
do it for
joe biden
write word cloud
biden underscore subset
and then i'll give the title as
word
cloud
for
joe biden
to it
replies
okay
let me run it
there you go
you can see we have a nice
word cloud
so on the top you can see the title
which says word cloud for donald trump
tweet replies
so here you can see
some of the words like real donald trump
then there's
president love
write
all these
similarly if i scroll down you can see
the word cloud for joe biden tweet
replies you can see there's the handle
joe biden
falls there are some
other words like do taxes believe even
will
it's fact
and you can see kamala had his name here
okay now that brings us to the end of
this demo on twitter sentiment analysis
using text data
you learnt how to classify tweets and
find the polarity
we also looked at how to create
interesting visualizations
with this data and understood the mood
of the public
finally you saw how to create a word
cloud that had the most frequently
occurring words in the tweets who is a
data science engineer are you a data
science engineer or are you going to be
looking for a different field what
exactly is a data science engineer well
a data science engineer is someone who
has programming experience in python and
r expert level knowledge ability to
write proficient codes and they we have
python and our i'm going to say python
or r once you become really proficient
at one language transferring those
skills into another one is usually
fairly easy now r is a little different
because it is an analytics platform so
going from python to r if you already
know the data analytics in python moving
to r is pretty easy now r doesn't have
all the other code that you can access
with python there's so many things you
can do with python that are not data
analytics so it's important to keep in
mind that you should probably be pretty
well-rounded in python and really have a
solid foundation in r or have a solid
foundation in r and be well-rounded in
another programming language where you
really get the programming side of it
strong sql and big data experience so
you have to have a strong coding skill
with hands-on big data experience and of
course we're showing sql here most
commonly used whether you're using a
microsoft sql server or mysql server you
can also start thinking hadoop and spark
in big data access hadoop file system is
not a huge jump if you've already
learned your sql and you've already
learned your basics and coding hadoop
sits on top of all that and does a
wonderful job creating huge clusters of
data but you really need to know your
sql because that is so common in most of
the large companies now accessing their
data and an ability to visualize models
and troubleshoot code of the models this
is a kind of an interesting one because
these models are can get very
complicated so you gotta be able to
break them down into something that you
can put the pieces together and digest
each of the pieces so being able to
visualize these models is very important
and then being able to drill down and
troubleshoot the different models or the
pieces in those models you need to be a
versatile problem solver equipped with
strong analytical and quantitative
skills a self-starter with a strong
sense of personal responsibility and
technical orientation this is an
interesting one because when you talk
about data science engineer it's such a
new field that most companies don't have
it well defined they don't know what
they're looking for you might not even
know what you're looking for you might
have an idea and you're looking for
patterns but where do those patterns
lead you so you really need that
self-starter side to jump in there and
figure out where to go and be able to
communicate that back to the team and
there we go we have a strong product
intuition data analysis skills and
business presentation skills and this is
what's talking about is you gotta bring
that back to the team so if you don't
have a strong product intuition if you
don't know what's going on with the
company what they need and where you're
going with your analysis it's going to
be a dead end and you got to be able to
present that to the shareholders to your
co-workers which leads us to great
teammate with excellent interpersonal
skills and this is kind of a strange one
because you spend so much time behind
your desk so you have to be able to kind
of float between you're studying all the
data and being able to explain this to
people in simple terms that they can
understand no one wants somebody to come
up and say yeah the p score on the f
score is this that and the other thing
and you might have two people in the
room understand you you have to be able
to sit down and explain what that means
and why so let's take a look at the data
science skill set we talk about data
science engineer skill set we're talking
about database knowledge statistics
programming tools data wrangling
probably the least favorite and most
used machine learning data visualization
and then the touch on big data and so
we'll start with database knowledge
the most common database is of course
your sql structured query language
think rows and columns it's an essential
language for extracting a large amount
of data from data sets so knowledge of
the sql is mandatory for data science
engineers and you can see there's tools
required there's the oracle database i
mentioned my sql server microsoft sql
server teradata there are so many
different forms of sql and it'll just
keep coming back and coming back so if
you don't have a solid basic
understanding of sql go get it very
important because it will come up you
know it's if you don't know it it's
gonna bite you and statistics of course
we are you know that's what this is all
about is figuring out and predicting
things so you need to know your
statistics statistics is a subset of
mathematics that deals with collecting
analyzing and interpreting data
therefore data scientist needs to know
statistics so you need to understand
your probabilities and what that means
and what the p-score means in the
f-score and means and mode and median
all that information standard deviation
all of those you need to be aware of and
then we get into the programming tools
and i mentioned this earlier a little
bit but you need to master any one of
these specific programming languages
programming tools such as r python sas
are essential to perform analytics in
data and again you know you can move in
there and you can be an expert in just r
you can be an expert in just sas and a
little bit you can be an expert in
python because
most of these when we're talking about
data science and data wrangling you
really kind of get down to the point
where you really need to have a full
programming language at least the basics
and if you're going to be working in
data science python right now is the
main one but you know there's also java
c plus plus so you need to know a solid
language at least the basics of it so
you can understand how to do basic
iterations and things like that i always
found that interesting that uh my sister
who runs a university data analytics
center that's the first question she
asks her people candidates to come and
work for is how do you iterate through
data you'd be amazed at how many people
don't understand that very basic concept
in programming so when we look at r r is
a free software environment for
statistical computing and graphs
supports most machine learning
algorithms for data analytics like
regression association clustering and
etc python python is an open source
general purpose programming language and
there's our general purpose i was just
talking about you need to know a little
bit about python libraries like numpy
and scipy are used in data science scipy
yeah numpy and scipy are very central to
python and i'd throw pandas in there
also that module those are very central
to working with python and data
analytics and then sas sas can mine
alter manage and retrieve data from a
variety of sources it can perform
statistical analysis on the data so
where r is the open source platform sas
is more like the paid for platform and
so it has some things more automated
because people are paying for it
developing it but it's also if you
really start using it as a company
you're going to have to pay for it where
rs freestore is a free software python
is also open source and free to use so
we're going to talk a little bit about
data wrangling and i mentioned earlier
that is both the probably people's least
favorite
aspects of data science and also
probably one of the places you spend the
most time so we talk about data
wrangling it is a process of
transforming raw data into an
appropriate format to make it useful for
analytics and it involves cleaning raw
data structuring raw data and enriching
raw data and this gets interesting
because you'll get stuck on something
like
in python you might get stuck on
something that is a date time based on
an integer 64 numpy set you might not
know what all those terms mean because
you work in r or something like that but
you get the point that it's all one
particular format and then you have to
figure out how to switch it so that the
computer can see it correctly in
whatever format you're using or whatever
analytics platform you're using
knowledge of machine learning techniques
such as supervised machine learning
decision trees linear regression knn etc
is useful for few job roles so this is
kind of interesting because sometimes
that's the center of the job role of a
data scientist and sometimes you just
have to be able to apply the programming
skills to it so you can get the answer
and let somebody else fine-tune your
machine learning techniques so really
depends on what it is you're working
with and you can see here we have our
nearest neighbor set up where it groups
things together that look alike linear
regression you're drawing a line through
the data or curve so you can predict
what the next value is going to be and
then our nice decision tree would start
splitting things up and says you know
it's sunny out yes let's go swimming uh
no it's raining we're not going to go
swimming yes it's sunny out we might go
swim it's raining uh we'll stay indoors
yes we'll walk the dog no so you have a
decision tree that helps figure out how
you get to the end result so decision
trees can be pretty powerful and data
visualization data visualization is the
study and creation of visual
representation of data data
visualization uses algorithms
statistical graphs
plots information graphics and other
tools to communicate information clearly
and effectively this one you really have
to master as a data science this one you
really have to master as a data
scientist and there certainly are so
many different tools to use to visualize
it but when you're communicating a
picture is worth a thousand words when
you can put a picture up and and people
can look at and go oh i see what's going
on that's worth a lot more than saying
yeah yeah this is good people hear that
and they just kind of go okay it's good
but why and you might say you know okay
these numbers make it look good no
people want something they can see and
there certainly is uh tabloo is probably
um one of the most popular ones out
there caleb view
power bi google data studio
in python there's
the pi kit and seaborn there's all kinds
of different options for visualization
you need to master
probably at least one or two of them so
you understand how they work and how
they're different
and then big data
big data is a massive amount of data
which cannot be stored and processed
using traditional methods big data has
various benefits like access to social
data can enable organizations to tune
their business strategies big data can
improve customer experience uh and so
we're usually when you say big data
we're almost always talking about hadoop
and apache spark it used to be hadoop as
your file system so that's how you store
all your data going across the nodes and
there certainly are other ways to store
it when we talk about hadoop we're
usually talking about at least 10
terabytes of data when you're dealing
with a hadoop file structure and then
you can use spark where hadoop processes
on and off the hard drive so it's
continually reading and writing to the
hard drive spark is running in your ram
and so when you're doing a very
intensive data process you'll run a
spark setup which will spread those
processes over multiple computers and of
course now the two uh combine and spark
sits on top of hadoop and you get your
big data there's also uh talent uh
tabloo has its own server set up there's
splunk uh cassandra you'll hear the
cassandra database pentaho i'm not even
sure how to pronounce that one it's not
one i've worked with certainly there's a
lot of options for big data the two big
players are of course hadoop and spark
and even your sql servers and mysql
servers will spread across five
different servers and you can be talking
about big data across five servers with
those pulling them into say apache spark
to do your high-end processing and then
there's non-technical skills probably
the most important one in data science
and any of our data analytics is
intellectual curiosity updating
knowledge by reading contents and
relevant books on trends in data science
this is such there's so much going on in
this field and it's exploding now that
it's hard to keep track of it all uh so
you really need to have that curiosity
in the data science probably even more
so than a lot of other fields but i
would say in just today's world you need
intellectual curiosity because things
are changing so rapidly in today's world
the way that it's going with our
technology understanding how the problem
solved can impact the business business
acumen this is the one where a lot of
people kind of skip over you have to
have a little business sense if you
don't know how it's going to impact the
business you're going to be in trouble
why do they want to even pay you to be
there unless they know what's going on
and they're getting something in return
so this is your bottom line for your
paycheck is what's going on with the
business how is this going to impact the
business what are you doing for them and
communication skills companies look for
someone who can clearly and fluently
translate technical findings to a
non-technical team and i've talked about
this a bunch and i i can't even iterate
this enough if you are struggling with
your communication skills work on
building them they don't have to be you
know this isn't rocket science where you
have to know all these complicated terms
what you need to do is take the
complicated terms you know from data
science and reduce that down to
something that anybody can understand so
when you come up and you have uh you
know knn no one knows what k n is you
know unless they're in data science
nearest neighbor looking for things that
match together you got to explain that
to people who do not have the technical
skill in the data science arena and a
data science engineer needs to work with
everyone in the organization including
customers uh so it's teamwork and that's
always one that throws people for a loop
but ultimately
you are analyzing your customers
information and so sometimes getting in
there and rolling up your sleeves if
you're let's say you're doing data
analysis for the sales team and you're
backing a sales team you might have to
get in there and go start making some
sales and making some phone calls and
see what it's like what is that team
doing when they call
15 people in cold calls and then they do
a follow-up two weeks later or three
weeks later which one works better two
or three does it work better to call and
send a fax call and send an email you
know when should you show up in person
if it's that kind of business so working
with everybody including the customer is
very important with the data and with
this kind of setup and non-technical
skills for a data scientist so let's
take a look at some of the roles data
science plays in the job market let's
drill in there just a little bit here so
when you have a data scientist they're
going to perform predictive analysis and
identify trend and patterns that can
help in better decision making companies
hiring data scientists include apple
adobe google microsoft i would say
that's even expanding down to smaller
companies you know where you're talking
about only 100 employees or something
like that they're starting to look at
data scientists because they need them
to come in and be a part of that team
and the role is understanding challenges
of a system and offer best solutions
this should always be the goal of a data
scientist is to be looking at the whole
system and then trying to find those
patterns that are going to best enhance
the company or the business or the
whatever group may be working with the
sales team or the marketing team and you
can see languages um pretty important to
have a these are a number of different
languages and again it depends on your
own specialty there's all kinds of
different variations but we have r sas
python matlab sql hive pig spark you
should have at least a knowledge of all
of these maybe a python programmer never
used r download it go through the basics
so at least you know what's going on in
r versus python because r is pretty
powerful for doing a very quick display
and then of course a lot of things you
can do in python you have to be able to
do queries on database from time to time
create and modify algorithms which can
be used to reduce information from large
databases and usually this is one of
those things you do at the beginning you
set it up and then you kind of let it go
until it breaks and you have to go back
and fix it because your query isn't
working that certainly is a very common
thing to to have happen especially if
you're pulling data off the web and the
internet and then we have some more
companies that are hiring data analysis
like ibm dhl hp and so we're talking
about data analyst the role is
responsible for a variety of tasks such
as visualization optimization and
processing large amount of data and so
when you talk about a data analyst we're
also we're still talking a lot of the
same stuff but you'll see we've now
thrown in javascript and html in here
because that's pretty common with the
data analyst versus a data scientist and
you can see that sql is still pretty
solid and also
cc plus is pretty big so some companies
also use java so i'd put java in the
languages also on that for a data
analyst and then you have a data
architect ensuring that data engineers
have best tools and systems to work with
and so companies hiring a data architect
are like visa logitech coca-cola they
create blueprints for data management
with the best security measures i cannot
highlight that a data architect really
spends a lot of time with security
measures that's big how many hacks have
we seen in the last year on large
companies have lost data for millions of
their customers and how badly that
affects them and we're looking at
languages as you see that sql is pretty
solid across all of these under a data
architect xml that's one that a lot of
the data science jobs don't really you
don't see as much but you're going to
see more xml with the data architect
because there's a lot of xml files that
are that have your security measures
embedded in them and of course your hive
pig those are hadoop systems we're doing
some basic queries uh so instead of
doing the high end queries you know how
these simplified query systems built
into hadoop and spark so if you're using
big data you're going to want to know
your spark also and then we have our
data engineer the data engineer updates
the existing systems with better version
of the current technologies to improve
the efficiency of the databases think
admin here a lot of work tracking down
what version you're in of the different
programs what version of python are you
using what version of r are you using
what version of c plus so companies
hiring data engineers are like amazon
spotify facebook and they develop
construct test and maintain
architectures such as databases and
long-scale processing systems and here
we have our languages our sql r matlab
sas spss python java ruby c plus plus
pearl hive pig you pretty much as a data
engineer at this level when you talk
about admin and updating all these
databases need to know all the different
stuff that's being used in the company
and you're testing out these structures
to make sure they work and so you really
are talking admin level uh kind of
setups if you like spinning up an admin
onto a google cloud service or amazon
cloud service now you start to get an
idea what we're talking about because
then you can test it out up there and
then you can bring it back and update it
to the company statition creates new
methodologies for engineers to apply and
so when we look at this this is where
we're digging into the math of which
models to use what setups going to work
what kind of activation do we have on
our neural network these little tweaks
are going to make a big difference and
we look for methodologies at a large
level what kind of data are we going to
be looking at how we're going to pull it
together companies hiring a data
engineer or we're talking about stations
we're talking about linkedin pepsico
johnson and johnson and of course these
companies probably hire a little bit of
everything but they have a lot of
statisticians working for them and so we
look at the role extract and offer
valuable reports from the data clusters
through statistical theories and data
organization and the languages across
the board we're still seeing sql r
matlab sas spss data that's a new one
that i've seen in some of the other
roles python perl an older version and
that shouldn't be a surprise because a
lot of these companies probably built a
lot of the original packages on perl if
you go look at johnson and johnson and
of course your big data hive pig and
spark and then our database
administrator i mentioned the other one
is an admin they're more an admin level
for the software itself so administrator
is another level some of the tasks
involved are monitoring operating and
maintaining databases installation
configuration defining schemas training
users etc and this is interesting
training users because when you build a
database and you define all the
different
tables that are embedded in that
database and how they're all connected
the end user's got to have that
information otherwise you're in trouble
when we have companies hiring data
engineers
of course tabloo twitter reddit
the role ensures that all the databases
are available to all relevant users
getting a little security in there what
role do they have is allowed in and not
and is performing correctly and is being
kept safe and you better be ready to
spend some time in security because
again that's a very big thing nowadays
with the number of people who hack into
these databases and the languages are
going to be covered you have your c
sharp your java sql ruby on rails xml
again there's that xml because a lot of
your security is embedded in xml files
um python all the main players depending
on what the company's using data and
analytics manager so when you see
manager that means that somebody's going
to sit on top and organize the people
underneath so they're going to improve
the business process as an intermediary
between business and i t oh you better
have some really good communication
skills for this one uh some of the
companies hiring a data engineers are
coursera motorola slack and of course
these companies are hiring data
scientists in almost all of these fields
so the role oversees the data science
operations and assigns the duties to the
team according to skills and expertise
so that's a big one you better be able
to communicate what's going on help your
team members come out and be able to
communicate with other people so
sometimes your job is just being able to
get people to talk to each other the big
thing on that is is the whole
communication line going from one end to
the other because you can't communicate
all the information that everybody's
working on you have to pretty much come
in there and and help people communicate
what there's going on and also know what
they're up to without being
micromanagement because that will crash
a company if you micromanage everybody
but if you just let them do whatever
they want and they never talk to each
other that will also destroy the company
you got to find that nice middle ground
and you really have to have an overview
of everything as a data and analytics
manager one of the things i mean you
know it's good to have at least one or
two solid bases of programming under
your belt for a data analytics manager
but you do need to have a very general
understanding of all the different tools
being used so that you know what's going
on with your different team members of
course sqlr sas java python matlab all
of those are big business analytics uh
so this is when you're talking about
your bi or your business intelligence
and your business analytics very
important to know this is kind of a
subdivision of a lot of the other stuff
we've talked about a lot of the other
roles we've looked at
so you possess specialized knowledge of
their business domain and apply that
knowledge and analysis specifically to
the operation of the business uh so you
might be a specialist in banking you
might be a
genetics engineer so you know about
genetics you might just be general
business
helping the marketing so a lot of
companies hiring data engineer oracle
uber dell and the role act is a link
between the data engineers and the
management executives so it's very
similar to when you go back up here we
look at data analytics manager a
business and analytics is going to also
kind of fill that role in between but
they're more specialized in business and
you better know sql because we're
talking about business specifically
most of the large companies are storing
their data that's up and running right
now that people are accessing to
purchase something on the home depot
website or the uber they're logging in
you better know your sql it's very
central to business analytics so let's
go ahead and take a look at the data
science engineer salary trends
and you'll see that our source is glass
door as we're pulling a lot of our data
from average base pay is around 117 000
in the us the average salary and we look
at india we're talking about 950 000 a
year and those are based on some of them
you need to go ahead and dig deeper to
find out what education level versus
entry level but those are pretty solid
base once you're in the industry and
once you created your career in there
and we look at the job titles the most
common job title is data scientist
business intelligence manager is the
second greatest one
that's kind of good to note that's why
they put that up there as being its own
little subcategory of data science
managers a business intelligence manager
because it's such a high level of jobs
and then we looked at some of the other
ones data architect business
intelligence architect again your bi
your business intelligence gets its own
ranking because it's such a
high level you know it's a business
people want their businesses to make
money so that's who's hiring of course
data engineer business intelligence
developer business intelligence
consultant business intelligence analyst
business analyst and data analyst so you
can look at the data analysis being the
general one that doesn't go specific to
business so if you're looking just for
your career as far as getting a job
probably should have some kind of
business understanding in the background
and again you know your companies want
to make money so they're going to hire
someone who knows business if banking
business if you specialize in banking or
retail if you specialize in retail and
marketing and you can see here on the
data science salary trends and the
growth and data science job listings
it's continually going up it's um since
2014 to 2012 we've gone from 400 to 600
that's a pretty big increase so you know
a huge growth in this market it's one of
the biggest growing markets right now
for jobs and careers so let's go ahead
and take a look at uh building a resume
always exciting putting ourselves out
selling ourselves and if you looked at
some of our other videos dealing with
resumes you'll see a trend here
the top part is so different than what
resumes were in the 90s
in the 2000 to 2010 they've evolved
they've really evolved it used to be
2000 2010 maybe linkedin
maybe one other reference now you're
going to see that we want those
references this is a sales tactic which
now has come into resumes used to be
that if you're a real estate agent every
real estate agent i knew i used to deal
with real estate software for the real
estate industry back in the 90s every
real estate agent won their picture on
their business card they wanted them
their picture if they could put on their
contracts they want people to see the
face so that's really a big change is to
make sure that it stands out you stand
out here's a picture of somebody so
you're more than just a couple letters
and a name but of course you need your
contact information should always be at
the top uh you have your summary what
are you focusing on be a little careful
with your summary because if you have
everything in your summary and then they
scroll down to experience and education
and skills they're gonna stop the second
you repeat yourself in your resume that
usually means to the reader hey this
person doesn't have anything more to
offer me i'm done so be a little careful
how you word your summary most companies
appreciate when you come in here and
you've adjusted this summary to be both
about you and how you're going to serve
that company so it's worth researching
that company to find out how those
connect and put that in the summary take
some time to do that that's actually a
pretty big deal and the references are
huge also especially in data science
when you're talking about any of the
programming or data science data
analytics having a place to go where
they can look it up and scroll down and
see different things you're doing
whether it's linkedin in this case which
is the business profile most commonly
used github where you have stuff
published facebook
i'm always hesitant because that tends
to push more towards uh social media
type jobs and other jobs but certainly
there's people who have facebook
who do marketing and stuff like that but
these links having these basic links
here is important uh people are starting
to look for that for some other uh setup
maybe you have a personal website this
is a good place to put that so that they
now have a multitude of links that go
back to you and highlight who you are
and then the next part or next four
parts so for the next four parts we have
a combination of experience education
skills certifications and you can see
they're organized if you have you know a
lot of people like to see what kind of
degree you have they want to know where
it came from and if you just got out of
college you're going to put education at
the top and then maybe you'll put skills
after that and then your experience at
the bottom if you've been in the field
for years
you know my degree
just to give you my age goes back to the
night early 90s so i usually put
education at the very bottom and then
because a lot of the stuff i'm trying to
sell myself on right now is my skills i
actually put that at the top and i'll
put my education my certifications at
the bottom my skills and then my
experience is
since it's a huge part of my resume goes
next you can organize these in whatever
order you want that's going to work best
for you and sell you so remember you're
selling yourself this is you don't wear
an old tie-dye t-shirt with holes in it
you know something nice because it is
professional and of course your summary
your and then what do you have to offer
the company and again when i put out
resumes and i haven't done a resume in a
while you go in there and you can take
this and reorganize this so if the
company's looking for something specific
you might put the experiences specific
to that company you might even take
experience if you have like a long job
history like i do i've gone into a lot
of different things you might leave out
those companies or those experiences
that had nothing to do with data science
because it just becomes overwhelming
resume should only take about 30 seconds
to glance over maybe a minute tops
because after that point you've lost the
person's interest and if they want to
dig deeper they now have links they have
your website they have linkedin and they
can now take this and they come back to
it and they go okay let's look at this
person a little closer so quick overview
this is your sell sheet selling you to
the company so always tie it to the
company so that you have that what am i
going to give this company what are they
going to get from me we've covered a lot
on data science engineer in general and
we've gone over a basic resume remember
keep it simple short and direct that is
so important with that resume today's
topic of discussion is how to become a
data scientist in 2021
so here are the topics we'll be
discussing today a brief introduction to
data science
laying the groundwork for a data science
career a short note on who is a data
scientist
later we'll discuss the in-demand
technical skills for data scientists
and then the salary of data scientists
after which we'll discuss the future of
data science and data scientists
so now let's have a brief introduction
to the field of data science
there is no specific definition to
describe data science if you ask 500
people to describe what data science is
you'll probably end up getting 500
different responses
because data science is a continually
evolving field
well under wikipedia data science is an
interdisciplinary discipline using
computational methods processes
algorithms and systems to derive
information and insights from both
structural and unstructured data
in simple terms data science is the
domain of study that deals with vast
volumes of data using modern tools and
techniques
these tools and techniques are used to
find unseen patterns
derive meaningful information and make
business decisions the data used for
analysis can be from multiple sources
and present in various formats
there is a saying
a jack of all traits and a master of
none
when it comes to being a data scientist
you need to be a bit like this but
perhaps a better saying would be a jack
of all trades and a master of some
let's now discuss about laying the
groundwork for a data science career
let's now look at some of the
prerequisites for getting a data science
job
have a relevant degree a solid
educational background is required to be
a data scientist
pursue an undergraduate degree in data
science or any closely related fields
like statistics computer science or
mathematics
after the undergraduate course a
master's degree in one of the relevant
areas is an added advantage
creativity and critical thinking
creativity in data science is very much
needed in this field you will need it
for creating a storyline for innovative
modeling for developing new tools
different ways to collect your data and
lots more
parallely critical thinking is very
useful in data science a data scientist
should be able to develop questions and
at the same time question the data as
well
require technical and non-technical
skills
we'll be discussing in-depth the
required technical skills later on in
this video
talking about the other necessary skills
in this field you will need problem
solving skills risk analysis and many
more
good communication skills
having a strong command over your
communication skills is very much needed
in this field
the outcomes that are delivered through
data science are quite complicated and
hard to explain
you will have to translate your
technical findings clearly and fluently
to the other teams
you will need good presentation skills
storytelling skills writing skills and
listening skills in short make sure you
focus on building lasting relationships
through your communication
here are some of the roles in the field
of data science
data scientist machine learning engineer
machine learning scientist
data engineer data analyst statistician
business intelligence developer
infrastructure architect
enterprise architect
applications architect
data scientist is most likely one of the
most sizzling job titles among the lot
and now
let's talk about who is the data
scientist
in simple terms a data scientist is the
one who practices the art of data
science
a data scientist analyzes business data
to extract meaningful insights
in other words a data scientist solves
business problems through various
methods
dj patil and jeff hammerbacker coined
the term data scientist
a data scientist's work typically
revolves around data and his role will
be a combination of three main subjects
computer science statistics and
mathematics
it's time to discuss the in-demand
technical skills for data scientists
to become a data scientist you need
various skills as mentioned earlier some
of the significant technical skills you
will need to master include
programming
there are several programming languages
for data scientists
learning and mastering at least one of
them is essential to realize various
functions of data science
but at the same time just a single
language can't solve problems in all
areas
python is the most widely used
programming language in the world today
when it comes to data science the next
widely used language is r
there are still some data scientists who
use r instead of python but if you're
doing applied data science these days
then you've got to learn python because
that's the most valuable programming
language for data scientists
some other languages include
javascript scala
sql etc
talking about python programming
language it is open source and easy to
use language
you will need to understand the basic
syntax of this language initially
you will need to know how to write
functions loops and modules
you should be familiar with both object
oriented and functional programming in
python
it is a general purpose and dynamic
programming language that supports
multiple paradigms
one of the factors that make python
stand out from the rest is its
flexibility
you can use python for almost all the
steps involved in data science
the next skill we'll be talking about is
machine learning
the concept of machine learning has been
around for a while now
however the ability to automatically and
quickly apply mathematical calculations
to big data is now gaining a bit of
momentum
you will need to learn techniques such
as supervised machine learning decision
trees logistic regression and natural
language processing one of the crucial
reasons why you need machine learning in
data science is because of the high
value predictions that can guide better
decisions and smart actions in real time
without human intervention
there are in fact a lot of advantages of
machine learning in data science
it helps analyze large chunks of data
and it changes the way data extraction
and interpretation works
to sum it up machine learning and data
science can work hand in hand
with machine learning being such a craze
data scientists need to learn it
this is why simply learn has introduced
a revolutionary machine learning
certification program that provides
advanced level training on the
applications and algorithms it uses
we have provided the link in the
description box for the same do not
forget to check that out here's to yet
another essential skill in data science
math
mathematics is the bedrock of any
contemporary discipline in science it's
one of the major requirements for data
science
some of the major math topics you will
need to know are
calculus linear algebra probability and
statistics some other math topics that
will help you solve data science
problems are discrete math
graph theory
information theory and many more
up next we have analytical tools
they help you extract useful meaningful
insights from data and provide you with
valuable frameworks for processing big
data
data analysis is a core practice of
modern day businesses and choosing the
right analytical tools is very
challenging as no tool fits every need
anyway some of the most used analytical
tools in data science are sql spark
hadoop hive and many more
coming to data visualization
it is an interdisciplinary field that
deals with the graphic representations
of data
data visualization plays two prominent
roles
communicating results clearly to a
general audience and organizing a view
of data that suggests a new hypothesis
of the next step in a project
some of the data visualization tools are
matplotlib ggplot and d3.js
data visualization encompasses
techniques that are used to communicate
data or information by encoding it as
visual objects that are contained in
graphics
well as big data keeps growing data
visualization becomes an increasingly
crucial tool
up next we have data wrangling
this is the process of gathering
selecting and transforming data to
answer an analytical question it will
help the data scientists fast in
decision making and hence get better
insights in less time
data wrangling is also known as data
cleaning or munching
at last we have
business acumen
when you are a data scientist you must
have more business sense in analyzing
the data in other words you need to know
whether the insights gained from the
data is of value to the business or not
hence business acumen plays a very vital
role in structuring business data
analytics
when we are talking about business
knowledge three things come into the
picture
general business knowledge industry
specific knowledge and company specific
knowledge
knowing these are very much important
when you are a data scientist
so guys this sums up the in demand
technical skills for data scientists
well let's now discuss the salary of
data scientists
before we go into the topic we would
like to introduce our new platform skill
up where you can find some of our best
courses for free we are offering more
than 1 000 hearts of content for free
which can help you acquire more than 300
skills across a number of different
categories
take the next step to grow in your
career by joining skill up by checking
out the link in the description
when we are talking about the salary of
data scientists many factors come into
the picture the salary would depend on
the experience he or she holds the
industry the company size educational
background and finally the region
according to glassdoor the average
salary of a data scientist in india is
close to 10 lakh rupees and that in the
united states is close to 1 lakh 13
309 dollars in the i.t field
the driving factor behind high data
science salaries is that the companies
and organizations are realizing the
power of big data and they want to use
it to drive smart business decisions
coming to our last topic of today future
of data science and data scientists
with every passing year data science is
improving and expanding at a
significantly faster pace
data science has found its applications
in almost every industry
healthcare companies are using data
science to build sophisticated medical
instruments to detect and cure diseases
video and computer games are now being
created with data science and that has
taken the gaming experience to the next
level
similarly data science has taken various
other fields to a whole new level
the top three most common search terms
in july 2020 are data science machine
learning and artificial intelligence
according to the 2020 emerging jobs
report linkedin listed data scientist as
the top third job with an annual growth
rate of 37 percent
for four years in a row data scientist
has been named the number one job in the
u.s by glassdoor
pursuing a career in data science is a
smart move
not just because it pays well and is
trendy it is because data is the pivot
point on which the entire economy turns
however you can also go through our
video on the topic tips for becoming a
data scientist for more information
thank you all for watching this full
course video tutorial on data science
with python i hope you liked it if you
have any questions then please feel free
to put them in the comments section
thanks again stay tuned for more from
simply loan
[Music]
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn youtube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos turn it up and get certified
click here
you